NUMBER THREE AND HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES -- TODAY'S
HEARING WILL BE COMPOSED OF TWO
PARTS PART A OF THE HEARING BE
COVERING -- DEPARTMENT SOCIAL-SERVICES CHILD WELFARE AND
COMMUNITY CARE LICENSING
[inaudible]
AND AND THAT THE FARM HEALTHCARE
SERVICES WILLALSO BE ON A PANEL
TO DISCUSS THE CUT THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE REFORM IMPLEMENTATION.
BE WILL BE COVERING -- SEVERAL
ITEMS INCLUDING -- THE SORRY
SURE WE HAVE A C. H. H. THE CHF
A MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
USE.
THAT MENTAL HEALTH -- SIMILAC
THE STATE AND THE STATE
HOSPITALS -- THE BASICALLY THE
THERE IS NO VOTE ONLY CALENDAR
DAY SO ALL ITEMS ARE UP FOR
DISCUSSION NO VOTES ARE BEING
TAKEN TODAY ALL ITEMS GOING TO
BE HELD OPEN.
AND WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
AFTER EACH MAJOR SECTION AND
WHAT WILL PRIDE WHAT WE'LL DO IS
IS THAT ACTUALLY.
I KNOW THAT WE HAVE SEVERAL
PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENTS FOR
SEVERAL OF AFTER A COUPLE OF THE
ITEMS.
SO I THINK WE'LL DO IS THAT.
WILL DO THE PART ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENT THAT SECTION WILL
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON THAT AND
THEN PROPOSAL INVESTMENTS IT
WILL TAKE SOME COMMENT.
ON ANY PROPOSALS SO WITH THAT --
WELCOME EVERYONE HERE AND WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND BEGIN A WITH THAT
THE FARM SOCIAL SERVICES
COMMUNITY CARE LICENSING.
AND SO WE AN HAVE THE AGENCY IN
LA -- IN.
FINANCE PLEASE COME UP.
CAN I JUST MAKE MENTION THAT --
ONCE AGAIN WE HAVE AN EXCELLENT --
STAFF.
REPORTS TO SELL WHAT WE WANT TO
USE FOCUS -- FOR THE VERVIEW ON
THE HIGHLIGHTS I KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF VERY IMPORTANT STUFF --
AND LOT OF THINGS COVERED BY
COMMUNICATOR LICENSING -- BUT
BEFORE AD ALSO BEFORE BEGIN
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND HAVE
EVERYONE INTRODUCE THEMSELVES TO
THE RECORDS ALL STAR THE AGENCY.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS POUNDED
FUSS DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
COMMUNITY CARE LICENSING THANK
YOU.
ACTING DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES HELLO JACKIE
BRASILIA.
MARKET IN LA -- HE FINANCE.
JUST INTRODUCED A FROM THE
FINANCE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO
WE'LL GO AHEAD WITH ISSUE ONE
WHICH IS THE OVERVIEW THAT THE
OF COMMITTEE CARE LICENSING.
OKAY ALL START WITH THE THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THAT WE'VE MADE
OVER THE PAST YEAR -- I WANT TO
SAY BEFORE I BEGIN THAT WE'VE
REFOCUSED OUR MODEL ON MORE OF
THE PREVENTION COMPLIANCE AND
ENFORCEMENT GOING FROM STRICTLY
ENFORCEMENT SO A LOT OF OUR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS ARE ARE GEARED
TOWARDS THAT.
SO WE MET OUR STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS -- FOR IN FOR
INSPECTIONS ADULTS SENIOR CARE
99% EVERY TWO YEARS CHILDREN'S
REST EVERY TWO YEARS AND AND
CHILD CARE EVERY.
THREE SO WE MET THAT WE DID
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND INSPECTIONS -- WE'VE
ALSO BEGAN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
OUR INSPECTION TOOLS WHICH WE
TALKED ABOUT LAST YEAR SO WERE
WERE INTO THAT PROCESS -- WE'VE
DONE A PILOT -- FOR ADULT FOR
THE SENIOR CARE WHICH ALL
PROVIDE MORE IN YOUR SECOND
QUESTION -- AND R. L. P. A.'S
HAVE ADDRESSED EVERY FOR EVERY
FACILITY THAT WAS IMPACTED BY
THE FIRES AND FLOODS THAT TOOK A
LOT OF OUR TIME THIS YEAR WE'VE.
WE BUILT A GOOD RELATIONSHIP
WITH CALLOW ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PROVIDERS THAT IS ABLE TO
PROVIDE REAL TIME AVAILABLE BEDS
THAT WE COULD ACTUALLY TRANSFER
RESIDENTS FROM ADULTS SENIOR
CARE FACILITIES. TO THESE OF
AVAILABLE BEDS AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE TO KEEP THEM OUT OF THE
SHELTERS -- SO WE'VE BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL ON THAT.
WE HAVE -- REALLY EMBELLISHED
OUR TRAINING IN THE PROGRAM
WE'VE CHANGED OUR LPA ACADEMY
THAT USED TO BE DEATH BY POWER
POINT ON AND IT'S NOW UTILIZES
BEST PRACTICES AN ADULT LEARNING.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND THE CORE COMPETENCIES
AND STATUTES SO IT'S A MUCH MORE
THEY'RE MUCH MORE PREPARED FOR
THIS JOB.
AND IN ALL THREE PROGRAMS THAT
DON'T SENIOR CARE CHILD CARE IN
CHILDREN'S ROSE WE'VE HELD
SYMPOSIUMS TO BUT TO PROVIDE
BEST SPECIFIC TRAINING WE DID A
MENTAL HEALTH SYMPOSIUM WHERE WE
HAD DR -- CONDITIONAL FROM UCSF
THAT CAME AND TALKED ABOUT BEST
PRACTICES IN AND MENTAL HEALTH
WE DID A CLINICAL HEALTH
SYMPOSIUM ABOUT FALL PREVENTION
IN OUR FACILITIES -- AND WE ALSO
DID A TRAUMA INFORMED CARE FOR
OUR CHILDREN'S RESIDENTIAL
FACILITY FOR OUR OUR STAFF TO BE
TRAINED ON THAT AS WELL AS PRINT
PARENTING.
AND THEN -- FOR CHILD CARE WE
DID SUPPORTING CHILDREN WITH
CHALLENGING BEHAVIOR SO WE'RE
TRYING TO REALLY EMBELLISHMENT
AND HAVE OUR STAFF BE MORE
AMBASSADORS OF CHANGE TO REALLY
FOCUS ON THE PREVENTION IN THESE
AREAS IN THE FACILITIES WHERE
THEY'RE HAVING STRUGGLING -- AND
LASTLY WE HAVE WE ARE TRAINING
ON DE ESCALATION WE HAVE A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER THAT'S ALSO
A SOCIAL WORKER THAT IS TRAINING
ALL OF UR STAFF BECAUSE THEY
GET INTO VERY -- EMOTIONAL
SITUATIONS HOW TO DE ESCALATE
THE SITUATION SO WE FOCUSED ON
THAT -- OUR WEBSITE ALL OF OUR
REPORTS ARE POSTED ON OUR
WEBSITE THE TRANSPARENCY WEBSITE
FOR BOTH COMPLAIN INVESTIGATIONS
AND INSPECTIONS.
SO WE HAVE -- DONE A REVAMP OF
HOW THEY DOCUMENTS CALL
PRINCIPLES OF DOCUMENTATION SO
THAT THEIR DOCUMENTED IN A
STANDARD FASHION SO IT'S MORE
UNDERSTANDABLE TO THE PUBLIC.
ON YOU KNOW WHAT VIOLATION HAS
pTHAT WERE ALSO DOING VIDEO
TRAINING THAT -- ONE OF THE
EXAMPLES OF VIDEO TRAINING AS
HAND OVER HAND -- ASSISTANCE
WITH SELF ADMINISTRATION OF
MEDICATION BECAUSE OUR ARMED
CARE GIVERS AREN'T ALLOWED TO TO
GIVE MEDICATION BUT IF YOU'VE
GOT A RESIDENT WITH.
PARKINSON'S OR SOMETHING THERE
IS A METHOD THAT YOU CAN DO HAND
OVER HAND TO ASSIST THE WE'VE
GOT VIDEOS ONLINE FOR OUR
PROVIDERS -- SO THAT THAT SOME
OF WHAT WE'VE DONE -- AND TO GO
INTO OUR CHALLENGES IS IT'S A
IT'S A COMPLICATED -- BALANCING
ACT IN OUR AND OUR FACIL IN OUR
REGIONAL OFFICES WE HAVE TWENTY
SEVEN REGIONAL OFFICES AND THEY
CONTINUALLY ADD TO KEEP UP WITH
THEIR INSPECTIONS.
WE GET THOUSANDS OF OF INCIDENT
REPORTS DAILY THEY NEED TO LOOK
AT AS WELL AS COMPLAINTS THAT
COME IN SO THEY'VE OT TO RE
PRIORITIZE ABOUT THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY ISSUE THEY NEED TO REALLY
GET OUT TO THAT FACILITY AND
CHANGE THEIR WHOLE.
ITINERARY SO AND THEN WITH THE
THE EMERGENCIES WITH THE FIRES
AND FLOODS THEY SPENT WEEKS OUT
YOU KNOW ASSISTING THE RESIDENTS
MAKING SURE THEY'RE OKAY IN THE
RE LOCATIONS AND SO IT'S THAT
CONSTANT BALANCING ACT OF WE DID
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED CLOSURES LAST
YEAR -- REVOCATIONS OF FOR NON
COMPLIANCE -- AND SO WERE WERE
REALLY TRYING TO FOCUS ON THE
PREVENTION ASPECT TO TRY TO GET
AHEAD OF THAT AND THAT'S WHAT WE
THINK THIS TOOL THIS GONNA HELP
US IDENTIFY THOSE AREAS -- THEN
THEN WE'VE GOT -- THE VACANCY
ISSUE WITH OUR L. P. A.'S THAT'S
A BIG CHALLENGE FOR US IT'S A
IT'S JUST A CONSTANT -- CHURNING
OF STAFF THE JOBS VERY DEMANDING
THEIR CASE LOW THEY'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES TO BE SEVEN DAYS A
WEEK -- TWENTY FOUR HOURS IF
THERE'S PROBLEMS THEY'RE THERE --
AND SO SOME STAFF JUST CAN'T
HANDLE IT THEIR THEIR LOW PAYING
JOBS THERE BELOW THE A. T. P.
A.'S THAT IS THAT THAT STANDARD
ANALYST POSITION IN THE STATE
THEIR TOP SALARY IS THE LOWEST.
OF THE EIGHT GPA SO THERE'S YOU
KNOW WHEN IT'S VERY CHALLENGING
TO KEEP THEM -- ON STAFF -- THEN
WE'VE BEEN -- WE HAVE THE
COMPLAINT BACKLOG THAT SOMETHING
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON FOR YEARS
THE COMPLAINTS HAVE BEEN GOING
UP BUT WE'VE BEEN KEEPING UP
WITH THE INCREASE OF COMPLAINTS
OVER NINETY DAYS.
BACK IN TWENTY FOURTEEN WE HAD
ABOUT. TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED AND
THE BACKLOG WE'RE DOWN TO ABOUT
CLOSE TO FIFTEEN HUNDRED OVER
NINETY DAYS SO WE'RE WE'RE
CHUNKING AWAY AT THE BACKLOG AS
WE CAN YOU KNOW BASED ON THE
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE.
AND LASTLY WE HAVE AN OUTDATED
LEGACY SYSTEM THAT IS A
CHALLENGE FOR US YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES THAT THE L. PA'S WILL
BE OUT ON INSPECTION AND THE
COMPUTER WILL JUST GO INTO A
CONSISTENCY CHECK FOR LIKE AN
HOUR TO TWO HOURS BEFORE THEY
CAN CONTINUE WITH THEIR
COMPLETING THEIR REPORTS.
SO WE RELY ON LOTUS NOTES AND
WE'RE WE'RE DOING THE BEST WE
CAN NINE HOURS OF THE BEST WE
CAN TO KEEP IT TOGETHER SO --
THOSE ARE JUST SOME OF THE SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES.
OKAY WHAT DO I JUST CONTINUE ON
WITH THE THE OTHER TWO QUESTIONS
AS WELL OKAY SO -- AND AN
OVERVIEW OF THE INSPECTION
PROCESS -- I DO HAVE A MORE
COMPLETE POWER POINT THAT I AM.
THAT YOU CAN BE PRESENTED THAT
HAS MORE OF THE DETAIL TO IT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS WE DID
A PILOT FOR THE SENIOR CARE WE
DID TWO HUNDRED INSPECTIONS --
AND SO NOW WE'RE GOING OVER THE
ANALYSIS RIGHT NOW WE'VE HIRED
SACKS STATE TO ASSIST US WITH
SOME ABOUT ANALYSIS -- AND THE
THE THE TOOLS ARE BUILT ON
DOMAIN SO IT'S WE NEVER HAD A
COMPREHENSIVE INSPECTION.
PACKET BEFORE A TOOL FOR THE L.
P. A.'S USE SO THEY ALL USED
THEIR OWN NAMES THEY MADE THEIR
OWN UP SO NOW WE HAVE A STANDARD.
ANNEKE IT HAS BUILT ON DOMAINS
LIKE RESIDENT RIGHTS MEDICATIONS
THEM BUILDINGS AND GROUNDS AND
SO IT'S MORE OF A YOU CAN GET A
WHOLE PULSE OF THE FACILITY
WHETHER IT'S IN THEIR INCOME
SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE SO --
THAT WE GOT A LOT OF DATA OUT OF
THE THE COMPREHENSIVE TOOL SO
WITH THAT TOOL WE'RE TAKING THAT
THAT THE DATA AND WE'RE BUILDING
THE STANDARD TO WHICH IS GOING
TO REPLACE THE CAT -- AND SO
I'LL TALK ABOUT THAT IN MY THIRD
QUESTION SO WERE -- ALL THREE
PROGRAMS THE CHILD CARE IN
CHILDREN'S ROSE HAVE DEVELOPED
THEIR TOOLS AND SO WE'RE GETTING
PREPARED TO DO THEIR PILOTS
BECAUSE WE'RE DOING PILOTS FOR
MOST OF THE FACILITY TYPES
BECAUSE THEY'RE ALL SPECIFIC.
TOOLS FOR EACH FACILITY TYPE.
AND SO YOU'RE ASKING HOW THE
INSPECTION PROCESS WILL BE
MEASURED -- WILL MEASURE IT BY --
THE CLOSURES AND THIS IS GONNA
BE A NEW BASELINE FOR US BECAUSE
WE HAVEN'T HAD WE WEREN'T ABLE
TO COLLECT DATA WITH THE KIT AND
SO.
WITH THESE NEW TOOLS WE'RE GONNA
BE ABLE TO COLLECT OUR BASELINE
DATA AND THE MEASURE BY CLOSURES
BY COMPLIANCE ISSUES BY NUMBER
OF CITATIONS.
THE TOOL ALSO HAS BUILT IN
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WHICH
DIDN'T HAVE AND THE OTHER TOOL
AND IT'S MORE OF AN INTER OF
PROCESS SO THE KID DIDN'T ALLOW
YOU TO UPDATE IT AS YOU GOT NEW
LAWS.
ENACTED SO THEY WOULD HAVE TO
TAKE A EXTRA PIECE OF PAPER
WRITE IT DOWN AND SAY I NEED TO
CHECK FOR LIABILITY INSURANCE OR
WHATEVER.
THIS IS THE INTERIM PROCESS WILL
BE CONTINUOUS QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT WE UPDATED AS NEW
LAWS OR REGULATIONS ARE IN PLACE
SO WE WE'RE VERY HOPEFUL THAT
THIS IS GOING TO HELP BUT THE
PREVENTION SIDE OF ITS VERY
TRANSPARENT WE HAVE IT ON OUR
WEBSITE SO.
PROVIDERS CAN ACTUALLY LOOK AT
THE WHOLE TOOL AND SAY THESE ARE
ALL THE REGULATIONS WE NEED TO
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR AND ACTUALLY
USE THAT AS A TRAINING
INSTRUMENT.
YOU MAY GO TO THE THIRD OKAY THE
THIRD QUESTION OF A BRIEF
HISTORY OF THE PROBLEMS WITH THE
KIT.
TOOL AND DESCRIPTION OF HOW THE
NEW TOOLS WILL BE VALIDATED.
SO THE KIDS ALTHOUGH THEY WERE
BASED ON SOUND RESEARCH IN THE
FIELD OF CHILD CARE THEY WERE
REALLY.
UTILIZE DUE TO THE SIGNIFICANT
CUTS OF RESOURCES DURING THE
RECESSION AND SO -- IF THEY
WEREN'T A GOOD INDICATOR OF A
HEALTHY FACILITY AND THAT'S ONE
THING THAT I FOUND ONE AFTER I
TOOK THIS JOB FIVE YEARS AGO
THAT WHY ARE WE DOING
INSPECTIONS THE YEAR TWO YET
LATER WERE FINDING THESE
COMPLIANCE ISSUES THAT WE DIDN'T
IDENTIFY.
SO -- SO THAT'S WHERE WE START
TALKING ABOUT THE NEW TOOL OR
YOU'RE REALLY LOOKING AT A WHOLE
COMPENDIUM OF THE REGULATIONS AT
EVERY PART OF IT NOT JUST A FEW
PIECES LIKE WE HAD ON THE CAT --
SO -- HOW WE'RE GONNA VALIDATED
AGAIN IS IS BASICALLY -- THE
POST INSPECTION LICENSING
SERVICE WHEN WE DID THAT THE
PILOTS WE ACTUALLY LEAVE A
SURVEY FOR THE LICENSEE AND THE
LPA TO FILL OUT WE'VE GOT
FEEDBACK FROM THEM WE HAD FOCUS
GROUPS AFTERWARDS -- THE INTER
RATER RELIABILITY WE HAD --
MANAGERS THAT WENT ON SITE TO DO
IN A RATER RELIABILITY WE ROUTE
74% SO 70% AS THIS IS THE MEDIAN
AVERAGE THEY TELL US YOU NEED TO
GET ABOVE THAT SO WE'RE LOOKING
AT HOW WE CAN MAKE THAT A LITTLE
BIT HIGHER -- SO THESE ARE ALL
THINGS THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT TO
ACTUALLY MEASURE IF IT THIS IS
DOING A GOOD JOB AT AND ALSO
LOOKING AT OTHER STATES
[inaudible]
MESSAGE.
THANK YOU -- COMES FROM ILIO
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
NO COMMENTS FOR MILLIONS OF OKAY.
QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY -- SO I ACTUALLY DID WANT
TO JUST -- TOUCH BASE A LITTLE
BIT ON SO FIRST OF ALL I GUESS.
HOW'S YOUR STAFFING.
AREN'T YOU YEAH WE DO TALK ABOUT
CUTS IN RECESSION WE NOW DID SO --
THEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT YOU
KNOW JERRY TROUBLE RETAINING
CERTAIN POSITIONS BECAUSE THE
PAY IS LOW.
SO CAN YOU WRITE TO WELL WE HAVE --
REALLY TRIED -- TO DO A GOOD JOB
OF PROVIDING MORE TRAINING SO
THAT THE THE THE LPA IS WHEN
THEY GO OUT ON THE JOB THEY'RE
NOT THEY'RE OUT THERE ON THEIR
OWN AND THEY'RE YOU KNOW THEY
CAN BE.
DANGEROUS SITUATION WE'VE HAD TO
CALL LAW ENFORCEMENT IS SO THAT
THEY HAVE THE TOOLS HOW TO DE
ESCALATE WHAT TO DO IN THESE
TYPE OF SITUATIONS WE HAVE A
BETTER RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR
LICENSEES SO WE'RE TRYING TO
RETAIN OUR STOP.
YES A TOW IT SO ARE WE HAVING
PROBLEMS LOTS WITH VACANCIES ARE
ARE YOU ABLE TO SELL YOUR
POSITIONS WERE WERE ABOUT 8%
VACANCY RATE RIGHT NOW WHAT
PERCENTAGE 8%.
AND WE HAVE ABOUT CLOSE.
TO ABOUT.
HUNDRED POSITIONS AND HOW THAT
COMPARES WELL AS A HISTORICALLY
I GUESS BEFORE THE RECESSION IS
I MEAN THAT.
IS YOUR NO IT'S MUCH BETTER.
SINCE THE RECESSION WE'VE WE'VE
RECEIVED SEVERAL POSITIONS YES
OKAY AND AND YOU'RE ABLE.
TO THAT DATE PERCENT VACANCY
RATE STILL HAVE ENOUGH PEOPLE TO
WHOM WELL.
OKAY OKAY I I KNOW FINANCES
BECAUSE THEY KNOW YOU HAVE TO
SAY YES IT'S FINE.
I WILL DO ON THE SIDE.
MOST OF WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW IS
WITH CURRENT STAFF THAT WE
ALREADY HAD THAT -- IS ACTUALLY
HAS THEIR OWN FULL JOB DUTIES
LIKE THE TOOLS ALL OF THAT IS ON
TOP OF OUR REGULAR THEIR REGULAR
JOBS SO -- ESCALATE -- HAVE YOU
HAVE YOU.
HAVE YOU DID YOU LOOK AT THAT
ISSUE AND THIS ISSUE -- ISSUE
VACANCY HAS BEEN SOME OF
DISCUSSED ISSUE IN THE CONTEXT
OF CCL I THINK ESPECIALLY -- AS
PA AS LAWS CHANGING POLICIES
CHANGE THAT REQUIRE MORE
FREQUENT INSPECTIONS -- THIS
ISSUE OF A FOR READY HAVING AN
ISSUE WITH RETENTION AND VACANCY
HOW THEN DO YOU BUILD UPON THAT.
TO INCREASED FREQUENCY AN
INSPECTION. FOR YEARS SO YOU
LOOK AT THIS TOO RIGHT AND SO.
DO YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON ON
DO YOU HAVE CAN STEER DO YOU
HAVE CONCERNS BASED ON THE
NUMBERS YOU LOOK THAT RELATE TO
THIS AGENCY.
I'M NOT FOR THE PURPOSES OF THE
OVERVIEW BUT IN GENERAL THERE
HAVE BEEN ISSUES RAISED ABOUT --
FOR NUMBER FACILITIES TO THE
EXTENT THAT THERE FOR
INSPECTIONS -- FOR FOR FREQUENCY
OF INSPECTIONS ARE SUPPOSED TO
RAMP UP WHICH SOME ARE -- IN THE
CURRENT YEAR BUT ALSO IN FUTURE
YEARS THE QUESTION OF ARE WE
THAT ARE DO WE HAVE ENOUGH STAFF
TO SUPPORT THAT RAMP UP THOSE
ARE QUESTIONS THAT WE'VE BEEN
MONITORING AND TRACKING.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO THAT THAT
CERTAINLY IMPORTANT SO YOU KNOW
NUMBER POSITIONS HOW MANY
VACANCIES BECAUSE IT'S HOW MANY
PEOPLE DO YOU REALLY HAVE TO
WOULD DO THE WORK OKAY.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE KEEP
YES IT WAS A MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS PAT KELLY REACTING
DIRECTOR -- THE ONE THING I JUST
WANT TO STRESS IS THAT HIRING
AND RETENTION OF STAFF IS A VERY
HIGH PRIORITY IN CCL SO AS
MISTER PROSS WAS OUTLINING SORT
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT GO ALONG
WITH THAT -- IT IS A VERY LARGE
POPULATION AND WE THERE IS
ONGOING WORK EVERY SINGLE DAY
THAT FOLKS ARE HAVING TO STEP IN
AND DO SO TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE DOING EVERYTHING
INNOVATIVE AND AND DIFFERENTLY.
WE POSSIBLY CAN TO HIRE AS MANY
QUALIFIED STAFF AS WE POSSIBLY
CAN AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GETTING
BETTER AND BETTER OUT -- WE THIS
THE LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN -- AND
AN ADMINISTRATION HAVE BEEN BOTH
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF ADDING
RESOURCES TO THE COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING OVER THE LAST FIVE
YEARS WE'VE SEEN A SIGNIFICANT
INFLUX TO REALLY TRY AND CHANGE
THE DIVISION.
CHANGE THE CULTURE THAT'S
REFLECTED IN MANY OF THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THAT YOU HEARD --
BUT IT WILL CONTINUE TO BE A DAY --
HIGH PRIORITY TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE HIRING EVERY SINGLE
AUTHORIZED POSITION THAT WE HAVE
OKAY WISEMAN BE SURE WE'RE
KEEPING AN EYE ON THAT --
BECAUSE I THINK AGAIN THIS THEM
FOR IMPORT ROLE AND I KNOW THAT.
PASSED HEARINGS YOU KNOW WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT.
RELATIONS SOME OF THEM FRANKLY
TO TRY TO SEE WHAT WE CAN DO TO
YOU KNOW -- TO DECREASE THE SUR
WORKLOAD RIGHT -- AND DOWN TO
EXAMPLES OF AND THAT IN ITSELF
IS IN THIS REALLY BAD BUT I
THINK IT'S RAISE SOME CONCERN
WHETHER.
SOME OF THE STEPS WERE TAKING NO
MIGHT CAUSE MORE THINGS TO GET
MISTER SOMETHING SO -- FOR
EXAMPLE IN ONE WORD AND THE UNIT.
BUT TO APPRECIATE SIMPLY LOOK AT
THE MAINS AND THEN YOU MIGHT
LOOK AT ONE MEASURE TO REFLECT
THAT DOMAIN.
AND BUY THINGS YOU ALWAYS HAVE
TO KEEP AN EYE ON IS OUR PEOPLE
THIS WAS A PEOPLE ARE VERY SMART
INTO THE YOU KNOW WHAT THE TEST
QUESTIONS ARE YOU YOU PREPARE
FOR THE TEST.
BUT THAT DOESN'T AND WHILE WE
TRY TO DESIGN A TEST SO THAT
THIS WAS QUESTIONS REFLECT THE
LARGER THING RIGHT BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT TO ASK FOR IT WE ASK
QUESTIONS ON EVERY SINGLE THING
YOU WOULD BE A REALLY REALLY.
BIG LONG EXPENSIVE TEST CENTER
WILL BE SURE PEOPLE AREN'T
GAMING THE SYSTEM IN A WAY THAT
THE MARKER ACTUALLY DOES A
MARKER STILL TRULY REFLECT OVER
TIME -- THE ACTUAL FULL THE MAIN --
NOTS AND WRITING THAT JUST
CONTINUALLY MONITOR AYE A TWO
SURE THAT THAT'S AND THAT WE'RE
NOT CREATING SORT OF PERVERSE
INCENTIVES TO DO CERTAIN THINGS
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
MEASURING OTHER THINGS THAT WE
DON'T MEASURE.
WE ALSO TO KEEP AN EYE ON RIGHT.
YES AND THAT'S WHY THIS TOOL IS
IS SO DIFFERENT THAN THE KIT
BECAUSE THERE'S THINGS WE DIDN'T
MEASURE SO WE WILL OUR QUALITY
ASSURANCE TEAM IS LOOKING VERY
CLOSELY AT AT THE THE DATUM THE
CITATIONS RIGHT AND THAT'S
THAT'S WHY.
SO I APPRECIATE THE UPDATE AS WE
HAD THIS QUESTION SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE WE WANT TO
KNOW HOW THAT WAS GOING AND
WHERE WE'RE GOING WITH THAT SO.
I MEAN WE WANT TO STRIKE THE
RIGHT BALANCE IN TERMS OF BURDEN
ON THE PEOPLE BE INSPECTED SO
FORTH AND BE SURE WE HAVE ALL
THE INFORMATION WE NEED.
FOR PROTECTION SAFETY RIGHT YEAH
OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
OKAY ANY OTHER.
SINGLE OKAY WANNA GO AHEAD AND
MOVE ON TO A DATA MIGRATION
ISSUE NUMBER TWO THE C. P. FOR
DATA MIGRATION FOR LEGACY
SYSTEMS. FOR AGAIN CALORIE WITH
DEPARTMENT -- ONE OF THE MOST
EFFECTIVE THINGS THAT WE CAN DO
TO IMPROVE EFFICIENCY AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR STAFF HAVE
THE TIME TO DO THE JOB THAT WERE
TASKING THEM WITH.
IS FOR IMPROVE THE TOOLS THAT
THEY HAVE TO USE IN THE FIELD
AND THE CURRENT SYSTEM THAT WE
ARE SYSTEMS THAT WE ARE USING.
OUR WERE INVENTED DURING PAGER --
TIMES -- AND THEY ARE NOT WHAT
ANYBODY AT THE TIME THEY WERE
CUTTING EDGE THEY TRULY WERE WE
USED TO HAVE L. P. A.'S WHO
LITERALLY CARRIED IN THE TRUNK
OF THEIR CAR BOXES FULL OF FORMS
AND MANUALS.
THAT THEY HAD TO BRING TO EVERY
SINGLE CHILD CARE IN THE STATE
SO THAT THEY HAVE THE RIGHT
FORMS TO DO IT WE TOOK ALL THAT
PAPER AND MADE IT A COMPUTER
SYSTEM.
WHICH IS HOW YOU USED TO DO
THINGS FACT THAT IT IS NOT HOW
WE WOULD BUILD A COMPUTER SYSTEM
TODAY BUT WE STILL ARE TASKED
WITH USING THIS LEGACY SYSTEMS
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
REPLACE SOME OVER THE YEARS.
SO WE HAVE BEGUN EFFORTS TO
REPLACE ALL OF THOSE SYSTEMS --
PART OF THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
CARES PROJECT INVOLVES -- THE
LICENSING PORTION FOR CHILDREN'S
RESIDENTIAL -- WE HAVE PLANNED
AS THAT PROJECT HAS MOVED
FORWARD THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
CHILDREN'S RESIDENTIAL LICENSING.
AND ALL OF OUR OTHER LICENSING
PROGRAMS ARE DE MINIMUS -- SO
WE'VE PLANNED EVENTUALLY TO USE
THAT WHAT'S DEVELOPED IN THAT
SYSTEM -- TO BE ABLE TO USE THAT
FOR OTHER SYSTEMS BUT WE'RE
STILL MANY YEARS AWAY FROM DOING
THAT BECAUSE CHILDREN
RESIDENTIAL IS A CENTRAL PART OF
IT THESE OTHER PROGRAMS ARE IT --
AND SO WE'VE BEEN LOOKING FOR
WAYS WE CAN IN THE INTERIM
CREATE A STOPGAP SO THAT AND
I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE ONE ARE
LPA GOES OUT TO A FACILITY TO DO --
AN INSPECTION OR COMPLAINT VISIT.
FREQUENTLY OUR SYSTEMS -- WILL
GLITCH AND YOU WILL GET A COT
WHAT'S KNOWN AS A CONTINUITY
CHECK WERE I I CALL IT THE
LITTLE BLUE SPINNING WHEEL OF
DEATH -- THAT HAPPENS THAT MIGHT
OCCUR AS LONG AS AN HOUR.
SOMEBODY MIGHT HAVE TO SIT THERE
AND NOT BE ABLE TO ENTER THINGS
ON THE COMPUTER FOR SONGS THAT
THAT'S AN HOUR THAT THEY ARE.
DOING OTHER THINGS.
SO WHAT WE'RE DOING IS MOVING
FORWARD WITH TRYINGTO FIND AN
INTERIM SOLUTION -- TO GET OUR
STAFF ON ALL MODERN PLATFORM
WITH MODERN TOOLS SO THAT THEY
CAN DO THINGS IN AN EFFICIENT
WAY.
IN AN INTUITIVE WAY AND HAVE
EVERYTHING AT THEIR FINGERTIPS
THAT THEY NEED WHEN THEY GO TO
AN INSPECTION -- INCLUDING THE
DIRECTIONS YOU KNOW BEING ABLE
TO GET THE RUSSIANS THE FACILITY.
PART OF ANY NEW SYSTEM OR
SYSTEMS WHATEVER PLATFORM YOU
USE IS ALWAYS HOW DO YOU DEAL
WITH THE DATA MIGRATION HOW DO
YOU DEAL WITH ALL THAT ALL DATA.
LICENSING NEEDS TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE PRIOR HISTORY OF SILLY
NEED TO KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
BEFORE SO THAT WE CAN SEE WHAT
THAT WHAT THEY DO.
BECAUSE ALL OF THE DATA THAT'S
IN THERE WAS CREATED OVER THE
LAST TWENTY TWENTY FIVE YEARS IT
IS AND IT WASN'T CREATED THE WAY
THAT WE WOULD DO A MODERN --
TECHNOLOGY IT'S IT NEEDS TO BE
MIGRATED TO A MODERN PLATFORM --
SHE MENTIONED LOTUS NOTES WE
ALSO USE EIGHT A BASS AND
NATURAL WHICH ARE COMPUTER
LANGUAGES NO ONE SPEAKS ANYMORE
IT'S EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TO FIND
STAFF TO WORK ON THESE SYSTEMS.
SO WHAT ARE THIS PROPOSAL IS IS
TO TAKE THAT DATA THAT'S
CURRENTLY THERE.
AND MIGRATED TO A MODERN --
ARCHITECTURE.
IT IS AHEAD OF WHERE YOU
NORMALLY SEE THAT AND IN A
PROJECT USUALLY SAY WELL HERE'S
WHAT WE WANT TO BUILD A FOUR BY.
FOUR LICENSE OR IN A BY LICENSES
FOR AND DATA MIGRATION IS A PART
OF THAT.
BECAUSE WE ARE STILL IN THE
PROJECT APPROVAL -- SCALE FOR
GOING FOR ONE EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO FOR THAT WE KNOW
THAT DATA MIGRATION IS AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF THAT.
AND WE KNOW THAT BY PUTTING IT
AT THE TAIL END SO TO THE
CABOOSE ON ON THE PROJECT.
YOU ARE WITHOUT MUCH LONGER
BEFORE YOU ACTUALLY HAVE WORKING
SOFTWARE IN THE HANDS OF THE
STAFF WHO NEED IT.
BY BRINGING THE DATA MIGRATION
FORWARD AND PUTTING IT IN IT IN-A IT'S IT'S A SYSTEM AGNOSTIC
WAY IT'S JUST PUTTING IT INTO A
MODERN ARCHITECTURE WE CAN
ACTUALLY FIND STAFF WHO CAN WORK
ON IT.
WHATEVER SYSTEM WE BUILD WILL BE
ABLE TO ACCESS THAT DATA AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN GET A SYSTEM
CONFIGURED TO BE ABLE TO DO IT
WE DON'T HAVE TO WAIT AN EXTRA
THREE YEARS AT THE TAIL AND TO
DO THAT.
SO THAT'S THE PROPOSAL BEFORE IT
OKAY ALL RIGHT COMING FAMILIA.
CONCEPTUALLY INTERSTATE AND THE
VALUE THAT THIS ACTIVITY WOULD
HAVE ESPECIALLY IN THE CONTEXT
OF JUST OPERATING.
CURRENT PROGRAM -- PRACTICES
JUST SOME TECHNICAL ISSUES WITH
A FLAG FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION AS WAS MENTIONED
THIS ACTIVITIES A PART OF A
BROADER BIGGER PICTURE I. T.
PROJECT -- SO JUST ENSURING THAT
IF THIS B. C. P. R. PROPOSAL
GOES FORWARD THAT THE DATA
MIGRATION OR THE DATA CLEANUP
ACTIVITY IS PULLED FROM THOSE
PROJECT PROPOSALS AND COST
ESTIMATES -- TO REFLECT THAT
THIS IS HAPPENING AND THEN
ANOTHER THING THAT WE WOULD FLAG
IS GIVEN THAT THE PROPOSAL'S
BASED OFF OF ESTIMATED COST --
AND WOULD BE SPENT ACROSS THREE
YEARS RATHER THAN PROVIDING THE
FULL AMOUNT OF FINDING AN
ALTERNATIVE WOULD BE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE -- TO PROVIDE FIRST
YEAR FUNDING AND THEN WHEN COST --
WE GET A BETTER SENSE OF COST.
OF ACTUAL COST -- HAVING THE
ADMINISTRATION COME BACK AND
REQUEST THE REMAINING AMOUNT --
THAT'S NEEDED [inaudible]
IT'S DOESN'T REDUCE FRONT OF AN
ANSWER -- AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT
OF THE DEPARTMENT'S PROPOSAL
THEN AS ACTING DIRECTOR LARRY
STATED THAT THERE'S AN AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE HERE THAT'S GONNA
INVENTION WE NEED TO BE UPDATED --
THE PROPOSAL IS IN LINE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGIES -- PAL
PROCESS AND ADDITIONALLY LAST
YEAR FINANCE INSTITUTED BUDGET
LETTER -- EIGHTEEN TWENTY THREE
THE REQUIRES THAT ANY PROJECT
THE RECIEVES FUNDING -- ANY AYE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY PROJECT
THE RECEIVES FUNDING -- PROVIDE
AN ANNUAL -- PLANNING
EXPENDITURE REPORT SO WE FEEL
THAT THERE'S ADEQUATE --
OVERSIGHT -- TO TO MAINTAIN AND
AND AND FOLLOW WHAT THE PROJECT
IS DOING SO AGAIN WE ENCOURAGE
AND SUPPORT THE THE PROPOSAL AS
IT IS FOR THE FUNDING OR THREE
YEARS.
THE QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ALRIGHT SO JUST TO CLARIFY SO
BASICALLY I MEAN THIS IS A THREE
YEAR PROJECT SO IT IS A FIXED
PERIOD OF TIME [inaudible]
CORRECT.
THE THE WAY THAT THE COST ARE
LAID OUT IN THE B. C. E. AND THE
COST WOULD BE EXPENDED OVER
THREE YEARS RIGHT.
BOB.
IT WILL TAKE TIME TO ACTUALLY DO
THE DATA MIGRATION TO GET TE
CONTRACT EXACTLY EXACTLY RIGHT
SO OKAY SO I I'M JUST SAYING NO
SO I MEAN FOR SO LIKE I HEAR
YOUR CONCERN ABOUT FIRST OF ALL.
VIEWS AS PART OF A LARGER
PROJECT WERE SERVED BUDGING FOR
THE SEPARATELY AND WE DON'T GET
DOUBLE COUNTED RIGHT SO BECAUSE
WE'RE PAYING FOR NOW ON ITS OWN
IS THAT WE NEED TO AND THEN WE
THAT SOMEONE FALLS INTO COSTS
AND OTHER THINGS AND THEN THE
OTHER PART.
THAT IT NEARLY YOU SAID IT'S A
LITTLE BIT YOU KNOW WE'RE
STARTING IT'S A LITTLE BIT AN
ESTIMATE WE DON'T KNOW BUT I
MEAN IT'S ALSO IT'S NOT AND IT
CONTINUES APPROPRIATIONS.
THAT OR ANYTHING SO IT IS IS A
THREE YEAR WE COULD NEXT YEAR
EVEN THOUGH WE APPROPRIATED
THREE YEARS SAY A HOW MUCH HAVE
YOU SPENT SO FAR WHERE ARE YOU
RIGHT SO.
AND THAT'S ONE ALTERNATIVE AS
WELL IF YOU GO FORWARD WITH AS
IT'S PROPOSED PROVIDE THE FULL
AMOUNT OF FUNDING BASED OFF A%
COST ESTIMATE IS JUST ENSURING
THAT THERE'S LANGUAGE -- THAT
WOULD REQUIRE.
THE ADMINISTRATION COMING BACK.
OF REFLECTING THOSE ACTUAL COST
MAKING THE ADJUSTMENT WE WOULD
REALLY APPRECIATE OBVIOUSLY
REPORT NEXT YEAR AS TO WHAT
ACTUALLY WAS EXPENDED DAY OUT OF
THE THREE YEAR POTTON WHERE YOU
ARE WITH THAT SO OKAY.
AND I I DO SO BY THE WAY WAS WAS
THE WAS THEIR STUFF SENT OVER IN
WORD PERFECT.
THERE'S SOME OF YOU MAY HAVE
BEEN BORN NO MORE TALK ABOUT
LOTUS AND WORD PERFECT.
SORRY I HAD TO THROW THAT IN
THERE.
AND CITY BUT THERE ARE PEOPLE
OUT THERE GOING WORK PERFECT FOR
YOU TALKING ABOUT.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WELL I APPRECIATE YEAH
I'D CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT
YEAH WE NEEDTO GET THE DATA
TOGETHER INTO A FORMAT -- SO
IT'S READY FOR MARTIN ARTS
ARCHITECTURE AND THAT AND THAT
DOING THAT HAD A TIME AS LONG AS
IT'S IN A DIME.
STRUCTURALLY NEUTRAL MANNER AND
YOU GO TO WORK AND I SOON
BECAUSE THE APART TECHNOLOGIES
INVOLVED OF THE LARGER PROJECTS
THAT THEY'VE GIVEN YOU ADVICE ON
WHAT.
DATABASE OR FORMAT DATABASE THAT
THIS TO GO INTO SO IT'S USABLE
BY.
OKAY EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT VERY
GOOD SOME OF THE COMMENTS ON AS
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE
REDUCING LAW ENFORCEMENT
CONTACTS AND CHILDREN'S
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES.
THIS PROPOSAL IS BASED ON THE
TRACKING OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
CALLS EMBOSSED INVOLVING FOSTER
USE -- WE HAD THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND CONTACTS IN IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND WHAT WE DO IS WE
CONDUCT CASE MANAGEMENT
INSPECTIONS OF ANY FACILITY
THAT'S BASED ON A LICENSED
CAPACITY THAT REPORTS ABOVE
AVERAGE.
AND SO WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS
IF THEY ARE THERE PROVIDING
ADEQUATE CARE AND SUPERVISION
PROVIDED TO DEAL WITH THESE
BEHAVIORS AND SAID I'M IN LIEU
OF CALLING LAW ENFORCEMENT SO
WE'RE ASKING FOR FUNDING. FOUR
THREE L. P. A.'S TO YOUR LIMITED
TERM BECAUSE WORST WERE HOPING
THAT THESE CALLS ARE GOING TO BE --
DECREASING AND SO WE WANT TO
HAVE TWO YEARS TO SEE JUST TO
FOR THE ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD.
OKAY THANK YOU ALEJO COMMONS
FINANCE.
QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY SOUNDS BUT MAKES LICENSE
OKAY LET'S MOVE ON ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR CCL RELATED.
HUMAN SERVICES TECHNICAL BCP'S
CELL YEAH I GUESS WITH A BUNCH
MARK.
SO I'LL JUST BRIEFLY GO THERE
SEVERAL LEGISLATIVE BCP'S IN
HERE SO THE FIRST ONE IS --
BASED ON ONE CHILD CARE CENTER
LICENSING -- A LICENSE INSTEAD
OF HAVING THREE SEPARATE
APPLICATIONS THAT WOULD INCLUDE --
SERVING INFANT TODDLER AND
PRESCHOOL SO THAT WAY THEY CAN
MOVE IT'S IT'S MARK STANDARD
THEY CAN MOVE CHILDREN IN
BETWEEN THOSE DIFFERENT LEVELS
MUCH EASIER.
SO THAT'S THAT'S ONE SO WE'RE
ASKING -- FOR ONE POSITION ONE
LPA JUST TO WRITE THE
REGULATIONS FOR THE POLICY.
A LIMITED TERM POSITION WHICH WE
DO A FAIRLY GOOD DESCRIPTION SO
YOU CAN KEEP IT REALLY SHORT ON
EACH ONE OKAY OKAY THE SECOND.
IS THE AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY FIVE
HOME CARE AIDE REGISTRY WHICH IS
LABOR ORGANIZATIONS JUST WORK
REQUESTING ME -- THE NAME PHONE
NUMBER OF EACH HOME CARE AIDES
SO WE JUST ARE ASKING FOR THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR OVERTIME
AND NO STAFF AND AND THAT'S RAN
A THOUSAND WILL ALSO BE FOR AN
I. T. DEVELOPER TO ACCESS THIS
INFORMATION -- AND THE NEXT ONE
IS AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY HAS
TO DO WITH LESS EXPOSED EXPOSURE
IN CHILDCARE FACILITIES AS WELL
AS DRINKING WATER TESTING.
SO WE'RE ASKING FOR ONE HEPA TO
DEVELOP THE POLICY AND INCREASE
AWARENESS -- FOR CHILDREN IN
THESE FACILITIES.
AND THE LAST ONE IS -- IS ASKING --
FOR POSITIONS FOR CENTRAL
APPLICATIONS UNIT WE HAVE --
WE'RE ASKING FOR FUNDING FOR
THREE PERMANENT POSITIONS AND
FOR LIMITED TERMS -- STAFF
SERVICES ANALYST FOR THAT TO
CATCH UP WITH THE THE NUMBER OF
APPLICATIONS WE RECEIVE.
AND THAT THE LAST PART OF THAT
IS THE THIRTEEN COMPLAIN AND
INVESTIGATIVE -- L. P. A.'S THAT
WE'VE RECEIVED TWO YEAR LIMIT
TERM FUNDING FOR THE LAST.
THREE BUDGET CYCLE SO WE'RE
ASKING TO CONTINUE IT FOR AN
ADDITIONAL TWO YEARS.
ENOUGH SAID OKAY INCOME IS
FAMILIAR -- NO FINANCE QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LET'S GO AHEAD TAKE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENTS ON THE FARM
SOCIAL SERVICES COMMUNICATOR
LICENSING IF YOU PLEASE COME UP
TO THE MICROPHONE AND ASK IF YOU
PLEASE TRY TO KEEP YOUR REMARKS
TO A MINUTE [inaudible]
APPRECIATE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF BOB NAIL
REPRESENTING SIX BEDS INK WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE ITEM NUMBER
TOO MUCH NEEDED.
IF THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
THE BROWN ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN
NOW WE SUPPORT THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THE COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING SO WITH THAT WE CAN
HELP NAMELY ON THE CHILD CARE
FACILITIES MAKING SURE THEY'RE
GETTING THE OVERSIGHT THAT THEY
NEED THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU.
ARE YOU SEE SOMEONE IS COMING UP.
HI ANNA JOHNSON FROM THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW
AND WE SUPPORT THE ITEMS AROUND
REDUCING LAW ENFORCEMENT
CONTACTS AND THERE WAS ANOTHER
ITEM BUT THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU.
YOU CAN ALWAYS SEND A NOTE TO
OUR STAFF WHEN YOU GOT THAT LIKE
ALL RIGHT.
ANY OTHER OKAY SCENE NO ONE ELSE
AT THE MICROPHONE WE WILL HOLD
OPEN ISSUES TWO THREE AND FOUR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND LOOK FORWARD TO
TAKING OF THESE ITEMS AFTER MAY
REVISE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ALRIGHT LET'S
MOVE ON TO THE FARM SOCIAL
SERVICES CHILD WELFARE SERVICES
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
SO WE'LL GO AHEAD WILL BE TAKING
UP ISSUES -- FOR THAT ONE TWO
THREE AND FOUR DELTA COM AND
THEN WILL TAKE THE PROPOSALS FOR
INVESTMENT ALL OF THEM AND THEN
HOLD.
THEN PEOPLE CAN TELL ME WHICH
ONES THEY LIKE.
ALL RIGHT -- SO -- WHEN WE GO
AHEAD AND HAVE EVERYONE
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES FOR THE
RECORD -- SO WE'LL START WITH.
START WITH THE AGENCY WELCOME --
GREG ROSE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
CHILDREN FAMILY SERVICES.
THE MORNING FOSTER CARE BY THE
PERCENT OF CHILDREN BURKE THANK
YOU IN MORNING HEATHER HOSLER
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF TRIBAL
AFFAIRS THANK YOU.
MORNING PITCHER BANCO CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT.
THANK YOU.
HELLO RANDALL ANDERS ELIA.
AND MARK NEWTON ALEJO HE FINANCE.
ALLEY SAID IN THE HOUSING
ASSISTANCE OR ITS BRANCHES THAT
THE SS OKAY THANK YOU.
NOW FINANCE JUST IMPRISONMENT
FINANCE OKAY THANK YOU.
SO -- GO AHEAD AND BEGIN WITH
THE OVERVIEW AND AGAIN WE DO
HAVE A WONDERFUL RIGHT AFTER --
ON THAT SO JUST TRY TO HIT THE
HIGHLIGHTS OF THE THINGS THAT --
YOU'RE DRESSING AND THINGS YOU
SEE COMING UP IN THIS COMING
BUDGET YEAR THANK YOU.
RIGHT WITH THANK YOU GREG
RESIDENT FOR THE DEPARTMENT -- I
I AGREE THE THE THE BACKGROUND
PAPER HAS ALL THE LOTS OF STATS
AND AND AND AND FIGURES I THINK
THERE'S A COUPLE THINGS I JUST
WANTED TO PUT ON YOUR ON YOUR
RADAR SCREEN NUMBER.
ONE IT WE ARE IN IN THE APRIL IS --
IS CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION MONTH
AND SO I I WANT IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR ME TO LET YOU KNOW THAT --
WE JUST RELEASED -- WE FIND A
TWELVE COMMUNITY -- HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS TO PARTNER WITH
CHILD WELFARE ON SUBSTANCE
EXPOSED INFANTS AND TREATMENT
FOR MOMS -- AND IT'S A THROUGH
THESE ARE THREE YEAR GRANTS FOR
A TOTAL OF SIX MILLION DOLLARS
OVER -- OVER THOSE THE OVER THE
THREE YEARS -- ALSO WE THERE IS
JUST A COMMERCIAL FOR THE KIDS
DAY AT THE CAPITOL ON THURSDAY --
WEAR BLUE SHOW UP ON THE WEST
STEPS AND BE PART OF THAT --
WHEN IT COMES TO ACCOMPLISHMENTS
WHEN THE FROM THE CHILD WELFARE --
SERVICES ARENA A COUPLE OF
THINGS COME TO MIND AND ONE IT
WILL TALK A LITTLE BIT LATER
AROUND ARE ARE OURS ARE
COMMERCIALLY SEXUALLY EXPLOITED --
CHILDREN THERE'S A SEPARATE ITEM
FOR THAT BUT ONE OF THE THINGS I
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT -- WHAT FOR
A IN AN ACCOMPLISHMENT WAS WE
HAVE -- RECENTLY -- PUBLISHED
AND WAS APPROVED AND ENDORSED BY
THE CHILD WELFARE COUNCIL.
HARM REDUCTION STRATEGIES TO TO
WORK WITH YOU TRAFFIC YOUTH AND
TO REALLY FOCUS ON YOU KNOW
EVERY DAY THAT -- THEY'RE NOT
BEING TRAFFICKED IS A IS IS GOOD
IS FOR THEM TO PROMOTE HEALING
AND IT'S A REALLY STRONG KIND OF
ENGAGEMENT MODEL THAT REALLY KEY
TRIES TO FOR CONTINUE.
TO FOCUS ON BEING WHERE THE USE
IS CONNECTING WITH THM NO
MATTER WHAT THE CIRCUMSTANCES
AND KEEP BE THERE FOR THEM WHEN
THEY NEED NEED THE ASSISTANCE
AND SO.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF A DIFFERENT
MODEL -- MINUTES BASED ON THAT
KIND OF RELAPSE TO RECOVERY KIND
OF MODEL THAT YOU OFTEN SEE IN
SUBSTANCE USE THAN OTHERS BUT WE
WE ARE KIND OF PUSHING THE
ENVELOPE AS A STATE WITH --
WORKING ON WITH THE HARM
REDUCTION MODEL -- A COUPLE OF
OTHER THINGS -- I WOULD SAY THAT --
OUT OF HOME CARE CASELOAD IS
DECLINING YOU'RE FORCING MORE
MORE PLACEMENTS WITH WITH
RELATIVES OFTEN TEENAGERS WITH
RELATIVES -- WE'RE CONTINUING TO
DO -- GOOD SOLID WORK WITH THE
MUROC IN THE CROUP TRIBES TO
IMPLEMENT THEIR OWN CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEMS UP IN THE NORTH
STATE -- WE'RE WE HAVE RECENTLY --
CREATED -- RECOMMENDATIONS WERE
ACTUALLY WERE SHELL HAS DONE
THAT OUR RECOMMENDATIONS OUT OF
THE OFFICE OF THE PROSECUTOR
OMBUDSMAN -- FOR NEW -- AN
UPDATED BILL OF RIGHTS -- AND SO
THOSE ARE A FEW OF THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS A FEW THAT THE
CUT THE CHALLENGES THAT THE THE
THE PROGRAM IS STILL FACING IS.
LARGE -- CERTAINLY AROUND
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE IN CARE THEY STILL --
THEY SAY THAT THE YOUNG PEOPLE
IN FOSTER CARE STILL PERFORM
EDUCATIONALLY -- LOWER THAN
VIRTUALLY EVERY OTHER POPULATION
THAT'S MEASURED -- IN IN BY
SCHOOLS AND SO WE REACH OUT
WE'RE WE'RE REDOUBLING SOME OF
OUR EFFORT THIS YEAR TO FOCUS ON
ON MEETING THE NEED THE
EDUCATIONAL NEEDS OF KIDS IN
CARE.
CERTAINLY WERE WE NEED TO WORK
ON THE CONTINUE TO WORK ON
PLACEMENT STABILITY.
AND WE ALSO AND ARE FOCUSING
SOME SOME IT INTEREST ON WORKING
ON SPECIALIZED PERMANENCY
SERVICES TO TO MOVE YOUNG PEOPLE --
INTO PERMANENT -- LIFELONG --
CARING RELATIONSHIPS.
KIND OF MY QUICK OVERVIEW OF
THAT OF THAT AT THIRTY THOUSAND
FEET.
AND ACTUALLY DO I JUST GO
THROUGH THE OTHER OPTIONS AS
WELL SO HAPPY TO DO THAT SO THIS
IS THE NEXT ITEM IS OUR OUR
ANNUAL ITEM -- AROUND OUR
PROGRAM IMPROVEMENT PLAN AND AS
YOU RECALL FROM LAST YEAR THE
THE PLAN WAS -- WAS WAS APPROVED
IT LAST SUMMER.
THE END OF THE THE THE PERIOD IF
FOR EVALUATION IS -- TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY SUMMER -- TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY THE THE PLAN
ITSELF HAS A LITTLE OVER A
HUNDRED ACTIVITIES -- CONTAINED
IN IT WE'RE ABOUT 40% THROUGH OF
THE THESE ACTIVITIES IN TEN OR
15% OF THEM AND ON AYE AYE UNDER
WAY NOW WE'RE ON WE'RE ON TRACK
TO TO HIT ALL THE ACTIVITIES.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE IS THAT WE
HAVE.
TO NOT ONLY HIT ACTIVITY EFFECT
COMPLETELY OUR ACTIVITIES WE
ALSO HAVE TO MOVE THE NEEDLE
SIGNED ON EIGHTEEN DIFFERENT
ITEMS -- SO FAR WE'VE MADE SOME
PROGRESS IN -- INCREASING FAMILY
INVOLVEMENT IN CASE PLANNING AND
DECISION MAKING AND ON THE STATE
WHAT QUALITY ASSURANCE SYSTEM --
MOST RECENTLY.
WE HAVE -- WE HAVE HAVE PASSED
IF YOU WILL THREE OF IMPROVEMENT
TARGETS ONE ON THE NEEDS AND
SERVICES OF KIDS AND AND PARENTS.
INCLUDING FOSTER PARENTS A RISK
AND SAFETY ASSESSMENTS AND AND
CASE MANAGEMENT AND THEN CASE
WORKER VISITS WITH WITH THE
CHILD AND SO THESE ARE ALL
MEASURES THAT ARE WE GET FROM
OUR OUR CASE MANAGEMENT REVIEWS
PROCESS.
ALL OF THEM -- MARK ARE
CONSISTENT WITH -- COUNTIES
IMPLEMENTATION OF THEIR CORE
PRACTICE MODEL AND CONSISTENT
WITH THE VALUES OF CC ARE THAT
WE'LL BE TALKING ABOUT LATER --
SO IT SO ONE AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER WE HAVE INTEL TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY OR SO -- TO TO
COMPLETE THOSE ITEMS WE HAVE
TILL TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
ANOTHER TWELVE MONTHS AFTER THAT
TOOK TO FOR THE NEEDLE TO TO TO
FOR TO MOVE -- TO ASSESS THE
LEVEL OF OF OF IMPROVEMENT.
AND SO BECAUSE SINCE WE'RE DOING
SYSTEM CHANGE A NUMBER OF EVEN
THOUGH THE ACTIVITIES MIGHT BE
COMPLETELY WILL TAKE A WHILE FOR
THE DATA TO CATCH UP WITH THEM
SO. TWENTY TWO IN IN -- IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE WILL KNOW --
WHERE WE ARE JUST AT TO CALL OUT
WE THERE IS A EIGHTEEN MILLION
DOLLAR PENALTY AT AT AT STAKE
HISTORICALLY -- THROUGH THIS IS
OUR THIRD ROUND THROUGH THE
FIRST TWO ROUNDS OF OF PROGRAM
IMPROVEMENT PLAN TO GO BACK --
YOU KNOW OVER A DECADE OR SO
EACH TIME WE'VE MET AND PREVENT
TARGETS AND AVOIDED PENALTIES WE
THINK WILL LIKELY BE IN THE SAME
SITUATION NOW IT'S STILL.
HARD TO TELL EXACTLY BUT THE
MOVE TO MOVE THE NEEDLES ARE
MOVING IN THE ACTIVITIES ARE
OCCURRING.
THE NEXT ITEM IS UP BRINGING
FAMILIES HOME AND MISS THAT WILL
HELP US WITH THAT.
THANKS FOR YOUR AGENDA DOES A
GOOD JOB OF OF AN OVERVIEW OF
THE PROGRAM BUT JUST A LITTLE
BIT OF AN UPDATE -- FROM THAT SO
IT YOU THE AGENDA MENTIONS THAT
EVALUATION THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BE -- TAKING ON SO A LITTLE BIT
ON THAT IT'S A A PRO BONO
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE UC AT
BERKELEY CAL POLICY LAB AND YOU
SEE -- USC'S CHILDREN DATED
DETERRENCE AND NETWORK THEY'RE
DOING AT A PRETTY REMARKABLE --
AS FAR AS WE KNOW FIRST TIME AT
PROJECT AFFAIR LINKING THE DATA
WE'RE DOING WITH OUR HOMELESS
MANAGEMENT INFORMATION SYSTEM
DATA.
IN THE TWELVE COUNTIES AT THIS
PROGRAM IS TAKING PLACE AND SO
IT'S GOING TO BE A A PRETTY
ROBUST -- EVALUATION WHAT WE
DON'T HAVE IT EVEN AT EARLY
EVALUATION RESULTS QUITE YET WE
PROBABLY WON'T HAVE THOSE.
UNTIL EARLY TWENTY TWENTY OR SO --
BUT JUST THE ACTUAL FEETOF
GETTING THAT DATA ELLINGTON PUT
TOGETHER IN ITS OWN RIGHT IS A
PRETTY EXCITING -- FEE AND SO
WHILE WE DON'T HAVE SORT OF
FORMAL EVALUATION RESULTS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT WE HAVE SEEN
SOME PRETTY REMARKABLE --
IMPROVEMENTS AND SUCCESS FROM
THE PROGRAM SO.
AS OF FEBRUARY AT THE PROGRAM
HAS SAFELY HOUSE FIVE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR FAMILIES WHICH OF
THE IN THOSE FAMILIES THAT
INCLUDES TWELVE HUNDRED CHILDREN
I'M SAYING THAT'S JUST AN
IMPORTANT PIECE TO KEEP IN MIND --
AND WITH THAT COUNTIES HAVE
REALLY SEEN SIGNIFICANT --
INCREASE IN IT AND THEIR ABILITY
TO HOUSE FAMILIES MORE FAMILIES --
ANNUALLY SO LAST FISCAL YEAR --
WE WERE AVERAGING ABOUT
SEVENTEEN FAMILIES A MONTH THIS
FISCAL YEAR SO FAR -- WERE
AVERAGING FORTY EIGHT FAMILIES A
MONTH SO YOU CAN SEE THAT AS THE
PROGRAM IS HAD SOME TIME TO
REALLY GET ITS LEGS IT'S IT'S
BEEN REALLY SIGNIFICANT -- SO
COUNTIES ARE EXPANDING THEIR
FUNDS PRETTY -- FOLEY -- AS OF
RIGHT NOW MANY OF THEM ACTUALLY
HAVE WAIT LISTS WE HAVE ALMOST
FIVE HUNDRED FAMILIES ON WAIT
LIST RIGHT NOW FOR THE PROGRAM --
AND HAVE SEEN SOME REALLY
EXCITING PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM AND
THEIR LOCAL HOMELESSNESS SYSTEM
AND THEIR THEIR PUBLIC HOUSING
AUTHORITIES TO THE POINT WHERE --
SOME OF OUR OUR COUNTIES
ACTUALLY PARTNER THE PUBLIC
PUBLIC HOUSING AUTHORITIES TO
GET ADDITIONAL FAMILY
UNIFICATION PROGRAM FOR VOUCHER
IS FROM HIDE AND MANY OF THEM --
OR SUCCESSFUL SIX OF THE TWELVE
COUNTIES GOT ADDITIONAL VOUCHERS
FROM HI THIS YEAR BECAUSE OF
THIS PARTNERSHIP SO THING A LOT
OF SUCCESS WE DON'T HAVE
EVALUATION RESULTS YET -- BUT
THE PROGRAM IS SET TO SUNSET
THIS THE FISCAL YEAR.
THE NEXT ITEM IS THE FAMILIES
FIRST ACT IN THE QUESTIONS WERE.
AROUND -- BASICALLY KIND WHAT IS
IT AND WHAT IMPACTS MIGHT THAT
MIGHT WE SEE.
I THINK.
THAT THE THE FEDERALIZED IS VERY
VERY COMPLICATED HAS MANY CAUGHT
MANY PARTS AND MANY STARTIN
START OUR START DATES AND SO FOR
THE PURPOSES OF THIS DISCUSSION
I THINK WHAT I'D LIKE TO FOCUS
ON A COUPLE OF AREAS PART.
ONE OFTEN SEEN AS THE PREVENTION
PART IN PART FOR WHICH IS THE
CONGREGATE CARE PIECE I THINK
ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS
FOR US TO TALK ABOUT.
TODAY -- HAPPY TO DO A MORE FULL
BRIEF AT SOME OTHER TIME BUT I
THINK THOSE ARE THE AREAS THAT
ARE REALLY -- IMPACT US THE MOST
AND SO -- THE THE THE THE THE
FAMILIES FIRST ACTIVE -- IF FOR
THE FIRST TIME KIND OF CRACKS
THE DOOR OPEN FOR STATES AND AND
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO USE
FEDERAL FOR E. FUNDING FOR
SERVICES HISTORICALLY THE FORTY
FUNDING HAS BEEN USED -- FOR
KAREN SUPERVISION AND
ADMINISTRATION CASE WORK THAT
KIND OF THING.
THE THE THE FOR THE FIRST -- THE
FIRST SECTION THE WITH OFTEN
KNOWN AS PART.
ONE IS -- AN OPTIONAL AN
OPTIONAL -- PROGRAMS THAT WOULD
BE THE STATE WOULD HAVE TO OPT
INTO IT AND IT ALLOWS -- FOR AND
IT CAN ONLY BE OPTED INTO ONCE
PARK FOR IS IN IN OPERATION SO
IN OTHER WORDS YOU DO THAT
CONGREGATE CARE PIECE THEN YOU
CAN OPT IN TO THE TO THE
PREVENTION PIECE.
IT ALLOWS FOR SERVICES AND FOR
UP TO TWELVE MONTHS FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO -- WHO ARE SO CALLED
CANDIDATES FOR FOSTER CARE SO IN
OTHER WORDS IF WITHOUT SOME KIND
OF INTERVENTION THEY WOULD BE
REMOVED FROM THEIR HOME?
ALLOWS SERVICES TO BE PROVIDED
TO THEM OR THEIR FAMILIES IN
KIND OF THREE THREE AREAS.
ONE IS -- SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT ONE IS MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND ONE IS IN HOME
PARENTING A SERVICES -- AND AND
A AND THE AND THE THE LOS
PRESCRIPTIVE ABOUT WHICH
PROGRAMS YOU CAN ACTUALLY USE OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
CREATED A LIST THAT -- IS MODEST
AT PRESENT -- AND POTENTIALLY
COULD GROW -- BASED ON BASED ON
A MORE EVIDENCE OF THESE ARE
EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAMS DECIDED
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT
CAN BE USED.
IN THESE PARTS FOR THESE
PURPOSES -- IT IN IN PART FOR
THE AND I'LL COME BACK A LITTLE
BIT TO THE IMPACT OF THOSE SEE
IF AT THE END.
SO IT IN PART FOR THERE'S WITH
IT IT'S IT'S VERY MUCH IT'S
SIMILAR TO BUT NOT EXACTLY THE
SAME AS THE KIND OF THINGS WE'VE
BEEN DOING WITH C. C. R..
IT IS IT HAS FOUR KIND OF AREAS
WHERE THERE'S THE TO THE WAY
THINGS ARE A LITTLE DIFFERENT
ONE IS THAT THE THE FEDS.
HAVE DESCRIBED THIS QUALIFIED
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT PROGRAM
SIMILAR TO OUR S. T. R. T. P.
HOWEVER THE THE ADMISSION
CRITERIA ISN'T IS NARROWER MUCH
IT MORE -- MORE -- CLINICAL IT
CAN BE AND LESS BEHAVIOR --
LET'S SAY THAN WE HAVE IN OUR IN
OUR IN OUR CURRENT LAW.
REQUIRES THAT NURSING --
SERVICES BE AVAILABLE TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN IT DOES SAY DEPENDING
ON THE PROGRAM WORSE WERE
SEEKING CLARIFICATION TO SEE
WHAT THAT IS THAT HOW THAT COULD
BE IMPLEMENTED HERE.
THAT IS SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT
FROM OUR STR TEEPEES IS THERE
REALLY A SOCIAL MODEL ONE NOT A
MEDICAL MODEL -- IT ALSO
REQUIRES AN INDEPENDENT ENTITY
THAT'S NOT ASSOCIATE WITH THE
STATE THE COUNTY OR THE PROVIDER
TO MAKE A DETERMINATION WHETHER
THAT YOU WHETHER THE YOUNG
PERSON SHOULD BE -- IT MATED TO
THAT FACILITY -- THE FEDS CAN
WAIVE THAT AND WE BELIEVE WE
HAVE OUR PROCESS IT FROM C. C.
R. WAS WOULD LIKELY MEET IT'S ME
TAKE THEIR THAT THE THE INTEREST
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN IN
IN IN THAT.
AND IT ALSO REQUIRES -- POSTED
DISCHARGE FROM THE FROM THE THE
THE THE Q. R. T. P. -- SIX
MONTHS OF AFTER CARE SERVICES
AND THAT IS A IS IS SOMEWHAT
TICKET THAT IS DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN IN OUR IN OUR
S. T. OUR G. P..
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT OFTEN THE
FOLKS?
WHO HAVE HAVE TALK WHO TALK
ABOUT -- THE FAMILY'S FIRST ACT
THINK ABOUT IT AS AS EIGHT
CONTINUE.
AN EXTENSION IF YOU WILL.
A TRIP FROM OF FOR FROM TO THE
WAY FROM A WAIVER SO.
IF YOU RECALL WITH NOT THE LAW
PASSED THE FEDERAL LAW PASSED
AND ARE AND THE FORTY WAIVERS
THAT MANY STATES ENJOY INCLUDING
OURS.
THE SUN SETS AT DURING THAT TIME
PERIOD THERE WAS THIS THAT
SUGGESTION THAT THE THE THE NEW
ACT WOULD ALLOW -- FOR DOES MANY
OF THE ACTIVITIES THAT WAIVER
COUNTIES ARE STATES TO TO BE
FUNDED IN THAT SO IN THAT PART.
ONE OUR ANALYSIS OF WHAT ARE
COUNTIES ARE DOING IS -- IT
TERMS OF PREVENTION IN EARLIER
THAN TO INTERVENTION ARE NOT
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT'S ON THE
APPROVED LIST AT THE MOMENT.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT CENTER
MEDICAID EXPANSION STATE MUCH OF
WHAT IS -- ALL THE COULD BE
FUNDED OUT OF FOR EASY -- FOR IN
SUBSTANCE USE AND IN MENTAL
HEALTH IS LAW LIKELY COULD BE
COVERED UNDER OUR CURRENT
MEDICAID CITY.
PART ONE DOESN'T SEEM TO HAVE
HAD BE IS INVITING TO TWO K. FOR
US AS IT COULD BE FOR OTHER.
OTHER JURISDICTIONS I SHOULD
MENTION SINCE THE IT'S IT'S
OFTEN TALKED ABOUT IN IN
SIMULTANEOUSLY WITH WAVE WITH
THE WAIVER -- ARE ARE COUNTIES
ARE LIKELY TO TO SEE A DECREASE
OF FEDERAL FUNDS IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF THREE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY SOME ODD MILLION
DOLLARS AT THE CONCLUSION OF THE
WAIVER -- BECAUSE OF THAT -- OF
DECK THE KICKED THE CASE WHAT
KIND OF REVERTING BACK TO PRE TO
POST -- TO THE CURRENT CASELOAD
VERSES THAT THAT THE CASE LAW
THAT WE LOCKED IN THE FEDERAL
FUNDS AND FOR SOME COUNTIES
ALMOST A DECADE AGO.
SO IF FAMILIES FIRST MAY NOT
ACTUALLY BE THE ANSWER TO OUR
WAIVER SITUATION AS BUT IT MAY
BE IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS LIKELY
NOT IN CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
NEXT ITEM.
OKAY NEXT ITEM IS ARE YOU WOULD
ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING TO IDENTIFY AND
IMPLEMENT BEST PRACTICES WHEN IT
COMES TO COMMERCIALLY SEXUALLY
EXPLOITED -- CHILDREN SO LIKE
ANY AND ANY NEW PROGRAM AND I
WOULD SAY THEY'RE THEY'RE STILL
THAT THE THE THE THE THE
LITERATURE IS THE PRACTICES ARE --
AND THE INSIGHTS ARE CONTINUING
TO EVOLVE AND IT'S NOT JUST HERE
BUT IT ACROSS THE NATION WHAT IS
SO WHAT WE HAVE DONE THOUGH OF
COURSE IT IS WHAT YOU WOULD
EXPECT US TO DO IS.
DO LITERATURE REVIEWS TALK TO X.
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS -- WE'VE
WE VISITED ALL OF THE THE
COUNTIES WHO HAVE OPTED INTO
THAT -- INTO THE PROGRAM -- TALK
WITH THEM ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE
DOING PROVIDED SOME TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE LEARNED A LOT FROM
THOSE VISITS -- AND WE ARE
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
TRAVEL FOR COUNCILS -- SEASICK
ACTION TEAM AND THE THE SURVIVOR
ADVISORY BOARD THAT'S CONNECTED
TO THAT WE WORK WITH THEM WE
ACTUALLY DEPARTMENT FUNDS THOSE
ACTIVITIES AS WELL -- IT'S AND
SO AS A RESULT THE FIRST KIND OF
THINGS WE'VE DONE IN ADDITION TO
THE THE HARM REDUCTION -- MODEL
I TALKED ABOUT EARLIER WE OF
COURSE CREATED -- AND A NUMBER
OF DEMO USE OTHER BE LOCAL
COMMUNICATION AND TASK FORCE AND
THOSE KINDS OF KIND OF SYSTEM
LEVEL THINGS.
HAPPENING WHAT WE WHAT WE
FOCUSED OUR ENERGY ON MOST
RECENTLY THOUGH -- GIVEN THE THE
THE THE NEED FOR SERVICE SAYS --
IS -- DEVELOPED A MODEL THAT WE
GO THROUGH -- THROUGH QUERYING
THE FIELD SO WE DID AN RFI -- IN
THAT IN LATE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN TO GET THE BEST
THINKING OF FROM THE FIELD ON
WHAT.
WHAT AND HOW OUGHT WE BEST SERVE --
VICTIMS OF TRAFFICKING IN AND
SUPPORT THEIR HEALING -- AND
THAT THAT ARE IF  WAS IN
TRANSIT TRANSLATED INTO AN R. F.
P. THAT WE RELEASED IN THE FALL
OF LAST YEAR.
WE ARE IN THAT THE THAT WE'RE
WE'RE IN THAT NOTIFICATION UP
SPACE NOW SO -- WE'VE WE WE HAVE
OUR INTENT TO NOTIFY THE AND THE
CONTRACT WOULD BE THE SAN
FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT ON THE
STATUS OF WOMEN -- WE INTEND IT
TOMORROW'S THE FINAL DAY FOR
LIKE PROTESTS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT SO BARRING ANY PROTESTS
WE'D BE ABLE -- TO TO AWARD THAT
CONTENT AWARD THAT -- THAT ARE
OF P. AND WE THINK THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE THE CONTRACT IN
PLACE -- IN SUMMER -- IN THIS IS
A DEVELOPING AT AT A A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
SERVING -- VICTIMS OF
TRAFFICKING THEY INCLUDES --
DROP IN KINDS OF CENTERS HOME
BASED -- CARE THAT'S VERY
SUPPORTED -- A RESIDENTIAL
COMPONENT -- CONNECTIONS TO A
COMMUNITY EXTRA CURRICULAR AND
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
LARGELY WE SEE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO BE -- AT ALL I A PILOT IN THE
BAY AREA COUNTIES -- WITH SOME --
WITH SOME -- EVALUATION ATTACHED
WE WE BELIEVE THAT WE COULD
POTENTIALLY MAKE SOME
MODIFICATIONS AND SPREAD TO THE
MODEL ELSEWHERE WE DOES IT SEEM
TO THAT OTHER THAT IT THAT THAT
BECAUSE OF THE RELATIVELY SMALL
POPULATION -- ALTHOUGH OF OF OF
FOOD THAT IT MADE SENSE FOR THE
STATE TO TAKE ON THIS KIND OF
WORK RATHER THAN EACH INDIVIDUAL
COUNTY TRYING -- TO THEY THEY
CONTINUE TO DO WHAT THEY NEED TO
DO BUT TRYING TO DEVELOP A MODEL
SEEM TO BE MORE -- THE KID TO
WHAT THE STATE -- THE VALUE TO
THE STATE COULD BRING WHILE THE
COUNTIES DO THE DAY TO DAY WORK
WITH THE WITH VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY -- COMES FROM ILIO.
OVERALL FINANCE QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YES SIR TARA.
QUICK QUESTION I'M JUST TRYING
TO GET A LITTLE BIT MORE
INFORMATION WHERE DO WE SEE --
EXPLOITATION ON YOU KNOW FROM
THE YOUTH IS THERE CERTAIN AREAS
OR CITIES IN THE STATE WHERE.
YOU'RE FINDING MORE --
CONCENTRATIONS OF THIS THIS
ISSUE HERE.
SO THE THE THE CERTAINLY THE BAY
AREA IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
TYPICALLY ANYWHERE THAT THERE IS --
A INTERSTATE HIGHWAY SOURCING
ALSO THE CENTRAL VALLEY -- AT AT
AND SO WE'RE YOU WILL LIKELY SEE
TRAFFICKING -- IN AREAS OF BIG
CITIES AND AREAS THAT ARE KIND
OF RESORT ISSUE AND THAT ARE A
NY NEAR HIGHWAYS.
AND WHERE THEY AT WHERE THERE
ARE.
CLOSEDINTERSTATE HIGHWAY SO
WE'RE SEEING IT FOR SEEING -- OF
VICTIMS OF TRAFFICKING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE NOT JUST TO
THE OFTEN PEOPLE THINK
EXCLUSIVELY OF MAYBE.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND MAY BE --
AND AND MAYBE THE BAY AREA AND
THE CLEARLY THERE ARE
CONCENTRATIONS THERE BUT WE'RE
WE'RE SEEING -- TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS IN VIRTUALLY.
ALL OF THE ALL OF THE COUNTIES
IN THE STATE.
DO YOU HAVE ANY DATA WE DO HAVE
DATA I CAN PROVIDE DON'T HAVE IT
WITH ME TODAY THE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE IT TO TO STAFF OR TO
YOUR STAFF DIRECTLY OUT.
WHEN IT WILL GET IT TO YOU THAT?
THANK YOU -- STASHED FEW
QUESTIONS -- SO FOR FIRST OF ALL --
YOU MENTIONED THAT -- NO THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES IS THE IS
EDUCATIONAL -- PERFORMANCE --
FOR TRUSTEES CHILDREN SYSTEM AND
CLEARLY THEY HAVE THEIR FACING A
LOT OF CHALLENGES -- AND TING
INCLUDING EVEN.
THEY'LL BE MOVED AROUND A LOT SO
THAT HAVING A WHAT IT WHAT IS
YOUR DEPARTMENT DOING LET'S SAY
WITH.
EDUCATION ARE I GUESS IS REALLY
MORE DOWN ON THE GROUND LEVEL
LIKE WORKING WITH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS I MEAN WE DO WELL CFF
SO RELEASE.
THE ORDERS BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
THERE'S NOT INVESTORS OF
COMMITTEE BUT THAT AIM TO IT TO
ANYTHING LIKE OKAY YOU
IDENTIFIED THIS PROBLEM HERE
RIGHT.
WHERE SHOULD WE BE COMING
TOGETHER TO TRY TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUES -- FOR FOR FOR FOR THESE --
CHILDREN.
PROVIDES SHOWN HERE THERE'S A
THERE'S A HANDFUL OF OF KIND OF
TANGIBLE AND PRACTICAL THINGS I
THINK THAT THE DEPARTMENT -- IS
AND CAN'T DO -- DO -- AND I
SHOULD ALSO SAY THAT WE AMONGST
MANY -- THE FORMER FOSTER USE
THEMSELVES -- EDUCATION THE
EDUCATION COMMUNITY OTHERS --
EVEN MONDAY IN THIS BUILDING HAD
AN EDUCATION SUMMIT AND THERE'S
AND SO THERE'S A LOT OF INTEREST
IN -- AT IN IN COLLABORATING TO
SOLVE THE BIGGER BIG PROBLEMS
AND SOME OF THE LITTLE LITTLER
PROBLEMS TO TO SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT IS SO WE WE DO
SUPPORT EDUCATION -- TASK FORCE --
THAT'S MADE ITS MULTI
DISCIPLINARY HAS PEOPLE LIVED
EXPERIENCE ETCETERA TO TO TO
LOOK AT THE POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES PRACTICES WITHIN OUR
PORTFOLIO AND SEE HOW WE CAN
BETTER.
DO THAT -- AND AT THE SAME TIME
WE WE ARE EXCHANGING DATA WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION SO
THAT WE CAN LOOK AT A SCHOOL
DISTRICT BY SCHOOL DISTRICT KIND
OF BASIS TO SEE HOW.
HOW HOW PERFORMANCE IS HAPPENING
SOME OF THE THE THINGS THAT I
THINK YEAH YOU MENTIONED EARLIER
ONE OF THE MANY?
OFTEN THE SCHOOL -- POOR SCHOOL
PERFORMANCE IS TIED TO
INSTABILITY OF PLACEMENT AND SO
IF WE CAN -- REDUCE PLACEMENT
MOVES WE ALSO REDUCE SCHOOL
MOVES.
AND SO WE ARE -- WE'RE FOCUSING
ON THAT AREA -- MOVE LARGELY BY
SUPPORTING CARE GIVERS AND YOUNG
PEOPLE IN CARE -- THROUGH THAT
THROUGH OUR CHILD AND FAMILY
TEAM PROCESS WILL TALK ABOUT
MORE IN C. C. R. BUT THROUGH BUT
THROUGH A WHOLE BUNCH AND
PROVIDING -- FOSTER PARENTS AND
RELATIVE CARE GIVERS WHAT THEY
NEED TO ADDRESS ISSUES THAT COME
UP AS A RESULT OF KIDS DEALING
WITH COMPLEX TRAUMA SO WE'RE
LOOK WORKING ON PLACEMENT
STABILITY WE ALSO NEED TO DO A
BETTER JOB OF OF OF WE THERE IS --
PROVISIONS IN LAW THAT ALLOW FOR
IT YOU KNOW UNDER REASONABLE
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
TO REMAIN IN THEIR SCHOOL OF
ORIGIN OR WITH THE SCHOOL UP
WITH THEIR SIBLINGS.
AND SO I THINK WE WE ARE
COMMITTED IN THE DEPARTMENT TO
WORK WITH SOME OF OUR ADVOCATE
COLLEAGUES AND AND WITH THE
COUNTIES ON MAKING SURE.
THAT -- FOSTER PARENTS AND CARE
GIVERS ARE ARE AWARE OF THE THAT
FUNDING SO THAT THAT MADE REPEAT
REDUCE SOME BARRIERS.
FOR STABILITY AS WELL.
WE ALSO -- PLAN TO YOU KNOW
BECAUSE OF THE ARE WE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB. TWENTY
EIGHTY THREE OF THE MOST I
SYSTEM INVOLVED YOUNG PEOPLE WE
HAVE -- SOLIDIFIED OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH -- THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT EDUCATION
THEY'VE BEEN DOING LOTS OF WORK
WITH US ON CC ARE THE SO CALLED
YOU KNOW THE MORE THAT THE THE
THE MULTI SYSTEM YOUNG PEOPLE --
BUT WE DO NOW HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO KIND OF WORK MORE
CLOSELY WITH THEM AS PART OF
THIS GROUP TO TRY.
TO TACKLE SOME OF THOSE THINGS
IT IS COMPLEX BECAUSE IT MUCH OF
IT IS THAT THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
LEVEL NOT EVEN AT THE COUNTY
OFFICE OF AD LEVEL -- MEN SO WE
ARE -- YOU KNOW WE'RE GOING TO
DO WHAT WE CAN DO WE'RE GOING TO
SUPPORT OTHERS TO WHO ARE GOING
TO ADVOCATING WORK LOCALLY BUT
THOSE TWO OF THOSE TO HE THINGS
I THINK ARE THE MOST TANGIBLE
THINGS WE CAN DO AT THE MOMENT.
YEAH SO CERTAINLY -- I WOULD
APPRECIATE -- UPDATES -- OUR
IDEAS ARE COMING OUT THINKING
ABOUT THIS PROCESS SO MANY.
SEGMENTS SO AT I'M JUST THINKING
LIKE ALRIGHT AND ACTUALLY --
BECAUSE I NOT ONLY CHAIR THIS
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIR HOUSE
I SAID ON EDUCATION I SAW HIM IN
SERVICES OKAY.
AND NOW IS A LOT OF THE LIKE
WE'RE TALKING A FOSTER YOUTH IN
THE SERVICE YOU PROVIDE THEM YOU
KNOW AND TERMS WHAT'S GOING
HOMES THAT YOU IN WHAT YOU CAN
DO THERE RELATED SCHOOL DISTRICT
I THINK ABOUT SCHOOL DISTRICT
SPECIAL EDUCATION BY MANY OF THE
MAYBE IN SPECIAL.
EDUCATION WE GOT MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES AVAILABLE AT SCHOOL
ONE THING I WANT TO TRY TO WORK
WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS HOW DO WE
DRAW DOWN MORE MEDI CAL MONEY.
FOR PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OTHER TYPES OF SERVICES
AT THE SCHOOL AND RECOGNIZING
THAT WAS CERTAINLY THE FOSTER
FAMILY THERE WITH IS YOUR
PRIMARY CONNECTOR I MEAN WE ALL
GREW UP IN WE HAVE.
TEACHERS OR COACHES OR OTHER
PEOPLE AT SCHOOL THAT ALSO HELP
MENTOR US AND SO FORTH SO THAT
RELATIONSHIP IN DISABILITY THAT
RELATIONSHIP CAN ALSO BE VERY
IMPORTANT IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
ANY USE.
AND PARTICULARLY FOSTER YOU SO.
THERE'S SOMETHING I HOW THESE
THINGS COME TOGETHER AND WE'RE
ON OUR OWN SILOS BUT SAYING LIKE
OKAY WHAT CAN WE ALL.
DO RIGHT SO ARE ARE THE HOLIDAY
OUR TO MENTAL HEALTH HEALTH
SERVICES AVAILABLE ART
EDUCATIONAL SERVES ABLE AND
WHERE DOES SUPPORT IN THE
COMEDIAN THE HOME WHICH I KNOW
IS THAT YOUR MAILING.
DEALING WITH AND HOW CAN WE MAKE
THIS ALL COME TOGETHER SO -- I
REALLY YOU KNOW -- WOULD CREATE --
YOU KNOW YOUR HELP AND YOUR
IDEAS I MEAN YOUR YOUR MARKS
THIS CELL.
AND SAYING LIKE OKAY HOW DO
ACROSS THE SILOS AND AND HOW CAN
WE HELP HERE TO HELP BRIDGE THE
SALAS TO WRITE AND SELL IT AND
AND I CONVERSATION.
SO OKAY NIGHT PRE SHEET THAT --
ANOTHER QUESTION I HAD -- IN
TERMS OF REALLY APPRECIATE THE
UPDATE ON BRINGING FAMILIES HOME --
YOU MENTIONED THAT -- WELL TO BE
A PEOPLE WEIGHTLESS IT SEEMS
LIKE THREE SUCCESSFUL AT SUN
SETTING SOON -- WHERE A SO WHAT
WE NEED TO DO NEXT AND ALSO IT?
OUT HOW DO WE MOVE THIS -- IN
TERMS OF SCALE IS THIS SOMETHING
WE CAN ALSO SHOULD BE THINKING
ABOUT.
THAT IT -- MAKING LARGER FOR
MORE REALITIES IT ALL OVER THE
STATE RIGHT NOW IS ONLY CERTAIN
COUNTIES.
SO YEAH Và BRIEFLY YEAH THAT
WOULD SO IT WAS A COMPETITIVE --
OPERATION RIGHT SO THERE ARE THE
TWELVE COUNTIES THAT ARE THEY'RE
DOING IT WAS INTENDED TO BE A
PILOT AND WE ARE TRYING TO WAIT
FOR THE RESULTS OF THE
EVALUATION.
TO EARLY INDICATIONS ARE SHOWING
THAT IT IS A UNIFYING FAMILIES
FASTER THAT SORT OF THING BUT
WE'RE DOING THE EVALUATION FOR
PURPOSE -- SO I MEAN I THINK
WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF TALKING TO
COUNTIES RIGHT NOW ABOUT WHAT
THE FUTURE HOLDS FOR THEM AND
SORT OF EVEN FOR THAT FOR THE
FAMILIES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
BEING HOUSE TRYING TO SEE IF
THERE'S OTHER RESOURCES IN THE
COMMUNITY FOR THE NEXT ROUND.
IF THEY'RE SOME OF THE OTHER
STATE FUNDING THAT THEY COULD BE --
CONNECTING THEM TO BUT WERE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT WITH WE TEND TO
DO A LOT OF PILOTS AROUND HERE
AND THEN SOME DAYS AFTER THE
PILOTS DONE WE JUST CONTINUE THE
PILOT AND LIKE WELL WE SHOULD BE
THEIR WORK SO MUCH TAKE IT THE
SCALE OR IT DOESN'T WORK.
SOMETHING ELSE RIGHT SO I
APPRECIATE THAT.
OBVIOUSLY VERY IMPORTANT TO GET
THE VALUATION DATA AND
APPRECIATE THE UPDATE ON THE
EVALUATION -- BUT I'M ALSO
THINKING LIKE OKAY.
CELLS THE END DON'T KNOW YET
BECAUSE VALUE WHICH HAS TO BE
COMPLETED BUT IF IT SOUNDS
PROMISING WE SHOULD BE STARTING
TO THINK ABOUT OKAY.
THE THINGS THAT SEEM TO BE
WORKING REALLY WELL HOW DO YOU
BRING THAT SCALE AND GET MORE
PEOPLE AND MORE RESOURCES -- THE
I'D START TO MAKE NOTE THAT --
IS YOU MENTION ON THE FEDERAL
LEVEL THE FAMILIES FIRST
PREVENTION SERVICES ACT YOU DID
MENTION WERE LOSING HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF FEDERAL FUNDING
POTENTIALLY - BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
LINED UP FOR THE DAY CARE THAT
RIGHT OR NOT.
YES I I THINK ULTIMATELY SO THE
THERE THERE ARE AT ACT ACT --
FEDERAL IS -- ACTIVITIES BY A
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES AND OTHERS
OTHER STATES TO LOOK AT OPTIONS
TO EXTEND THE WAIVER UNDER THE
CURRENT SITUATION WHAT -- WHAT I
WAS DESCRIBING IS THAT -- THERE
THAT SAYS COUNTIES ARE AT RISK
OF FOR LOSING SOME OF THE
FEDERAL FUNDS THAT THEY'RE
THEY'RE FEDERAL ALLOCATION WILL
WILL WILL WILL WILL DROP -- AS A
RESULT OF THE THE WAIVER AND
THAT KIND OF WHAT I WOULD ARGUE
THE DISAPPOINTMENT OF THE
FAMILIES FIRST ACT FOR WHAT THEY
HAPPEN TO BE.
HAPPEN TO BE DOING -- SO THERE
WE WE ARE SO DO WE HAVE A PLAN
FOR IF THAT HAPPENS I THE OF
REAL CERTAINLY LEASE HUNDREDS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN THE
SYSTEM.
AS A RESULT OF THAT EVERY.
THE READ.
ARE WE THINKING ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO ABOUT THAT OR DO YOU
SIMPLY SAY WHAT WE LOST A FEW
HUNDRED MILLION FEDERAL FUNDS
ARE WE GONNA TRY HAVE TO MAKE UP
SOME ATTITUDE RELY I'M JUST
TRYING.
TO I I HEARD THE LOSS OF HUNDRED
HAVE BEEN HERE PLAN ABOUT OKAY
WE'LL LOGIN DO ABOUT IT RIGHT
WITHOUT ZERO BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
SELL.
SPEAKING ABOUT OKAY WHAT WHAT
WHAT DO I NEED TO BE PUTTING A
MARKER ON JUST JUST RAISED FROM
FRANCE I THINK I JUST WANT.
TO TRY TO CLARIFY THAT WE'RE
TALKING AT THE THE END OF THE
TITLE FOR E. WAIVER RIGHT YEAH
ENDS I THINK OF CORRECT IT'S
COMMITTEE CORRECT OKAY IN IN THE
PARTS SEVEN COUNTIES -- COUNTY
TO PARTICIPATE IN AND AT THE
TIME KNEW THAT IT WAS A WAY FOR
OUR THAT IT'S BEEN EXTENDED A
FEW TIMES BY THE FENCE SO --
IT'S EIGHT EIGHT I GUESS THE THE
THE THE EASIEST WAY TO PUT IT IS
THAT COUNTIES HAVE BEEN AWARE
THAT THIS.
THAT THE THE AVAILABILITY OF THE
USE OF THE THAT OF THE TITLE FOR
YOU EVER FINDS -- WOULD END AT
SOME POINTS FOR THAT THEY SHOULD
BE IN THE PLANNING AHEAD TO KIND
OF ADDRESS.
HOW THEY WOULD -- HOW THAT GAP
THAT THEY COULD POTENTIALLY --
END UP -- MISSING OUT ON WOULD
WORK BUT I DON'T THINK THAT
THERE IS.
THAT THERE'S ANY SORT OF
ADDITIONAL PLAN BEYOND THAT AT
THE MOMENT SO I GUESS -- EVEN IF
YOU QUOTE NOW AND I APPRECIATE
PEOPLE KNOWING WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN
ADVANCE.
DID I FORGET THE HELPFUL.
THIS WEBSITE WE KNOW IS IF WE'RE
GONNA LOSE HUNDRED DALE I DON'T
KNOW HOW MANY HUNDRED MILLION
EVER.
LIKE AROUND THREE HUNDRED OKAY
SO MY GUESS IS THAT LOSS OF
THREE HUNDRED MILLION WHAT WE
SHOULD DO ABOUT IT NOW WE'LL
FIGURE OUT I HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
BUT LOST THREE HUNDRED MILLION
IS PROBABLY.
SOMETHING THAT IS NOT JUST GONNA
HAPPEN AND WITHOUT SOME
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT GREAT.
YES I WOULD SITES I WOULD I
WOULD SAY THIS THAT THE A AS
MISTER FREEZE SAID THIS WAS A
CHILD WELFARE WAIVER
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT.
THE THE THE HOPE I THINK FROM
THE STATES AND JURISDICTIONS
THAT DID THE DEMONSTRATION WAS
THEY WOULD DEMONSTRATE
ACTIVITIES THAT MADE SENSE AND
THOSE WOULD ULTIMATELY MAKE IT
INTO WHATEVER THE FINANCE REFORM
OR THE FEDERAL LAW CHANGE WOULD
BE.
WITH THAT DID NOT NECESSARILY
HAPPEN FOR US IN IN CALIFORNIA
ALL THE COUNTIES PER THE TERMS
AND CONDITIONS DO YOU HAVE A
FACE DOWN PLAN AND THINGS LIKE
THAT SO THEY'RE OF MECHANISMS IN
PLACE -- THE OVER THAT SO IS
THERE SO I I IMAGINE THAT I
CAN'T READ THE MIND OF THE SAID
BY A MANAGER THEY SAID OKAY --
WE GIVE THESE WAIVERS PEOPLE DO
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT WILL
DECIDE WHICH ONES WE THINK WORK
BEST WHETHER WE AGREE OR NOT
HERE BUT SO WE ASKING PEOPLE
THAT THEN TRY TO LINE UP WITH US.
SO THAT WE CASE WITH WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S CURRENTLY
PROPOSING OR IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT THE DEPARTMENT DOESN'T
AGREE WITH IN TERMS I'M JUST
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT LIKE WHERE
ARE WE SUPPOSED TO GO AFTER THE
WAIVERS -- COUPLE THINGS VOTE
WILL LIKELY WILL WILL IMPLEMENT
THE FEDERAL LAW IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THE WAIVER EXPIRES IN IT
BEFORE THAT -- CERTAINLY THE THE
THE WE CAN WORK WITH OUR COUNTY
COLLEAGUES AND OTHERS TO
IMPLEMENT THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE THROUGH.
THE THE PREVENTION PIECE IT'S
NOT EXACTLY WHAT THE THEY'RE
DOING FOR PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION NOW WOULD BE
DIFFERENT AND AS I SAID.
BECAUSE IT IS SO MUCH OF IT
COULD BE MEDI CAL --
REIMBURSABLE THERE'S A QUESTION
ABOUT HOW MUCH YOU CAN REALLY DO
YOU AND THEY WON'T THE AND WE
HAVE TO DETERMINE THAT MEDI CAL
COULDN'T DO SOMETHING BEFORE WE
COULD USE THE FORTY CLEARLY.
BUT THAT IT WILL BE USING THE
NEXT TWO YEARS OUR THAT'S OUR
TOP TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN
ADDITION TO BE LINING UP WHAT WE
NEED TO DO TO IMPLEMENT PART FOR
BECAUSE IT'S THE LAW.
WE WILL BE WORKING ON A WAYS TO
MATT TO TO LOOK AT BOB HOW
COLLUDED WITH SOME OF THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE CANDIDATES
AND THEIR FAMILIES GET SERVICES.
AND AT THE SAME TIME WE'VE BEEN
LOBBYING THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO EXPAND THE LIST -- WE HAVE.
MANY MANY STATES HAVE THAT THE
THAT WE KNOW THAT THE LIST OF
APPROVED PROGRAMS WILL IN FACT
GROW THERE ARE SOME VERY
SPECIFIC KINDS OF REQUIREMENTS
RELATE RELATED TO KIND OF
RESEARCH ASSOCIATED WITH THEM.
WHICH MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE
SEEN -- PROMISING OUTCOMES AND
TO DETERMINE IT TO TO MAKE THAT
LESS SO -- WE WILL BE DOING WHAT
WE CAN TO WORK WITH OUR COUNTY
COLLEGE TO MAXIMIZE WHATEVER WE
CAN FROM THE CURRENT THE NEW
FEDERAL LAW ALL RIGHT SO --
SINCE WE HAVE THE SELF WHEN
THINGS LET'S PUT A MARKER ON
THIS THAT DELVE INTO MORE DEEPLY
E. IS BECAUSE WE HAVE TWO YEARS
RIGHT HE SAID ROUGHLY CELL BY
NEXT YEAR WE DEFINITELY BETTER
HAVE A PRETTY GOOD IDEA.
IF THE SO THE THAT'S OUR
OFFICIALLY FOLLOW THIS OKAY.
ALL RIGHT NOW THANK YOU AND THAT
THEY REALIZE THAT YOU'RE WORKING
WITH IN THIS FEDERAL CONSTRUCT
TO SELL BUT DIED THINK WE WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT WHAT THE
PLAN IS FROM THE COUNTIES AND
WHAT.
THE STATE'S GOING TO DO.
AND WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO ABOUT
THE THE SITUATION YES.
I JUST WANNA TO AN ADULT SO THAT --
SOME OF THE FUNDING THERE WHERE
WE'RE DISCUSSING HERE SO SEATED --
IS PART OF THE THE PROGRAMS OR
YOU WENT REALIGNED IN THE TWO
THOUSAND OLYMPICS SAFETY
REALIGNMENT SO -- THERE ARE
THERE ARE FUNDS A COUNTIES TO
RECEIVE THROUGH THE LOCAL
REALIGNMENT FUNDS AND SO ON SO.
I THINK THAT THERE HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSIONS AND AND KIND OF TO
GIVE COUNTY NINETEEN THEY'RE
AWARE OF ALL THIS -- BUT WE JUST
ONE NOTE THAT -- THERE IS
CHALLENGES DICTATING WHAT COUNTY
STILL ISN'T EVERYTHING FALLS
INTO THAT PROPOSITION THEY'RE
ALL OF THIS IS I I THINK I THINK
IT'S HELPFUL I APPRECIATE YOU
SAYING I THINK IT'S HELPFUL JUST
KNOWING THAT THIS IS COMING
ONLINE TO MAP THIS OUT RIGHT SO
WHAT ARE.
COUNTIES PLANE TO DO WHAT WE
GOTTA DO IS A STATE AND SO FORTH
AND AND DELAWARE WHERE THE FED'S
RATE AND HOPEFULLY THE LIST IS A
LONGER AND OTHER TYPES OF THINGS
BUT I ALSO FEEL THAT WITH THREE
HUNDRED MILLION THAT.
COULD DEAL WHETHER IT'S GOING
AWAY OR YOU CAN GET A THROUGH
ANOTHER MECHANISM OR WHATEVER
ELSE WE JUST.
I THINK WE HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT.
IT WAS GOING -- TO HOW WE'RE
GOING.
TO HANDLE THIS AND DON'T
COUNTIES MAKE HAVE TO MAKE
DECISIONS ON THEIR OWN TO BE
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT WE WILL BE
MAKING DECISIONS RIGHT NOW THIS
IS A BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE CELL.
RESIDED I UNDERSTAND THE WHOLE
MAP AND IN THE END WE WOULD NEED
TO BE SURE THAT NOW THE KIDS ARE
TAKING CARE WHICH I KNOW
SOMETHING WE ALL SHARE SIDE.
AT THAT AT THIS OR FEEL LIKE I
SHARED THIS THING AND A NEED TO
HAVE A BETTER IDEA ABOUT WHAT'S
REALLY GOING ON RIGHT -- IN THE
SITUATION THAT MAYBE WE SHOULD
DELVE INTO A LITTLE MORE MAYBE
IT FOR HALF THE LA -- CAN HELP
OUT TOO OKAY YES.
FEATURE RINKER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT JUST TO ADD ON YOU
KNOW AS OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
INANCE INDICATED COUNTIES HAVE
BEEN AWARE THAT THIS IS IRVING
FOR A LONG TIME I I WANT YOU TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU HEAR FROM US.
WE'RE HEAVILY ENGAGED WITH OUR
SEVEN WAIVER COUNTIES RIGHT --
IN PLANNING FOR SUSTAINABILITY
AND WHAT TO DO AND WHAT NOT TO
DO MANY OF THEM ARE ALREADY
TAKING ACTIONS -- THE WAIVER
EXPIRES AT THE SEPTEMBER
THIRTIETH OF THIS YEAR -- SO
THEY'RE ALREADY MAKING THEIR
COUNTY BUDGETS FOR THE NEXT YEAR
IN PLANNING AHEAD FOR THAT -- WE
HAVE A LOT OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE NOT JUST FROM WITH IN
CALIFORNIA BUT OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA AS WELL HELPING US.
THINK THROUGH PLANNING AN
ALTERNATIVE FUND SOURCES -- IN
TWO THIRDS OF THAT IMPACT THAT
YOU JUST HEARD ABOUT IS JUST IN
LA COUNTY ALONE -- THEY'RE
THEY'RE ALSO LOOKING AT THEIR
REALIGN FUNDING BALANCES AND SO
I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT WE
HEAVILY ENGAGED IN OUR PLANNING
WITH COUNTIES.
AND EVERYBODY HAS A SHARED
INTEREST IN PROTECTING THE WELL
BEING OF SNOW AND JUST WANTED TO
SAY IT FOR THE ROUND I I
APPRECIATE IT AND AND SURE THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK GOING ON
IN IT AND I THINK IN OUR
OVERSIGHT ROLE HERE.
I AM I JUST FEEL LIKE I DON'T
HAVE I WOULD LIKE TO BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT'S GOING ON
BECAUSE I'M SURE PEOPLE ASK ME
EVENTUALLY.
AND SO WE DON'T REALLY HAVE AS
MUCH TIME RIGHT NOW TO GET INTO
THAT AND I WOULD ASK YOU TO
PREPARE ALL THAT STUFF THAT I
WANTED A MARKER.
FOR NEXT YEAR THAT -- WE MAY
WANNA SPEND JUST A LITTLE MORE
TIME AND GET LOW MORE FORMATION
ABOUT HOW THIS ALL MAPS OUTS AND
I I UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW THE
COUNTIES UNDERSTAND WHAT THE THE
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S SO IT'S ONE
FIGURE OUT LIKE WHAT'S OUR OUR
MAPS MOVING FORWARD AND WHAT
PEOPLE'S AT EXPECTING WHAT
PEOPLE PLANNING TO DO SO.
FROM THE FROM OVERSIGHT
PERSPECTIVE.
YEAH ABSOLUTELY WE'RE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE WHATEVER OKAY NECESSARY.
TO KEEP EVERYBODY FULLY INFORMED
OKAY I APPRECIATE THAT OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY SO WELL WHAT WE GO AHEAD
AND MOVE ON THEN -- HAVE NEXT
ISSUE [inaudible]
AS SO THE FUN PART IS IS YOU DO
SUCH IMPORTANT WORK THAT'S WITH
ASK ME QUESTIONS.
OKAY.
ISSUE NUMBER TWO B. C. P. OFFICE
OF FOSTER CARE OMBUDSMAN FOSTER
CHILD COMPLAINT INVESTIGATION.
A GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF MY NAME'S OUR
CHILDREN BURKE FOSTER CARE --
BUT THE PERSON -- THE OFFICE OF
THE FOSTER CARE BY THE PERSON
HAS BEEN IN EXISTENCE FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS -- BY STATUTES
PASSED IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
BY SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
USE CONNECTION MY OFFICE IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR RECEIVING --
INVESTIGATING IN INFORMALLY
RESOLVING COMPLAINTS ABOUT HOW
FAST YOUTH RIGHTS BEING VIOLATED
OR ANY CONCERNS RELATED TO CARE
PLACEMENT OR SERVICES.
WHERE AN IMPARTIAL AND
INDEPENDENT ENTITY THAT ENSURE
FAST YOU HAVE A PLACE TO VOICE
THEIR CONCERNS AND TO PROTECT
THEIR INTERESTS?
WE ALSO ACT AS A SYSTEM
ACCOUNTABILITY MECHANISM BY
PROVIDING SO -- RECOMMENDATIONS --
TO SAYS FOR SYSTEM WIDE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT BENEFIT
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES INVOLVED
IN CHILD WELFARE IN FOSTER CARE --
THE APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT SIX
MILLION OVER THE TWO YEAR OF
LIMITED TERM FUNDS WILL ALLOW
OUR OFFICE TO HIRE SIX
ADDITIONAL STAFF TO RESPOND TO
THE APPROXIMATELY TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND CALLS WE RECEIVE EACH
YEAR -- IT WILL ALSO ENSURE THAT
WE PROVIDE TIMELY RESPONSES AND
INVESTIGATIONS OF ABOUT SIX
THOUSAND NEW CASES EACH YEAR
IT'S ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED A MONTH --
AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE A BACKLOG
OF APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY CASES THAT HAVE BEEN
OPEN FOR MORE THAN NINETY DAYS --
WE ALSO PROVIDE ALMOST TO THE
APPROXIMATELY TWO THOUSAND
VERIFICATION LETTERS TO FORMER
FOSSE THAT ALLOW THEM TO ACCESS
FINANCIAL AID AND EDUCATION
BENEFITS -- AND LESS WE
DISSEMINATE INFORMATION ON COST
YOU THE RIGHTS TO FOSTER YOUTH
CARE GIVERS AND OTHER ADVOCATES.
WE'VE OPERATED -- THE OFFICE OF
AUSTIN CAMPUS PERSON FOR TWENTY
YEARS ON THE SAME -- RESOURCES
DESPITE -- NEW DEMANDS AND A
210015% INCREASE IN CALLS JUST
IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
THESE RESOURCES ARE ABSOLUTELY
CRUCIAL TO MAINTAIN THE
INTEGRITY OF THE OFFICE AND TO
PERFORM OUR STATUTORY FUNCTIONS --
IF WE DON'T GET THESE RESOURCES
I FOR THAT THERE WILL CONTINUE
TO BE A BACKLOG OF CASES -- THAT
OF RIGHTS VIOLATIONS AND
CONCERNS WILL REMAIN UNADDRESSED.
IN LEAVING IT CHILDREN IN UNSAFE
SITUATIONS ON THE INABILITY TO
MEET THE STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS
OF DISSEMINATING FALSE YOUTH --
ALSO PROVIDE -- IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE YOUTH ARE ALREADY ON
AWARE OF THEIR RIGHTS AND WE
NEED TO DO A BETTER JOB MAKING
SURE THEY UNDERSTAND THE THANK
YOU -- COMES FROM ILLEGAL
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
REMEMBER QUESTIONS YES CENTER
STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR THE PRESENTATION -- BUT WHAT
IS THE DEPARTMENT -- DOING TO
ADDRESS THE EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
COMPLAINTS OF MOTHER SEEMS LIKE
A LOT AND FIVE HUNDRED CASES --
AND DO YOU HAVE ANY ANY EVIDENCE
BASED PROGRAMS THAT YOU THINK
WILL OPEN BIG MITIGATE THE THE
COMPLAINTS OVER RECEIVING.
I DON'T KNOW THE EVIDENCE BASED
PROGRAMS WILL NECESSARILY
MITIGATE THE COME THE COMPLAINTS
RECEIVE MUCH OF WHAT WE DO IS A
LOT OF A CONFLICT MEDIATION
WE'RE WORKING TO CONNECT SOCIAL
WORKERS AND YOUNG PEOPLE IN
ADVOCATES AND ATTORNEYS TO
RESOLVE THE ISSUES.
I'M SO IT'S REALLY QUITE DYNAMIC
DEPENDING ON THE TYPES OF
COMPLAINTS WE GET WE ALSO WORK
CLOSELY WITH LICENSING TO ENSURE
THE THAT THERE ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM IS -- THERE TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS SO -- I THINK A LOT
OF THE WORK IS -- RELATED TO
JUST ENSURING THAT FOSS YOU'D
HAVE A VOICE THE PEOPLE
pRESPONDING TO THEIR CONCERNS AND
THAT THEY ARE IN SAFE AND
HEALTHY -- HOMES WHICH I DON'T
DISAGREE WITH A AND IF YOU IF
YOU LOOK AT TRENDS OVER THE SAY
THE PAST FIVE YEARS WOULD YOU
SAY THE NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS IS --
BIG COMMENSURATE WITH THE NUMBER
OF CASES THAT YOU OVERSEE
COLLECTIVELY OR WOULD YOU SAY
IT'S INCREASING OR DECREASING.
I THINK THAT.
THAT'S HARD TO TO TOTALLY ANSWER
WHAT WE DID DO IS -- IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE AND IMPLEMENTED A
NEW -- TOOK TELEPHONY -- A
PROGRAM THAT ALLOWS US TO ACTION
ACTUALLY COUNT OUR CALLS PRIOR
TO THAT IT WAS USING PAPER AND
PENS AND CHECKING HOW MANY BOXES --
A DATE OUR STAFF GOT -- AND WE
ALSO IMPLEMENTED A NEW CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM -- JUST THE IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN IN JULY TO
BETTER LOOK AT THE TRENDS AND TO
REALLY ASSESS -- EVENING WEAR
THESE GAPS ARE AND WHAT WE CAN
DO AS A SYSTEM TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES.
AND JUST QUICKLY -- WHO WHERE
MISS THESE CALLS COMING FROM?
OUR TEAM GIVE YOU A DESCRIPTION
WHERE THE CALLS ARE COMING FROM.
THE OTHER CALLS COME FROM A
VARIETY OF PLACES WE GET CALLS
FROM PARENTS WE GET CALLS FROM
CLASSES WE GET CALLS FROM
LAWYERS WE GET CALLS FROM YOUNG
PEOPLE -- FOSTER PARENTS SO
REALLY IT'S A DIVERSITY OF OF
CALLERS AND ARE CALLING OUR
OFFICE WITH COMPLAINTS.
AND I WOULD MAKE NOTE OF THESE
IN THE BUDGET PROPOSAL IT LOOKS
LIKE THE CASELOAD IS FAIRLY CUTS
AT LEAST THERE'S NOT DRAMATIC.
INCREASE OR DECREASE SO IT BUT
YOU DO KNOW THAT THERE'S A
RATHER LARGE INCREASE IN NUMBER
OF CALLS.
IS AT THE DO YOU KNOW WHAT THAT
MIGHT BE ATTRIBUTED.
TO OUR WELL I TELL IT SOUNDED
LIKE -- SO THERE'S TWO THINGS I
THINK THAT ARE A IN FACT IMPLY
ONE IS WE AS RICHELLE MENTION WE
WE COUNT BETTER NOW WE HAVE A
MECHANISM TO TO REALLY THAT'S
ALWAYS A GOOD THING CAL DEBT --
AND I ALSO FEEL LIKE AFTER
TWENTY YEARS OR EVEN A TWENTY
YEAR CELEBRATION FOLKS ARE MUCH
MORE AWARE OF THAT HAVE BECOME.
MORE AND MORE AWARE OF THE
OFFICE AS A RESOURCE OVER TIME
I'M NOT I'M NOT NECESSARY I I'M
NOT NECESSARILY SAYING THAT
THERE'S A INCREASED NUMBER OF
COMPLAINTS AS NECESSARILY.
A DECREASE IN THE QUALITY OF
CARE OR QUALITY QUALITY OF
PRACTICE MORE AS FOLKS KNOW THAT
IF THERE IS IF THERE'S A DISPUTE
OR SOME KIND OF ISSUE THAT NEEDS
TO BE RESOLVED THEY KNOW THERE
IS A PLACE TO GO. TO FOR THAT
KIND OF HEALTH OKAY ALL RIGHT
WELL CERTAINLY GREATER AWARENESS
THE THIS IS A GOOD THING SO BY
SIDE.
THE SHOW WE WERE LOOKING INTO
THAT BECAUSE OF CALLS GOING UP
IN CASE LOAD STABLE LIKE WHAT'S
GOING ON HERE SO IT.
WELL THEN THAT MEANS YOU GAINES
DOING GOOD JOB GETTING PEOPLE IN
THAT WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
AND PEOPLE FEEL YOU ARE USEFUL.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT -- OKAY ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS ALRIGHT.
LET'S MOVE ON AND ISSUE NUMBER
THREE PC PC TRAVEL COUNTY
ENGAGEMENT AN INDIAN CHILD
WELFARE ACT COMPLIANCE.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS HEATHER HOSLER AGAIN
THE DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
TRIBAL AFFAIRS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES -- I AM ALSO A MEMBER
OF THE WHO BUT TRIED LOCATED IN
HUMBOLDT COUNTY CALIFORNIA -- SO
TODAY I WANT TO GIVE YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND BECAUSE
THE OFFICE A TRIBAL AFFAIRS IS A
BRAND NEW PROGRAM THAT CDSS.
IT WAS THAT DEVELOPED IN JULY OF
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IF WE WAS
CREATED WITH MY APPOINTMENT TO
THE POST AND I WAS TASKED WITH
CREATING THIS NEW PROGRAM TO DO
BETTER ENGAGEMENT.
AND IN IMPACTS.
REVIEW OF THINGS THAT HAPPENED
THAT DSS NOT JUST IN CHILD
WELFARE BUT THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE DEPARTMENT.
PRIOR TO THIS POST I WAS THE
CHIEF DEPUTY TRAVEL ADVISOR FOR
GOVERNOR BROWN SO HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK AND TRAVEL
AFFAIRS THROUGHOUT THE AN EXACT
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
AND SO BROUGHT A LOT OF THIS
EXPERIENCE WITH TRIBAL
CONSULTATION AND A BETTER
ENGAGEMENT AND HOW TO WORK
THROUGH LOG JAMS THAT TRIBES
OFTEN FACE -- WORKING WITH THE
STATE WHAT'S COMPLEX ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL IS -- OR WITH THIS THAT
DEPARTMENT IN THIS RELATIONSHIP
BUILDING AS AT THE COUNTIES
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT OF COURSE
THEY DID IT THE INDIAN CHILD
WELFARE ACT.
AND SO WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
TODAY IS HOW DO WE DO BETTER
RELATIONSHIPS HOW DO WE AS THE
STATE PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND GUIDANCE TO THE
COUNTIES.
BUT ALSO CULTIVATE THAT
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE LOCAL
TRIBES A LOT OF THE A IT THE
REPORTS WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF THAT.
DISCUSSIONS WITH TRIBES HAVE
SAID WE WANT TO DO BETTER
COLLABORATION WITH THEM WE WANT
TO HELP THEM GET IT RIGHT IN THE
COUNTIES ARE SAYING WE NEED MORE
SUPPORT RESOURCES.
BUT PROVIDING THE GUIDANCE FROM
CDSS AT A HIGH LEVEL -- WILL
ACCOMPLISH SO MUCH AND SO WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT IS REALLY
LOCALIZING IN IMPLEMENTING THESE
POSITIONS REGIONALLY. TO SUPPORT
THOSE ACTIVITIES -- I THINK IT
WITH WHAT WHEN I CAME TO THE
DEPARTMENT THE RELATIONSHIPS
WERE STRAINED -- AND TRIBES ARE
SAYING HEY WE NEED SOME YOU KNOW
WE NEED MORE RESPONSE IN THAT
THE DEPARTMENT WAS.
VERY WELL INTENTIONED AND SAID
LET'S DEVELOP THIS OFFICER
TRIBAL AFFAIRS IN SO NOW.
WHEN THE LAST EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
MONTHS WE HAVE REALLY
DRAMATICALLY IMPROVE
RELATIONSHIPS WE'VE DEVELOPED A
MULTI AGENCY TRAVEL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THAT INCLUDES TRIBAL
LEADERS?
OTHER DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE FEDERAL AGENCIES AND OTHER
INTERESTED PARTIES TO MEET THREE
TIMES PER YEAR -- WE JUST HELD
OUR SECOND MEETING TO DISCUSS
THESE SORT OF ISSUES ARE THE
OTHER THING THAT WE'VE DONE IS
TRIBAL CONSULTATION.
AND SO WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF
THESE IN THESE ISSUES COME UP SO
WHAT WE HOPE THAT THIS WILL DO
IS REALLY TAKE THIS LIMITED TERM
FINDING. TO SEE IF THIS IS THE
RIGHT WAY TO GO ABOUT IT
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST EQUIP
HEELS AND ALL OF THE COUNTRY.
WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND NINE
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES AND SO THE
COORDINATION THROUGH ALL OF THAT
IS INTENSE AND THEN TO ADD TO
THAT.
THROUGH OF FORD HISTORICAL
FEDERAL POLICY THERE'S
RELOCATION CITIES WE HAVE A
LARGE NUMBER OF IT TRIBES TRIBAL
MEMBERS FROM OUT OF STATE SO
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING TO DO IS TO
REALLY LOCALIZE THE SUPPORT.
I THANK YOU -- COMES MILIEU.
FINANCE A QUESTION COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF THANK YOU IT'S A
FIFTY P. SHEET -- PARCELS OF
CERTAIN THE SOCIAL SERVICES
RECOGNIZING THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT.
PARDON AND AND I THINK -- WELL I
DON'T YOU YOU KNOW BY BETTER AND
I YOU KNOW UNFORTUNATELY --
MAYBE NOT TELL WILL FOR
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE PEOPLE
WORKING NOW BUT THERE'S
UNFORTUNATE HISTORY ALSO IN THE
PAST WITH TRIBES IN.
AND AND TROUBLED CHILDREN SO
APPRECIATE THAT WE'RE REACHING
OUT THAT WAY THANK YOU.
OKAY LET'S MOVE ON ISSUE NUMBER --
FOUR CWS RELATED HUMAN SERVICES
TECHNICAL BCP'S.
AND JUST BRIEFLY.
THANK YOU PETER FRANK AGAIN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT -- SPEAK TO ISSUE
ONE AND AT AT A DISCOUNT RATE
WAS SHELTERED TO TALK TO ISSUE
NUMBER.
TWO THE WELL BEING PROJECT THIS
IS THE FOR A WAIVER WE WERE JUST
TALKING ABOUT IT'S BEEN A MULTI
YEAR EFFORT IN CALIFORNIA --
WHILE THE WAIVER ITSELF EXPIRES
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH OF THIS YEAR
AS I MENTIONED THERE STILL IS TO
DO SO CONSIDER AMOUNT OF FISCAL
RECONCILIATION THAT HAS TO
HAPPEN ENDING.
INCLUSIVE OF CLOSING OUT OUR
EVALUATION OF THE WAIVER PROJECT
WE'RE SIMPLY ASKING THAT SOME
EXISTING POSITIONS BE CONTINUED
FOR TWO MORE YEARS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE SUCCESSFULLY CONCLUDE
THE WORK.
THE OTHER PART [inaudible]
IT'S OKAY.
ALL RIGHT GROW SEVEN YES OKAY
YEAH THAT'S FINE YEAH THAT'S THE
PROBLEM WITH CHOREOGRAPHY UPSET
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT OF ANY COMES FROM LA --
THAN ON THE THESE OKAY FINANCE.
ALL RIGHT OKAY SO -- WHAT WE DO
NOW IS ACTUALLY -- WE DO HAVE
SEVERAL PROPOSALS WERE
INVESTMENT BEFORE WE GET INTO
THOSE -- WERE THAT'S GO AHEAD
TAKE -- PUBLIC COMMENTS THEN ON
THE THIS SEGMENT OF THE FARM
SOCIAL SERVICES CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES SELF THERE'S PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS DEPARTMENT --
AND THE PC PROPOSALS UP PLEASE
COME OF THE MICROPHONE AGAIN ASK
THAT YOU INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND
TRY TO KEEP YOUR COMMENT TO THE
MINUTES OR LESS THANK YOU
WELCOME.
A SEDAN AND IF AND THE CHILDREN
NOW HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL STAFFING
FOR THE BUT THE OFFICE THEY
PERFORM A VITAL OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FUNCTION AND
ROCHELLE HER TEAM DO AN AWESOME
JOB.
WE'RE VERY THANKFUL TO HAVE THEM
SO WE SUPPORT THIS [inaudible]
WELCOME.
I ANNA JOHNSON FROM THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOU FLY IN SUPPORT OF
BOTH THE BUT ASK AND THE A C<c.cyan></c>
ASK -- THAT WERE HEARD TODAY ON
THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH
LAW WEBSITE KURT CHILD WHO'S
HERE IN THE OFFICE IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX WROTE A REPORT ON
BUZZ OFFICES ACROSS THE STATE
AND GAVE RECOMMENDATIONS THERE --
I YOU KNOW IT'S JUST VERY NEEDED
TO HAVE THIS KIND OF SPACE --
AND AND WORK WITH FOSTER USE ON
INVESTIGATION SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
KRISTIN POWER THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS WE ALL STORE
IN SUPPORT OF INCREASED FUNDING
FOR THE OFFICE OF THE BUT THE
PERSON AS WELL AS A QUICK
COMPLIANCE WE AGREE THAT THOSE
ARE.
NECESSARY ADDITIONS TO THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM.
THANK YOU.
BUT AS A HERNANDEZ WITH
CALIFORNIA'S CONNECTION AND
SUPPORT WITH THE ADDITIONAL
STAFF FOR THE FIRST CARE ****
OFFICE AND A QUOTE ASK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF JACQUI HUANG FROM
GRACE IN CAN AND CHILD POVERTY
ON THE ON BY THIS AND THE ECHO
ASK THANK YOU.
I'M NOT JACQUI.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME PRINTED AT NEW THE
CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER OF
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE TO I AM VERY
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE OMBUDSMAN'S
ASK AS ATTORNEYS FOR CHILDREN IN
THREE COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA WE
FREQUENTLY REFER CLIENTS TO THE
OMBUDSMAN'S OFFICE FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
FOR INFORMATION ABOUT HOW TO RE
ENTER FOSTER CARE FOR TONS OF
OTHER INFORMATION FOR OUR
LAWYERS SO IT'S A VERY GREAT
SERVICE THEY PROVIDE PLEASE --
OF THAT OUT HER REQUEST OKAY
THANK YOU.
WELCOME LILY COLBY ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA COURT APPOINTED
SPECIAL ADVOCATE ASSOCIATION WE
HAVE OVER SEVEN THOUSAND
VOLUNTEERS WORKING WITH OVER.
THIRTEEN THOUSAND FOSTER YOUTH
ACROSS THE STATE AND WE'RE
SUPPORTING THE UNDEAD'S PERSONS
ASK -- THIS IS A VITAL RESOURCE
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE AND THOSE WHO
SUPPORT THEM ACROSS THE STATE
AND WE WOULD LOVE TO SEE THIS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHEN MEASURE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES AND I'D LIKE.
TO OF BUT AS TO DIRECT MY
REMARKS TO THE TITLE FOR E.
SECTIONS OF THE F. P. S. A
IMPLEMENTATION.
OF THE ASSOCIATION IS VERY
INTERESTED IN WORKING WITH BOTH
THE COMMUNITY AND WITH THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES.
IN IMPLEMENTING THOSE BIT PARTS
OF UP FOR EASY THAT WARD
EXPANDED IS AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
ALLOW OUR OF SUBSTANCE USE
TREATMENT IN OF RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT PROGRAMS WHERE THERE
ARE WOMEN WITH THEIR CHILDREN
AND TO KEEP FAMILIES TOGETHER.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH BOTH THE COMMITTEE AND WITH
THE DEPARTMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GEN REX ROAD WITH CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CARE GIVERS
REPRESENTING -- FOSTER AND
RELATIVE CARE GIVERS WHO -- ARE
PLACING A LOT OF CALLS TO THE
EMBEDS PERSONS OFFICE AND FIND
THIS TO BE A VERY AND CRITICAL A
RESOURCE AND SERVICE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI GUYS ANDRE MINIMIZE MICHAEL --
PREVENTS HE'LL I'M --
REPRESENTING ALL THE YOU KNOW
FOSTER YOUTH AND SOMEONE CAN
COUNTY AND I JUST WANTED TO LET
YOU GUYS KNOW YOU KNOW I'M.
I'M GONNA SO MANY DIFFERENT
FOSTER HOMES GROUP HOME IN
LOCKDOWN INSTITUTIONS AND RIGHT
NOW I'M A FOSTER PARENT ACTUALLY
ADOPTED PARENTS.
YOU KNOW NOT SAYING -- BUT THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM FAILED ME
[inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
IN ALL THOSE HOMES IN AND NOT
PROVIDING YOU YOU KNOW TO BE
SELF SUFFICIENT YOU KNOW IF IT
WASN'T FOR FATHER'S FAMILIES OF
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY.
YOU KNOW I WOULDN'T BE THE
ADOPTIVE PARENTS ACTUALLY I'M A
SINGLE FATHER RAISING THREE
CHILDREN BY MYSELF ONE IS
ADOPTED.
BY LAW LIKE I SAID THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM FAILED MEANNESS
FEELING A LOT OF OTHER -- YOU
YOU KNOW YOUNG PEOPLE IN SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY -- AND YOU GUYS
SAID IT WAS CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION MONTH IN APRIL RIGHT
WITH THESE FACILITIES ARE STILL
OPEN AND THE CHILDREN ARE STILL
BEING ABUSED.
SELECT ABOUT IT [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FRANK
MCCOURT THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION SUPPORTING
THE BCP'S BOTH FOR THE OFFICE.
OF THE OMBUDSMAN AND EQUIP
COMPLIANCE AND WE VALUE THE WORK
THAT THOSE TWO OFFICES.
TO THANK YOU.
WELCOME BUDDY SANCHEZ ON BEHALF
OF SCA YOU CALIFORNIA -- WANT TO
EXPRESS APPRECIATION FOR THE
COMMITTEES WILLINGNESS TO DIG
DEEPER INTO TITLE FORTY WAIVER
CONCERNS WE ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED
BEING AWARE OF IT COMING IS VERY
DIFFERENT FROM BEING PREPARED
FOR IT COMING.
AND AS MISTER FRANK UP MENTIONED
TWO THIRDS OF THE THE FACT IS IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND THAT'S A
REALLY BIG HEAD SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL.
ON TO MAKE SURE THAT SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS CAN CONTINUE TO BE
PROVIDED. TO KIDS AS WE WIND OUR
WAY THROUGH THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
LUCY STILL FEEL CARTER WITH THE
YOUTH LAWCENTER WE WORK TO
TRANSFORM THE CHILD WELFARE AND
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEMS AND I
AM I WANT TO JUST EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT FOR THE INCREASE IN
BUDGET FOR THE ON BUT IT'S
PERSONS OFFICE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
HI CHRIS STONER MERTZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES ALSO SUPPORTIVE
OF THE OMBUDSMAN'S ASK AND ALSO
THE ATTENTION GIVEN TO THE
WAIVER -- THAT'S COMING UP WE WE
SIMILARLY WANT TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
KNOW WHAT'S COMING AND HOW TO
PLAN FOR IT.
THANKS I THANK YOU.
OKAY SEEN MILLER'S MICROPHONE
WHAT WE GET IS GOING HERE --
ESTE CLOSE PROPOSALS FIVE SO I
GUESS WE'LL IN THESE WILL NEED
SOME ROOM UP THE FRONT --
ACTUALLY ASK IF. ONE OF THE
SENIOR PEOPLE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT CAN KICK YEAH I CAN
JUST BE AT THE TABLE IN CSE
THEY HAVE ANY ANY COMMENT FROM
THE DEPARTMENT.
YOU GUYS CAN FIGURE OUT WHO.
ARE YOU CAN HAVE BOTH OF YOU SIT
UP HERE THAT'S FINE.
I WILL ASK MAYBE LA OVER FINANCE
JUST MOVE AROUND SO WE HAVE ROOM
UP FRONT SO [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE GONNA START
WITH THE FIRST PROPOSALS CHILD
WELFARE TRAINING SYSTEM OF
CALIFORNIA FOR DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION.
AND JUST AS A SOCIAL WORKERS AND
SEIU INTERNATIONAL -- WELCOME
AND YOU KNOW THE RULES THREE
MINUTES TOGETHER OKAY.
THANK YOU WELCOME THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FRANK MAKE WITH CWD
A ON BEHALF OF ANY AS W. S. YEAH
YOU.
WERE SEEKING TEN MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND FOR THE CHILD
OFFERS TRAINING SYSTEM IN ORDER
TO STRENGTHEN THE CAPACITY.
OF SOCIAL WORKER SUPERVISORS AND
MANAGERS TO EFFECTIVELY MEET THE
NEEDS OF KIDS AND FAMILIES.
WHEN LEVERAGE WITH FEDERAL
MATCHING FUNDS IT WOULD RESULT
IN TWENTY TWO MILLION ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS INTO THE INTO THE
TRAINING SYSTEM?
WHEN THE STATE REALIGNED THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR CHILD WELFARE
IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN TO
COUNTIES?
THE LEGISLATURE MADE A VERYINTENTIONAL DECISION NOT TO
REALIGN TRAINING.
I'M NOT FUNDING REMAIN THAT
RESPONSIBILITY REMAINS A STATE
RESPONSIBILITY.
IN PART TO ENSURE STATEWIDE
CONSISTENCY AND EXCELLENCE IN
TRAINING UNFORTUNATELY THE
SYSTEM WAS UNDERFUNDED IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN HAS REMAINED
RELATIVELY FLAT FUNDED SINCE
THAT TIME.
DESPITE INCREDIBLY SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES TO THE CHILD WELFARE
PROGRAM IN THE INTERVENING YEARS.
INCLUDING EXTENDED FOSTER CARE
C. SACK CHILD AND FAMILY TEAMING
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVALS.
ETCETERA.
THE STATE'S ALSO IN THE MIDDLE
OF IMPLEMENTING A FEDERALLY
REQUIRED -- FOR PROGRAM
IMPROVEMENT PLAN -- BASED ON A
FEDERAL REVIEW OVER CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM AND THAT.
PROGRAM IMPROVEMENT PLAN CALLS
FOR SIGNIFICANT INCREASES.
IN SERVICE DELIVERY IN
CALIFORNIA AND FAILURE TO MEET
THE PET PLAN COULD RESULT IN
PENALTIES OF APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS.
OUR PROPOSAL WOULD IMPROVE UPON
THE EXISTING TRAINING SYSTEM TO
BETTER MEET THAT THE NEEDS OF
KIDS AND FAMILIES AND A COUPLE
SIGNIFICANT WAYS.
I'M IT WOULD PROVIDE TRAINING
OUTSIDE OF THE CLASSROOM NOT
JUST INSIDE OF THE CLASSROOM.
IT WOULD PROVIDE TRAINING FOR
MORE ADVANCED AND SPECIALIZED
TYPES OF SERVICES FOR SPECIALTY
POPULATIONS.
IT WOULD PROVIDE TRAINING FOR
SUPER VISION AND NOT JUST FOR
LINE STAFF WHICH WE ON THOSE
CRITICAL TO THE OUTCOMES OF
KID'S -- AND IT WOULD AND
INVOLVE -- MEASURING THE
ACCOUNTABILITY OF WHETHER OR NOT
THE TRAINING IS IMPROVING THE
PRACTICE AND IT WOULD INCLUDE
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THAT TRAINING.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON A PORT
WITH THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT
OF HOUSING -- ALONG WITH -- ARE
CO SPONSORS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND HOUSING
CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE SEEKING TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND FOR
THE NEXT TWO BUDGET YEARS.
BOB FOR THE BRINGING FAMILIES
HOME PROGRAM AND THIS IS REALLY
JUST A PAUSE BECAUSE I THINK
YOU'RE.
YEAH THAT'S AN EXTRA FALLS ALL
RIGHT THIS IS THE NEXT ONE OKAY
SO MUCH HOLD ON THERE SO YOU'RE
DONE WITH THE FIRST ONE RIGHT
OKAY.
SO ANY COMMENTS FROM THE FAR
SOCIAL SERVICES.
NO I I THINK WE WOULD JUST
OBSERVE AND AND SHOULD BE SURE
MISTER MAC A SENTIMENT I THINK
EVERYTHING HE SETS FACTUALLY
ACCURATE WAS RETAINED AT THE
STATE FOR SPECIFIC REASONS THAT
HE THAT HE ENUMERATED -- IT WAS
LAST LEFT THAT WAY AND THERE'S A
LOT OF SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN THE
PROGRAM.
THAT SAID IT'S NOT INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AT THIS
POINT -- BUTI'VE NEVERHEARD
SOMEBODY SAY I'VE BEEN OVER
TRADE OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL AT IT
MAKE NOTE IS AT THIS POINT SO WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY IN MAY.
ALL RIGHT -- ACTUALLY COMING
FROM LA -- NO ALL RIGHT FINANCE.
TRY TO ASSIST WITH THE
MICROPHONE OVER THERE -- JUSTIN
PRAISE FROM FINANCE AND THINK
THAT ARE JUST BECAUSE FOR CLEAR
FOR ALL THE OBJECT PUZZLES THAT
WE DON'T HAVE A A POSITION ON
ANY OF THE PROPOSAL.
THE MINUTE SO THAT WAY WE CAN
CAN SIX TIME GOING FORWARD RIGHT
NOW I I RECOGNIZE THAT FINANCE
L..
COR SUPPORTS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL HAS NO CABINET BUT AT A
SAFETY IF THERE'S ANY COMMENT OR
OBSERVATION AND THE IT ALWAYS
IT'S ALWAYS HELPFUL SO IF YOU'D
THERE IS NONE THAT'S FINE.
TOO SO -- I'M NOT EXPECT THE
FINANCE TO SAY THAT -- WELL
ACTUALLY WE MADE A MISTAKE YOU
CAN SAY THAT AFTER MAY
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO I APPRECIATE THAT
OKAY -- ALL RIGHT -- SO THANK
YOU AND THEN LET'S MOVE ON TO
PROPOSAL NUMBER TWO SO SORRY TO
INTERRUPT US OKAY I'VE I
SHOULD'VE CLARIFIED I WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE NEXT -- ONE SO --
THIS REALLY IS A PROPOSAL AROUND
AS YOU MENTION I'M A SENATOR PAN --
SUSTAINING AND OF AND BRINGING A
LITTLE BIT MORE TO SCALE THE
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM --
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN C. S. H.
MY ORGANIZATION AND HOUSING
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATED FOR THE
CREATION F THIS PROGRAM -- AND
AT THAT WAS BASED ON NATIONAL
DATA REALLY SHOWING A VERY
STRONG LINK BETWEEN HOMELESSNESS
AND CHILD WELFARE TO INVOLVEMENT --
AT THAT TIME NATIONAL DATA
SHOWED ABOUT A THIRD OF CHILD
WELFARE INVOLVES FAMILIES HAD
BEEN HOMELESS.
EVEN MORE COMMON -- I HAVE THERE
IS A STRONG LINK BETWEEN
FAMILIES TRYING TO REUNIFY AND
THEIR EXPERIENCES OF
HOMELESSNESS AT VALLEY EVEN IF A
FAMILY HAS DONE EVERYTHING THAT
THEY CAN DO TO REUNIFY.
WITH THEIR CHILDREN -- THEY
CANNOT REUNIFY WITH THEIR KIDS
IF THEY DON'T HAVE A SAFE AND
STABLE HOME.
I'M SO THE BRING FAMILY HER
FAMILY'S HOME PROGRAM WAS
CREATED AS A DEMONSTRATION --
AND IT USES A HOUSING FIRST
MODEL AN EVIDENCE BASED
INTERVENTIONS THAT WE SEEN WORK
ACROSS THE COUNTRY FOR THIS
POPULATION.
COUNTY AGENCIES COLLABORATE TO
OFFER HOUSING SUPPORTS AND HELP
FAMILIES SUCCESSFULLY REUNIFY
AND OFTEN PREVENT REMOVALS --
FOR INTO FOSTER CARE.
AND AS YOU'VE HEARD -- EARLIER
TODAY MS SUTTON TALK ABOUT DSS
STATUS SINCE JULY TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE PROGRAM IS
PERMANENTLY HOUSE. FIVE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR FAMILIES WHICH HAS
SURPASSED THE LEGISLATURE'S
ORIGINAL GOAL FOR THIS PROGRAM
WHICH WAS HOUSING FIVE HUNDRED
FAMILIES OVER A LONGER PERIOD.
DURING THE COURSE OF THE
DEMONSTRATION WE'VE ALSO GAIN A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
EXTENT OF HOMELESSNESS
HOMELESSNESS AMONG CHILD WELFARE
INVOLVE FAMILIES ONE COUNTY FOR
EXAMPLE.
MATCH CHILD WELFARE -- DATA WITH
HOMELESS SYSTEM DATA AND FOUND
THAT ABOUT HALF OF THEIR
FAMILIES WERE HAD RECENT OR
CURRENT EPISODES OF HOMELESSNESS --
AS YOU HEARD TODAY FUNDING FOR
THIS PROGRAM IS SET TO EXPIRE ON
JUNE THIRTIETH.
AND GIVEN THE STRONG EARLY
SUCCESSES AND THE THE NEED TO
THEM SIGNIFICANT NEED OUT THERE
WERE REQUESTING -- ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM OF
TWENTY FIVE MILLION OVER THE
NEXT TWO FISCAL YEARS I'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWERING QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE.
I THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS FROM
THE FARM SOCIAL SERVICES.
I I'D ONLY REITERATE WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE ALLISON SAID EARLIER
IT'S OKAY PROMISING PROGRAM
INTENDED AS A PILOT AND I
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION ON
THAT ALEJO ANY COMMENTS NOW
FINANCE ACCOUNTS OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
ALL RIGHT -- NEXT IS THE
ELIMINATE BARRIERS FOR TO ENTER
OR RE ENTER ASCENDED FOSTER CARE.
AND THAT WE HAVE TWO PRESENTERS
OKAY.
AND IT AGAIN THREE MINUTES
TOGETHER SELF.
WELCOME.
THERE IS LOTS IS FOR BAY AREA
LEGAL AID.
OKAY [inaudible]
BETTER.
MY NAME'S ERIN PLUS YEARS I'M
FROM BAY AREA LEGAL AID -- AND
I'M HERE.
WITH A CLIENT MY CLIENT -- OR
IT'S A CYDIA WHO'S GOING TO
SPEAK TO THE IMPORTANCE OF
CLOSING THE GAP THIS IN THIS
PROPOSED BILL -- AND WE BELIEVE
PARTICULAR AFTER LISTENING TO
THIS MORNING AS A RATHER MODEST
PROPOSAL TO CLOSE A VERY
IMPORTANT GAP IN EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MARITZA
STUDIO I AM IN ON MINOR
DEPENDENT FROM CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY I'M HERE TO ASK YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVEN FOUR EIGHT I KNOW FROM
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE HOW
IMPORTANT TO SERVICES AND
OPPORTUNITIES OF EXTENT FOSTER
CARE CAN BE AND HOW HARD IT CAN
BE TO ACCESS THEM AFTER A
CERTAIN AGE.
I WAS RAISED BY MY GRANDPARENTS
STARTING WHEN I WAS AN INFANT.
MY FATHER IS A SABLE THERE WAS
NEVER ABLE TO CARE FOR HIMSELF
OR ME.
MY MOTHER CARE MY MOTHER COULD
NOT CARE FOR ME EITHER BECAUSE
SHE STRUGGLES A SERIOUS DRUG
ADDICTION.
WHEN I WAS SIXTEEN BOTH MY
GRANDPARENTS DIED WITHIN A FEW
MONTHS OF EACH OTHER IT WASN'T
LONG BEFORE I HAD NO PLACE TO GO?
I STARTED COUCH SURFING AND SICK
REACHING OUT FOR COMMUNITY
SERVICE PROVIDERS I WAS
SERIOUSLY DEPRESSED AFTER MY
GRANDPARENTS DIED IT WASN'T SURE
WHERE TO TURN.
BY THE TIME THE CFS SOCIAL
WORKER MET WITH ME AND ACTUALLY
EXPLAIN FOSTER CARE AND THE
SERVICE IS AVAILABLE I WAS ABOUT
SEVENTEEN AND A HALF.
THE SOCIAL WORKER TOLD ME THAT
BECAUSE I WAS SO CLOSE TO
EIGHTEEN THERE WAS NOTHING
ANYTHING CFS COULD DO FOR ME.
SHE TOLD ME THAT WOULD.
THAT THEY WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
COMPLETE THINGS IN COURT IN TIME
TO PROVIDE ME WITH ANY LONG TERM
HELP AND I DID NOT MAKE SENSE TO
ENTER FOSTER CARE FOR JUST A
SHORT TIME.
WITH WITHOUT OTHER OPTIONS I
CAPS COUCHSURFING AND WORKING
WITH SERVICE PROVIDERS THAT YOU
SELL TO SHELTERS. TO COME UP
WITH THE PLAN ONE OF THE SHELTER
WORKERS REFERRED ME TO A LAWYER
WHO WAS FINALLY ABLE TO ASSIST
ME WITH ACCESSING FOSTER CARE
SERVICES.
MY LAWYER COULD NOT GET A CFS
CASE TO COURT IN TIME EITHER.
BUT SHE FOUND AN OLD TRUANCY
CASE AND HAD A CONVERTED TO A
PETITION PETITION THAT ALLOWED
THE COURT TO PLACE ME IN FOSTER
CARE.
THE FACT IS I GOT LIKE YET THE
LAST MINUTE WORKING WITH MY
PROBATION OFFICER WHO HAS BEEN
REALLY SUPPORTIVE I'VE BEEN ABLE.
TO BENEFIT FROM CHANGES SIGNAL
HOUSING WAS FIRST PLACE FROM FOR
YOUTH I HAVE BEEN ABLE TO STAND
THERE PEEING KEEP WORKING
THROUGH THE LOSS OF MY
GRANDPARENTS AND MY FEELINGS
ABOUT MY PARENTS.
I AM CLOSE TO FINISHING HIGH
SCHOOL I HAVE A JOB AND I'M
TRYING TO SAVE SOME MONEY I AM
WORKING WITH PROVIDERS TO
COMPLETE COLLEGE APPLICATIONS
AND BELIEVE THAT COLLEGE IS A
REAL POSSIBILITY.
PERHAPS THE MOST PERHAPS THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING ABOUT
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE FOR ME IS I
WAS ABLE TO FIND PEOPLE WHO CARE
ABOUT ME AND THIS HAS MADE ME
ABLE TO CARE ABOUT MYSELF AGAIN.
WITHOUT THE SUPPORT I CURRENTLY
HAVE I BELIEVE I WOULD BE LIVING
IN A CAR OR WORSE I WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO CONTINUE
SCHOOL AND I KNOW I WOULD HAVE
LOST THE MOTIVATION TO WORK.
I AM SURE THAT COLLEGE WOULD NOT
EVEN BE ON MY MIND I AM ASKING
THAT YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL SO
THAT CHILD WELLS.
WELL FIRST AGENCIES ARE ABLE TO
HELP YOUNG PEOPLE LIKE ME AND SO
THAT OTHER YOUNG PEOPLE DON'T
LOSE HIM FOR IN A LIFE CHANGING
SUPPORT JUST BECAUSE OUR COURT.
CASES TAKE TOO LONG TO COMPLETE
THANK YOU.
DE RIGHT ON TIME.
I HAVE WHICH I CANNOT ALLOW THE
RULES ARE NO CLAPPING -- THERE
BUT IF YOU WISH TO EXPRESS YOUR
SUPPORT YOU CAN DO THIS.
GO WE GOT IT ALL RIGHT.
OKAY SO IT'S THE HOUSE RULES --
ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU ANY
COULD THAT COMES FROM THE PART
OF SOCIAL SERVICES AND ACCOUNTS.
OKAY DELEO COMMENTS FINANCE THE
COMMENTS ON THIS ONE OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING AND
PRESENTING THANK YOU.
RIGHT LET'S MOVE ON WE HAVE --
NUMBER FORCE HOUSING AND REALLY
SUPPORTS AND EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE PROGRAM WE HAVE SEVERAL.
SUPPORTERS OF THIS [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
KATHY SAID NEARLY MCDONNELL WITH
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION WORK BECAUSE BONTA
IN THIS HOUSE WITH US YEAH YOU
THE ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS.
CHILDREN NOW AND WORKING WITH
FIRST PLACE FOR USE YOUTH AND
GRACE AS WELL -- I'LL JUST DO A
QUICK OVERVIEW AND THEN PASS IT
TO OUR WITNESS WHO CAN EXPLAIN
MORE ABOUT HIS EXPERIENCE WITH
THE ISSUES THAT WERE RACING.
EXCEPT FOSTER CARE WAS ENACTED
AS YOU KNOW THREE A. B. TWELVE
IN TWENTY TEN AND THE RESEARCH
SO FAR HAS FOUND THAT IT HAS
NUMEROUS BENEFITS.
IF THE YOUTH WHO PARTICIPATED
AND THAT TAKE A RATE HAS BEEN
FAR MORE THAN WE EVER
ANTICIPATED.
ARE EXPERIENCING BETTER
EDUCATION HOUSING AND SOCIAL
SUPPORT OUTCOMES JUST ACROSS THE
BOARD.
THERE IS SOME UNFINISHED
BUSINESS AND THERE'S SOME GAPS
THAT WERE IDENTIFYING FIRST IS
RELATED TO THE CASE WORKERS WE
JUST DIDN'T REALIZE THAT THE
YOUTH WE NEED AS MUCH -- WORK
AND SOCIAL WORK AT SUPPORT AS
THEY REALLY DO NEED AND SO WE'RE
ASKING FOR THIRTY TWO POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS TO INCREASE CASE
WORKERS FOR OUR YOUTH.
THE OTHERS SIGNIFICANT AREA IS
WITH HOUSING AND WE'RE FINDING
THAT USE OUR COUCH SURFING THERE
TOO OFTEN HOMELESS.
I DON'T THINK IN TWENTY TEN WHEN
WE AND ACTED THE LAW WE REALIZE
HOW BAD THIS HOUSING CRISIS WAS
GOING TO GET AND ARE YOU THERE
JUST NOT PREPARED THEY'VE NOT
HAD.
TO NAVIGATE THIS SUMMER ASKING
FOR TEN POINT TWO MILLION FOR A
SYSTEM OF HOUSING NAVIGATORS OF
FUND OF TWO MILLION THAT WE
COULD USE TO DO THINGS LIKE PAY
FIRST AND LAST MONTH'S RENT AND
SECURITY DEPOSITS.
AND FOUR POINT TWO MILLION TO
HELP BUILD CAPACITY OF OUR
FOSTER CARE GIVERS TO BECOME
HOST FAMILIES FOR THESE YOUTH
AND GIVE THEM A PLACE TO LIVE.
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
ZACHARY -- CARSON AND HE WILL
SHARE SOME ABOUT HIS STORY AND
WHY THIS WOULD HELP HIM SO MUCH
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS A CARD
COURSING IN TODAY I WOULD LIKE
TO TELL YOU ABOUT SOME MY
EXPERIENCE IN CHALLENGES I FACE
ON THE ROAD TO INDEPENDENCE IN
ADULTHOOD.
BEFORE I TURNED EIGHTEEN I
DECIDED TO GO INTO A STANDARD
FOR SECURE SO I CAN GET THE
SUPPORT I NEEDED TO REACH MY
FULL POTENTIAL.
I'VE BEEN IN TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING WITH FIRST PLACE WE'VE
NOW FOR THREE YEARS AT FIRST
WITH YOU BY MY OWN APARTMENT THE
ROOMMATE WHO IS ALSO IN PROGRAM
AND I WAS SUPPORT TEAM WITH THE
YOUTH ADVOCATE IN IN EDUCATION
AND EMPLOYMENT SPECIALISTS.
GROWN UP THERE WERE AND ALWAYS
WILL BE UPS AND DOWNS FOR ME I'M
ENCOUNTER SOME CHALLENGES DURING
MY TIME IN PROGRAM.
THERE WAS A TIME IN MY LIFE WHEN
I GOT INVOLVED WITH THE WRONG
PEOPLE WHO WEREN'T A GOOD
INFLUENCE ON MY LIFE AND WE'RE
HELPING ME GROW.
I WAS LIVING IN OAKLAND A
PROGRAM THE FIRST PLACE AT TIMES
IN THE SITUATION THOUSAND WELL
WE'VE GOT TO THE POINT WHERE THE
COPS HAD TO BE INVOLVED AND I
WAS EVEN AT RISK OF GETTING
KICKED OUT OF MY PROGRAM AND
BEING OUT ON MY OWN.
MY YOUTH ADVOCATE DIDN'T GIVE UP
ON THE SUPER SO HARD FOR ME TO
BE ABLE TO STAY IN PROGRAM EVEN
THOUGH THERE HAVE BEEN INCIDENTS
WITH THE POLICE.
NOT ONLY DID SHE FAR FROM ME SHE
ALSO WE'RE GOING TO HELP
IDENTIFY THE ROOT OF THE PROBLEM
I HAD A HAND.
I MOVED TO AN APARTMENT ANY
OXTAIL A FIRST PLACE FOR YOU BUT
THAT WASN'T THE END OF MY
TROUBLES I WAS WORKING REALLY
HARD TO GET MY LIFE ON GOOD
TRACK WORK IN A JUMBA JUICE
MAKING A LOT OF PROGRESS TOWARDS
MODELS.
WITH SOME OF THE GUYS I KNEW
FROM OAKLAND FOUND ME AT MY JOB
I FOUND OUT WHERE I LIVED. TO
THE DANGERS INCIDENT AND COULD
HAVE GONE REALLY BAD IT WASN'T
SAFE FOR ME TO STAY IN ALSO
WASN'T SAY FROM MY ROOMMATE
BECAUSE THE GUYS TO SHOW UP AT
MY PLACE.
MY Y. A. M. I. E. WANTED ME TO
MOVE TO ANOTHER PLACE AND
CONQUER FOR SAFETY BUT IT.
COULDN'T BE READY RIGHT AWAY
THERE IS NO SHORT TERM PLACE FOR
ME GOING FOR ME TO GO BEING THAT
I WAS UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY
ONE THEY COULDN'T PUT A MINOR IN
A MOTEL ROOM SO I HAD TO CALL
AROUND AND FIND A FRIEND.
WHO HAD A COUCH I COULD CRASH ON
LOCALLY I FOUND SOMEONE?
THIS BUDGET REQUEST IS IMPORTANT
FOR YOUNG ADULTS UNDER TWENTY
ONE WHO NEED TEMPORARY SUPPORT.
STABILITY AND MORE SUPPORT
FINDING AND KEEPING HOUSING
APOLOGIZE YOUR THAT WE HAVE TO
WRAP UP SHORTLY SORRY THAT SHE
IS LAST COR.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THE SYSTEM
IS DESIGNED TO MAKE SURE THESE
BUMPS ALONG THE WAY DON'T BRING
EVERYTHING CRASHING DOWN AROUND
US THIS BUDGET REQUEST WILL HELP
BECAUSE IT WOULD HELP GIVE US
MORE TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX TO
HELP SOLVE PROBLEMS GET ON A
PATH TO PROGRESS.
EVEN THE HARD TIMES COME UP I
THINK FOR HIM TO BE EXTREMELY
ACTS FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND AND
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU I JUST SAID THAT THE
ATTACKING SO.
OKAY ANY.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE FARM
SOCIAL SERVICES.
NO NOTHING TO ADD AS WITH THE
LAST ITEM YOU DON'T COMPETE WITH
PEOPLE WHO HAVE LIVED EXPERIENCE
AND SHARE THEIR STORIES OKAY
APPRECIATED OKAY ELIO ANY
COMMENTS OF THE RATIONS FINANCE
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SIR PRESENTATION.
OKAY NEXT UP IS -- DRESSING
IMPACT OF STATEMENT A WAGE ON
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES WE HAVE.
SUPPORT BY SEVERAL ORGANIZATIONS
[inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible] THREE MINUTES.
OKAY.
HI THE HONORABLE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU I'M DOCTOR
LAURA FIND TIME CEO OF STAMFORD
THE SOLUTIONS HERE IN SACRAMENTO
WE SERVE OVER A THOUSAND
CHILDREN IN THIS REGION.
ANNUALLY.
WE OF ALL WE FOUNDED AS AN
ORPHANAGE IN NINETEEN HUNDRED
STANFORD HOME FOR CHILDREN AND
RECOGNIZE THAT EVERY CHILD TO
LIVE IN HOMES.
AND SO ARE CONTINUING CARE HAS
CHANGED TO SUPPORT YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE.
I AM SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES -- THIS
IS ACTUALLY A SIMPLE HER CLASS
IT IS -- I REQUEST TO STAY IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE MANDATED
MINIMUM WAGE LOSS.
AND I WILL EXPLAIN THE CONTEXT --
WE DEFINITELY -- ARE IN SUPPORT
OF ADEQUATE PAY FOR PEOPLE IN
OUR COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA.
THE STATE SET FFA RATES
CURRENTLY.
HAVE BEEN FROZEN SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ONE AND WERE CUT 10% IN
TWO THOUSAND NINE WE HAD A
SLIGHT INCREASE ABOUT THREE
YEARS AGO.
BUT NOT NEAR ENOUGH TO COVER THE
SOCIAL WORK COSTS THE SOCIAL
WORKER INCREASE COST OVER YEARS.
THE STATE LAW.
REQUIRES THAT EXAM PROFESSIONALS
WHICH ARE SOCIAL WORKERS MASTERS
LEVEL ARE PAID DOUBLE THE
MINIMUM WAGE.
AND WHILE THE MINIMUM WAGE ACT
MANDATES ANNUAL INCREASES
THERE'S NO MECHANISM FOR US TO
HAVE A RATE INCREASE ON A SOCIAL
WORKER.
HEY HOW DO WE KEEP UP WITH THE
MANDATES WITHOUT AN INCREASE.
IN OF DEVELOPED INTO THE
BUDGETING SYSTEM.
FFA RATES DO NOT CURRENTLY COVER
OUR COSTS FOR PAYING FOR SOCIAL
WORKERS -- WE HAVE TO MAINTAIN
THE RATIO REQUIREMENTS DICTATED
BY OUR REGULATIONS -- SO THERE'S
REALLY NO FLEXIBILITY AND FIND
THE MONEY ELSEWHERE -- FFA
SOCIAL WORKERS ARE CONSIDERED
PROFESSIONALS ARE ON CALL 247-2
SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES.
AND OUR FAMILIES PRIMARY
COMPLAINT IS SOCIAL WORKER
TURNOVER.
IT DISRUPTS OF PERMANENCY IT
DISRUPTS -- PLACEMENTS AND IT
IMPACTS THE USE THEMSELVES
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO RE ATTACH
WE CAN ACT WITH THE NEW SOCIAL
WORKER.
AT THE PHASER REALLY CAUGHT IN A
BETWEEN A ROCK AND A HARD PLACE
WE WANT TO PAY OUR SOCIAL
WORKERS.
AND YET WE DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO DO SO.
AT A PHASE ARE ALSO --
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IN THE WORK --
OF CCIR WE SURVIVE -- THIRTEEN
THOUSAND CHILDREN IN IN THE
STATE AND 25% OF ALL THE FOSTER
CARE CHILDREN.
USUALLY THE CHILDREN THAT
ABOUNDS HOME FROM HOME TO HOME
LIVED IN HUNGER CARE.
AND WHEN THEY LANGUISHING CONGER
CARRIED ACTUALLY COSTS A LOT
MORE FOR THEM.
WHEN WE WORK ON PERMANENCY WERE
ACTUALLY SUPPORTING -- A
REDUCTION IN COSTS OVERALL FOR
THE COST OF CARE OF A CHILD.
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT -- OUR
REQUESTS TO SPECIFICALLY IS
TWENTY SIX MILLION SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY NINE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE DOLLARS.
FOR TWO NINETEEN TWENTY AND THEN
AN ADJUSTMENT BASED ON THE CPI --
THEREAFTER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
FORMS SOCIAL SERVICE ANY COMMENT.
BUT I WE AGREE WITH EVERYTHING
THAT SHE SAID FACTUALLY IS THAT
IT'S AN IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
CARE FOR USE -- AS YOU'VE HEARD
US SAY ON MULTIPLE PROGRAMS --
THE ABILITY TO SERVE PEOPLE WELL
DEPENDS ON A STABLE COMPETENT
WORKFORCE AS WELL AND
PARTICULARLY WHEN DEALING WITH
YOUTH AND THE THE BENEFITS OF OF
STAYING CONNECTED WITH SERVICES
AND MAINTAINING RELATIONSHIPS IS
IMPORTANT.
AND APPRECIATED ALEJO
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
CAN EVEN NOW SO YEAH I AND THEY
DID IT AND JUST.
TO GET TO THE POINT THAT PART OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT.
YOU KNOW WE RAISE THE MINIMUM
WAGE FOR LIFE GOOD REASONS.
AND THERE'S ALSO A MINIMUM WAGE
FOR PROFESSIONAL THAT'S BASED ON
TWICE SO.
BASICALLY IT IS THE STATE POLICY
THAT'S DRIVING UP AND UP SO SIDE
FROM RECRUITMENT RETAIN AND ALL
THOSE ISSUES I MEAN -- AND WE
AND AND THE NEED OF THAT LEVEL
WHETHER EVEN THE PAYS ENOUGH FOR
THAT.
BUT THE D. VIOLATION THE LAW IF
YOU DID ACTUALLY INCREASE THE
SOCIAL WORKER PAY IN ADDITION
OKAY.
SO I MEAN THAT SOUNDS LIKE
SOMETHING WE SHOULD.
TRY TO BE SURE WE ADDRESS IT'S
OUR OWN POLICIES THAT ARE ALSO
DRIVING THAT UP OKAY.
RIGHT THANK YOU THESE RICH OKAY
ITEM NUMBER SIX CHILD WILL FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSING EARLY
INTERVENTION PILOT PROGRAM.
IN THIS AND YOU [inaudible]
HEY WELCOME. TO BOTH THREE
MINUTES OF YOUR BUT DOING THE
THREE DIVIDE UP TIME OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LIBBY
SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF US YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA I'M GONNA TO FOR MY
TIME TO OUR WITNESS DIAPERS
DIAPER STEWART A PH AN FROM LA
COUNTY I DID WANT TO JUST POINT
OUT IN RESPONSE TO A POINT YOU
MADE PREVIOUSLY REGARDING PILOT
PROJECTS AND NEEDING. TO MAKE
SURE THERE ARE MARK COME MARKER
OUTCOMES INCLUDED INTO ANY PILOT
WE'VE GOT SOME GREAT IDEAS
INCORPORATED INTO THIS.
ONE A GOOD MORNING DOCTOR PAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DEBORAH STUART AND I AM A MEMBER
OF SEIU LOCAL.
SEVEN TWO ONE I'VE BEEN A CHAO
WILL FOR SERVICES PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSE FOR TWENTY YEARS NOW.
AND PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES PERFORM
A WIDE ARRAY OF FUNCTIONS BUT
THOSE LIKE ME WORKING IN WHAT WE
CALL CHAO WILL FOR SERVICES.
THE PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES
ACCOMPANIED SOCIAL WORKERS ON
HOME VISITS WHERE CHILDREN ARE
NOT.
YET.
AT IN FOSTER CARE BUT AT RISK
FOR BEING PLACED IN FOSTER CARE.
SO THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY
ELEVEN THOUSAND CALLS THAT COME
IN LA COUNTY REPORTING THE
SUSPECTED CASES OF CHILD ABUSE
AND NEGLECT EVERY MONTH.
SO PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES DON'T GO
ON EVERY CALL THE RATHER THE
CALLS WITH THE CHILD WHEN A CALL
COMES THROUGH FROM A HOSPITAL OR
DOCTOR CLINIC.
A SOCIAL WORKER NGUYEN HAS BEEN
DETERMINED THAT A SUPPLEMENTAL
HEALTH EVALUATION ASSESSMENT HAS
TO BE MADE BY PUBLIC HEALTH
KNOWS AND IS VERY NECESSARY
WHILE WE DON'T GO ON EVERY CALL
WE DO MAKE AN ENORMOUS
DIFFERENCE.
IN THE CASES WE ARE CALLED OUT
ONE WE ASSESS EVERY TALENT THE
HOME.
NOT ONLY THE ONE THAT THE CALL
IS MADE FOR THAT IS THE FOCUS
TH<c.cyan> BUT FOR EVERY CHILD THAT</c>
IS ATTACHED TO THAT FAMILY.
AND BECAUSE OF OUR MEDICAL
TRAINING WE ARE ABLE TO OFTEN
NOTICE HEALTH AND BEHAVIOR
INDICATORS EVEN MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES THAT.
MIGHT OTHERWISE GO UNNOTICED
UNFORTUNATELY ON MANAGED HEALTH
CONDITIONS OFTEN RESULT IN
CHILDREN HAVE A TO BE REMOVED.
FROM THEIR HOMES IN PLACE INTO
THE CHAO WILL FOR SYSTEM
FORTUNATELY IT IS ALSO TRUE THAT
THE MORE HME IS A PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSE MAKE AN ARE ABLE TO GO ON
I WE ARE BETTER ABLE TO SERVE.
AND DETERMINE WHETHER THE KIDS
HEALTH THEIR MENTAL HEALTH THEIR
BEHAVIOR NUTRITIONAL NEEDS ARE
BEING MET AND CONNECT THESE KIDS
AND THEIR FAMILIES WITH THE
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES THEY NEED.
AND KEEP FAMILIES TOGETHER I'M
HERE TO ASK YOU FOR FUNDING IN
FUND DOLLARS WHICH WE BELIEVE
WILL BE MATCHED BY FEDERAL TITLE
NINETEEN DOLLARS SO THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSES.
ARE ABLE TO GO OUT ON ME ANYMORE
HOME VISITS AND THEN WE ARE
CURRENTLY ABLE TO DO.
DO REAL CAPPED -- STAFFING IN
CASELOAD ISSUES I'D LIKE TO ALSO
SHARE A STORY WITH YOU.
I RECENTLY WAS INVOLVED WITH THE
FAMILY THAT CAME IN ON A
REFERRAL WHERE THE CHILD WAS NOT
BEING SEEN.
WHEN I WENT T THE HOME THERE
WAS A FATHER WHO HAD RECENTLY?
COME OUT OF THE PRISON SYSTEM HE
HAD BEEN A HOUSE IN THE SYSTEM
FOR OVER.
SIXTEEN YEARS IN AND OUT AND THE
LAST STAND WAS.
LIKE SEVEN EIGHT YEARS HE HAD
NOT REALLY BEEN INVOLVED IN
THESE CHILDREN'S LIVES ALL
HOWEVER THE MOTHER WAS FACING
MULTIPLE DRUG ISSUES AND AT THAT
TIME.
SHE WAS INCARCERATED AND HEAR
THIS FATHER WAS LEFT WITH FIVE
BOYS ADHD N. FOR HEMOPHILIACS.
THERE WAS ALSO ANOTHER FATHER
THERE WHO DIDN'T HAVE DIDN'T
HAVE TO GET INVOLVED BUT WAS
THERE AND I WAS ABLE TO SUPPORT
THIS FAMILY GET THEM THE
SERVICES THAT THEY NEEDED.
AND JUST LINK THEM TO WHAT IS
DEFINITELY -- REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR OUR FAMILIES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES IN AND I'D LIKE TO
JUST REQUEST THAT -- A PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSES BE ABLE TO PLAY
THIS ROLE FOR MORE CHILDREN IN A
COMMUNITY CENTER AND COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THREE MUCH
ANY COMMENTS FROM DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES -- AGAIN YOU
YOU'VE HEARD OR DESCRIBE THE
VALUE.
ITEM THE SYSTEM DISAPPEARS TO BE
A FOLLOW ON TO RECENT
AUGMENTATIONS TO THE BUDGET OKAY
RIGHT BUDGETS.
HELLO COMMENTS FINANCE RIGHT
QUESTION COMMITTEE MEMBERS ISSA
THURSTONE THROUGH QUICKLY IS IS
THIS A A PILOT JUST FOR LA
COUNTY RECESS FOR OTHER COUNTIES
ARE GOING TO PARTICIPATE.
THE PILOT IS FOR LA COUNTY
HOWEVER WE'RE HOPE WE ARE REALLY
KNOWING THAT THIS WILL EXPAND TO
THE WHOLE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THERE PERHAPS WE CAN MAKE THE
PILE OF A LARGER RIVERSIDE NOT
TOO FAR AWAY.
I SEE SACRAMENTO'S ON THE FOUR
WAY THERE ISN'T.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION
CERTAINLY IS A PHYSICIAN I'VE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY GO WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES OUT INTO
THE FIELD AND AND THAT ACTUALLY
MADE IT OFF BUT PUBLIC OTHERS
ABLE ACCOMPLISH AND IS THIS
ABOUT PREVENTION.
AS WELL SO THANK YOU THANKS FOR
MATCH.
YOU.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN FOSTERING
SUCCESS SUPPORTING VULNERABLE
FOSTER AND CROSSOVER USE
NATIONAL CENTER OF FEW FLAW
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
OKAY THANK YOU.
MINUTES GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS FRANK IT WAS MINE I'M
AN ATTORNEY AT THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW ON OAKLAND.
AND I'M HERE TO SPEAK -- IN
SUPPORT O A ONE TIME BUDGET
ALLOCATION OF NINE MILLION
DOLLARS TO AUGMENT THE FOSTERING
SUCCESS FUND -- I'D LIKE TO JUST
ARE A BLESSING OF THE THE THIS
FUND WOULD.
OF FURTHER SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A COMMUNITY BASED
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WOULD --
HELP COORDINATE SERVICES -- AND
AN AGENCY PROGRAMS TO DIVERT
YOUTH AWAY FROM INCARCERATION
FOSTER YOUTH AWAY FROM
INCARCERATION AND SYSTEM
INVOLVEMENT.
PROVIDE TRAINING TO TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS AS WELL AS
A GROUP HOME AND SHELTER STAFF
WORKING WITH FOSTER YOUTH.
AND DELIVER TRAUMA INFORMED A
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
SERVICES IN THE COMMUNITIES
WHERE THESE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
RESIDING IN GROUP CARE.
AND I'D LIKE TO KNOW IS THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY BEGUN TO
MAKE A MOVE TOWARDS A PUBLIC
HEALTH APPROACH OF DEALING WITH
YOUNG PEOPLE IN NEED -- AS AS
NOTED LAST YEAR CALIFORNIA DID
MAKE A FOUR MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET ALLOCATION FOR THIS THIS
PROGRAM AND THIS -- PROGRAM IS
WELL UNDER WAY WITH CDC.
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES RELATING THE RFP
RECENTLY AND HAD A WEAPON ARE
FOR INTERESTED PARTIES WHICH
YIELDED. FOUR HUNDRED FORTY
PARTICIPANTS AND SO THE DEBT WE
KNOW THAT THE DEMAND IS IS IS
PRETTY GREAT AND UNFORTUNATELY.
THE FOUR MILLION DOLLARS THAT
WAS BUDGET LAST YEAR IS IS A IS
VERY HELPFUL BUT WOULD ONLY
COVER ABOUT ONE QUARTER OF THE
TOTAL NEED STATEWIDE.
THE COUNTIES REPRESENT ON THIS
COMMITTEE ALONE WOULD CONSUME
ALL OF THIS MONEY -- AND AS A
NOTED EARLIER AND AND OTHER --
CONVERSATION AT THE TABLE WE ARE
EXPERIENCING RECORD HIGH CALLS
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND CHILDREN FALL IN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM YOU KNOW HAVE
EXPERIENCED SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS
OF OF OF ABUSE AND NEGLECT IN
TRAUMA.
AND YOU KNOW THE VIEW IT
PARTICULAR THOUGH THE GROUP CARE
ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE TO TO
BEING PUT INTO THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT RELYING ON
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO DEAL WITH
THESE.
ADOLESCENT BEHAVIORS ARE ARE NOT
ONLY A WASTE OF OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT RESOURCES BUT ALSO
PUSH SYSTEM A KIDS INTO THE
SYSTEM AT A TIME WHEN THEY
REALLY NEED.
OUR HELP AND SUPPORT AND TO BE
SURE ENOUGH FOSTER YOUTH IN THE
STATE'S CARE SHOULD RECEIVE THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF CARE AND
SUPERVISION UNTIL THE RETURN TO
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
WHICH WE BELIEVE THIS FUND WILL
SUPPORT.
AND SO YOU KNOW WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS BUDGET IS BOTH SOCIALLY AND
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE BY REDUCING
OUR OVER RELIANCE ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND PRIORITIZING
COMMUNITY BASED.
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE AND
SERVICES FOR YOU VULNERABLE
YOUTH -- WILL ALSO BETTER
UTILIZING SCARCE LAW ENFORCEMENT
RESOURCES TO IMPROVE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND I'M ENTIRE
DRIVE ALL -- DEALER TO THIRTY
SECONDS.
WELL I JUST WANT TO REITERATE BY.
BRING IN THEORY TO PRACTICE.
I AM A FOSTER YOUTH I AM THIRTY
EIGHT YEARS OLD I'VE BEEN OUT ON
PRO SIX MONTHS AFTER BEING
SYSTEM IMPACTED.
I SPENT TWENTY YEARS IN PRISON
DUE TO MY TRAUMA MY I'LL CRY FOR
HELP.
BEING CRIMINALIZE SO WHAT
HAPPENS IS WHEN WE INTRODUCE
FOSS SO YOU SEE ANY KIND OF
CONTACT WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT WE
HAVE THE NUMBERS TO RECOGNIZE
THAT INCREASES THEIR CHANCES.
NOT FROM WRAPAROUND SERVERS ARE
CASE MANAGEMENT BUT FOR BEING
INTRODUCED TO DISCO TO PRISON
PIPELINE SOUL.
THE COMMON SENSE IS THERE WE
NEED TO ASK YOURSELF IN A
SOCIETY WHERE WE MAKE AN
INVESTMENT IN PRODUCTS TO MAKE
SURE THEIR PRODUCTS DON'T FEEL
WE NEED TO ALSO MAKE AN
INVESTMENT AND FOSTER YOU'VE TO
WHERE SHOULD I PAY DON'T THE
OTHERS WHERE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE RAIN HERE ANY COMMENTS FROM
PARTS OF SERVICES.
I REALLY CAN'T TELL YOU IS AS MR
ROSE SAID EARLIER ABOUT
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT
INVOLVEMENT WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS ANOTHER AREA WHERE FOSTER YOU
FLAG.
OUTCOME MEASURES RELATIVE TO ANY
OTHER GROUP THAT'S MEASURED AND
YOU'VE HEARD AS REFERENCE THAT
THERE WERE A NUMBER OF PLACES IN
YOUR AGENDA ALREADY TODAY WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WAYS TO
DECREASE THE USE OF OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AND FIND OTHER METHODS THAT CAN
BE MORE HELPFUL AND SUPPORTIVE
OKAY THANK YOU LA L. THE
COMMENTS FINANCE.
ALL RIGHT -- SAID SO THANK YOU
SO VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION IS THAT THIS IS THE
AUGMENTATION OF EXISTING PROGRAM
AND APPRECIATE -- IN YOUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU THANKS
MUCH THANK YOU.
OKAY AND FINALLY WE HAVE PARENTS
ANONYMOUS -- WELCOME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ZAHN OKAY
GOOD.
THANK YOU A CHAIRMAN PAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE. FOR
INVITING US HERE TODAY TO
ADVOCATE FOR A GOOD INVESTMENT
IN STRENGTHENING CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES WITH EVIDENCE BASED
PARENTS ANONYMOUS.
IT IS ACTUALLY THE FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY PARENTS -- IS THE
OLDEST CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION.
PROGRAM BORN IN CALIFORNIA.
I AM DOCTOR LEE SUPPLIER BERLIN
THE PRESIDENCY -- PARENTS
ANONYMOUS.
WE ALSO ARE THE ONLY EVIDENCE
BASED PARENT PARTNER PROGRAM --
AS HIGHLIGHTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
SPACE CLEARING HOUSE WE'RE
ASKING YOU TO INVEST FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS.
IN EVIDENCE BASED SERVICES TO
STRENGTHEN CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
WE HAVE TWENTY TWO MILLION
PERRANCE IN THE STATE.
SERVING IN RAISING NINE MILLION
CHILDREN.
WE'RE ASKING FOR TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
SUBSEQUENTLY ONE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR EVERY SUBSEQUENT NEAR TO
SUPPORT THE ONLY CALIFORNIA
PARENT HELPLINE.
THE PROVIDES VITAL EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT HELPS PEOPLE IN CRISIS
ALSO HELPS PEOPLE FIND SOLUTIONS
FOR THEIR MEDIA SITUATIONS AND
MOVE FORWARD TO REACH OUT AND
GET THE HELP THEY NED.
AS WELL AS THE EVIDENCE BASED ON
GOING CULTURE RESPONSIVE AND
COMMUNITY BASED SUPPORT GROUPS
TO RUN FOR ALL PARENTS CHILDREN
USE.
NO MATTER WHAT THEIR LIVING
SITUATION IS SO THEY COULD BE
THE ADOPTIVE PARENTS THEY COULD
BE THE BIRTH PARENTS TAKE A
GRANDMA RAISING CHILDREN.
PARENTS AND SCREWS OR WEEKLY
OTHER EVIDENCE SPACE WHERE THEY
SHOW THE SHOW THAT WE MITIGATE
THE IMPACT OF ACES SO IF YOU
BUILD THE RESILIENCY OF PARENTS
CHILDREN USE WE CAN THEN IMPACT
THE LONG TERM RESULTS OF BASIS.
WHICH IS AS WE KNOW ALL MAJOR
HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH AND RISKY
BEHAVIORS.
SO THEY'RE NOT DETERMINANT THEIR
PREDICTIVE AND WE KNOW HOW TO
MAKE AN IMPACT THAT'S WE WANT
YOU ALL TO INVEST IN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE LEFT YOU
A PACKET OF MATERIAL -- FOR YOUR
REVIEW THANK THANK THANK YOU SO
MUCH ANY COMMENTS FOR THE FARM
SOCIAL SERVICES.
NO PERHAPS JUST A GLOBAL
COMMENTATING ACROSS THE ISSUES
YOU JUST HEARD YOU'VE HEARD FROM
EVERY SINGLE PARTNER THAT HAS A
ROLE IN CHILD WELFARE SERVICES
COUNTY SOCIAL WORKERS PARENTS
THE YOUTH THEMSELVES.
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES EVERYBODY'S
GOT A VITAL ROLE AT THE END OF
THE DAY.
I THINK IT COMES DOWN -- TO A
QUESTION OF WHAT WE CAN AFFORD
AND AND WHERE WE THINK WE CAN
STRUCTURE THINGS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE GETTING WHAT WE THINK
WE SHOULD BE FOR THOSE
INVESTMENTS.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
AVAIL LOANS FINANCE OKAY WELL
THAT IS THE BUDGET PART OF THAT
PROCESS SO -- ANY QUESTIONS
MEMBERS OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION THANK YOU.
SO NOW WE'RE GONNA TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT WE HAVE.
EIGHT THE PROPOSALS SO -- ASKED
THAT -- PEOPLE CAN INDICATE
WHICH WHEN THEY LIKE.
LIKE MOST I SHOULD SAY AND YOU
HAVE -- ASK THAT YOU KEEP YOUR
REMARKS TWO MINUTE WE DID HERE
AGAIN PRESENTATIONS ON EACH OF
THE PROPOSALS.
ALL RIGHT -- SO WELCOME.
AFTERNOON MY KNEE CAM HEARTY
CAMPBELL REPRESENTING SACRAMENTO
COUNTY CHILD PROTECTIVE SERVICES
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE
CONTINUED FUNDING FOR THE
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM.
SINCE -- WE IMPLEMENTED THE
PROGRAM OR ONE OF THE TWELVE
COUNTIES WE HAVE ADDRESS THE
HOUSING NEEDS OF OVER NINETY
FAMILIES AND HAVE SEEN A HUGE
IMPACT AND IF I COULD JUST.
SHARE ONE QUICK EXAMPLE OF A
FATHER OF FOUR CHILDREN
RECEIVING REUNIFICATION SERVICES
AND PARTICIPATED IN SERVICES AND
WAS READY TO REUNIFY BUT FOR
HOUSING -- THE FATHER WAS
ENROLLED IN THE PROGRAM WE WERE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY HOUSING PRETTY
QUICKLY.
AND THAT THE CHILDREN WERE.
IMMEDIATELY STARTED DOING
EXTENDED VISITS AND RETURN TO
THE NEXT HEARING THAT'S FOR
CHILDREN OUT OF FOSTER CARE SO I
STRONGLY URGE YOU. TO CONTINUE
THAT THE FUNDING FOR THIS
PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
KATHLEEN DESIGNEE ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOU FIVE
WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF BOTH
THAT.
ELIMINATING BARRIERS TO REENTER
TO FOSTER CARE AS WELL AS THE
HOUSING SUPPORTS. FOR YOUTH AND
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE ALL TOO
OFTEN WE SEE THESE YOUTH WHO ARE
IN THE MOST CRITICAL POINTS MOST
VITAL POINTS FALLING THROUGH THE
CRACKS AND BELIEVE THAT THESE
WILL HELP SUPPORT THOSE YOUTH.
AND MEET THE STATE'S OBLIGATION
BOTH THE TACTICAL AND ITS LEGAL
OBLIGATION TO HOUSES YOUTH AND
TO SUPPORT AND CARE FOR THOSE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON JANE SCHROEDER
WITH FIRST PLACE FOR YOUTH WE
PROVIDE TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
SERVICES TO NON MINOR FOSTER
YOUTH IN SIX COUNTIES.
AND IN ADDITION TO THE ITEM FOR
HOUSING SUPPORT AND EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE WERE ALSO HERE TO
SUPPORT THE ITEM TO ELIMINATE
BARRIERS TO ENTRY AND REENTRY.
TO EXTENDED CARE AND THE
FOSTERING SUCCESS BUDGET ACTIVE
SUPPORT BONNEVILLE YOUTH THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SMITH
WEBSTER I'M ENOUGH OF A SOCIAL
WORKER HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
AND I JUST WANNA SHARE A QUICK --
CASE THAT I HAD I WENT AND
INTRODUCED MYSELF TO FOSTER YOU
AFTER INTRODUCED MYSELF HE
LOOKED ME DEAD IN THE EYE AND
SAID HOW SOON UNTIL YOU'RE GONE.
TO OUR YOUTH DESERVE MORE I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THE FAA -- SOCIAL
WORKER INCREASED.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM
SINCE ITS INCEPTION THEY'VE
ALREADY HAS SIXTY FAMILIES
UTILIZING THE FUNDING.
AS WELL AS THE SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF CHILD WELFARE
TRAINING.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS JENNIFER JOINER
I CAN AFFECT A SOCIAL WORKER FOR
ALMOST TEN YEARS.
I'VE NOTICED -- A LOT OF
TURNOVER IN THIS TIME AS ECHO
THROUGH ALL THAT EXPERIENCE AND
STORIES -- THE ROLE OF THE
SOCIAL WORKERS SO ESSENTIAL --
AND THE RETENTION -- AND
STABILITY IS ESSENTIAL AND
REALLY HELPING OUR YOUTH AND
FAMILIES TIME IN SUPPORT OF THAT
FATE ON MINIMUM WAGE INCREASE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS NATALIE LANDON
I HAVE BEEN AREA AS A SOCIAL
WORKER IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY FOR
THE PAST THREE YEARS.
AND I AS WELL HAVE SEEN HOW
TURNOVER CAN NEGATIVELY IMPACT
OUR YOUTH AND SO I AM IN SUPPORT
OF INCREASING THE F. OF A SOCIAL
WORKER WAGES WELL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
HELLO JULIE MCCORMICK FROM THE
CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER OF
CALIFORNIA OUT WE REPRESENT OVER
THIRTY FIVE CHILDREN IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEMS AND LOS
ANGELES.
SACRAMENTO AND PLASTER COUNTIES
MANY OF THESE PROPOSALS WILL
DIRECTLY IMPACT OUR CLIENTS AND
MUCH NEEDED WAY I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT OF THE BRING IN FAMILY
HOME.
A PROPOSAL THE ELIMINATING
BARRIERS TO ENTER AND REENTER
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE CHILDREN'S
LAWCENTER IS VERY HAPPY TO BE A
CO SPONSOR OF THAT BILL.
AS WELL AS THE HOUSING AND
RELATED SUPPORTS AN EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE PROGRAM THAT IS A
MUCH NEEDED ASSISTANCE TO OUR
YOUTH WE ARE ALSO SUPPORTING.
THE PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE A PILOT
PROGRAM AS WELL AS THE FOSTERING
SUCCESS THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI AM CRISTINA HERE FMFA SOCIAL
WORKER HERE IN SACRAMENTO --
I'VE WATCHED SIGNIFICANT
TURNOVER AND MY TIME AS A SOCIAL
WORKER -- THIS NOT ONLY IMPACTS --
THE SOCIAL WORKERS WHO REMAIN BY
INCREASING THE CASELOAD AND
OFFER LESS AFFECTED SERVICE BUT
ALSO AFFECTS ARE YOU -- ARE
BEING ABLE TO KEEP OUR RESOURCE
FAMILIES -- AND OUR BIRTH
FAMILIES SIMON SUPPORT OF
INCREASING THE WAGE FOR A SOCIAL
WORKERS THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS KEREN SECARA
METHOD A SOCIAL WORKER HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND I SUPPORT THAT
THE FAITHFUL SHORTER MINIMUM
WAGE INCREASE -- AS I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THE FOSTER YOUTH
THAT WE WORK WITH SHOULD FEEL
THE IMPACT OF THE HIGH TURNOVER
RATE THAT'S FFA SOCIAL WORKERS
TO GO THROUGH.
AND AS THIS ONLY CONTINUES TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE GRIEF AND LOSS
THAT FOSTER YOUTH EXPERIENCE
WHEN THEY ARE REMOVED FROM THE
HOME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
A HI MY NAME IS THE CARNAL MIND
AND I'M A SOCIAL WORKER IN TURN
IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE
ENTRIES -- FOR FFA SOCIAL WORKER
INCREASE AS WELL.
INCREASE AND I JUST WANTED TO
SAY LIKE I'M A PRODUCT OF MANY
OF THE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
MENTIONED HERE TODAY -- AND
WITHOUT THOSE SUPPORTS THAT ARE
IN PLACE TO HELP INDIVIDUALS --
IT'S A REALLY -- DIFFICULT
SITUATION AND I'LL BE GRADUATING
WITH MY MASTERS BECAUSE OF THE
HEART THE HELP AND SUPPORT THAT
I RECEIVED TO A LOT OF THESE
PROGRAMS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME MICHELIN KEIRAN AND I'M A
SENIOR PROTECTIVE SERVICE
WORKERS -- WITH SAN DIEGO COUNTY
CHAO WILL FOR SERVICES -- I CAME
HERE TODAY ON AS PART OF
THEOPHILE YOU I'M SORRY -- AND
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF BOMBS THE
TROUBLE FOR SERVICES FAMILY
URGENT RESPONSE SYSTEMS --
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL THE
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE AND THEN
ALSO THE LOS ANGELES PILOT FOR
THE PUBLIC HEALTH NERVOUS NURSES
PROGRAM -- I WORK PERSONALLY --
WITH OUR FAA -- STAFF EVERY
SINGLE DAY -- AND I AND I SEE
FIRSTHAND THE BACKLOG OF OF OF
OF OF THE APPROVAL PROCESS OF
RESOURCE FAMILY HOMES.
AND AND IT DOES CREATE A BARRIER
FOR CREATING STABILITY FOR
CHILDREN EVERY SINGLE DAY AND
AND WE DO SEE CHILDREN THAT GO
INTO DETENTION FACILITIES
TEMPORARILY -- BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO GET THOSE HOMES APPROVED
FAST ENOUGH AND THERE'S JUST NOT
ENOUGH WORKERS TO SUPPORT IT SO
I JUST -- JUST ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TO INCREASE THE FUNDING
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME SCOTT THE
MORE I'M HERE FROM THE COUNTY
SAN DIEGO I'M A PROTECTIVE
SERVICES WORKER.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE LA
COUNTY PILOT AND ALSO ON THE OF
CE FOR SECURE FUNDING
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS FRANCIS MARTINEZ
SAMA I SEE ARE YOU A UNION
MEMBER ALSO A A CPS SOCIAL
SERVICE WORKER FROM.
KERN COUNTY I'M HERE TO SUPPORT --
RESTORING AN INCREASE IN THE RFA --
BECAUSE I'M ALSO AN EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE SOCIAL SERVICE
WORKER WE FIND OUT SOME ARE USED
WHEN THE HAVE A STABLE RFA HOME
THAT CAN TRANSITION.
TO M. M. MISSED IN THE FOSTER
CARE IN THE SAME HOMES WITH THE
GREAT WE HAVE MORE ARE OF FACE
WE ARE MORE POTENTIAL HOMES.
WITH EXTEND THE FOSTER YOU ALSO
PROBATION USE.
ARM WHEN THEY ARE FINISHED OFF
THE RESTITUTION Là THEN WILL
TRANSFER OVER TO BE DEPENDENT ON
THE COUNTY SORT WEARING BILLS TO
PROP PUBLISHERS ARE INCREASING
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MONIES MARKET THE HARRIS I'M
A PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE I'VE BEEN
THERE FOR OVER TEN YEARS AB I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE CHAO
WE'RE FOR PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE
EARLY INTERVENTION PROGRAM.
I HAD A CHILD IT WAS WILL BE
SAID HAD A TRAIT THAT WASN'T
TAKEN CARE OF ONCE I WAS
INVOLVED THE CHILD WAS ABLE TO
GO BACK TO THE HOME SO WE HAVE.
THE BUDGET FOR THIS WE CAN
PREVENT CHILDREN FROM GOING INTO
FOSTER CARE EVEN TEMPORARILY
THANK YOU SHE JUST SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS
JESSICA -- ENDS AND I AM COMING
HERE -- TO SUPPORT THE MINIMUM
WAGE INCREASE INCREASE FOR AT
THE FACE SOCIAL WORKERS I'M A
MASTER'S LEVEL SOCIAL WORKER
I'VE BEEN IN FFA SOCIAL WORKER
FOR THE LAST SIX YEARS.
AND I JUST WANT TO REMIND YOU
THAT -- AT THE FACE SOCIAL
WORKERS ARE THE SOCIAL WORKERS
WHO ARE WORKING -- ONE ON ONE
WITH CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN WE WORK WITH
THEM DIRECTLY OFTENTIMES
MULTIPLE TIMES A WEEK -- A MESS
SO WE SEE A LOT OF TRAUMA A LOT
OF DIFFICULTIES -- BUT IN
ADDITION TO BEING A MASTER'S
LEVEL SOCIAL WORKER I'M ALSO ONE
OF THE VERY FEW -- FOSTER YOUTH
WHO WERE ABLE TO OBTAIN A
COLLEGE EDUCATION AND A MASTER'S
DEGREE SO I'VE SEEN FIRST HAND
DIRECTLY -- AT WHAT IT TAKES TO
SUPPORT THESE INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO
REMIND YOU THERE'S A LOT OF
RESEARCH THAT SHOWS THAT
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE DIRECT
EXPERIENCE IN CHILD WELFARE OR
WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED TRAUMA
THEMSELVES TEND TO COME BACK AND
WORK I THIS FIELD -- SO
SUPPORTING -- INDIVIDUALS LIKE
ME WHO LACKED A SUPPORT SYSTEM --
I THINK SHOULD BE A PRIORITY --
AND IN ADDITION I AM ENOUGH OF A
SOCIAL WORKER IN BUTTE COUNTY
MANY OF YOU KNOW.
SO YOU'RE BRINGING OVER TIME
OKAY VIEW COUNTY THIS YEAR --
WAS -- AT EXPERIENCED A MAJOR
NATURAL DISASTER SO IN OUR
COMMUNITY NOT ONLY ARE WE
DEALING WITH ISSUES OF TRAUMA
AND NEGLECT.
SUBSTANCE ABUSE THAT KIND OF
THING BUT ALSO THE TRAUMA
ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE KINDS OF
NATURAL DISASTERS WHICH WILL
ONLY SEE MORE OF AS TIME GOES ON
DUE TO GLOBAL WARMING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE THE CHALLENGES THAT
HAPPEN WITH ALL THE FIRES AND
AND THANK YOU WELCOME MY NAME IS
LEE CSE SO I'D AND I AM A
RESOURCE FAMILY IN REDDING
CALIFORNIA.
SO I HAVE TWELVE CHILDREN EIGHT
CHILDREN CURRENTLY IN MY HOME
FIVE OF WHICH ARE A OUR FOSTER
CHILDREN IN THE PROCESS OF
ADOPTING.
AND THE BEGINNING OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN HAD OUR FAMILY
REALLY HARD WITH THE LOSS OF OUR
SOCIAL WORKER WHO MY CHILDREN
HAVE ESTABLISH A STRONG BOND
WITH.
THE LOSS OF HER WAS BECAUSE SHE
COULD NOT SUSTAIN HER FAMILIES.
TO SUPPORT HER FAMILY WITH THE
WAGES THAT ARE BEING OFFERED.
I WAS SADDENED TO FIND THAT WHEN
I CALLED FOR UBER THAT SHE WAS
ACTUALLY THAT YOU PER DRIVER.
AND SO -- WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SUPPORTING THESE FFA SOCIAL
WORKERS.
WE DO HAVE TO INCREASE THEIR
WAGES MY CHILDREN NOW HAVE HAD
TO EXPERIENCE ANOTHER ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCE WHICH WE
LEARN AND TRAIN AND ARE TRAINED
ON THAT BASED ON THE FACT THAT
THEY HAVE LOST ANOTHER ADULT OUT
OF THEIR LIFE.
THAT THEY DID IT DEPENDENT SO
MUCH ON SO TODAY I'M ASKING.
FOR YOU TO SUPPORT AND TO PROVE
THAT IN THE FUTURE HOPEFULLY
SOON.
AND FUNDING FOR INCREASED WAGES
FOR OUR CITY SOCIAL WORKERS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS TWENTY THE VEGAS I
AM A PROTECTIVE SERVICES WORK
WAS SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND A
MEMBER OF SCA YOU IN HERE.
AND ASK YOU AND SUPPORT THAT
THIRTY TWO POINT NINE MILLION
FOR THE EXTENDED FOSTER CARE AND
FOR MORE CASE WORKERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU [inaudible]
HI WELCOME.
HI I'M VANESSA JOHNSON A PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSE I WORK IN LA COUNTY.
I WORK IN ONE OF THE MOST
EMPOWER WORKING FOR MY CORRIDOR
AND I'M HERE SUPPORT OF SEIU
SEVEN TO ONE I WORK IN ONE OF
THE MOST IMPOVERISHED AREAS IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
AND I DO WHAT CASES ALL THE TIME
WITH CHILDREN WOULD GO DEPRIVE.
THAT HAVE CEREBRAL PALSY THAT
ARE MALNOURISHED AND ONLY WEIGH
TWENTY POUNDS AND I THINK THAT
IF WE CAN GET IN AND INTERVENE
EARLY BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT OF
pTHAT ARE NOT ONLY IMPOVERISH
THEY'RE ACTUALLY GREAT THEIR
ACTUAL GRADE LEVEL IS LIKE SIX
GRADE OR LOWER SO I THINK IF WE
CAN GET IN.
AND DO -- BUT INTERVENTION FOR
THE FAMILY AND TEACH THEM.
BUT THINGS THAT THEY NEED TO DO
TO OF MEDICAL WISE IT WOULD BE
BEST FOR US AND I SUPPORT THE
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE PILOT
PROGRAM.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS PROBABLY AN
THAT
YEAH YOU AT LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
I'M HERE TO STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
CHILD WELFARE PUBLIC COLDNESS
EARLY INTERVENTION PROGRAM.
AND PART OF THE RAISES WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE CHILDREN
DON'T END UP BEING DETAINED
BECAUSE I WANT WHICH WOULD OF
WENT HOME OF PARENTS.
SO THE GOAL IS TO HAVE OF THEM
NOT BECOME DETAINED TO BEGIN
WITH AND THEN ALSO WE DON'T WANT
TO LOSE LIVES.
SUCH STRONG SUPPORT THE
INTERVENTION PROGRAM THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER SMITH AND
I'M A CHILD WELFARE PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSE IN LA COUNTY AND I
WORK IN THE ANTELOPE VALLEY
SWITCHER SOME OF THE POOREST
PARTS OF LA COUNTY AND ALSO IN
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY.
AND PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES WHEN WE
GO INTO A HOME WE PROVIDE A MUCH
DIFFERENT SPUR PERSPECTIVE THE
NIGHT OF SOCIAL WORK IT COMES
FROM ABOUT GOING TO PREVENTION
AND EDUCATION.
AND SO BY BEING ABLE TO GO INTO
THE HOME WHERE SOCIAL WORKER
MIGHT CHECK IS THEIR FOOD IN
THIS HOME A NURSE CAN SEE YES
THERE'S FOOD BUT IS IS THE
PROPER DIET FOR THE CHILD'S
MEDICAL CONDITION.
SO IT'S A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT WAY
OF LOOKING AT THINGS AND THAT'S
WHAT ALLOWS US TO PROVIDE THE
EDUCATION TO THE PARENTS SO THAT
WE WE CAN KEEP THESE CHILDREN IN
THE HOME AND KEEP THEM OUT OF
FOSTER CARE.
AND IN SUPPORT OF THIS PILOT
PROJECT I REALLY THINK THAT
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO SEE DATA SINCE
LA COUNTY IS SO LARGE IT HAS
MANY DIFFERENT TYPES OF AREAS IN
IT.
THAT YOU CAN TAKE THIS DATA AND
MAKE THIS INTO A STATE RIGHT
PROGRAM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THAT AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TONY
ENDS ON WHILE I AM IN A SEE I
USE SEVEN TO ONE MEMBER.
AND A PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE FROM
LOS ANGELES COUNTY I IF
FERVENTLY FERVENTLY SUPPORTS THE
P. H. AND PART PROGRAM IN LA
COUNTY AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE
IF IT WORKS -- HOPEFULLY WILL GO
WITH IT -- JUST TAKE AWAY MORE
OF US WE HAVE MORE WE WORK WE
CAN DO FOR THE KIDS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BRIAN AND AND CEO ADMINISTRATOR
FOR TRANSITIONS CHILDREN'S
SERVICES OR A FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCY AND FRESNO SERVING FRESNO
MADERA KINGS AND TULARE COUNTIES.
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR OF HIS
SOCIAL WORKER SALARIES -- SINCE
JANUARY WE LOST FOUR OF HIS
SOCIAL WORKERS ALL TO HIGHER
PAYING POSITIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
YOU MY NAME IS CAROLINE METERS I
AM THE CHIEF PROGRAMME OFFICER
FOR LEYVA FAMILIES WE SERVE
LOCALLY OVER TWO HUNDRED
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE.
BEEN IN THIS FIELD IN THE FFA
FEEL FOR TWENTY FOUR YEARS HAVE
NEVER EXPERIENCED SUCH RETENTION
ISSUES WITH OUR OUR SOCIAL
WORKERS -- WE ARE CRITICAL PIECE
OF THE SEC OUR VISION.
AND MISSION -- WHAT OUR PARTNER
FOR THE SOCIAL IMPACT OUR PERMIT
SIERRA OUTCOMES ARE INCREDIBLE
AND I AM HERE? TO STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE INCREASE FOR OUR FFA
SOCIAL WORKERS THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
WELCOME.
MY NAME IS KEVIN CLARK I'M A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AS WELL AS
THE STUDENTS IN THE SCHOOL
SOCIAL WELFARE UC BERKELEY.
I'M HERE SUPPORT -- THE FFA
SOCIAL WORKER INCREASE THE
GROOVY GREATS IF WE CAN ENSURE
THAT SOCIAL WORKERS MAKE THEIR
ENDS MEET WHILE ALSO PROVIDING
FOR THEIR WELL BEING AND SAFETY
OF CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME I AM SHAUN HUGHES I LIVE
IN NAPA COUNTY I'M HERE ALSO FOR
THAT THE FACE SOCIAL WORKER
INCREASE -- BECAUSE HAVING A
HIGH QUALITY WORKFORCE THE KEY
TO MAKING SEE SEE OUR WORK
THANKS THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
A C. THAT ARE MEANT TO HEAR MY
CAPACITY AS A BOARD MEMBER WITH
HILL SITES -- GREATER LOS
ANGELES SERVICE PROVIDER IN
SUPPORT OF THE TWENTY SIX POINT
SEVEN MILLION FFA SOCIAL WORKER
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASE BECAUSE
OUR SOCIAL WORKERS DESERVE
ADEQUATE PAY. TO PROVIDE
ADEQUATE CARE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS AMY HEILEMAN I
AM THE DIRECTOR OF FOSTER CARE
AND ADOPTION WITH CHILDREN ZERO
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE SERVE
THROUGH OUR FFA THE COUNTIES OF
LOS ANGELES RIVERSIDE SAN
BERNADINO AN ORANGE COUNTY.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE FFA
SOCIAL WORKER INCREASE -- BY
BEEN IN FFA SERVICES SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ONE OF THE BIG PASSION
OF MINE AND IT'S REALLY HARD TO
SEE HOW MANY OF THEM ARE HOW
MANY OF OUR WORKERS.
ARE ABLE TO SUSTAIN THEMSELVES
AND LEAVE AND TO SEE ALL THE
TRAUMA THAT IS CREATED FOR OUR
CHILDREN -- AND THAT IT'S REALLY
HURTING OUR OUR ABILITY TO HAVE
SAFETY WELL BEING AND PREGNANCY
OUTCOMES THINKING THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS CINDY MUST SEE US
AND I AM HERE TO SUPPORT THE
WAGE INCREASE FOR FOSTER CARE
SOCIAL WORKERS -- OUR KIDS NEED
QUALITY SOCIAL WORKERS AND RIGHT
NOW WE'RE LOSING THEM TO OTHER
JOBS THEY HAVE ENOUGH --
OFTENTIMES ARE TAKING CONTRACT
WORK TO MAKE UP FOR WHAT THEY'RE
NOT MAKING IN FOSTER CARE -- AND
AGAIN I THINK WHAT IT COMES DOWN
TO IS THE WELL BEING OF OUR KIDS
IN FOSTER CARE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
I'D UPPER TRICIA GISH SENECA
FAMILY OF AGENCIES OR A
STATEWIDE PROVIDER CHILDREN
SERVICES.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE FOSTER
CARE SOCIAL WORKER WAGE INCREASE.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME EVERY CHURCH ST WITH
QUEEN ANNE OF FAMILY SERVICES
AND WE EMPLOYEE OVER EIGHTY SIX
SOCIAL WORKERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND I AM HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE FUNDING TO INCREASE
SOCIAL WORK WAGES FOR AFFECT ACE.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME HI GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
STACY ROTH IN THE C. O. O. IT
HEALTH SITES IN PASADENA WE
SERVE OVER SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
CHILDREN YOUTH AND FAMILY WITHIN
LA AND SAN BERNARDINO COUNTIES.
I THINK WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
IS THE STATE A LOT OF TIME AND
MONEY ON C. C. R. C. C. R. AND
WE NEED TO SET IT UP. TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND BY SUPPORTING THE
INCREASE FOR FOSTER CARE SOCIAL
WORKERS WILL ALSO HELP ENSURE
THE SUCCESS OF CCIR.
GRAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
BUT AFTERNOON MY NAME IS YURI
CAMARA FROM SACRAMENTO ON THE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR OVERSEEING A OF
FOSTER CARE PROGRAM AND WE HAVE
SEEN A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
TURNOVER OVER THE LAST. TEN
YEARS.
IN OUR PROGRAMS AND WHILE WE ARE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE -- PASSIONATE
DEDICATED HARDWORKING SOCIAL
WORKERS SUPPORT OUR KIDS AND
FAMILIES AND OUR FAMILIES
REGULARLY IDENTIFIED -- THEIR
pWORKERS THE REASON WHY THEY'RE
SATISFIED AND THEY CONTINUE TO
FOSTER -- WE HAVE SEEN THE
NEGATIVE IMPACT OF SOCIAL
WORKERS WHO ARE UNABLE TO STAY
UP.
BECAUSE OF THE SELLERS SOCIAL
WORKER STABILITY AS WE'VE SAID
IS LINKED TO THE STABILITY OF
FAMILIES AND USE AND CARE AND SO
I SUPPORT THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO ADDRESS THE IMPACT OF MINIMUM
WAGE LAWS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI I'M LIZ HE MENACE -- DIRECTOR
OF AN INTENSIVE SERVICES FOSTER
CARE PROGRAM IN CINEMA COUNTY.
INTENT OF SERVICES FOSTER CARE
IS ONE OF THE FOUNDATIONS OF THE
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION OF
CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM.
I HAVE ONE AYE SFC FAMILY THAT
WE'VE WORKED WITH FOR ONE YEAR
ANDIN THE COURSE OF THAT YEAR
WE HAVE HAD TO ASSIGN FIVE
DIFFERENT.
SOCIAL WORKERS TO THAT FAMILY
THREE OF THE FOUR WHO LEFT LEFT
TO DO SPECIFICALLY TO LOW WAGE.
SO THIS IS A CRITICAL THAT WE
INCREASE THE FUNDING SO THAT
FOSTER CARE AGENCIES CAN PAY
THEIR SOCIAL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME SEASON FREDDIE AND
I AM THE CEO OF TLC CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES AND I AM HERE TO
SUPPORT THE INCREASE IN FFA
SOCIAL WORKERS.
AB IT'S BEEN YEARS NOW I MEAN IT
WAS SAID BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
AND ONE THAT THIS HOUSE IS
NEEDED TO BE FIXED AND IT HASN'T
BEEN WE'VE HAD TROUBLE
RECRUITING AND MAINTAINING
QUALITY MASTERS LEVEL SOCIAL
WORKERS FOR YEARS NOW.
BUT THE ROBBERS PRETTY MUCH HIT
THE ROAD WE HAVE A STATE MANDATE
NOW AND WE REALLY NEED YOUR HELP
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO LOOK AT THE
SERIOUSLY.
SEE SEE OUR NEEDS TO WORK AND
OUR ATTENTION AND TIMES GOT TO
BE ON GETTING FAMILIES AND
WORKING WITH CHILDREN AND NOT
WORRYING ABOUT IF WE'RE GONNA BE
ABLE TO MAINTAIN SOCIAL WORKERS
TO DO THE WORK.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME SENATORS AT CHAMBERLAIN
CEO OF ALTERNATIVE FAMILY
SERVICES TO MY KNOWLEDGE
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST.
AND MOST EXPERIENCED FOSTER
FAMILY AGENCY I WANT TO POINT
OUT TO ASPECTS OF THE MINIMUM
WAGE ISSUE FOR SOCIAL WORKERS
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN ADDRESSED.
SO FAR ONE HAS TO DO WITH SYSTEM
CAPACITY.
CENTERS YOU MAY NOT BE AWARE BUT
I'M SURE THE DEPARTMENT WILL
CONFIRM THAT.
PLAIN DISCUSSIONS ARE HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW 480-0 CHILDREN WHO ARE
GROUP HOMES THAT MIGHT NOT MAKE
THE OR IF A CUT. TWO UNDER THE
REGULATIONS FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCIES ARE PART OF THE
SOLUTION FOR THOSE EIGHT HUNDRED
KIDS THIS -- WOULD HAVE A
DEVASTATING EFFECT ON SYSTEM
CAPACITY.
IF YOU DON'T IF YOU DON'T
ADDRESS THE THE WAGE ISSUE THE
OTHER IS -- CENTER QUITE WHAT
YOU JUST SAID THAT THE THIS IS A
DRIVEN ENTIRELY BY STATE POLICY
AND I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LEGAL LIABILITIES.
OF WHAT IS MY TORT LIABILITY
RISK IF AN EMPLOYEE SUES ME
BECAUSE I'M NOT FOLLOWING THE
LAW.
PAYING TWICE THE MINIMUM WAGE
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO DO THAT.
SO THERE IS A AND AND AND THAT --
LIABILITY COULD VERY WELL TAXES
STATE AS WELL RUNNING THE SYSTEM
IN A TO POINT FUNDS THANKS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME HELLO MY NAME IS
CHURCHES THE INFORMALITY OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILY SERVICES --
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICE SHOWS
THAT HEALING HAPPENS IN THE
CONTEXT OF A HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIP WE CAN PROVIDE THIS
TO OUR CHILDREN DUE TO STRESS TO
UNDERPAID AT THAT THEY WORKERS
WITH HIGH CASELOADS AN AROUND
THE CLOCK CRISIS WORK.
IF WE SAY WE WANT STABILITY FOR
CHILDREN AND WE NEED TO SHOW
THEM WHAT STABILITY LOOKS LIKE.
WE HAVE WONDERFUL WORKERS IN
THIS FIELD THAT HAD THE HARD TO
DO THE WORK THEY DO BUT CAN'T
CONTINUE TO DO THIS IF WE DON'T
PROVIDE THEM AND RESPECT THEM
FOR THE IMPACT THEY HAVE NOT
ONLY FOR THE INDIVIDUAL CHILDREN.
BUT FOR GENERATIONS TO COME
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI I'M DIVERSE SIMPSON AND I AM
A FOSTER PARENT.
HERE IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
SOCIAL WORKERS I'VE SEEN
PERSONALLY THE CHANGES IN SOCIAL
WORKERS AND THE DIFFERENCE THAT
IT MAKES THE CHILDREN IS JUST
AMAZING.
THEY COME IN NOT TRUSTING.
AND THEN WHEN THEY HAVE TO
SWITCH SWITCH SO MANY SOCIAL
WORKERS OR GO THROUGH SO MANY.
THEY LEARNED NOT TO TRUST AGAIN
AND IT'S I JUST IN HERE TO
SUPPORT THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU HE WOKE UP.
HI MY NAME IS WESLEY MATTHEWS ON
WITH ALTERNATIVE FAMILY SERVICES
AND DEBBIE IS MY RESOURCE FAMILY --
AND SO SHE SPOKE AND I CAN'T I
JUST ECHO EVERYONE SENTIMENT --
I ACTUALLY LIVE IN YOUR DISTRICT --
AND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE STABILITY
FOR OUR KIDS IN CARE FROM THAT
FROM INSIDE FROM THE TIME THEY
COME INTO ARE ALL THE WAY
THROUGH ADOPTION WE'RE SEEING
SUCCESS WE WOULD LIKE TO KEEP
OUR STAFF SO THEY CAN ASSIST
WITH THAT.
AND SUPPORTING MORE MONEY FOR
FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES IS THE
WAY THAT WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO FIND STABILITY FOR OUR
CHILDREN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS BILL RICHARDSON
I'M A SOCIAL WORKER FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS IN PLASTER COUNTY
WITH AN FFA.
OUR SUPPORT TO SOCIAL WORKER
INCREASE -- IT'S GROWING
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT TO FIND
SOCIAL WORKERS -- AT THE AMOUNTS
WERE ABLE TO PAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
BY DAVE WESSON FROM PLASTER
COUNTY -- I WAS SERVE FOSTER
PARENT FOR MANY YEARS AND TOOK
IN TWENTY SEVEN FOSTER KIDS --
WHEN MY YOUNGEST WAS -- FOR IN
MY MY MY OLDEST WAS FOR MY
YOUNGEST WAS A NEWBORN.
AND WE TOOK IN 90% OF THOSE KIDS
TWENTY SEVEN KIDS WERE --
TEENAGER SO I HAD KIDS ARE OLDER.
AND IN THAT TIME OF MAJORITY OF
THOSE WERE -- PROBATION KIDS OF
THEIR VERY DIFFICULT.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
REALLY KEPT US IN THE GAME WAS
BECAUSE OF OUR SOCIAL WORKER.
AND SO ONE OF THE THEORIES WE
HAD IS A KISS DON'T BLOW OUT OF
FOSTER CARE OF HOMES IT'S
PARENTS BLOW OUT.
IN I SEE THAT THE SOCIAL WORKERS
ARE SO IMPORTANT TO BE WITH THE
FOSTER PARENTS TO KEEP THEM IN
THE GAME SO THEY DON'T GIVE UP
ON THESE KIDS SO I'M IN -- FOR
HAVING THAT REYES WITH THE
SOCIAL WORKERS THANK YOU.
WELCOME IRISH IN A THREE WAY
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF
THE PROPOSALS. TO AN EXTENT THE
TO THE EXTENDED FOSTER CARE
HOUSING SUPPORT PROGRAM IN THE
BRING A FAMILY HOME PROGRAM WE
SEE THIS AS A CONTINUE EFFORT.
TO HAVE COUNTIES EXPAND ON THEIR
HOUSE INSTABILITY EFFORTS FOR
THEIR USE OF YOUTH THE YOUTH
THAT ARE IN CRISIS -- AS WE KNOW
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING WE
CAN'T CONTINUES TO BE A
CHALLENGING ISSUE FOR ALL
POPULATIONS IS NO DIFFERENT FOR
CHAO WILL FOR FAMILIES AND
FOSTER YOUTH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME I AM SO EVANS AND THE
SALE -- HOLDEN FUNNY SERVICES I
FROM WITH A FIGHT COUNTY WE
PROVIDE FULL STICK HEAD IN
RIVERSIDE SOMEBODY DINO LA AND
SAN DIEGO.
WE ARE PROVIDING ON WORKING WITH
THE COUNTIES TO PROVIDE SOME OF
OUR MOST VULNERABLE FOSTER YOUTH
WEEK HAVE A LOT OF FAST YOU
THROUGH SPECIAL HEALTH CARE
NEEDS WE ARE TRYING DESPERATELY
TO INCREASE OUR CAPACITY AS
POLICY SIERRA.
BUT WE ARE STRUGGLING WITH
RETAINING EXPERIENCE SKILLED
WORKERS AND IT'S ESSENTIAL THAT
THESE MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN
HAVE SKILLED EXPERIENCED SOCIAL
WORKERS AND THE ONLY WAY WE CAN
RETAIN THEM IS BY OFFERING A
COMPETITIVE SALARY.
AND SO I AM IN SUPPORT THAT THE
RATES INCREASE THANK YOU THANK
YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
SAM GOLDEN WITH CURRENTLY FAMILY
SERVICES I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THE
REYES IN THE INCREASE FOR HALF
OF A SOCIAL WORKERS OF IT
INDUSTRY FOR THIRTY SIX YEARS.
AND WE'RE HERE AT A TIME WHERE
WE NEED SOCIAL WORKERS MORE THAN
WE EVER HAVE.
AND WE CAN'T AFFORD TO LOSE
QUALITY SOCIAL WORKERS.
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION SERVICE
CONSIDERATION FOR THIS RACE
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
AND MICHELLE SERVICE I'M A
FOSTER PARENT AND I JUST AM IN
SUPPORT OF THE F. OF A PAY
INCREASE -- OUR FOSTER YOU
THIRTY EXPERIENCE SO MUCH LOS.
SO TO BE ABLE TO STAY CONNECTED --
TO ONE CASE WORKER WOULD BE
REALLY IMPORTANT TO THEM SIMON
SUPPORT THE FFA PAIN CHRIS THANK
YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS CLAUDIA AND I AM A
AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT FOR THE
FATE INCREASE AS WELL -- IT IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE OUR SOCIAL
WORKERS WORK SO HARD WE HAVE AN
EMERGENCY WE CAN COLUMN THERE
THERE TWENTY FOUR HOURS HOSPITAL
VISITS THERE THERE TO SUPPORT US.
SO IT IS IMPORTANT FOR THEM THEY
WORK VERY HARD OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS DEBBIE MAGISTRADO
I'M AN ADMINISTRATOR FOR PARENTS
BY CHOICE IT'S LOCATED IN
STOCKTON CALIFORNIA I LIVE IN
ELK GROVE I COVER FAMILIES AND
SOLANO COUNTY.
WE PROVIDE INTENSIVE SERVICES
FOSTER CARE RFA HOMES AND THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM ACT WE
ARE IMPLEMENTING IT AS BEST AS
WE CAN HOWEVER.
THE WAGE INCREASE IS HUGE -- WE
ARE CURRENTLY RECRUITING FOR
SOCIAL WORKERS AND EVEN JUST
FINDING SOMEONE WITH A MASTER'S
DEGREE IN SOCIAL WORK IS VERY
DIFFICULT.
SO I WOULD STRONGLY -- WISH THAT
YOU WOULD SUPPORT THE INCREASE
I'M ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING AND THE RE
ENTRY FOR EXTENDED FOSTER CARE
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS ARE IS REALLY
GONNA I AM THE SOCIAL WORKER
SUPERVISOR HER PARENTS BY CHOICE.
I LIVE IN LODI CALIFORNIA.
AND I WORK A LOT WITH THE
HIGHEST OF SEE KIDS.
AND THESE ARE SOCIAL WORKERS ARE
AMAZING THEY GO ABOVE AND BEYOND
THEY WERE MORE THAN ONE HALF
PACKED.
AND I HAVE PARENTS WHO COME TO
ME WHO ARE AFRAID WHEN THEY
ENTER THAT AYE SFC ROUND.
AND THEY SAY WE REALLY COULD NOT
DONE THIS IF IT WASN'T FOR YOUR
SOCIAL WORKER.
SO I WOULD REALLY IN SUPPORT OF
THE INCREASE FOR SUCH AGO SOCIAL
WORKERS THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS ELIZABETH LEWIS
AND I'M AN FFA SOCIAL WORKER AND
THEN I CAN COUNTY AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THE INCREASE FOR
SOCIAL WORKERS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS CYNTHIA MERION I'M
IN SUPPORT FOR THE INCREASE WAGE.
SOCIAL WORK WHICH I AM ENOUGH OF
A SOCIAL WORKER FOR THE I. S. OF
C. PROGRAM WITH PARENTS BY
CHOICE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS SUNDAY EMORY AND
I'VE BEEN A FOSTER PARENT FOR
TWENTY TWO YEARS AND SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY ALL OF THAT TIME I'VE
BEEN WITH EFFORT DAYS.
AND I'VE HAD OVER A HUNDRED
CHILDREN IN MY HOME OVER THAT
TIME I'M AND THE ONLY REASON
THAT I'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT
AND MY CHILDREN HAVE TURNED OUT
TO BE SO SUCCESSFUL WAS BECAUSE
OF MY SOCIAL WORKERS.
BUT I'VE HAD MANY OF THEM IN THE
TWENTY TWO YEARS I CAN'T EVEN
TELL YOU HOW MANY I'VE HAD IN MY
HOME BECAUSE OF THEM NOT BEING
ABLE TO SUPPORT THEIR OWN
FAMILIES WHILE THEY DO A JOB
THAT THEY LIVE.
SO I WOULD REALLY LOVE FOR THIS
BILL TO BE PASSED SO THAT THEY
WOULD BE ABLE -- TO SUPPORT
THEIR FAMILIES AND STILL BE A
SUPPORT TO S. AS RESOURCE
PARENTS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS AMY BAILEY I'M
AN FFA SOCIAL WORKER HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE
INCREASED WAGE FOR FFA SOCIAL
WORKERS TO INCREASE THE
STABILITY OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANGIE POTS I AM
THE FOSTER CARE PROGRAM DIRECTOR
AT CREATIVE ALTERNATIVES WE
SERVE CHILDREN AND MERCED AND
STANISLAUS COUNTY.
AND I AM HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
EFFORT FACED SOCIAL WORKER PAY
INCREASE AND I ASK THAT YOU ALSO --
CONSIDER THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS EMILY KAISER AND I
AM AN FAA ADMINISTRATOR HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND I ALSO AM A
FOSTER ADOPTIVE PARENT.
AND SPEAKING FROM BOTH ROLES I
AM IN SUPPORT OF THE OF OF A
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASE I DO TO
THE NEED FOR STABILITY FOR OUR
YOUTH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
I AM JUST KAMALA FROM FOSTER
COUNTY I'M IN A FACE SOCIAL
WORKER SUPERVISOR THE FOSTER
ADOPTIVE MOM -- JUST FROM MY
EXPERIENCE IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
CRITICAL THAT WE KEEP AND RETAIN --
X. KILLED BUT OF A SOCIAL
WORKERS TO SUPPORT OUR KIDS
THROUGH THE MOST DIFFICULT TIMES.
THANK YOU THANK YU WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON ADDRESSES
DIRECTOR OF POLICY ADD UP WITH
FAMILY SERVICES WERE STATEWIDE
CHILDREN'S BEHAVIOR HEALTH AND
CHILD WELFARE AGENCY.
ARE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO ADDRESS
THE IMPACT OF THE MINIMUM WAGE
LAW ON SOCIAL WORKERS WE BELIEVE
THE STATE MANDATED MINIMUM WAGE
LAW.
SHOULD NOT BE DETRIMENTAL TO
SOCIAL SERVICES ESPECIALLY AT A
TIME WHEN THE SUCCESS OF THE
CONTINUED OF CARE REFORM.
IS -- NEEDS HIGHLY SKILLED AND
EXPERIENCED SOCIAL WORKERS THANK
YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MY NAME IS GORDON RICHARDSON
REGIONAL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND
UPLIFT FAMILY SERVICES WE SERVE
UP HUNDREDS OF KIDS ACROSS THE
STATE IN FOSTER CARE -- WE
STRONGLY SUPPORTED THE THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
DECISION.
TO INCREASE THE MINIMUM WAGE.
WE SIT HERE AND IT'S A LITTLE
IRONIC THAT THE THE FFA RATES
ARE ONE OF ONLY TWO STATES THAT
FOSTER CARE RATES THE RECEIVE NO
ANNUAL INCREASE LINKED TO THE
CALIFORNIA NECESSITIES INDEX --
I STRONGLY URGE -- THE COMMITTEE
AND HOPEFULLY OF EVENTUALLY THE
LEGISLATURE.
TO APPROVE THE TWENTY SIX NINE
DOLLAR INCREASE IN AND REDRESS
THIS -- THIS NEED.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING AFTERNOON
WHAT IS A LEE UNDER CLICK HARVEY
ON THE AFTERNOON THAT.
THE ITEMS WE HONOR CLICK HARVEY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AGENCIES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE FFA SOCIAL WORKER
RATE.
INCREASE THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME'S EARLY STILLER
ANTI AND I'M A SUPERVISOR WITH
FFA HI FOR THE YOLO COUNTY IN
GREATER SACRAMENTO AREA FIRST OF
ALL THIS TURNOUT.
I THINK SPEAKS VOLUMES AS TO WHY
WE NEED THIS INCREASE -- WE DO
SO MUCH WORK WITH OUR FAMILIES
COUNTIES CHOOSE TO WORK WITHOUT
THAT PHASE BECAUSE OF THE WORK
WE DO FOR OUR FAMILIES.
AND WE CAN'T CONTINUE TO DO THAT
WORK IF WE CAN'T PAY OUR WORKERS
WHAT THEY DESERVE.
JUST LIKE WE WANT OUR FAMILIES
TO HAVE STABILITY OUR WORKERS
DESERVE STABILITY AS WELL THANK
YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME'S KELSEY DAHLIN I'M
I'M A PROGRAM SUPERVISOR AT LILY
BUT FAMILIES WHICH IS A LOCAL
FFA AND I AM HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BUDGET INCREASE -- ARE SO
ARE SOCIAL WORKERS LIKE PEOPLE
OUTSIDE WORK TWENTY FOUR HOURS
ON SEVENTIES A WEEK AND SOME OF
THEM WORKED MULTIPLE JOBS JUST
ABOUT FOOD ON THEIR TABLE THAT'S
NOT ACCEPTABLE SO.
HOW WE ARE DEFINITELY AND
SUPPORTER AND HOPE THAT YOU ARE
AS WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME SAMANTHA KINI M. FROM
FRESNO AND I'M AN FFA SOCIAL
WORKER.
I SUPPORT THE EVER FACE SOCIAL
WORKER INCREASE I'VE SEEN MANY
OF MY TALENTED COLLEAGUES SLEEP
POSITIONS THAT THEY LOVE. FOR
BETTER WAGES TO SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILY.
THIS IS NOT FAIR TO THE FAUCET
FOSTER YOUTH WE SERVE SOCIAL
SOCIAL WORKERS AND FOSTER YOUTH
DESERVE BETTER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI ANNA JOHNSON FROM THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF ITEM SIX
AND SEVEN ON ITEM SIX THE PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSING PROGRAM.
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW AS
THE ARE YOU THE LEGISLATURE IN
CDSS WORKS. TO HIRE PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSES FOR THE ISSUE OF
OVER MEDICATION OF CHILDREN
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN THEIR IMPACT
ON IMPROVING THOSE SAFE
PRACTICES.
I KNOW THIS PILOT WILL YIELD
GREAT RESULTS FOR USE IN THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES ARE
STRENGTH OF THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM THAT WITHOUT FEDERAL
MATCH IT'S IT'S A WISE
INVESTMENT.
SECOND I WAS SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF JACQUI HUANG WHO COULD BE
HERE TODAY FROM GRACE AND AND
CHILD POVERTY CAMPAIGN SHE IS IN
SUPPORT OF THE FOSTERING SUCCESS --
ASK ITEM SEVEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS MALLORY MUNCH I'M
FROM FRESNO AND I'M AT THE FACE
SOCIAL WORKER AS WELL.
I A SUPPORT THE FFA SOCIAL WORK
BUDGET INCREASED -- AND I HAVE
SEEN A HIGH TURNOVER RATE I HAVE
BEEN A SOCIAL WORKER FOR THREE
YEARS.
AND I JUST HAVE A SHORT STORY --
I DO -- I'VE HAD -- I'VE HAD A
ONE OF MY GIRLS I MAKE HE SAID --
SHE I WAS THERE AND IN THE HOME
WITH ONE OF MY INTERNS THAT I
SUPERVISE OR THAT I OVERSEE AND
HE WENT WITH ME ON A VISIT AND
WHEN SHE SAW HIM I CAN SEE IT
LIKE THE STRESS AND THAT -- THE
STRENGTH IN HER IN HER REACTION
AND SHE ASKED ARE YOU GONNA BE
MY NEW SOCIAL WORKER AND SO I
WHICH IS I REASSURED HER THAT
NOTE HE WAS NOT GOING TO BE HER
SOCIAL WORKER BUT I CAN SEE THE
STRESS IN IT.
AND AND I KNOW THAT THE KIDS
WHEN THEY DO HAVE -- TO SWITCH
SOCIAL WORKERS THEY DO -- GET
RECEIVE THAT LOSS IN IN IT THAT.
IT'S KIND IT'S SAD THAT THEY
HAVE TO REPEATEDLY EXPERIENCE
LOSS WHEN THEY'VE ALREADY LOST
SO MUCH THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS MEGHAN LINSEY I
AM AN FFA SOCIAL WORKER FROM
TULARE COUNTY -- AND I AM ALSO A
FORMER FROST YOUTH AS WELL FROM
TULARE COUNTY -- I AM HERE -- TO
I SUPPORT THE MINIMUM WAGE.
INCREASE -- FOR ME I JUST WANTED
TO GIVE MY STANDPOINT AS A YOUTH --
AND WHY PURSUE BEING A SOCIAL
WORKERS WALL -- WHEN I WAS IN
CARE IT WAS REALLY DIFFICULT FOR
ME TO TO BOND WITH A SOCIAL
WORKER BECAUSE IT WAS SUCH A BIG
TURNOVER?
I JUST I WAS VERY STANDOFFISH
WITH A NEW WORK AT THAT WOULD
COME IN HOW JUST STAY.
HI BE THERE ANSWER THE QUESTIONS
AND THEN I WOULD GO I WOULDN'T
REALLY.
BE ABLE TO FEEL LIKE A CAN
SUPPORT THAT BECAUSE OF THE HIGH
TURNOVER.
AND I WOULD SPEAK WITH MY FOSTER
MOM ON A REGULAR BASIS ABOUT IS
THAT GOING TO BE THE SAME SOCIAL
WORKER OR IS IT CAN BE A
DIFFERENT.
ONE SO -- WHEN I WENT INTO
SCHOOL I WANTED TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THAT ABILITY TO SUPPORT THE
KIDS THAT I CARE [inaudible]
FOR THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS LISA CAMDEN AND I MET
SUPERVISOR WITHIN FFA AGENCY WE
SERVICE FRESNO MADERA COUNTIES.
AND I'VE BEEN A PRACTICING
SOCIAL WORKER FOR OVER THIRTY
FIVE YEARS -- MUCH OF WHICH HAS
BEEN SERVICING.
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE -- I AM
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE MINIMUM
WAGE INCREASE -- I CERTAINLY
DIDN'T COME INTO SOCIAL WORK FOR
THE MONEY.
I CAME TO MAKE AN IMPACT -- AS
MUCH AS I PROMOTES AND WANT TO
EMPOWER OUR OUR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH IN CARE.
WE NEED TO BE EMPOWERED AS WELL.
I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND ASK
THAT YOU CONSIDER ARE INCREASED
THANKS THANK YOU AND THEN WE
WILL BE CONSIDERING IT.
HI THIS IS THAT YOU KNOW.
OKAY THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LEAH
AND I AM HERE -- WITH FRIENDS
THE IMPROVISED THOUGHT WITH THE
FAA AND I AM HERE.
IN SUPPORT OF THE FFA PAY RATE
INCREASE THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS HAPPENING
ROBERSON JUNIOR AGAIN I'M THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE EQUITY
ORGANIZER. FOR FAR THE FAMILY
SAN JOAQUIN I SPOKE OR NOT AND
NEVER SEVEN SO IT'S NOT -- ROCKY
SIGNS THAT I'M HERE IN SUPPORT
OF ADAM THERE WERE SEVEN BEFORE
I WAS BRIEFLY CT OFF BUT I
WOULD BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T
SPEAK TO THE END OF SEXUALITY.
OF ALL ITEMS RIDE WHAT THE IN
SUCH AN ALLEY ACTS OF US IS A
MEASURE.
HOW RE MEASURED UP AS A SOCIETY
ON HOW WE INVEST IN OUR YOU'VE
FOSTER CARE?
AT B. YOU BECOME A SYSTEM WHERE
YOU IN THERE FEEL THAT PEOPLE
DON'T CARE ABOUT THEM.
SO THEY HAVE ALREADY BEEN PUSHED
OUT OF ALREADY BEEN SHOT OUT NOW
THAT BEING DISPLACED AND NOW
WE'RE WE'RE FINDING IN THIS DATA
THAT.
THE BEST WRAPAROUND SERVICES
PROVIDED TO HIM AS A CALL.
291-1 RIGHT SO NOW THEY'RE BEING
FORCED AND SYSTEM IMPACTING
PUSHED INTO THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE.
AND WE HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF ARE
WE NOT BETTER THAN THAT AS A
SOCIETY RIGHT SO WE HAVE THE
FOSTERING SUCCESS AND A SLIGHT
THE TERM IS LIGHT.
IS TO AT LEAST LIKE IT'S COMMON
SENSE BUT WE'RE ASKING THAT THE
BUDGET.
BECOME ALSO COMMONSENSE THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
A GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER WE REPRESENT
APPROXIMATELY TEN THOUSAND
SOCIAL WORKERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF
MANY THESE PROPOSALS BUT I WANT
TO CALL OUT A FEW WHERE A CO
SPONSOR ON THE FIRST ONE FOR
CHILD WELFARE TRAINING SYSTEM WE
FILL IT.
IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR SOCIAL
WORKERS TO RECEIVE THE BEST MOST
ADVANCED TRAINING AVAILABLE I
THINK IT SUPPORTS THE CHILDREN
IN THE SYSTEM BUT IT ALSO HELPS
THE SOCIAL WORKERS DO THEIR JOB
TO THE BEST.
OF THEIR ABILITY -- ITEMS FOR
WHICH IS THE HOUSING RELATED
SUPPORTS FOR FOSTER CARE -- AS
YOU KNOW HOUSING IS IS A
CHALLENGE AT THE CHALLENGE --
FOR FOR ADULTS BUT IT'S
DEFINITELY A CHALLENGE FOR THE
KIDS THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SO
WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THAT I
ALSO WANT TO SUPPORT.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE THE FFA SOCIAL
WORKER ON INCREASES YOU
ACKNOWLEDGE DURING THE HEARING
THAT SOMETHING YOU REALLY HAVE
TO DO -- BUT ALSO YOU HEARD
ABOUT THE REAL IMPACTS ON THE
CHILDREN -- IS THAT OUR THEY HAD
NEW SOCIAL WORKERS WHEN THE
OTHER ONE LEAVES BECAUSE OF THE
POOR PAY -- AND THEN LASTLY I
WANT TO MENTION ITEM SEVEN
FOSTERING SUCCESS SUPPORTING
VULNERABLE FOSTER IN CROSSOVER
YOUTH AS ANOTHER IMPORTANT
PRIORITY -- I'M ALSO HERE -- FOR
AND MARTHA GUERRERO WHO HAD TO
LEAVE WITH LA COUNTY AND SHE
JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT THEY ARE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER --
ONE NUMBER THREE AND NUMBER FOUR
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
RIGHT WELCOME.
THE CENTERS ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT OF ITEM
NUMBER ONE CHILD WELFARE
TRAINING SYSTEM AND ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF NUMBER FOUR REGARDING
SUPPORTS -- FOR EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE I THINK NONE OF US REALIZED
WHEN WE IMPLEMENTED AB TWELVE
THE UNIQUE NEEDS AND VARIED
NEEDS OF THAT PARTICULAR
POPULATION OF FOSTER YOUTH AND
HOW LABOR INTENSIVE IT IS TO
MAKE SURE.
THEY GET ALL THEIR NEEDS SERVICE
SO THAT THIRTY TWO POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IN INCREASED
FUNDING FOR CHILD WELFARE SOCIAL
WORKERS ENGAGE AN EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE WILL BE IMPERATIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
HELLO MY NAME IS YOU THIRTIES
AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
FFA -- WHICH INCREASE -- AS A
MASTER'S LEVEL SOCIAL WORKER
WITH BILINGUAL SQUARE SKILLS I
FIND IT VERY UNFORTUNATE THAT
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE TO
LEAVE THEIR JOBS WHERE THEIR
SKILLS ARE BETTER PAID OFF.
YET THEY LOVE THEIR JOB.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
I'M IS THERE LIKE A REAL EFFORT
FACED SOCIAL WORKER AND TULARE
COUNTY I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE
INTERFACE ON WAGE INCREASE
THERE'S JUST A SUCH A TURNOVER --
COLLEAGUES LEAF FOR BETTER JOBS
AND NOT ONLY THAT BUT WHENCE THE
CHILDREN ARE TRANSITION INTO A
DIFFERENT SOCIAL WORKER.
THEY OF COURSE JUST BLOCK AWAY
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS JACQUELINE
SCHOFIELD AND A PROGRAM
SUPERVISOR FOR FFA SERVING
SEVERAL COUNTIES HERE.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
WE CAN'T.
KEEP OUR STAFF IF WE DON'T GET A
WAGE INCREASE SO STRONGLY
SUPPORT THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS KATIE GREEN AND
I'M AN FFA PROGRAM SUPERVISOR IN
PLASTER COUNTY AND I SUPPORT
THAT FFA MINIMUM WAGE INCREASE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL PROVENTIA
WHEN I SUPPORTER FOSTERING
SECESSION THE INITIATIVE -- BUT
I ALSO WANT TO SAY YOU KNOW LET
YOU GUYS CHOOSE TO BE YOU KNOW A
SOCIAL WORKERS YOU KNOW THESE
THESE YOU.
KNOW THEY DIDN'T CHOOSE TO BE
REMOVED FROM THEIR HOME YOU KNOW.
SO -- YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW GIVING MORE MONEY TO
THE ACTUAL FOSTER PARENTS XIN
ARMENIA -- I AGREE YOU KNOW YOU
GUYS NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE
MONEY BUT BUT BUT LIKE I SAID.
THE FOSTER PARENTS THE MORE
MONEY YOU KNOWN THAT'S HOW YOU
FOSTER SUCCESS YOU KNOW.
THAT'S HOW YOU KNOW -- I'M I
APOLOGIZE -- HAVE THE
EDUCATIONAL LEVEL YOU THAT YOU
GUYS HAVE NOT COME FROM THE
STREETS BECAUSE YOU GUYS YOU
KNOW THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM OF
FORCED ME INTO THE STREET YOU
KNOW HOMELESS YOU KNOW WITH NO
HOME TO GO.
TO NO MOTHER NO DAD OPEN THE
SISTER IN ALL CORNERS.
NOBODY YOU KNOW SO SO SO YOU
YOUR SYSTEM REYES ME LIKE THAT
YOU KNOW.
BUT SO I I YOU KNOW I DON'T
DISAGREE THAT YOU GUYS NEED MORE
MONEY YOU KNOW -- BUT BUT THE
FOSTER PARENTS THE MORE MONEY
YOU KNOW TO GIVE A TO GIVE A
FOSTER PARENT.
IN ALL SIX SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
TO TO CARE FOR A CHILD YOU KNOW.
IT IS THAT'S WRONG YOU KNOW.
YOU NEED TO DO MORE.
I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS MICHELLE IT'S A
VERY I'M A PROGRAM SUPERVISOR
WITH LILY PUT FAMILIES IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA.
I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE FFA
SOCIAL WORKER RATE INCREASE I'VE
BEEN IN THE CHILD WELFARE FIELD --
FOR THE LAST EIGHT YEARS AND I
HAVE SEEN NUMEROUS SOCIAL
WORKERS COMING GO JUST DUE TO
THE FACT THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
GET PAID BETTER MONEY AND UNDER
AND OTHER AREAS.
AND I'VE SEEN THE IMPACT IT HAS
ON THE TEAMS THAT ARE LEFT
BEHIND AND ALSO ON THE FAMILIES
HAVING BEEN WITH THE SAME AGENCY
FOR THE LAST EIGHT YEARS -- WE
HAVE A YOUTH WE ARE WORKING WITH
WHO IN COMPLETING A SCHOOL
ASSIGNMENT SAID WHEN SHE GROWS
UP SHE WANTS TO BE A LITTLE BIT
SOCIAL WORKER.
IT REALLY SHOWS THE IMPACT THAT
OUR SOULS WORKERS HAVE HONOR
FAMILIES AND HOW MUCH WOULD
IMPACTOR THAT SOCIAL WORKER WERE
TO LEAVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
I AM DANIEL ENSLEY WITH -- I'M
UP PROGRAM SUPERVISOR ALSO WITH
ONLY PUT FAMILIES -- AND I'M
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE INCREASE
AS WELL FOR THE ABOUT FACE -- AS
A SUPERVISOR I HAVE SEEN THE
TURN OVER AND THE IMPACT OF THAT
NO NOT ONLY HOUSE ON OUR
AGENCIES AND LEUCINE QUALIFIED
AND SKILLED WORKERS BUT ALSO
THAT.
DEVASTATING IMPACT ON FAMILIES
LIKE I THINK MANY PEOPLE OF SAID.
IT'S ANOTHER LOSS OF THESE
CHILDREN AND THOSE PARENTS NEED
CONSISTENT SUPPORT FROM THEIR
SOCIAL WORKERS AND THAT'S HARD
WHEN THE TURNOVER OCCURS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MARYLAND SEXTON ON THE ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR FOR NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
YOUTH AND FAMILY PROGRAMS.
AND OBVIOUSLY WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THE OF HAVE A SOCIAL WORKER
INCREASE BUT AS A FORMER FOSTER
USE OF THE SIXTIES AND SEVENTIES.
ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA CAN DO TO
MAKE THEIR LIVES BETTER FOR
FOSTER YOUTH WE SHOULD BE DOING
THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANKS CHRIS STONE -- MERTZ
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES WE ARE
SUPPORTING A NUMBER OF THESE --
SUGGESTIONS FOR INCREASES
BRINGING FAMILIES HOME.
ELIMINATING BARRIERS TO ENTRY
FOR EXTENDED FOR EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE.
AND FOSTERING SUCCESS.
REQUESTS AND OF COURSE THE FFA
INCREASE WHICH IS SO CRITICAL --
AND NOT JUST FOR A ONE TIME
INCREASE BUT TO REALLY.
GET IN INCLUDE A REGULAR CNI --
TO ENSURE THAT OUR SOCIAL WORK
STAFF ARE.
ARE REALLY ABLE TO PAY THEIR OWN
BILLS SO THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU.
CNN IF I'M A CHILDREN NOW HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE HOUSING
PROPOSAL I LEFT MY THING I
BELIEVE IT WAS NUMBER -- FOUR
ALSO JUST TO SAY THAT WE ALSO
SUPPORT AN INCREASE IN RATES
RESOURCES FOR SOCIAL WORKERS BUT
WOULD SAY WE ACTUALLY SUPPORT AN
INCREASE FOR ALL PEOPLE WORKING
IN THIS FIELD AND FOR THE SYSTEM
OVERALL.
IT'S HIGHLY UNDERFUNDED IN OUR
OPINION.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON CAN LOW'S
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOU THAN A SPARE
AND THAT AND SUPPORT OF ITEM
NUMBER THREE AND WE APPRECIATED
HER SUPPORT LAST YEAR AND HOPE
WE CAN.
GET TO A RESOLUTION ON THAT THIS
YEAR AND CONTINUE OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND YES LAST AND ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE NUMBER.
FIVE TIME WE WANT TO SUPPORT OUR
SOCIAL WORKERS AND ENSURE THAT
WE ARE IN COMPLIANCE WITH STATE
LAW THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON KRISTIN
POWER THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS ARE GOING
SUPPORT FOR THE ELIMINATING
BARRIERS FOR ENTRY.
AND RE ENTERING EXTENT OF FOSTER
CARE -- APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
LAST YEAR AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING THROUGH THAT ISSUE THIS
YEAR AGAIN ITEM FOR HOUSING
RELATED SUPPORTS FOR EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE.
AND ITEM FIVE THE STATE MINIMUM
WAGE INCREASE THE EFFORT FACED
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
HI GENEREX ROAD WITH CALIFORNIA
LANCE OF CARE GIVERS AD I'M
SPEAKING AND SUPPORT BOTH FOR
INCREASED FUNDING FOR AND SOCIAL
WORKERS WITH THE FFA IS.
AND INVESTMENT AND AND AB TWELVE
YOU THINK SENATE FOSTER CARE AND
JUST WANNA SHARE QUICKLY THAT I
AM FOSTERING I'M A YOUTH AN
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE SHE'S BEEN
WITH ME IT.
A COUPLE OF MONTHS SHE'S HAVING
A BABY.
IN JUNE AND I WANT TO ASSURE YOU
THAT THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE
INVESTMENT -- SHE'S MADE SO MUCH
PROGRESS AND REALLY THE SYSTEM
IS NOW PREVENTING HER LITTLE ONE
FROM ENTERING SO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FRANK MECCA WITH C. A B. D. A
WERE CO SPONSORING THE BRINGING
FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT TO EXTEND IT.
I'M ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA -- TO GIVE
YOU THE SAME MESSAGE WERE ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF NUMBERS FOR NUMBER
SIX RELATED TO EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE HOUSING AND PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSING.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SO -- WE ARE GOING TO
IS A AN OUNCE AT THE BEGINNING
THIS HEARING -- WE'RE NOT TAKING
VOTES ON ANY ITEMS THESE ARE ALL
ON HOLD AND WILL BE CONSIDERED
FOR THE IT MAY REVISE I WOULD
MAKE NOTE IT IS NOW -- ONE
TWENTY FIVE YES IF I COULD MAKE
SUCH A CENTER STONE YES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
AND FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO THANK --
EVERYBODY.
FOR TAKING THE TRIP FROM ALL
OVER CALIFORNIA TO BE HERE TODAY
AND AND ESPECIALLY THE FOSTER
CURRENT SOMEONE THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR SERVICE WHEN.
OUR HEAVENLY CREATOR ****
CREATED ANGELS I THINK ALL HE
DID HE DID NEED TO LOOK ANY
FURTHER THAN LOOKING AT SOCIAL
WORKERS WITH YOUR PASSION AND
YOUR CARE FOR THESE IS THE
GENERALIZED.
TO EFFECTUATE SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT -- MISTER CHAIR IT'S
OBVIOUS BASED ON WHAT WE'RE
HEARING HERE TODAY THAT.
WE HAVE A CRISIS IN THE CITY
CALIFORNIA WITH THE SOCIAL
WORKERS AND HAVE BEEN.
CHRONICALLY UNDERPAID FOR FOR
MANY MANY YEARS -- THEIR THEIR
SERVICES -- DISCERNING RECOGNIZE --
AND HAS A DIRECT EFFECT ON THE
THE WELL BEING OF THE KIDS THAT
THEY IN FAMILIES OF THE OVERSEE
ESPECIALLY WITH THE CONTINUITY
OF CARE AND THE STABILITY OF THE
FAMILIES OF THE TRUST THAT THEY
HAVE WITH THE SOCIAL WORKERS.
AND SO I I KNOW TO TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLAR -- COST THAT I
KNOW THAT BIT MINISTRATION AS
INPUT IN THE BUDGET MAYBE
THEY'LL CHANGE AFTER THE MAY
REVISE BUT I KNOW THAT WHEN WE
SEE THE MAY REVISE AND WE GO
THROUGH OUR BOATS WE'RE GONNA BE
GOING THROUGH HUNDREDS OF VOTES
ARE GONNA GOING YES YES YES NO.
YES IT IS RIGHT HOPEFULLY MORE
YES IS THE NOSE.
AND I DON'T WANT THIS TO GET
LOST IN THE SHUFFLE I THINK IT'S
THAT IMPORTANT SO MY REQUESTED
OF YOU AND OUR STAFF IS IT.
WE HAVE THIS EITHER FOR AN UP OR
DOWN VOTE TO TO SHOW THE SOCIAL
WORKERS THAT WERE HEARING THEM.
AND THAT WE WANT TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS BECAUSE I'M
WORRIED THAT MORE SOCIAL WORKERS
ARE GOING TO FIND.
HIGHER PAYING JOBS IN THEM AND
THE PRIVATE SECTOR OR WITHIN
COUNTIES WHERE THEY PAY MORE.
AND LIKE YOU ALLUDED TO AND I
AGREE WITH YOU 1100%.
WE CREATED THIS ISSUE WITH OUR
MINIMUM WAGE LAWS WHICH WOULD
WE'RE NOT HERE TO DEBATE THAT IT
IS LAW.
BUT I DON'T WANT OUR SOCIAL
WORKERS TO SUFFER BECAUSE OF
WHAT WE DID IN THE LEGISLATURE
NOT.
AN ERROR EVERY CREATURE YOUR
SUPPORT ON THAT RIGHT NOW THANK
YOU CENTER STONE I POINT OUT
THAT -- TODAY MADE REMARKED AT
THE END OF THE PRESENTATION ON
THAT VERY ITEM.
THAT -- WE HAVE PASSED POLICY
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IN FACT IF WE DON'T MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS -- WE WILL
EVENTUALLY WELL FORCED AGENCIES
INTO A VIOLATION OF THE LAW AND
WE CANNOT DO THAT SO.
I THINK THAT -- BELIEVE ME THIS
WILL NOT BE LOST IN THE SHUFFLE
THAT NONE OF THESE PROPOSALS
WILL BE AND WE'RE CONSIDERING
EACH ONE OF THEM -- AND SO I
FIGURED ISSUE COMMENTS.
OKAY SO I WOULD JUST MAKE NOTE
THAT -- WE STILL HAVE NOT
COMPLETED PART A AND WE STILL
CONTINUING SO -- WE STILL HAVE
THE DEPARTMENT CHILD.
SOCIAL SERVICE CHAU WERE FOR
SERVICESAND WE'RE NOW ACTUALLY
I KNOW PEOPLE MADE REFERENCE TO
IT.
WE ARE ACTUALLY NOW GOING TO BE
TALKING ABOUT THE CONTINUE OF
CARE REFORM IMPLEMENTATION WE
ALSO HAVE HERE TO THE FARM
HEALTH CARE SERVICES BECAUSE
BOTH OF THEM ARE INVOLVED IN
THAT.
SO -- ISSUE NUMBER ONE WHICH IS
THE CITY OF CARE REFORM
IMPLEMENTATION.
AND I WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT
AFTER WE CONCLUDE DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES. FOR ALL OUR
MENTAL HEALTH ADVOCATES WE HAVE.
WE HAVEN'T STARTED ON MENTAL
HEALTH YET SO I AM JUST TRYING
TO BE CONSCIOUS OF EVERYONE'S
TIME AND AND I KNOW THAT MANY
PEOPLE ARE HERE THE CONCERN OF
MANY DIFFERENT ISSUES.
SO -- LET'S GO AHEAD BEGIN WITH
ISSUE NUMBER.
ONE THANK YOU WELCOME.
THANK YOU GREG ROSE AGAIN DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR CHILDREN AND FAMILY
SERVICES DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES.
END OF FIVE WE CAN JUST THE
AVAIL.
RANDALL AND IS ILLEGAL.
MARTIN LA ON FINANCE.
CHRIS **** BERMAN FINANCE.
IF YOU.
JUST REYES PART OF PLANTS OKAY
AND WE'LL START OFF WITH THE
PRESENTATION OF THE AGENCY AND
THEN WE HAVE A PANEL WHO WILL
ALSO BE ACT COMMENTING AS WELL
AND THEN.
ALRIGHT SO WANT TO GO AND BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GREG ROSE AGAIN FOR THE
DEPARTMENT -- I AT JUST AS MY
PREVIOUS COMMENT ABOUT THE THE
QUALITY OF THE OF THE BACKGROUND
PAPER THE AGENDA THERE'S A
NUMBER OF IN IMPORTANT FACTS AND
FIGURES IN A RELATED.
TO CONTINUE WITH CARE REFORM I
WANTED TO JUST -- TALK ABOUT A
FEW THINGS IN IN THIS ITEM
NUMBER ONE IT'S JUST TO REMIND
US THAT -- THE POLICY GOAL THAT
WE HAD ALL AGREED ON THAT YOU
KNOW CHILDREN AND YOU SHOULD
GROW UP IN FAMILIES AND FAMILIES
NEED TO BE SUPPORTED BY
COMMUNITIES BOTH IN THE PUBLIC
AND THE PRIVATE SECTOR -- IS IS
WHAT WE'RE WHAT WE'RE DRIVING
TOWARDS -- AND WHAT WE'RE
IMPLEMENTING IT AND THAT WOMEN
YOUNG PEOPLE NEED A STRUCTURED
ENVIRONMENT TO HEAL FROM TRAUMA
THAT WE SHOULD BE PLANNING FOR
THEIR DISCHARGE FROM DAY ONE AND
WORKING WITH AND WORKING TO
SUPPORT AND NURTURE THEIR
EXISTING RELATIONSHIPS BECAUSE
THAT'S HOW.
FOLKS HILL FROM TRAUMA AND THAT
I WOULD SAY THAT YOU KNOW AS
WE'VE WE'VE BEEN AT THIS FOR A
WHILE WE'VE TALKED TO A NUMBER
OF YEARS IN A ROW ABOUT OUR OUR
PROGRESS AND I THINK WE'VE MADE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS AND SYSTEM
CHANGE DOES TAKE.
SOME TIME AND WE'VE BEEN USING
KIND OF IT AN ADAPTIVE -- THE
MODEL FOR THE TO MAKE CHANGES IN
REAL TIME BASED ON INFORMATION
THAT WE HAVE THROUGHOUT THE
CONTINUES QUALITY ASSURANCE
PROCESS -- THERE ARE NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT THAT WITH OF THAT
ARE -- ARE SIX WE HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL WITH DECREASING THE
NUMBER OF KIDS IN GROUP HOMES
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF MOUNT
AMOUNT TO CHILD AND FAMILY TEAMS --
ESPECIALLY IN THE PROBATION
WORLD BUT ARE NOW IN THE IN
CHILD WELFARE OVER 40% OF ALMOST
50% THE YOUNG PEOPLE ARE GETTING
CHILD THE FAMILY TEAMS --
THERE'S MORE PEPLE ARE MORE
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE PLACED WITH
RELATIVES THE THE LICENSING
PROCESS IS IS ARDUOUS BUT BUT
WILL BE WORKING IN CREATING --
PROGRAMS THAT WILL HAVE
INTEGRATED HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND THAT WE'RE SEEING
SOLID PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN K<c.cyan></c>
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES BUT
THE THE THE MENTAL HEALTH PLANS
AND THE CHILD WELFARE AGENCIES.
I WHICH IS WHAT WON'T WANT TO
MENTION A A SUCCESS STORY
BRIEFLY I MEAN WHAT SOMETIMES WE
TALK ABOUT NUMBERS ALL ALL THE
TIME AND PROCESS SEES.
AND JUST TERE THERE WAS A THERE
WAS A YOUNG MAN THAT THAT
RECENTLY -- ACHIEVED -- A FOSTER
CARE STATUS THAT WITH THAT MANY
FOR THAT WITH WITH THINGS
STACKED AGAINST HIM THERE'S A
YOUNG MAN OF PROBATION -- FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY WHO WAS PLACED
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COMPLETED
HIS SEX OFFENDER PROGRAM -- WHO
HAD HAD HAD?
WASN'T ABLE TO GO HOME BECAUSE
OF HIS -- BECAUSE HIS VICTIM WAS
STILL IN THE HOME OUR WORK WITH --
WITH THE COUNTY OUR CONSULTANTS
WORKED ANNE'S GOODMAN'S WITH THE
COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENT AND
OTHERS REALLY IF HELP THIS YOUNG
MAN IDENTIFY -- ACTUALLY WAS A
SCHOOL TEACHER IN HIS IN HIS
PUBLIC SCHOOL IN IN IN SAN
BERNADINO COUNTY.
THAT ULTIMATELY BECAME HIS
FOSTER PARENTS OF THIS THIS
YOUNG MAN IS A ISREPRESENTATIVE
OF THE A NUMBER OF THE YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO WE OFTEN SEE SPEND
THEIR ENTIRE -- TEENAGE YEARS IN
GROUP HOMES AND AND WITH KIND OF
OUR WITH THE DOG HAD TO KIND OF
REACH.
BEING RE LET MISS AT RELENTLESS
AND WITH A SENSE OF URGENCY I
BELIEVE THAT THAT THIS KIND OF
SICK CHILD SPECIFIC RECRUITMENT
EFFORTS.
HAD A CAN MAKE IT MAKE A
DIFFERENCE AND SO I WANT US TO
KIND OF REMEMBER THIS YOUNG MAN
AS WE AS WE TALK ABOUT THIS AND
THE CHALLENGES I KNOW YOU WANT
ME TO ALSO TALK ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES LET ME JUST TELL YOU
I THINK WHERE WE THINK.
WE NEED TO SUPPLY FOCUS OUR
EFFORTS FOR THE NEXT -- THE NEXT
YEAR SO.
AS WE HEARD IN PUBLIC COMMENT
THERE ARE EIGHT HUNDRED YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN LOWER LEVEL
GROUP HOMES THAT -- THAT -- 72%
OF WHICH HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED BY
COUNTIES AS NOT MEETING THE
REQUIREMENTS -- FOR S. T. R. T.
P. LEVEL OF CARE IT'S THOSE IT'S
THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT I THINK
WE NEED TO FOCUS ON RIGHT NOW --
AND AND FIND FAMILIES FOR THEM --
I THINK WHAT THINK WE ALSO NEED
TO CONTINUE TO WORK OUT WITH OUR
HIGH FIDELITY CHILD AND FAMILY
TEAMS.
AND AND AND AND MAKE SURE THAT
YOU THAT YOU HAVE VOICE AND
CHOICE AND IN THEIR PROCESS WE
DID WORK BETTER.
BETTER AT LOOK AT THE STATE
LEVEL AND LOCALLY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE THE CANS ASSESSMENT
INFORMATION IS SHARED SO THAT
COULD BE USED BY BOTH SYSTEMS
AND ONE ASSESSMENT FOR ONE KID.
I THINK THAT WE ALSO HAVE TO
REALLY FOCUS ON ON IN TRAUMA AND
HEALING INFORM SYSTEMS OF BOTH
AT THE PROVIDER LEVEL AND IN OUR
COUNTY WITH OUR COUNTY
COLLEAGUES.
AND WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO BUILD
OUT A A SYSTEM OF CARE DEBTS
BAIT THAT THAT THAT SUPPORTS
FAMILIES AND AND FOSTER CHILDREN
INCLUDING THERAPEUTIC FOSTER
CARE.
INTENSIVE TREATMENT FOSTER CARE
OR INTENSIVE SERVICES FOSTER
CARE WRAPAROUND AND OTHER HIGHLY
COORDINATED WAYS TO TO MATH TO
MAKE SURE THAT KIDS GET SERVICES
WHERE THEY ARE.
AND NOT HAVE TO BE MOVED TO
WHERE THE SERVICES ARE THAT'S MY
QUICK IS FAST AS I COULD GO OVER
YOU.
THANK YOU AND ACTUALLY WE HAVE
THE PROPER HEALTHCARE SERVICES
YOU'RE TOO RIGHT.
AT THE AREA OKAY.
SO ALL RIGHT AND OKAY AND IN
TERMS OF THE REMAINING QUESTIONS.
SOCCER SERVICES WAS GONNA HANDLE
THE THE NEXT COUPLE QUESTIONS
AND I'LL BE BACK TO ME OKAY SO
YEAH SO IT'S A PART OF SERVICE.
THANK YOU BRENDA GRANT WISH
ACTING DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SERVICES AT THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE TODAY TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT OUR EFFORTS -- WORKING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH SAW SOCIAL
SERVICES IN OUR COUNTY PARTNERS --
SO WE TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING TO TO
TRACK WHETHER OR NOT CHILDREN
AND YOUTH ARE GETTING SERVICES --
WE DO HAVE A DATA SHARING
AGREEMENTS ARE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
THAT WE'VE HAD IN PLACE FOR
QUITE A FEW YEARS NOW AND UNDER
THAT DATA SHARING AGREEMENT WERE
ABLE TO TRACK SCREENING AND
REFERRAL SO WHEN CHILDREN AND
YOUTH ARE GETTING SCREENED --
FOR MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS AND THE
REFER TO THEN WERE ABLE TO TAKE
THAT DATA MATCHING OVER INTO OUR
DATA SYSTEM TO SEE WHICH
CHILDREN AND YOUTH ARE GETTING
REFERRALS SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
THAT ON A QUARTERLY BASIS WE
REPORT OUT AT THE CCAR'S
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT LANGUAGE
MEETINGS -- TO TO BE ABLE TO TO
DISCUSS THAT MONITOR THAT WITH
LEGISLATIVE STAFF AND SO THAT'S
A THAT'S ONE OF OUR BIG EFFORTS
AND SO I WITHOUT IT'S TWO PIECES
WERE WORKING ON IMPROVING DATA
QUALITY AND ALSO THE ACTUAL.
SERVICE DELIVERY AND PROCESS
ITSELF SO -- AND THEN -- AS FAR
AS THE THE APPROACH IS THAT WE
HAVE TO HELP SUPPORT -- CCR AND
MAKING SURE THE KIDS ARE GETTING
THE SERVICES THAT THEY NEED AND
YES YOU'RE TWO PEAS -- WE HAVE
QUITE A FEW EFFORTS THAT ARE
UNDER WAY -- WE HAVE BEEN DOING
SOME REGIONAL COUNTY AND
PROVIDER CONVENIENCE -- WITH OUR
CONTRACTED PROVIDER THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SOLUTIONS AND
ALSO BEEN REALLY -- POPULAR AND
WELL ATTENDED -- CONVENING -- TO
BE ABLE TO TALK ABOUT -- AS HERE
TO FUSE THEIR PEAK FOSTER CARE --
JUST ANYTHING RELATED TO SEE SEE
ARE THAT -- AND SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH -- WE'VE BEEN WORKING
CONTINUING OUR WORK ON
THERAPEUTIC FOSTER CARE
IMPLEMENTATION -- TRACKING THE
DATA -- WE HAVE MONITORING
COMPLIANCE WE DO TRY ANNUAL
REVIEWS AND SO WE'RE ABLE TO
TRACK -- ACCESS THROUGH OUR
TRAINING REVIEW NEWS -- AND THEN
JUST IN GENERAL -- YOU KNOW IT
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PLANS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING OR
ARRANGING FOR THE PROVISION OF
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
TO CHILDREN AND YOUTH TO MEET --
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH MEDICAL
NECESSITY CRITERIA SO -- YOU
KNOW AS PART OF THOSE EFFORTS ON
ALL COUNTY PARTNERS HAVE TO WORK
VERY CLOSELY TOGETHER -- YOU
KNOW WITH REGARD TO S. T. R. T.
P. USING OTHER BEEN ISSUES WITH --
KIND OF SOME COORDINATION SO
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON WE DO
DEPARTMENTS -- CDSS STATIONS
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH OUR
COUNTY ASSOCIATION CWD ACV HDA --
I HAVE TO DEVELOP KIND OF A STEP
BY STEP PROCESS TO REALLY HELP
KIND OF DEVELOP COME A RECIPE OR
LA AND LAYING OUT EXACTLY WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE -- TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE SURE THE KIDS RECEIVE
THE SERVICES MADE THEY NEED IN A
TIMELY MANNER -- SO OTHERS THAT
WORK AND THEN -- JUST IN GENERAL --
FOR SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES -- IN A TRANSITION
PLANNING MAKING SURE THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE A SERVICES BEFORE
DURING AND AFTER THEIR PLACEMENT
BUT ALSO TRANSITION PLANNING AS
WELL.
I HAVE A WOULD END UP BEING
REDUNDANT AND I NOTICE TO YOUR
IT'S TIME SENSITIVE.
OKAY WELL I JUST WANNA BE
SENSITIVE TO EVERYONE TO YOU
BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT OF THINGS
ON OUR AGENDA BUT ALSO BE SURE
WE COVERED THIS -- AND EACH ITEM --
EARLY ENOUGH SO.
OKAY -- ANY COMMENTS FROM A
ALEJO.
AND SEE CENTER IN PLANTATION.
NOT ON THE PARTICULAR MODEL
SERVICES ASPECT OF IT OF THE
OKAY BUT WHAT ABOUT SEIZE YOUR
INFLATION OVERALL.
THE OVERALL SIR -- JUST LIKE
THREE EIGHT ARE -- COMMENTS THAT
WE MADE IN OUR HUMAN SERVICES
PUBLICATION THAT WE DON'T TAKE
AN OVERALL ISSUE WITH ESTIMATES.
FOR THE BUDGET -- GIVEN THAT IT
IT DOES WE DO KNOW THAT IT TAKES
IN AND CUT INTO ACCOUNT THE MORE
RECENT TRENDS IN THE ACTUAL
CASELOAD MOVEMENT -- THAT SAID
THERE ARE.
SOME ISSUES THAT WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION -- ONE BEING THAT
THERE ARE STILL SOME OUTSTANDING
ISSUES OR QUESTIONS RELATED TO
THE LOC OR LEVEL OF CARE RATE
STRUCTURE -- PARTICULARLY IN
TERMS OF THE THE CHECK THE
RECENT CHANGES AT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS MADE TO THE
LC TOOL -- IN CONSULTATION WITH --
STAKEHOLDERS -- AND ANY KINDS OF
OUTSTANDING RISKS AND
UNCERTAINTIES THAT MIGHT STILL
BE -- ASSOCIATED WITH THAT -- AS
WELL AS IN PARTICULAR THE
TIMELINE FOR THE ROCK TO THE
REMAINING A POPULATION OF FOSTER
YOUTH FOR ME WOULD BE APPLIED --
TO AND THE DETAILS ON THE
VALIDITY TESTS THAT WOULD BE
APPLIED -- AFTERWARD -- TO FOR
THEIR VERIFIED THAT VALIDITY --
AND FINALLY -- THE THERE'S STILL
A QUESTION AS TO WHAT THE NET
IMPACT OF IMPLEMENTATION -- OF
THE LOC RATE STRUCTURE WILL HAVE
IN CONJUNCTION WITH PLANS -- FOR
CHANGES TO S. CI OR SUPPLEMENTAL --
CHARACTER INCREMENTS AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL ON WHAT TOTAL --
RATE FAMILIES WILL RECEIVE --
ARE TAKEN CARE FOSTER CHILDREN --
THE OTHER -- ISSUE THAT WE LIKE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
IT ARE -- GIVEN THE IMPORTANCE
OF OUR FAITH IMPLEMENTATION TO
THE OVERALL SUCCESS OF THE CCIR --
WE WE DO NOTE THAT THERE ARE
STILL ISSUES WITH -- DELAYS IN
TERMS OF THE PROCESSING OF OUR
FAILED LOCATIONS BUT COUNTIES
ARE -- EXPERIENCING AND GIVEN
THAT -- WHAT'S THIS YOU MIGHT
WANT TO CONSIDER WHETHER
ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR
THAT IS -- MERITED -- INCLUDING
A SUPPORT FOR FAMILIES WITH THE
PLACEMENT PRIOR TO APPROVAL WHO
ARE STILL EXPERIENCING -- ARE
FAY PROCESSING TIMES AT OUR
EXCEED THE OF THE NINETY DAYS
THAT AS AMENDED BY LAW
[inaudible]
FINANCE [inaudible]
COMMENTS OKAY.
THE ARTIST THEIR FAQ AS.
I MISS READ YOUR OKAY AND I AM
WHAT I AM TO ACTUALLY I LIKE ALL
THE QUESTIONS AS I GO YOU LEFT
THESE OKAY CAN'T SPEAK TO THE
THE TWO QUESTIONS THAT WORKS --
TO THAT THAT MR MILLER JUST
BROKE AND DOES SPEAK TO IF YOU'D
LIKE AND OKAY PLEASE DO YEAH
THANK YOU YEAH I IF YOU CAN
BELIEVE THAT THERE WAS GO
THROUGH ALL THE QUESTIONS AND
AND YEAH AND AND APOLOGIES FOR
MISTER MISREADING YEAR.
YEAH -- YOUR THAT LIKE I DO SAID
LET'S GO THROUGH ALL THE
QUESTIONS THAT IT'S AYE AYES
ELEMENTS SO THAT OTHER GUY Là
PUZZLE THAT.
ALL RIGHT YOU KNOW ANSWER THOSE
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO RIGHT SO ON THAT
THERE IS THE THE QUESTION ON
REGARDING THE THE NINE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
ON OUR IF A AND AND ITS BACKLOG
WELL WE CAN'T DETERMINE
SPECIFICALLY.
HOW MANY HOW HOW MUCH THE
BACKLOG WAS DECREASED BY THOSE
DOLLARS WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT --
THAT THE THE ESPECIALLY IF YOU
LOOK AT THE THAT THE CASE THE
CASES WHERE IT'S THE PLACEMENTS
PRIOR TO APPROVAL.
THOSE -- THOSE HAVE DECREASED --
1818% IN JUST THE LAST FEW
MONTHS -- THE THE TOTAL THE OF
THE I'M SORRY THE GRAPH MISSING
CAP REMINISCENT THE TOTAL OF THE
OF THE ONES THAT ARE OVER.
NINETY BUT IN BETWEEN IT BUT
LESS THAN A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
HAVE DECREASED BY 31%.
AND THE THE ONES THAT ARE OVER A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAYS HAVE
HAVE DECREASED BY 16% WE'VE SEEN.
A TOTAL OF A OF 600-670-00600
AND SIXTY SEVEN ACT APPLICATIONS --
THE DEAD ARE THAT BACKLIT
DECLINED BY SIX HUNDRED SIXTY
SEVEN APPLICATIONS THIS IS JUST
OF THAT THE PLACEMENTS PRIOR TO
APPROVAL THE OVERALL -- AND WHAT
WE'VE NOTICED ON THAT THE TREND
OF ALL OF THE THAT THE RFA
PROCESS IS THAT.
THE THE THE TIME TO APPROVAL
WHILE NOT AT NINETY DAYS IS IS
COMING DOWN AND AT THE SAME TIME
TO PROVE THOSE ARE GOING MORE IT
MORE MORE APPLICATIONS ARE
COMING THROUGH THE DOOR.
CLEARLY THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE
DONE THERE AND AND THE OTHER
QUESTION IS WHAT WHAT WHAT
HAPPENED.
OR HOW WHAT WAS WHAT HOW IS THE
MONEY USE AND WE'VE SEEN IT
BEING USED IN OVERTIME.
SOME SOFTWARE PACKAGES WE'VE
SEEN IT BEING USED -- TO BOX
PROVIDE AND BY MOBILE I'VE
SCANNED MACHINE SO THAT THINGS
COULD BE DONE OUT IN THE FIELD
AND SO WE'VE SEEN OF THOSE AT
THOSE ACTIVITIES AS WELL AS SOME
JUST SOME SOME CHANGES WITHIN IN
SOME DEPARTMENTS ABOUT.
HALF ALL HANDS ON DECK TO CLEAR
THE BACKLOG -- AS A AS A RESULT
AT RESULTING IN THE THE CHANGES
THAT I MENTIONED EARLIER.
AND THEN WITH RESPECT TO THE THE
LEVEL OF CARE -- PROTOCOL BUT
I'D SAY IT WHEN I WHEN I WHEN I
THE THERE IS THE QUESTION IS A
KIND WHEN WILL BE BE DONE I
THINK IS HOW I READ IT RIGHT.
AND SO THERE'S A COUPLE THINGS
I'D SAY WE DID DO EVER RECOVER
RELIABILITY STUDY OF OF OF WHILE
BACK IN IT DETERMINED THAT THE
THE THE TOOL WAS WAS WAS ROBBERY
WAS REASONABLY RELIABLE.
AND THE NEXT STEP WAS TO THEN
ADD.
TO ADD SOME ADDITIONAL YOU KNOW --
AT SOME ADDITIONAL -- KIDS INTO
THE INTO THE USE THE PROTOCOL
AND DIFFERENT CHILDREN ON
ADDITIONAL CHILDREN I'M SORRY.
AND THE WE ARE DOING THAT NOW AT
THE SAME TIME WE'VE DEVELOPED
THE VALIDITY STUDY AND WE WENT
WITH ATTHE CONCLUSION OF THE
VALIDITY STUDIES WILL BE ABLE TO
GO -- MAKE WHATEVER FINAL TWO
WEEKS WE NEED AND THEN GO GO
LIVE FOR FULL IMPLEMENTATION.
AS MR MELINDA'S MENTIONED IN THE
MEAN IN THE INTERIM WE ARE IN
FACT DOING UPDATING THE MANUALS
WE ARE UPDATING SOME OF THE
PLACEMENT AGREEMENTS THAT ARE
THAT ARE KEY.
AND SO THERE'S A NUMBER OF
ACTIVITIES ON THAT AND IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN AND HAVING A
FURTHER DISCUSSION ABOUT THE THE
THE THE SCIENCE BEHIND --
PROTOCOL WOULD BE HAPPY TO HAVE
A DIFFERENT A PRIVATE DISCUSSION
WITH YOU ON THAT OKAY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT AND THEN FIND HE ATE
ISSUE NUMBER.
SIX NUMBER SIX IS IS THE IS THE
THE SO CALLED PAPERS FUNDING TO
FOSTER PARENT RECRUITMENT
RETENTION AND SUPPORT FINING.
SO I WOULD SAY IT AS AS YOU AS
YOU MAY RECALL THE
ADMINISTRATION INCLUDED FLIPPERS
AND SOME ARE OF A FINDING AS
EVER ADDITIONALLY AS AN UP FRONT
INVESTMENT OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD OF TIME WHICH NOW IS
SUNSET IN THE PURPOSE OF THAT
WAS. TO TO JUMP START AND
IDENTIFY SOME ACTIVITIES THAT
WERE REALLY KEY -- TO TO
RECRUITING EVERY TEN AND
RETAINING -- FOSTER FAMILIES --
AND SO THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S WHAT
BROUGHT US TO TO TO TO WHERE WE
ARE TODAY.
THE WHAT WE HAVE WHAT WE HAVE
SEEN -- THE THE FINDING THE USED
FOR AND AT A IS ACTUALLY ON PAGE
TWENTY EIGHT OF OF YOUR AGENDA
THERE'S A PIE CHART.
BUT LARGELY IT'S IT'S BEEN A
GOOD DEAL OF IT HAS BEEN USED TO
SUPPORT EXISTING FOSTER PARENTS --
AS THERE OFTEN -- WORD OF MOUTH
IS A IS A GOOD ARE --
RECRUITMENT STRATEGY AND AND AND
A NUMBER OF CONCRETE SERVICES SO
THAT THAT FAMILIES COULD
ACTUALLY.
TAKE IN YOUNG PEOPLE WHEN --
WHEN THEY NEED -- TO THE THE THE
REMAINING PART OF THE QUESTION
HIS WORLD WHAT AT WHAT ELSE ARE
WE DOING TO SUPPORT THAT KIND OF
WORK AND I WOULD SAY THERE'S A
THERE'S A HANDFUL OF THINGS THAT
WE'RE THAT OUR ON GOING AGAIN.
WE HAVE WE HAVE SUPPORTED --
THROUGH CONTRACT ANNE'S
GOODMAN'S WORK ON CHILD SPECIFIC
RECRUITMENT SHE'S WORKING A
NUMBER OF COUNTIES WE WE HAVE.
WE HAVE WORKED HAVE SUPPORTED
ALONG WITH CW DA THE QUALITY
PARENTING INITIATIVE THAT IS
REALLY FOCUSING ON CHANGING THE
BUSINESS MODEL AND COUNTIES
AROUND -- TRUE PARTNERSHIP WITH
WITH A RESOURCE FAMILIES.
AND WE'RE ENTERING INTO SOME
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE DAVE THOMAS
FOUNDATION -- ABOUT THEIR
WENDY'S WONDERFUL KIDS WHICH
ALSO IS A CHILD SPECIFIC
RECRUITMENT STRATEGY THAT WOULD
BE THAT COULD POTENTIALLY BRING
ADDITIONAL RECRUITERS TO THE
STATE [inaudible]
OKAY.
AND ANY OTHER COME AVAILABLE I
KNOW YOU'RE GIVING A
PRESENTATION OKAY THANK YOU
COVERED IT OKAY FINANCE WITH.
JUST REYES PART OF FINANCE AND I
MANY MISTER ROSE -- AND ANSWERED
ALL THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE LAID
ON THE AGENDA AS WE WOULD AGREE
WITH AND JUST TO REITERATE THAT --
THE DAY IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
DOESN'T PROPOSE ELIMINATING THE
FLIPPERS FUNDING IT'S IT'S STILL
MAINTAINING THE ORIGINAL
AGREEMENT OF THE UP FRONT
INVESTMENT AND THAT'S JUST TO
MAKE THAT CLARIFICATION.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT -- SO NOW WE HAVE
MOVED TO THE PANEL WE HAVE --
DIRECTOR HERE -- VANESSA
HERNANDEZ ALL RIGHT FROM --
CALIFORNIA'S COMMISSION BAG
EASTER DAWSON OKAY I GUESS YOU
GUYS COME ALIVE -- RATES NOVA
COUNTY AND SET THE MONTH SAYS.
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY SO -- ONCE YOU WANT TO GO
AHEAD AND BEGIN YES IT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FRANK MAKE WITH CW
DAY AND I'LL TRY TO BE.
QUICK AND JUST HIT THE
HIGHLIGHTS -- YOUR AGENDA DOES A
REALLY GOOD JOB OUTLINING -- HOW
WISE AND AUDACIOUS AND -- IN
SOME WAYS OVERWHELMING C. C. R.
IS AND IT'S IT'S VERY EXCITING
TO BE ASSOCIATED WITH IT.
AS YOU MIGHT IMAGINE THERE ARE
SOME THINGS THAT WE THINK ARE
WORKING WELL FOR SOME THINGS ARE
VERY MUCH A WORK IN PROGRESS AND
HAVING A GOTTEN TO WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW.
THERE'S SOME AREAS WHERE WE DO
HAVE SOME CONCERN IN EPPING
GAUGE WITH THE STATE TO TRY TO
PROBLEM SOLVE DURING%
IMPLEMENTATION WHAT'S GOING WELL
I THINK WE AGREE WITH MR ROSE SO
I WON'T I WON'T RECOUNT IT --
THE GROUP HOME PLACEMENTS ARE
DOWN WE BELIEVE CF TEAS ARE A
MUCH BETTER WAY OF DOING CASE
WORK WE THINK OUR AFFAIRS A MUCH
BETTER WAY TO GET HIGH QUALITY.
FAMILIES TO CARE FOR KIDS.
THE THE DELAYS ARE STILL THERE
THEY'RE GOING DOWN THE DELAYS
ARE GOING DOWN AND WE'RE VERY
MUCH CONCERNED.
ABOUT THE ELIMINATION OF FUNDING
FOR OUR FAA WHICH YOU'LL HEAR
ABOUT LATER -- WITH RESPECT TO
JUST A COUPLE OF AREAS WHERE
WE'VE BEEN WORKING A LOT WITH
THE STATE -- WERE THINGS THAT
HAVEN'T GONE EXACTLY AS WE'D
HOPED -- THE FIRST IS GROUPON
CONVERSIONS INTO S. T. R. T.
PEAS -- AS OF TODAY -- JUST OVER
HALF OF THE CHILDREN WHO -- ARE
BEING -- SERVING CONGREGATE CARE
ARE IN FACILITIES THAT HAVE NOT
CONVERTED TO AN S. T. R. T. P. --
WHICH MEANS ONLY HALF OF THEM
HAVE -- THOSE FACILITIES THEN
ALSO ULTIMATELY ARE REQUIRED TO
GET A MENTAL HEALTH
CERTIFICATION IN A MENTAL HEALTH
CONTRACT.
MANY OF THE FACILITIES THAT HAVE
NOT MADE IT THROUGH THE S. T. R.
T. P. PIPELINE YET IN OUR
OPINION.
ARE ACTUALLY QUALITY PROVIDERS
BUT THEY MAY BE SMALLER
PROVIDERS AND THE ADMINISTRATIVE
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH
BECOMING LICENSED AND THEN
CERTIFIED AND THEN GETTING A
MENTAL HEALTH CONTRACTOR
CONSIDERABLE.
AND WE THINK THAT IT'S INCUMBENT
UPON ALL OF US TO THINK ABOUT
WAYS TO DEVELOP.
MORE INTENSIVE INTENTIONAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SO THAT
THOSE FACILITIES THAT ARE HIGH
QUALITY AND CAN PROVIDE
EXCELLENT CARE.
pHAVE UNTIL UNDER CURRENT LAW
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST OF THIS
YEAR -- AFTER WHICH CHILDREN
WILL NOT BE ALLOWED TO BE -- IN
THOSE FACILITIES AND AND
PARTICIPATE IN STATE FUNDING AND
SO WE THINK THAT'S THE DATE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO RE VISIT
IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS.
THE SECOND AREA OF I THINK
FOCUSING THINK WE AGREE WITH MR
ROSE AGAIN.
IS -- INTENSIVE FAMILY FINDING
PARTICULARLY FOR FAMILIES.
THAT CAN CARE FOR AND HELP
CHILDREN HAVE EXPERIENCE
SIGNIFICANT TRAUMA HE'LL --
THERAPEUTIC FOSTER CARE IS NOT
EVEN CLOSE TO FULLY ESTABLISHED
ACROSS THE STATE.
AND THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
THAT CC ARE PROMISED FOSTER
FAMILIES.
WHO CARE FOR KIDS WITH
SIGNIFICANT -- COMMA HASN'T
ALWAYS BEEN THERE ARE NO
PROPOSALS BEFORE YOU LATER --
CHANGE TAKES TIME AND WERE VERY
CONCERNED OVERALL ABOUT THE RUG
BEING PULLED OUT FROM UNDER THAT
SUPPORTS PREMATURELY.
PARTICULARLY WITH RESPECT TO
FIBERS AN RFA [inaudible]
X..
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S VANESSA
HERNANDEZ AND I AM THE DIRECTOR
OF POLICY FOR CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTION.
SEE WE SEE AS A YOUTH LED
ORGANIZATION WHO EMPOWER WHO
DEVELOP LEADERS TO EMPOWER EACH
OTHER AND THEIR COMMUNITIES TO
TRANSFORM.
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM THROUGH
POLICY PRACTICE IN LEGISLATIVE
CHANGE.
WHAT MAKES YOU A C. MOST UNIQUE
IS THAT OUR MEMBERS ARE
CURRENTLY IN CARE OR FORMALLY
EIGHT IN CARE AND THEY DEVELOP
THEY IDENTIFIED THE LARGEST GAPS
ON THE WITHIN THE SYSTEM AND
THEY DEVELOP THE SOLUTIONS AND
THE RECOMMENDATIONS?
ON HOW TO IMPROVE THOSE.
SEE WE SEE HAS BEEN ACTIVE
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE REFORMS FOR OVER THE PAST
FIVE YEARS -- WE ARE ENCOURAGED
BY SOME OF THE BRIGHT SPOTS IN
SOME OF THE IMPLEMENTATION WORK
AND WE ARE ALSO HAVE A WAIT AND
SEE APPROACH TO SOME OF THE
OTHER PIECES -- ONE OF THE
BRIGHT SPOTS THAT WE'D LIKE --
TO SHOULD TALK ABOUT BRIEFLY IS
THE TOM FAMILY TEAMS ARE WE'RE
VERY ENCOURAGING EXCITED THAT
THIS IS A NEW SYSTEMATIC WAY IF
INCLUDING YOUNG PEOPLE'S VOICE
AND FAMILY BOYS.
IN A WAY THAT INFORMS ALL
DECISIONS IN THEIR LIVES WE
APPRECIATE THAT WE ARE
RECOGNIZING THEM AS EXPERTS IN
THEIR OWN LIVES -- TODAY I'D
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE C.
C. R. COMPONENTS THAT WE VIEW
IT'S ESSENTIAL TO THE REFORM.
AND THAT ARE NEEDING THE MOST
ATTENTION AND STRATEGY FROM THE
LEGISLATURE THE DEPARTMENT AND
THE COUNTIES -- I DO AGREE WITH
A LOT OF THE COMMENTS SHARED BY
BOTH MISTER ROSEN MISTER MET
THEM -- ONE THING WE'D LIKE TO
ELEVATE IN HIGHLY IN THE SETTING
IS THAT THE STATE I'M NEEDS TO
DRAMATICALLY CHANGE HOW WE
SUPPORT HOME BASE FOSTER HOMES.
OR RESOURCE FAMILIES --
ENCOURAGE STABILITY IN ALL
ASPECTS OF THE FAMILY'S
EXPERIENCE -- WE WE'D LIKE TO
HIGHLAND ELEVATE THAT THIS
STABILITY GOES BEYOND
DISPLACEMENT IT INCLUDES --
EDUCATIONAL STABILITY STABILITY
AND RELATIONSHIPS AND STABILITY
AND QUALITY SERVICES INCLUDING
MENTAL HEALTH -- ANOTHER WAY TO
TALK ABOUT THIS POINT
SPECIFICALLY IS THAT WE NEED
BETTER SYSTEM COORDINATION AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND DELIVERING
SERVICES THAT ARE QUALITY.
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE AND
TIMELY FOR OUR YOUTH AND OUR
FAMILIES.
THE OTHER THING WE'D LIKE TO
ELEVATE IS THAT WE NEED TO
DRAMATICALLY CHANGE HOW WE LOOK
AT THE FORMULA OF HOW WHEN AND
WHY YOU THE END UP IN CONGREGATE
CARE.
WE KNOW THAT DISPROPORTIONATELY
THESE YOUTH ARE OF COLOR WE KNOW
THAT THESE YOU HAVE EXPERIENCE
FIVE OR MORE POLICEMEN CHANGES
AND MANY OF THEM IDENTIFIES LGBT
Q. I EIGHT AND THEY ARE OLDER.
SO WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
FAIR PER PLANS AND WE LOOK AT
HOW ARE IS THIS NEW MONEY BEING
USED -- A PLANE AND EQUITY LANDS
A BASED ON WHO THIS POPULATION
IS IS VERY IMPORTANT WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THIS MONEY IS BEING
USED ON EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAMS.
THAT IT IS EQUITY BASED AND THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE TRAUMA THAT
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
EXPERIENCING WITHIN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM. TO QUICKLY TOUCH
ON THE RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL
PROCESS THAT IDEA IN THE VISION
IS THAT THIS HAPPENS WITH IN
LESS LESS THAN NINETY DAYS.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS CAN BE
I'M A HEAVY ENDEAVOR AND OUR
COMMENT THERE IS THAT
BUREAUCRACY SHOULD NEVER
DIRECTLY IMPACT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
AND FAMILIES AND CARE.
THE LAST COMMENT WE'D LIKE TO
MAKE IS THAT A MAJOR PART OF CCR
IS LOOKING AT ACCOUNTABILITY AND
PERFORMANCE MEASURES OUTCOMES IN
THAT THE I CQ WHY APPROACH.
NEEDS TO BE APPLIED TO MAKE SURE
WE ARE NOT IN THE SAME BOAT WITH
A NEW TYPE OF GROUP HOME IN FIVE
YEARS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OKAY NEXT TRY TO KEEP IT WITHIN
THREE MINUTES.
RIGHT THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE MONTEZ AND I'M A
SUPERVISOR WITH CINEMA COUNTY
FAMILY YOUTH AND CHILDREN'S
SERVICES AND I SUPERVISE OUR
CARE GIVER TREATMENT SUPPORT
UNIT.
BECAUSE QUALITY PARENTING IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT INVENTION THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE YOU THINK CARE
CINEMA COUNTY FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN SERVICES LAUNCHED OUR
CARE GIVER MENTORING PROGRAM IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN CENTS THAN
TEN SEASON RESOURCE PARENT
MENTORS HAVE SUPPORTED FIFTY
FIVE NEWLY APPROVED FAMILIES.
THIS LEVEL PEER SUPPORT HAS BEEN
VITAL AND PLACEMENT STABILITY
AND HELPING CARE GIVERS NOT ONLY
TO PROVIDE THE BEST QUALITY OF
CARE FOR CHILDREN IN USE.
BUT ALSO HELP THEM FEEL
CONFIDENT AND STEPPING OUTSIDE
THEIR COMFORT ZONE. TO CARE FOR
CHILDREN A VERY NEEDS IN AGES
FIBERS FUNDING HAS BEEN CRITICAL
TO SUPPORTING THIS PROGRAM.
THE PROFESSIONALISM OF OUR CARE
GIVERS AND THEIR CONTRIBUTION TO
THE SUCCESS OF CCIR.
CRISTINA CURRENT MENTOR SAYS.
MY INTRODUCTION TO BEING AN
APPROVED FOSTER PARENT WAS A
CALL FROM MY MENTOR TO SAY
WELCOME.
LET'S GET TOGETHER I'M HERE TO
HELP I INSTANTLY THOUGHT A
MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY I WASN'T
ALONE AND HAD SOMEONE TO HELP
NAVIGATE THE CONFUSING WORLD OF
CHILD WELFARE.
AND THEN WHEN THE TIME CAME THAT
I WAS JUST BARELY STAYING AFLOAT
MY MENTOR EMPOWERED ME TO FIND
RESOURCES HAVE EFFECTIVE
COMMUNICATION AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT I MAKING A POSITIVE
DIFFERENCE EVEN WHEN IT DIDN'T
FEEL LIKE I WAS.
I BECAME A MENTOR BAND BECAUSE I
WANTED TO GIVE TO NEW FAMILIES
THE SAME WELCOME AND SUPPORT
THAT I WAS GIVEN.
I BELIEVE WITH A STRONG SUPPORT
NETWORK RESOURCES AND GUIDANCE
AT FAMILY HAS THE IDEAL
FOUNDATION TO BEST CARE FOR OUR
YOUTH IN CARE.
THE MENTOR PROGRAM IS A STRONG
PILLAR OF THIS FOUNDATION AND I
AM THANKFUL TO HAVE HAD A MENTOR
AND I AM PROUD TO NOW PROVIDE.
THAT LEVEL OF SUPPORT FOR NEW
RESOURCE FAMILIES.
WITH THE SUPPORT OF OUR MENTOR
ANOTHER ONE OF OUR FAMILIES WHO
HISTORICALLY ONLY TOOK INFANTS
AND TODDLERS.
STEPPED OUT OF THEIR COMFORT
ZONE TO CARE FOR SIBLINGS TWO
BOYS AND MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL.
THIS RESOURCE FAMILY WHO
PROVIDED TEMPORARY CARE IN ORDER
TO KEEP THEM OUT OF OUR
EMERGENCY SHELTER.
AND AND A FAMILY HOME ENDED UP
CONNECTING WITH THESE BOYS IN A
WAY THAT WE COULD HAVE NEVER
ANTICIPATED.
THEY MAINTAIN CONTACT WITH THE
FAMILY EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE NOW
WITH THEIR FOREVER FAMILY AND
BECAUSE OF THE SUPPORT THE
FAMILY RECEIVED THESE BOYS HAVE
YOU BEEN MORE CARING ADULTS IN
THEIR HOME.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- CINEMA COUNTY HAS --
REALLY I THINK BENEFITTED FROM
C. C. R. AND THE FIRST FUNDING
BECAUSE ONE OF THINGS IT'S A LOT
OF TO DO IS REALLY LOOK AT SORT
OF RELATIONSHIP BASED WAY OF
DOING CHILD WELFARE -- AND AN
EXAMPLE OF WHAT HAS CHANGED
SIGNIFICANTLY IN OUR COUNTY IS
FOUR YEARS AGO WE HAD OVER A
HUNDRED CHILDREN CONGREGATE CARE.
AND AS OF LAST MONTH WE WERE
DOWN -- TO THIRTY AND THAT'S A
SIGNIFICANT SHIFT -- SOME OF THE
WAYS THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO
THAT IS THROUGH -- IMPROVED GATE
KEEPING UP BY CREATING A
COMMITTEE THAT REVIEWS CHILDREN
THAT ARE -- AND APPROVED ANY
CHILD THAT IS GOING TO GO IN A
IS BEING CONSIDERED FOR
CONGREGATE CARE AND THEN ALSO
LOOKING AT WHAT ARE OTHER
OPTIONS.
AND WHEN CHILDREN ARE READY TO
STEP DOWN REALLY BEGINNING TO
PLAN FOR THAT AHEAD OF TIME --
WE ALSO WITH THROUGH C. C. R.
AND ALSO THROUGH FLIPPERS HAVE
IMPLEMENTED THE FAMILY FINING
COLLABORATION WHICH IS EIGHT
COUNTY BASED ON A COUNTY WIDE
APPROACH TO RECRUITMENT SO WE
WORK WITH OUR FFA IS IN OUR
COUNTIES.
IN OUR MARKETING AND RECRUITMENT --
WE DO COMBINED EVENTS WE DO
COMBINED TRAINING AND SUPPORT
GROUPS AND REALLY LOOK AT IT AS
A COUNTY AGAIN IT'S THE IDEA OF
RELATIONSHIPS WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITY AND CONNECTING
TOGETHER TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT FOR
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN -- ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF KIND OF A UNIQUE
PROGRAM THAT WE'VE CREATED OUT
OF C. C. R. AND WITH SUPPORT.
FROM PEPPERS HAS BEEN A CO
PARENTING MODEL -- AND THIS IS
WHERE WE REALLY -- LOOK AT
BUILDING RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN
OUR BIRTH PARENTS BIRTH PARENTS
AND RESOURCE PARENTS -- AND
WE'VE DONE THIS THROUGH OUR
BIRTH PARENT FOSTER PARENT
PARTNERSHIP WHICH BRINGS A
SOCIAL WORKER -- A FOSTER PARENT
MENTOR -- AND BIRTH PARENT
MENTOR TOGETHER -- TO REALLY
HELPED BUILD THE CONNECTION
BETWEEN THE BIRTH PARENT FOSTER
PARENT AND THEY DO THIS THROUGH --
SHARED DECISION MAKING ON GOING
COMMUNICATION AND REALLY KEEPING
THE CHILD AT THE CENTER -- AND
NO MATTER WHAT WAY THE CASE GOES --
THE CHILD IS ALWAYS SUCCESSFUL
WHETHER THE PARENT RE UNIFIES OR
IF WE HAVE ANOTHER PERMANENCY
CHOICE FOR THAT KID -- BECAUSE
THEY GET TO KEEP THE PEOPLE THAT
WERE IMPORTANT IN THEIR LIVES
PART OF THEIR LIVES AND SO -- WE
SEE THAT A SUCCESS FOR THAT
CHILD HOWEVER THE CASE GOES --
SOME OTHER THINGS THAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO DO UNDER C. C. R.
IS IN -- DEVELOP THE CARE GIVER
RECRUITMENT SUPPORT TEAM WHICH
STEPHANIE -- OVERSEAS AND THAT
REALLY ALLOWS US TO PROVIDE THE
SUPPORT FOR FAMILIES SO THAT WE
CAN STRETCH THEM TO TAKE ON KIDS
THAT THEY DIDN'T THINK OF
OTHERWISE -- OR THAT THEY WERE
AFRAID TO BUT NOW THAT THEY HAVE
THE SUPPORT OF A MENTOR AND THEY
HAVE THE SUPPORT OF A TEAM.
THEY'RE WILLING -- TO CONSIDER
TAKING AND MEDICALLY FRAGILE
CHILD OR CONSIDER TAKING A
SIBLING GROUP OR OLDER CHILDREN --
AND I BELIEVE THE FACT BECAUSE I
COULD GO ON AND ON THANK YOU --
SO ACTUALLY -- IT'S WHAT CRITICS
DIED IN AND OTHERS OF THE AND
WE'RE GONNA HEAR SOME
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS LATER ON
BUT SO THERE'S A LOT
CONVERSATION ABOUT FAVORS AND
THE MONEY AND DALY OF THE PIE
CHART AND THE THING AND ACTUALLY
WHILE MOST.
WHILE.
PERHAPS A LARGE PORTION GOES THE
CARE GIVERS I MEAN IT'S STILL
EVEN THAT PORTION IS NOT THAT
THAT'S LIKE WHAT. TWENTY JOINT
FRACTION OF IT SO IT'S MAYBE
LIKE.
TWENTY DAHLE CARRIER SUPPORTS
PROBABLY.
IN THE NASH TRAIN AT FIVE TESTS
ABOUT QUARTER OF THAT MONEY SO
[inaudible]
TORRANCE.
SAYING OH MY GOD THE MONEY'S
GOING AWAY FOR PREFERS BUT WHAT
EXACTLY SO WHAT HOW AND BUT
YOU'RE SAYING THAT THERE'S OTHER
MONIES IT'S COMING IN THAT'S THE
DIRECTLY LIKE.
CAN WE CLARIFY WHAT'S WHAT WHAT
IS THE PLAN AND AROUND.
THE OF USERS FOR THE TEMPORARY
TO WRITE AND THEN -- SUPPOSE SO.
CAN CAN -- CAN IT BE FOR
ABSOLUTE SO YET YOU WANTED TO
TALK ABOUT IT SO HOW.
DOES IT DO THAT USE SAYING THAT
WHILE YOU'RE STILL GAME I JUST
GOT COME FROM A DIFFERENT PLACE
OR USE THAT OUR HOUSE IS
SUPPOSED TO WORK SO. EIGHT I
THINK WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
SAYS THAT THAT THE FIRST ONE IS
AND IT'S IT'S NOT A NEW IDEA.
A FOSTER PARENT RECRUITMENT
RETENTION SUPPORT IS SOMETHING
THAT HAS BEEN GOING ON AND
COUNTIES IN WAS INCLUDED IN PART
AGAIN AND TO MENTION -- THE TWO
THOUSAND THE REALIGNMENT SO
COUNTIES OF ALWAYS BEEN
RESPONSIBLE -- FOR FOR A LOT OF
THAT WILL COME WITH PAPERS
ACTIVITIES WHEN SIX HERE IS A
WAS DEVELOPED ONE OF THE
AGREEMENTS WAS IS BECAUSE WERE.
WERE THE STATE'S LOOKING TO
ELIMINATE GROUP HOMES AT A
FASTER RATE WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE IS UP FRONT INVESTMENT TO
HELP ASSIST WITH THAT.
WITH THE AND AND ALL
STAKEHOLDERS LEGISLATURE ONE AT
THE TIME IN AGREED -- THAT THAT
THAT WOULD BE THE APPROACH THAT
THERE WOULD BE THIS UPFRONT
INVESTMENT TO HELP WITH THAT
BECAUSE THESE ARE GONNA STILL BE --
ACTIVITIES THAT COUNTIES ARE
GONNA RESPONSE WERE DOING GOING
FORWARD -- SO -- TO THE EXTENT
THAT THIS ENDS UP BEING ME
COMING IN A AYE LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITY.
WELL -- TO CONTINUE OR ADD
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THESE
ACTIVITIES THAT WERE HAPPY.
TO ENGAGE IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS
WITH HIM PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE -- BUT WE JUST AGAIN
THAT WORK.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THIS
RELATED FUNNY IN IS IS
MAINTAINING THE AGREEMENT THE
ESSENTIAL HOUSES ARE WAS GOING --
TO TO MOVE FORWARD.
MISTER CHAIR IF I COULD I FROM
THE COUNTY STANDPOINT WE SORT OF
A GREEN PARDON DISAGREE IN PART --
THE THE IDEA THAT -- THERE WAS
ALL IT WAS ALWAYS THE COUNTY'S
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO FOSTER
PEREGRINE IT'S TRUE -- BUT THAT
WAS WHEN THE LAWS DIDN'T
PROSCRIBED THE USE OF CONGREGATE
CARE FACILITIES -- AND
COMPLETELY CHANGE THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM SO THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE STATE. TO
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES NECESSARY
TO ALLOW THE COUNTIES TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN IMPLEMENTING C. C.
R. WHICH IS THE LEGISLATIVE
REQUIREMENT I THINK CHANGED THE
NATURE.
OF WHAT THE OBLIGATIONS WERE
BETWEEN THE STATE IN THE
COUNTIES PRIOR.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN I THINK THE
OTHER THING I WANT TO SAY IS
THAT THE IDEA THAT FLIPPERS OR
FOR THE ENHANCED FOSTER PARENT
RECRUITMENT RETENTION IS SOMEHOW
SOMETHING.
THAT YOU ONLY NEED TO FUND UP
FRONT AND THEN ONCE THAT HAPPENS
WERE GOOD -- IT'S FLAWED.
LARGELY BECAUSE MANY OF THE
FAMILIES THAT WERE RECRUITING
AND SUPPORTING A RELATIVE CARE
GIVERS.
AND WE ASK THEM TO COME INTO --
OUR SYSTEM IN CARE FOR THEIR CAN
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THEY WERE
LOOKING TO DO WE KNOCKED ON
THEIR THE IT ON THEIR DOOR.
VERY FEW OF THEM WHEN THAT CHILD
REACHES PERMANENCY OR REACHES
MAJORITY SAYS.
HEY I'VE BEEN RECRUITED THAT
USED PEPPERS MONEY I'M GOING TO
STAY IN THE POOL AND SO.
THE NEED FOR A HIGH A NUMBER OF
HIGH QUALITY FAMILIES TO CARE
FOR CHILDREN GIVEN THAT MANY OF
THEM ARE GOING TO BE RELATIVES
MEANS THE WORK NEVER ENDS.
THE INTENSITY OF THE ON GOING
WORK NEVER ENDS AND SO I DON'T
THINK THAT THE PREMISE THAT
SOMEHOW FLIPPERS.
IS A STATE OBLIGATION THAT ENDS
AT SOME POINT IS CONSENT IS
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT WE KNOW TO
BE THE WAY C. C. R. IS ROLLING
OUT.
OKAY -- COMING FROM [inaudible]
THE NEED.
SUCH SERVICE TO THAT -- I THINK
EVERYTHING THAT YOU'VE HEARD IS
IS CRACKED -- I I THINK THOUGH
IT'S A MISTAKE.
THAT WE WOULD CONSIDER THINGS
ALTHOUGH WE BUDGET THEM BY LINE
ITEM TO THINK THAT TE TOTALITY
NEEDS TO BE CONTINUED AS AS
INDIVIDUAL LINE ITEMS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH -- C. C. R.
WAS NEVER INTENDED AS A FISCAL
COST SAVING MEASURE.
IT WAS ALWAYS INTENDED TO
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES.
AND FIRMLY ROOTED IN THE BELIEFS
REFLECTED LATER IN THE FEDERAL
LAW FF PSA THAT WE DISCUSSED
EARLIER -- THAT KIDS ARE BETTER
IN HOME BASED FAMILY CARE
SITUATIONS RATHER THAN
CONGREGATE CARE SITUATIONS
ALTHOUGH THERE'S AN APPROPRIATE
ROLE OF COURSE FOR CONGREGATE
CARE AS WELL.
BUT DIFFERENT COUNTIES ARE IN
DIFFERENT PLACES IN TERMS OF
THEIR ABILITY SOME HAD ALREADY
VERY LOW RATES OF CONGREGATE
CARE -- CONGREGATE CARE ALSO
TENDS TO BE VASTLY MORE
EXPENSIVE -- IN PART BECAUSE OF
THE NEED TO TREATMENT NEEDS OR
THE SERVICE NEEDS OF THE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES -- AND THE
REDUCTION IN THAT CONGREGATE
CARE ALSO PROVIDES A IS A
REDUCTION IN PLACEMENTS AND
CONGREGATE CARE NOT ONLY
PROVIDES IMMEDIATE MONTH TO
MONTH FISCAL SAVINGS RELATIVE TO
A HOME BASED PLACEMENT.
BUT ALSO YOU HAVE TO HAVE THAN A
CONVERSATION ABOUT PLACEMENT
STABILITY.
PLACEMENT DURATION.
OF THE LIFE OUTCOMES OF THE USE
AND THE NUMBER OF ACES THAT
THEY'RE EXPOSED.
TO THE NUMBER OF RELATIONSHIPS
THAT MAY BE ENDED OR MAINTAINED
SO I I THINK IT'S A MISTAKE TO
THINK ABOUT.
INDIVIDUAL LINE ITEMS ALTHOUGH
THEY'RE IMPORTANT -- WE NEED TO
BE FOCUSED ON THE OUTCOMES WERE
TRYING TO WILL SHE EVEN FIGURE
OUT WHAT IT TAKES TO GET THERE
AS A WHOLE PACKAGE.
I THINK THAT'S THE MAIN PART OF
MY QUESTION IS IS REALLY COMES
DOWN TO OKAY WELL WE HAVE A
CERTAIN DREAM AND STRUCTURE.
IN TERMS OF HOW WE LABEL
DIFFERENT.
PIECES OF MONEY [inaudible]
CURRENTLY AND LIVING.
FOR STATE SO AND THE VALUES YOU
SEE THIS PART SHARDS THEY WILL
WORDS MAY ACTUALLY GO AND IT'S
GOING TO A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS AND THE QUESTION IS IS
THAT.
IS THE TOTAL LEVEL SUPPORT.
NECESSARY THERE AND MAYBE IF.
WE MORE SPECIFICALLY LABEL LIKE
OKAY WELL WE'RE GOING TO BOOST
MONEY UP HERE FOR THIS PURPOSE
AND SO FORTH BUT THAT.
THE GUY A ON VERSES LIKE -- WELL
ENOUGH SO WE REDUCING THIS AND
WE'RE INCREASING THIS ONLY JUST
REDUCING THIS.
RIGHT AND CERTAINLY I THINK THE
THE SPEAKS TO THE NEED -- FOR
SAID YOU RECRUITING FAMILIES
THEY NEED TO KNOW THE SUPPORT IS
THERE A DATE DATE.
IT'S IT'S NOT THAT'S GOING TO GO
AWAY AND THERE'S ALWAYS NEW
FAMILIES RIGHT THERE'S
UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S NEW KIDS
TO ENTER TO SYSTEM AND THERE'S
NEW FOSTER FAMILIES AND I THINK
IT IS I JUST HAVE TO SAY IN THE
SHORT RUN.
THE URGENT QUESTION AS ARE THE
RESOURCES GOING TO BE THERE FOR
COUNTIES TO BE SUCCESSFUL TO
IMPLEMENT THE STATE MANDATES.
IF IN A IF IN A LONGER RUN OR
MEDIUM TERM RUN THE STATE WANTS
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH THE
COUNTIES ABOUT.
CHANGING THE NATURE OF HOW WE
FIND ON AN ONGOING BASIS C. C.
R..
THAT THE CONVERSATION WE'RE
HAPPY TO HAVE WE CAN'T REDEFINED
PROP.
THIRTY THAT'S IN THE
CONSTITUTION -- BUT TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE CAN WORK WITHIN
THE BOUNDS OF PROP THIRTY IN
TALK ABOUT.
DIFFERENT MORE EFFECTIVE WAYS TO
FUND THE PROGRAM TO GET THE
OUTCOMES MAKE WE WANT WE SAY.
ABSOLUTELY BUT IN THE SHORT RUN
I'M TELLING YOU FROM THE COUNTY
STANDPOINT IF WE PULL THE RUG
OUT FROM UNDER OUR A FANFIC PERS
WE'RE NOT GOING TO SUCCEED.
YOU KNOW I MEAN OBVIOUSLY WE
SUPPORT WHAT'S CONTAINED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND AND BUT
WE'RE ALSO RECOGNIZING THAT THE
WORLD IS NOT STATIC AND WE WOULD
BE HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS.
YOU DON'T GET KIDS OUT OF
CONGREGATE CARE WITHOUT HOME
BASE PLACEMENTS TO PUT THEM IN
THAT'S WHAT THE FLIPPERS MONEY
WAS ALL ABOUT.
MISTER MAC IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
NOT ONLY ARE THE MORE OF THEM
RELATIVES BUT WE NEED MORE OF
THEM PERIOD THAN PREVIOUSLY THEY
HAD.
AND ARE RFA FUNDING THAT YOU
THAT THAT WAS TALKED ABOUT
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL TO GET
THEM TO BE APPROVED PLACEMENTS
IS A SIGNIFICANT WORKLOAD AND
THERE'S A BACKLOG THERE.
AND WE HAVE BEEN ADDING FUNDING
AS WE GO ALONG TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS THAT WE SEE EMERGENCY C.
R. IMPLEMENTATION CONTINUES OKAY.
AND THE OTHER GUESTS -- QUESTION
DOES BROUGHT UP WAS ABOUT -- IN
GROUP HOMES FOR ONLY HALF OF
THEM ARE NOW -- QUALIFY TO BE
STR TNCS [inaudible]
AND THAT'S HOW WE HELP THE OTHER.
HALF THAT ARE GOOD WHOCOMES BUT
IN A WAY HAVE CHALLENGES BECAUSE
THE SCALE SIZE RESOURCES
ETCETERA.
ARE WE RIGHT NOW OUR OUR OUR
TEAM.
AND OUR COLLEAGUES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND OFTEN THE
ASSOCIATIONS AND FRANKLY THE
COUNTIES WHO HAVE WRITTEN
LETTERS OF SUPPORT FOR THE
VARIOUS -- PROGRAMS ARE HAVE
TELEPHONE CONVERSATIONS ON A
REGULAR BASIS TO TRY TO REDEFINE
REFINE THE PROGRAM STATEMENTS
THAT IT MEETS THE QUALIFICATIONS
OF THAT WAS INTENDED SO THAT
THAT WE CAN THAT WERE -- THAT
WORSE WE FEEL COMFORTABLE THAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO TO TO TO SERVE
THAT THE YOUNG PERSON WITH THAT
LEVEL OF NEED THAT IS WHAT IS
SUGGESTED BY.
A BEFORE THREE SO WE'RE HAVE A
WE HAVE A GOOD DEAL OF OUR STAFF
AND SOME CONSULTANTS WORKING --
ALONG SIDE -- ARE A NUMBER OF
THE PROVIDERS AS WERE -- IN AND
ENTER IT GREG LIVE IT SENATOR TO
PROCESS AND AT SOME LEVEL
PAINFUL FOR ALL ALL ALL PARTIES
BUT IT'S REALLY INTENDED TO BE
REALLY CLEARLY -- IT A WAY TO DO
THAT WE FEEL COMFORTABLE THAT
FOLKS TAKE BEFORE GIVE SOMEBODY
A LICENSE THAT WE KNOW THEY CAN
SUPPORT THAT THAT LEVEL OF NEED.
AND BECAUSE WERE FOLKS WE'RE NOT
WE'RE FLAT WERE FOCUSING MORE ON
OUTCOME AND QUALITY THAN WE DID
IN THE PAST WE WANNA HOLD FOLKS
ACCOUNTABLE TO IS THE PROGRAM
STATEMENT IN WHICH THEY THE
STATE THEY WROTE.
THIS IS HOW WE DO OUR WORK THIS
IS HOW WE'RE GOING TO GET OUR
OUTCOMES AND RATHER THAN JUST
GOING IN AND KIND OF COUNTING
WIDGETS AND COUNTING PROCESSES
WE WANT TO BE ABLE.
TO SAY YOU THIS IS HOW YOU GO
ABOUT YOUR WORK AND SO WE IT HAS
BEEN AN ARDUOUS PROCESS NO DOUBT
WE ARE MAKING SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS THERE ARE SOME THERE
ARE SOME PROVIDERS THAT HAVE.
MADE OTHER CHOICES -- AND SOME
JUST PROVIDERS THAT WE HAVE AT I
TALKED WITH ABOUT MAKING OTHER
CHOICES [inaudible]
OKAY.
AND THEN WHEN IT COMES TO I KNOW.
THE PRESENTED ABOUT -- IN TERMS
OF YEAH THE MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAM APPROVAL WITH THESE ARE
THERE SPECIFIC THINGS THE I MEAN
IS THERE A WAY TO WEAKEN.
HELP THE ONES WHO ARE INTERESTED --
WHO MAY HAVE FEW RESOURCES GET
THAT KIND OF APPROVAL AND A WHAT
KIND OF BARRIERS ARE ARE TO TO
THAT PIECE OF IT?
I MEAN THAT'S WHY I THINK WITH
OUR CONVENIENCE WERE BEEN TRYING
TO DO THAT TRYING TO GET TA OUT
TO THE COUNTIES IN THE PROVIDERS
TO HELP THEM WITH THOUGHT AND WE
HAVE OUR REVIEWERS ON YOU KNOW
WE HAD LATELY ASK ANOTHER
QUESTION AND AND RELATE THAT AND
I DON'T.
KNOW WHETHER YOU HAVE THE ANSWER
ONE OF THE OTHER FANS SO -- IS
THAT YOU TRY TO GET T. A.'S OUT
TO THESE PEOPLE IS THAT.
ARE THEY FEELING LIKE A T. A.'S
HELPFUL ENOUGH THIRTY GETTING
ENOUGH SUPPORT.
ON THAT PIECE.
THERE'S ONLY NINETEEN AS TIER
TEEPEES HAVE MET ALL THE MENTAL
HEALTH QUALIFICATIONS.
NINETEEN IN THE STATE HAS NINE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
CONGREGATE CARE FACILITIES --
OKAY IT'S THE THAT CAPACITY TO
DO PROPER BILLING AND
DOCUMENTATION AND IT'S IT IT'S
YOU KNOW SOMEWHAT IT'S A LOT OF
WORK AND IT'S DIFFICULT AND I
APPRECIATE THAT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CONVENING.
BUT IT'S OUR OBSERVATION THAT IT
NOW IT'S TIME TO DO A LITTLE
MORE.
HAND IN HAND.
FACILITY SPECIFIC -- TRAINING
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
BUILD OFF OF THE MORE GENERAL.
SORT OF WEAPON OUR SYMPOSIA TO
SAY.
WE THINK THESE FACILITIES ARE
GOOD THESE ARE THESE THESE CAN
BE HEALING PLACES FOR CHILDREN.
LET'S FIGURE OUT HOW TO HELP
THEM SPECIFICALLY AND IT'S THAT
TYPE OF I THINK INTENSIVE
SUPPORT FOR THIS FOR THIS GROUP
OF FACILITIES THAT WE WOULD LIKE
TO WORK WITH THE STATE.
AND THE PROVIDER COMMUNITY I'M
TO HELP THOSE FACILITIES ARE YOU
JUST THE RIGHT IN ITS NINETEEN
OUT HOW MANY.
THERE'S ABOUT NINE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE CONGREGATE CARE
FACILITIES I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
OF THEM INTEND RIGHT YES RIGHT.
OKAY BUT NOT LIVE AT NINETY OKAY
SO CAN CAN CAN YOU SPEAK TO ALL
OF YOU MY NUMBER SO OKAY.
AS OF APRIL FIFTH -- WE'VE
RECEIVED -- A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
NINE APPLICATIONS FOR MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAM APPROVALS OKAY --
WE'VE CONDUCTED NINETY EIGHT
REVIEWS OF THE NINETY EIGHT
REVIEWS OF SIXTY SIX MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAM APPROVALS HAVE
BEEN GRANTED THESE ARE FOR S. T.
OPPORTUNITIES IT JUST.
I DON'T KNOW FOR THOMAS
SOMETHING DIFFERENT IT WAS.
MY POINT WAS TO MEETING ALL
THREE MENTAL HEALTH REQUIREMENTS
WHICH INCLUDES GETTING A
CONTRACT.
AND IT TO THE CONTRACTOR OKAY.
SO SO SO THIS IS A SILLY SORT OF
THAT HAVE PASSED THE MENTAL
HEALTH APPROVAL THEY'VE GOTTEN
MEDI CAL CERTIFIED AND THEY HAVE
A CONTRACT.
WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PLAN OKAY THAT'S NINETY
EIGHT NINETEEN AND YOU YOU HAVE
PROBABLY THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO.
MAY NOT YET HAVE A CONTRACT
AFTER THE OKAY.
WELL LET ME JUST.
SO -- ABOUT DEADLINE SO WHAT'S
THE GOAL LIKE END OF THE YEAR
WERE SHOULD BE VIçT.
LIKE END OF TWENTY NINETEEN HOW
MANY PEOPLE SHOULD BE WHERE.
AT THIS IS NOT MEANT TO SOUND
SORT OF TRIED BUT IT SHOULD BE
EVERYBODY THAT WE NEED OR WE'RE
GONNA NEED SOME PROCESS FOR AN
EXTENSION FOR THOSE FACILITIES
THAT.
WE CONTINUE TO THINK -- SHOULD
BE PLACES FOR CHILDREN BUT WHO
WE CAN'T.
CAN'T GET ACROSS THE LINE BY THE
END OF THIS CALENDAR YEAR YES
DCS WHAT'S I MEAN.
OBVIOUSLY THE CONTRACT WITH THE
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH.
OF IT YEAH SO RIGHT SO RIGHT
THAT THAT THAT'S NOT YOUR PIECE
OF IT OBVIOUSLY WE WE CAN TALK
TO THE HERE FOR ALL DIRECTORS
ABOUT THAT BUT IN TERMS OF YOUR
PIECE OF IT.
ARE YOU PLAYING ARE YOU GONNA BE
ABLE TO QUOTE ARE YOU GET
EVERYBODY BY THE END OF THE YEAR
ARE WELL WE'RE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING JUST APPLICATIONS THAT
WE'VE BEEN RECEIVING AND WORKING
WITH THE COUNTY SO AND IT REALLY
JUST COMES ON AND AS AS FAR AS
YOU KNOW.
IF THEY'RE PASSING ALL THE
REQUIREMENTS TO GET THE APPROVAL
AND TO GET THE CERTIFICATION SO
WE'RE PROVIDING ALL THE TA THAT
WE CAN TO THE COUNTIES TO GET
THEM READY TO GO AND AND WE'VE
BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THEM SO.
OKAY HERE COUNTIES AND HERE'S
THE GROUP.
SO I MEAN I THAT IS THE COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH PLANS AND THE HAVE
TO CONTRACT WITH THE S. T. R. T.
P. PROVIDERS IN A WEEK I MEAN
ASIDE FROM T. A AND I WAS THAT'S
IMPORTANT OUR OUR IS THERE SOME
MINOR CHANGE FROM IS AFRAID.
LIKE.
SO WE KNOW SOLD BY THE END OF
THE YEAR WE KNOW HOW THAT THE
ART OF WHAT WHAT KIND OF
INCENTIVES ARE THINGS ARE
GETTING TOO SO THAT THE
MONITORING.
HOW MANY ARE ACTUALLY HAVING
CONTRACTS WITH?
OKAY YOU TELL HOW TO GET A
CONTRACTOR TO ACTUALLY
CONTRACTING.
I GUESS THAT'S MY QUESTION I I
THINK THERE'S A LOT THAT GOES
INTO IT SO IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
ALL THE DIFFERENT THERE'S
THERE'S MANY DIFFERENT STOPS AND
REMEMBER I'M WE CAN TALK ABOUT
AND WE TALK ABOUT THAT IN AN H.
P. ENOUGH HOW WE CONTRACT WITH
THEM.
BUT YOU KNOW IMAGE PEAS ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO CONTRACT THEY HAVE
SELECTIVE PROVIDER CONTRACTING
BUT THE CCR MODEL IS FOR US TO
YOUR TWO PEAS DUE TO HAVE A
GUEST HERE TO PEACE CANNOT EXIST
WITHOUT THESE -- THE SEE THAT'S
WHAT I'M WORRIED ABOUT YOU I
KNOW I CAN'T EXIST WITHOUT THEM
YEAH THE IN YOUR SIR TELLING ME
WELL THE OF EXCLUSIVE CONTRACTS
AND THEY DON'T HAVE TO CONTRACT
SO.
AND THE RIGHT PIECES HAVE TO BE
IN PLACE SO THEY HAVE TO HAVE
THE MEDICAL CERTIFICATION IN
PLACE THEY HAVE TO HAVE THE
PROGRAM APPROVAL IN PLACE AND I
THINK -- FOR A LOT OF THESE S.
T. R. T. P. IS THEY'RE NOT USED
THIS IS ALL THE NEW PROGRESS
WELL OKAY SO SO SO.
WHAT I'M?
SORRY ON THE OUT OF ANY OF YOUR
OF TRAINS.
YOU KNOW I'M REALLY NERVOUS
ABOUT AN ITEM THAT AND WHEN DID
YOU START TWENTY TO START
GETTING APPLICATIONS HOW LONG
THIS IS THAT WHEN YOU CITY GOT.
NINETY EIGHT SIXTY SIX I MEAN
THIS IS SINCE LAST YEAR ALONE SO
THIS IS THE WHOLE YEAR.
ANNUALLY THIS FAR.
WHAT IT IS NOW APRIL?
THEY HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
LICENSE AND I KNOW I GET IT
RIGHT OKAY WELL I I GUESS I
GUESS THE QUESTION IS IS THAT
WE'RE GONNA END UP BY.
ANDERSON THE TWENTY NINETEEN I
MEAN I AND I'M WORRIED ABOUT
DEADLINES NOW DO YOU TO CHANGE
SOME DEADLINES OR WHAT OVER ARE
WE ARE GOING TO BE -- IT DOES
DEADLINES.
ARE WE GOING TO HAVE A LOT OF
WE'RE GONNA FIND OURSELVES LIKE
OH MY GOD WE ONLY HAVE A HANDFUL
OF THIS YEAR PEAS AVAILABLE AND
EVERYONE ELSE IS OUT NOW AND
WE'RE YEAH I THINK.
IT'S OF CAUSING CONCERN.
OKAY I WON'T LET.
CONCERNED OKAY ARE YOU CONCERNED
OKAY I'M GOOD YOUNG CONCERNED
OKAY.
I I THINK THERE WERE ALL DAY
THERE'S CLEARLY THERE IS --
THERE EVERYBODY IS IS CONCERNED
I THINK WHAT.
THE THE THE LAW LAID OUT THIS
KIND OF LINEAR PROCESS YOU GET
YOUR LICENSE FIRST THAT YOU GO
THROUGH THIS OTHER STUFF.
THAT THAT THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS FOR EXAMPLE WE HAVE MORE
PEOPLE LICENSE THEN WE DO HAVE
WITH MENTAL HEALTH APPROVAL EVEN
APPLICATIONS AND IS THERE IS A
LINEAR PROCESS AND I DO THINK --
WE WOULD WE WOULD WE CAN AND
SHOULD TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION
WHERE YOU KNOW WHERE WE ARE AND
IF THERE IS IF WE IF IF WE CAN'T
WE CAN'T -- YOU KNOW WITH THEIR
THERE'S NO INTENTION TO THROW
YOU YOUNG PEOPLE OUT ON THE
STREET THERE'S NO INTENTION. TO
TO IT IT TO TO DO TO DO HARM I
THINK SO WE WE MAY HAVE TO LOOK
AT YOU KNOW IF IF WE EXTENDED
GROUP HOMES A LOT LONGER WHAT
WOULD THE CRITERIA.
BE AND WHAT WOULD THE
ACCOUNTABILITY STRUCTURE BE SO
THAT WAY THAT WE COULD GET TO A
A POSITION WHERE WE HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE.
PLACES FOR CHILDREN TO LIVE AND
AND I THINK THAT'S I THINK
THAT'S THAT'S PARTLY WILL OUR
DISCUSSION WITH THE THE COUNTIES
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET THERE IS A
REAP THERE'S A THERE'S AN THAT
REQUIREMENT.
THAT SWEET YOU KNOW HOW IS THAT
IT'S A KNOWN AS YOU KNOW THIS --
PART TO DATE AND PART OF THAT IS
WORKING WITH OUR COUNTY
COLLEAGUES -- TO COOK WE'VE CALL
IT WE WERE OUT OF COLLECTING
DATA TO TURN TRY TO DETERMINE
WHAT IS THE CAPACITY NEED. FOR
ANY INDIVIDUAL JURISDICTION IN
TERMS OF ITS CONGREGATE CARE
NEEDS IT'S IT'S HOME BASE NEEDS
IT CETERA AND THEN HOW CLOSE TO
THAT THAT MARK ARE EACH ONE OF
THOSE COUNTIES -- AND HOW AND
HOW CAN WE FACILITATE -- THE
THAT EXPEDITING YOU KNOW THE THE
PROCESS SO THAT WE CAN GET FOLKS
LICENSE YOU NEED TO BE LICENSE.
SO WHAT I I THINK WE'RE IN IT
WERE IN A PROCESS NOW TO IT
IDENTIFY.
BECAUSE ONE OF YOUR QUESTIONS IS
HOW WE KNOW WE HAD THE RIGHT
NUMBER AND FRANK SAYS WE
ABSTRACT SAYS WE NEED WHAT WE
NEED AND I THINK THAT'S TRUE WE
HAVE A PROCESS BY WHICH WERE
WORKING. TO TRY TO IDENTIFY WHAT
THE CAPACITY NEEDS ARE IF THAT
MEANS THAT WE NEED TO
POTENTIALLY LOOK AT A DIFFERENT
YOU KNOW DEADLINE FOR CONVERSION
I THINK WE WOULD WE WOULD BE
OPEN TO THAT IT WOULD LIKELY WE
NEEDS TO COME WITH SOME KINDS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR EVERYONE AT
THE TABLE. TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE ALL DOING WERE SUPPOSED TO
DO ALL RIGHT THAT IT GET IT SO.
I KNOW IN THE PAST WILL
CERTAINLY I A AGAIN.
AGREE WITH THE OVERALL GOAL
ABOUT THAT IDEALLY YES EVERY
FOSTER YOUTH YOU KNOW IN A HOME
ETCETERA ALL RIGHT.
AB.
THE VOICE HAD SOME CONCERNS
FEATURE XIN IS TAKING CARE OF
CHILDREN BEHAVIORAL ISSUES THAT --
BY SAID WE SHOULD NEVER GIVE UP
ON ANYONE I EIGHT YEAH I WONDER
ABOUT [inaudible]
THE YEAH EXACTLY ESPECIALLY JUST
ARE GAINES -- TO YEAH MORE
SEVERE SITUATIONS IT'S AT RENDON
I MEAN AND AND AND AND AND I
APPRECIATE ALL APPRECIATE THE
HARD WORK AND AND AND AND FAMILY
FINING AND SO FORTH -- FOR TO
FOSTER PARENTS AND YOU KNOW THE
THE ELEVEN DAY THEY THEY ARE
ANGELS AND THEY PUT UP WITH A
LOT.
RIGHT AND THEY NEED A LOS
SUPPORTS -- BUT ALSO AND NO
WONDERING LIKE.
HOW REALISTIC IT IS TO GET ALL
OF THEM OUT BUT AT THE SAME TIME
WHY DON'T WANT TO DO IS CREATE A
BUREAUCRATIC IMPERATIVES THAT'S
WHY I'M CONCERNED ABOUT?
RIGHT BECAUSE I AM SYSTEM WITH
OF COURSE UP HERE WE'D MAKE
POLICIES AND DEADLINES AND STUFF
LIKE THAT WE CREATE A
BUREAUCRATIC IMPERATIVES THAT
DOESN'T PLAY OUT IN REAL LIFE
AND THEN WHAT HAPPENS IS AND AND
I KNOW YOUR INTENTION IS NOT TO
YOU KNOW.
AND BUT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE WE HAVE YOU KNOW
FOSTER USE ADDRESSED.
YOU KNOW AND AND AND AND AND AND
AND SO FORTH AND AND AND BECAUSE
WE ARE WE'RE PULLING OUT THE RUG
UNDER.
STATE AND IN DOWN UNDER SITUATED
SO.
I DON'T WHY AMAZON HEARING IS
LIKE YES WE HAVE A MODEL AND IT
IT.
SOUNDS GREAT AND IT DID AND SO
FORTH BUT TERMS OPERATIONALLY
RIGHT WHERE ARE WE ON THESE
DIFFERENT COMPONENTS AND THAT
WHILE.
AND IT'S FOUR AND WE NEED TO BE
SURE WITH THE CAPACITY TAKE CARE
OF ALL THESE KIDS AND AND SO I
AM I'M JUST.
YEAH ACES ABOUT OKAY WE HAVE
THIS MODEL WE HAVE THIS YEAR
FEES WE NEED TO MOVE THESE OR
OVER THERE BUT WE'RE NOT YOU
KNOW WE'RE NOT GETTING PEOPLE
CONTRACTS IN TIME YEAH YES THEY
SHOULD HAVE MENTAL HOW IT'S IT'S
NOT DISAGREEING WITH WHAT THEY
SHOULD HAVE.
IT'S MORE ABOUT OUR WILL WE DO
WE HAVE THE THINGS IN PLACE. TO
MAKE SURE WE ACTUALLY LAND THERE
AND AND WE DON'T HAVE TO GO OUT
GUESS WHAT YOU MISSED THE
DEADLINE SO TOO BAD AND YOU KNOW
AT THAT AND AND THEN WHAT
HAPPENS ALL THE KIDS ARE IN THAT.
SYSTEM SO -- SUCH THAT EIGHT AT
NINE AM FEELINGS BECAUSE IT
AVOIDS IDEA ABOUT WHAT WHAT'S
GOING ON AND WHEN WE QUOTE HOLD
SOMEONE ACCOUNTABLE IS IT THE
PERSON WHO'S ACTUALLY
RESPONSIBLE OR IS ACTUALLY THE
MAIN PERSON WHO GETS HURT AS THE
PERSON WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
PROTECTING.
AND I WILL BE SURE THAT THAT'S
THAT WAS GONNA HAPPEN I KNOW YOU
ALSO AGREE WITH THAT TOO BUT I
SO I WANTED SIDE I'M JUST REALLY
NERVOUS ABOUT THAT RIGHT NOW.
IS THAT AND IS ADDING SOCIETY
MISPLACED OR NOT.
NOT IN EVERY MONTHLY SEAT EVERY
DAY BOARD MEETING [inaudible]
OKAY.
IT'S YES IT'S QUITE CHAIRED.
YOU SAID YES I THINK YOU'VE
HEARD FROM EVERYBODY AROUND THE
TABLE NOBODY WANTS KIDS HEARD
AND WE'RE GOING TO WIN
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN I CAN
TELL YOU -- THE STAFF SOME OF
WHICH WE WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT
ON PAGE THIRTY FIVE OF YOUR
AGENDA IN THE NEXT ITEM.
OUR E. SENSUAL INVOLVED PARTIES
IN THE ON GOING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THERE WERE REFERENCE
TO PART TWO THERE'S ATTACHMENT A
DATA WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT
KIDS WHO ARE CURRENTLY IN
CONGREGATE CARE.
HAVE INDIVIDUALIZED REPORTS
COMING TO THE STATE ABOUT WHAT
THEY NEED IN TERMS OF SERVICES.
FOR FOR THE YOUTH THAT ARE
IDENTIFIED AS HAVING LOW NEEDS
THAT ARE IN FACILITIES THAT
WE'VE IDENTIFIED AS MAYBE LESS
LIKELY THAN OTHERS TO ULTIMATELY
BE SUCCESSFUL IN A TRANSITION.
THE PRIORITY HAS BEEN FINDING
HOME BASED CARE LOCATIONS FOR
THOSE LOWER NEEDS KIDS TO REDUCE
THE OVERALL NEED FOR STR TEEPEES
AT THE SAME TIME WE ARE WORKING
MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF OVERTIME WITH
OUR STAFF. TO HELP GET AT PEOPLE
WITH POOR PEOPLE FOR FACILITY
APPLICATIONS FOR STR TEEPEES
THROUGH THE PIPELINE GET THE
LICENSE.
I KNOW THE SAME IS TRUE -- FOR
FOR BRENDA GRAY ALICIA IT DH CS
AND HER TEAM.
YOU KNOW MOVING THOSE
APPLICATIONS THERE ARE MODEL
CONTRACTS FOR RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH AND
THE INDIVIDUAL STR TEEPEES.
THAT COULD BE USED TO ACCELERATE
THE PROCESS WHERE SOME PEOPLE
ARE STOCK AND WHERE THEY ARE
STUCK THERE ARE ONGOING EFFORTS
AMONG ALL THE PARTIES INVOLVED
AND CB HDA. TO FIND SOLUTIONS
AND MEDIATE INDIVIDUAL
SITUATIONS SO I DON'T WANT YOU
LEFT WITH WE'RE SPINNING OUR
WHEELS WALKING UP TO THE
DEADLINE AND NOT MUCH IS
HAPPENING THAT'S ABSOLUTELY NOT
THE PHONE.
BUT WE'RE ALL PANICKED THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO MAKE THE
DEADLINE AND IT IS EVERYTHING
THAT.
AND SO SO I GUESS I WANT TO SAY
IS THAT IS THAT.
THAT DEADLINES ARE GOOD ON ONE
LEVEL BUT ALSO -- BECAUSE AND
OFTEN TIME I'M UP HERE ASKING
WHEN YOU'RE GONNA GET SOMETHING
DONE SO I DID -- BUT I I THE
WHITE LIGHT PARTICULARLY WANT TO
BE SURE IS THAT IF THERE'S
DEADLINES DO THE REGULATORY
ISSUES YOU WILL FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO WAIVE THAT IS IF THEY WERE
NOT GOING TO GET THERE AND IF
THERE'S SOMETHING IN LAW THAT I
NEED TO FIX.
IN STATUTE THEN I AND YOU NEED
TO TELL ME BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENS
I DON'T WANT SOMEONE TURNING
AROUND AND SAY OH BY THE WAY THE
LOSS SAID AND LEGISLATURE PASSED
SO GUESS WHAT. TOO BAD WE HAVE A
PROBLEM HERE AND AND SO.
YOU KNOW IF THERE'S A IF THERE'S
A LEGAL STATUTE THAT NEEDS TO
NEEDS TO BE.
ADJUSTED TO CREATE GIVE YOU THE
FLEXIBILITY TO BE ABLE TO TELL
WE DON'T RUN INTO A WALL.
ON THE LAWMAKER HERE TELL ME
OKAY I MEAN I NEED TO KNOW RIGHT
I NEED TO KNOW I NEED TO BUILD
COMMUNICATE TO MY COLLEAGUES I
DON'T THE DINNERS WITH THAT
THAT'S I TALK ABOUT THE
BUREAUCRATIC COMPARED IT RIGHT.
AS I KNOW LEVEL WANTS TO DO THE
RIGHT THING SO BUT LET'S ALSO BE
SURE THAT WE DON'T CREATE A
SITUATION WHERE.
EVERYONE'S LIKE I WANT TO DO THE
RIGHT THING BUT THE LAW THE
REGULATIONS MAKE ME DO SOMETHING
THAT I KNOW ISN'T GOING TO BE
HAPPEN.
SO THAT.
THE SUBGENRE DOING MY JOB MOST
IN FULL TRANSPARENCY OUR AGENCY
SECRETARY STARTS ON MONDAY WE
NEED TO HAVE SOME BRIEFINGS
SUBJECT.
THE ONGOING IMPLEMENTATION AND
GOAL OF SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION IS C. C. R.
REMAINS A PRIORITY OKAY THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT I JUST ONE SECOND CAR
WITH MISTER TRIPPING BECAUSE
DESCRIPTION OF EVERYONE'S
ACTIVITIES THE NOTHING I'VE SAID
WAS MEANT TO DISPARAGE ANYONE'S.
INDUSTRY OR INCENTIVE FOR THE
WORK THAT THEY'VE DONE IT WAS TO
POINT OUT -- THAT WE'RE WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED ABOUT WHERE WE ARE
CAUSES US TO BELIEVE THAT WE
NEED TO GO DEEPER AND WITH MORE
INTENTIONALLY. TO HELP THOSE
THOSE GOOD FACILITIES THAT ARE
STILL PENDING AND THE OTHER
THING I'VE THAT I WANT TO
UNDERSCORE AGAIN ISM WHEN WE
PASSED C. C. R..
A KEY -- PLACEMENT IDEA FOR
THOSE YOUTH VETERAN THOSE LOWER
LEVEL GROUP HOMES WITH TREATMENT
FOSTER CARE.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE PREDICATE OF
CCIR WAS THAT CHILDREN WOULDN'T
NEED TO GO INTO CONGREGATE CARE
UNNECESSARILY BECAUSE WE WOULD
DEVELOP THIS.
WE HAVEN'T -- THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK TO DO ON ON THAT FRONT AS
WELL IN MISTER ROSEN I'VE TALKED
ABOUT THIS I KNOW THERE IS
COMMITTED TO IT IS ANYBODY -- IN
GETTING THERE BUT THIS ISN'T
JUST ABOUT HEY LET'S GET AS MANY
GROUP COMES ACROSS THE WORD AS
TIER TEEPEES FOR THOSE CHILDREN
WHO DON'T NEED TO BE THERE.
WE NEED TO BUILD OUT THE FOSTER
HOME TREATMENT FOSTER HOME
OPTION AS WELL.
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO I LOOK FOR TO
FUTURE.
AND NOT SO FUTURE CONVERSATIONS
THAT I WOULD SERVICE YET OF YOU
GET WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
RIGHT GOOD ALRIGHT LET'S --
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR THE PANEL
THANKS SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
AND YOUR HARD WORK.
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWO CC ARE RELATED HUMAN
SERVICES TECHNICAL BC P..
AS IS TECHNICAL KEEP IT VERY
VERY BRIEF.
ALTHOUGH TAKEN.
SORRY GREAT AND I'VE BEEN DOING
THIS ALL DAY -- OTHER THERE ARE
TWO ISSUES HERE -- AB TWENTY
EIGHTY THREE THIS WAS CHAPTER
LEGISLATION LAST YEAR -- AND YOU
CAN YEAR AGENDA DESCRIBES
EXACTLY WHAT IT IS ALL POINT OUT
THE DH CS COUNTERPART FOR THIS
IS ON PAGE THIRTY EIGHT OF YOUR
AGENDA UNDER THAT DEPARTMENT SO.
LINK THE TWO IN AN EFFORT THERE --
THE THIRTY FOUR POSITIONS IN THE
SECOND B. C. P. HERE THESE ARE
EXISTING POSITIONS ALL OF THEM
AND THEN SUMMER FILL THESE ARE
THE PEOPLE WORKING HARD FOR CC
ARE IN ALL OF ITS ASPECTS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
AND WE'RE SIMPLY ASKING THAT
THEY BE CONTINUE TO ALONG WITH
THE OTHER EFFORTS.
HERE EXCELLENT OKAY ANY COLLEGE
MILIEU THANK YOU OKAY FINANCE
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY -- SO WHAT WE'LL DO NOW IS
WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUE ONE ISSUE.
TWO IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT
EITHER.
ONE OKAY I DON'T SEE ANY.
ALONE ARE A NICE OKAY THAT'S
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WELCOME.
CHRIS STONER MERTZ THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
FOR A CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES
WE ARE WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH --
CDSS ON THIS ISSUE OF OF MANY OF
OUR MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS WORKING
TO BECOME S. T. R. TEEPEES.
AND THE ONEROUS PROCESS
PARTICULARLY AROUND THE MENTAL
HEALTH CERTIFICATION IN THE
CONTRACTING PROCESSES -- EVERY
STEP IS A STRUGGLE FOR OUR
MEMBERS -- WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
INDIVIDUALLY TO ADDRESS THE T. A
QUESTION WITH MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS AND MORE OFTEN
SPENDING HOURS REVIEWING PROGRAM
STATEMENTS WITH THEM TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE GETTING.
IT JUST RIGHT -- AND MANY OF
THESE ARE NOT WE NOT IN
EXPERIENCED FOLKS THERE FOLKS
WHO'VE BEEN RUNNING HIGH LEVEL
GROUPON FACILITIES FOR A LONG
TIME SO -- IT THE PROCESS HAS
BEEN A CHALLENGE -- CDSS HAS
BEEN VERY RESPONSIVE WHEN WE'VE
HAD INDIVIDUAL ISSUES WE DO NEED
TO EXTEND THE TIME FRAME THOUGH
WE NEED TO BUILD UP TREATMENT
FOSTER CARE -- AND AS WELL AS
WE'VE GOT TO CREATE A
FLEXIBILITY TO ADDRESS
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI SUSAN FREDDIE CEO OF TLC
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE A QUICK COMMENT
THAT WE TLC TELL ME SERVICES IS
A HIGH FUNCTIONING RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAM WE HAVE ALL PROGRAMS.
ZERO TO TWENTY FOUR AND THERE'S
NO MONEY AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
IS TO SUPPLY MONEY FOR THESE
CONTRACTS I THINK THAT'S A
HUGELY IMPORTANT PIECE SEVEN
CONCEPT AT ALL -- SOUNDS
WONDERFUL TREATMENT FOSTER CARE
WOULD BE GREAT WE BARELY CAN GET
OUR CONTRACTS IN PLACE TO COVER
AYE SFC WHICH WILL BE NEW MONEY.
PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFER WHICH IS
INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
BE HERE HOLD THIS GO -- PAYING
SO DO THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO SAY THAT YOU KNOW
ALL THIS OVER TIME AND
EVERYTHING IS SO AMAZING THAT'S
HAPPENING HERE BUT MY ENTIRE
TEAM IS DOING IT FOR ZERO
DOLLARS THERE IS NO OVERTIME
IT'S JUST A LOT OF WORK SO
WHATEVER YOU CAN DO THINK YOU.
DOCTOR HAND FOR EVERYTHING
YOU'VE SAID OKAY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THE DOCTOR PAN MARK THE GORILLA
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
WHERE IS SUPPORT OF RESTORING
THE FUNDING -- FOR THE FAMILY
STABILITY FUND -- WE HAVEN'T
NEEDED THAT FUNDING SOURCE TO
MAINTAIN THE FAMILIES THAT --
ARE -- PROVIDING THE CARE FOR
OUR CHILDREN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SO WE'LL MOVE ON NOW
TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE WE SHOULD
HAVE FIVE FIVE PROPOSALS FOR
INVESTMENT -- SO MAYBE BECAUSE
AND WE JUST MOVE OVER AROUND A
LITTLE BIT. ONE TEAR OVER SO I
THREE CHEERS UP THERE SO FOR
START FIRST START OFF THAT
FAMILY STABILITY FUND IS SIR
PRESENTER FOR THAT C. W. A
CALIFORNIANS OKAY USER.
I. S. ARTERIAL JEAN REX ROAD
CALIFORNIA LANCE CARE GIVERS
WELCOME.
IN PRESENTS A HERE PROPOSAL FOR
INVESTMENT. THREE MINUTES MAX.
THANK YOU.
AND MUCH OF WHAT NEEDS TO BE
SAID HAS ALREADY BEEN SAID --
BUT BASICALLY.
THEY ARE DURING THE INITIAL
INVESTMENT FOR AND FIFTH BERSERK
NOW THE FAMILY STABILITY FUND --
MANY MUCH NEEDED SERVICES --
WERE IMPLEMENTED LAKE IN CINEMA
COUNTY.
AND HAVE AND HAVE KIND OF TAKEN
OFF HIM PROVIDED THAT -- SUPPORT
THAT'S NEEDED -- AS PLACEMENT
SPECIFIC -- RECRUITMENT --
FAMILY FINDING THOSE ARE.
TWO AND PIECES OF THAT -- OF
THAT PROPOSAL THAT HAVE BEEN
EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL THAT WE
KNOW THAT WE NEED MORE OF FOR
THE CHILDREN THAT STILL NEED TO
STEP OUT OF CONGREGATE CARE.
SO THAT IS -- HIGH LEVEL AND
INTENSIVE WORK THAT HAS BEEN
PROVEN SUCCESSFUL WE KNOW THAT
IT WORKS.
AND IT PUT IT -- HELPS SUPPORT --
PLACEMENTS ABILITY AND AND AND
WE'RE NOT AT A PLACE OBVIOUSLY
WHERE WE CAN -- WE CAN STOP THAT
WORK AND WE NEED THAT CONTINUED
INVESTMENT ALSO WITH AND PARENT
SUPPORT -- WE WANT TO RETAIN OUR
CURRENT CARE GIVERS AND
ESPECIALLY AND AS IT HAS BEEN
NOTED.
ON FOSTER FAMILIES ARE TAKING
AND MUCH HIGHER NEED KIDS
WITHOUT THAN.
NECESSARILY THE SUPPORT IN PLACE
THAT IS NEEDED SO WE DEFINITELY
NEED MORE PROGRAMS AND SERVICES.
LIKE CINEMA COUNTY AT THE
RESOURCE FAMILY LIAISONS A LOT
OF THE WORK THAT AND COUNTIES
HAVE DONE THAT'S BEEN REALLY
SUCCESSFUL.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ANY COMMENTS
FROM FORCES SERVICES ON THIS NOW
ALL RIGHT ALEJO [inaudible]
FINANCE.
JUST REYES FINANCE JUST BLANKET
TO LATER THAT YOU HAD A POSITION
ON ANY PER -- PROPOSAL OUTSIDE
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
OKAY THANK YOU.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH RIGHT OKAY NEXT ONE IS --
FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE SYSTEM.
AND WE HAVE -- CW A BELIEVE
SOMEONE FROM STE.
OKAY [inaudible]
AMERICA.
WE KEEP YOU BUSY HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FRANK
MAKE UP.
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF SEVEN HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS
WERE IN SUPPORT.
OF A FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND FOR NINETEEN TWENTY
AND THIRTY MILLION ON GOING TO
FUND THE FAMILY URGENT -- ROOF --
RESPONSE SYSTEM.
IT WAS IN A BIPARTISAN BILL LAST
YEAR THAT PASSED UNANIMOUSLY DID
NOT GET SIGNED BECAUSE WE DID
NOT HAVE THE FUNDING IN THE
BUDGET.
BUT JUST TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF
THE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR THE
CONCEPT.
THE CONCEPT IS BASICALLY -- A
RESPONSE SYSTEM THAT PROVIDES
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
AND THEIR CARE GIVERS A TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN HOTLINE TO PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE SUPPORT THEY NEED WHEN
ISSUES ARISE IN THE HOME THAT
THREATEN THE STABILITY OF THE
PLACEMENT.
FURTHER INCLUDE TWO COMPONENTS A
STATEWIDE HOTLINE STAFFED BY
INDIVIDUALS ARE SPECIALLY
TRAINED TO PROVIDE TRAUMA BASE
SUPPORT AND CRISIS INTERVENTION.
AND IF NECESSARY ALSO A MOBILE
RESPONSE TEAMS THAT ARE
ORGANIZED BY COUNTIES TO PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE IN HOME DE ESCALATION
IN SUPPORT. TO YOUTH ENTER THEIR
CARE GIVERS ONCE THAT RESPONSE
OCCURS THE TEAM AND THEN LINK
THE YOUTH AND THEIR FAMILIES
WITH.
AN EXISTING CONTINUUM OF LOCAL
SERVICES.
SEE SEE OUR ENVISIONED A
CONTINUUM OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AND OTHER SUPPORTS THAT WOULD BE
PROVIDED ON A TIMELY BASIS FOR
FAMILIES.
IN A AND CHILDREN IN THEIR HOMES
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS BROUGHT TO
CARE GIVERS IN YOUTH REGARDLESS
OF THE PLACEMENT SETTING.
UNFORTUNATELY CCR DID NOT CREATE
A STRUCTURE TO SUPPORT THAT
PREDICATE.
PURCHASED THE STRUCTURE NEEDED
TO MAKE THAT CALL THE REALITY.
AND MOMENTS OF TENSION OR
POTENTIAL CRISIS BETWEEN CARE
GIVERS IN YOUTH THE CURRENT
SYSTEM SIMPLY ISN'T STRUCTURE TO
RESPOND TO THEIR IMMEDIATE NEEDS
FOR ASSISTANCE.
AS A RESULT YOU THINK CARE
GIVERS OFTEN END UP CALLING ONE
FORSMAN.
BECAUSE THEY LACK OTHER MORE
APPROPRIATE TOOLS FOR IMMEDIATE
HELP WHICH RESULT IN
INAPPROPRIATE CRIMINALIZATION OF
TRAUMATIZED YOUTH AND OFTEN
LEADS TO SEPARATION OF CARE
GIVERS AND YOU FOR PLACEMENTS
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN MAINTAINED.
WITH APPROPRIATE SUPPORTS.
PERSONAL FILL A GAP THAT CCR
DIDN'T ADDRESS SOME WILL PROMOTE
TRAUMA HEALING FOR YOUTH AND
CARE GIVERS AND FOR THESE
REASONS OR COALITION OF SEVEN
HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS URGES YOU
IN THE COMMITTEE TO APPROVE THIS
BUDGET REQUEST.
THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
FARM SOCIAL SERVICES.
THE STATE BOTH THIS ONE AND THE
PREVIOUS ONE AND CLEARLY ARE AT
VALUE CARE GIVERS WE WEEK AS AS
AS MISTER PHRASES THE
MINISTRATIONS OF THE POSITION ON
THESE VENTURE THE BECOME A ANY
KIND OF LEGISLATIVE INTERESTS
WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS.
TO ABOUT IMPLEMENTATION OKAY ALL
RIGHT ELIA COMMENTS NOW FINANCE
RIGHT.
OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH.
THE NEXUS -- FAMILY RESEARCH
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL IN
KANSAS ASSESSMENT AND WE HAVE
THE THEIR OKAY AREA BACK.
WE TALKED WE TALKED AT SOME
LENGTH ABOUT THIS IS THE
OVERVIEW PANEL WE DID -- THE
RESEARCHFAMILY APPROVAL PROCESS --
IS AN ENTIRELY NEW WAY OF
APPROVING RELATIVES IT SHOWS
GREAT PROMISE. TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE A CARE GIVER THAT REALLY
KNOWS THE CHILD AND THAT CAN
CONNECT WITH THE CHILD IN THE AN
APPROPRIATE LONG TERM
PLACEMENT FOR A CHILD IF
NECESSARY THE PROCESS IS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN THE OLD PROCESS
THERE IS A PRETTY.
LONG BACKLOG IN GETTING ALL OF
OUR RESOURCE FAMILIES THROUGH --
THE BUDGET -- DOES NOT CONTINUE
THE RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL
FUNDING THAT WAS PROVIDED LAST
YEAR.
AND GIVEN HOW IMPORTANT ARE A
FAIT IS TO THE SUCCESS OF C. C.
R. WE'RE REQUESTING AN EXTENSION
OF OUR FAA SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK.
ON THAT SO IMPORTANT TO THE
SUCCESS OF C. C. R..
THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
PARSER SERVICES I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD THAT FROM
OUR PREVIOUS CONVERSATION THAT'S
RIGHT OKAY L. L. [inaudible]
FINANCE [inaudible]
RIGHT.
OKAY NEXT IS -- CONTINUED
EMERGENCY CARE GIVER FUNDING AT
TIME OF PLACEMENT AND THAT IS
ANDY SCHWARTZ FROM THE LINES FOR
SHOWS RIGHTS WELCOME.
HI ESSENTIALLY TOWARDS POLICY
DIRECTOR OF THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS AND I
APPRECIATE THE EARLIER
DISCUSSION.
ON THIS ISSUE AND YOU OBVIOUSLY
KNOW ABOUT THE LENGTH OF TIME
WITH THE RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL PROCESS THE EMERGENCY
CARE GIVER PROGRAM WAS CREATED
LAST YEAR IN RESPONSE TO A
CRISIS.
BEING FACED BY OUR RELATIVES AND
EXTENDED FAMILY MEMBERS THAT
ACCEPT PLACEMENT PRIOR TO
APPROVAL BY THE PROBLEM THIS
YEAR FOR THE COMING FISCAL YEAR
IS THAT THE TIME LINES FOR
EMERGENCY CARE GIVER FUNDING ARE
BEING REDUCED. TO NINETY DAYS
RIGHT NOW IT'S A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DAYS AND THERE'S GOOD
CAUSE TO EXTEND TO THREE SIXTY
FIVE WHEN THEY CAN SHOW THAT THE
DELAY -- IS IS YOU KNOW NOT
SOMETHING THAT'S BEING BECAUSE
BY THE FAMILY -- NEXT YEAR IT'S
GOING TO GO TO NINETY WITH NO
GOOD CAUSE TO EXTEND AND THAT'S
JUST GOING TO RE CREATE A CRISIS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY
SUCCESSFULLY ADDRESSED AND
RESOLVED.
I APPRECIATE THE LA THOSE
COMMENTS ON THIS PARTICULAR
RECOMMENDATION EARLIER.
OUR REQUEST IS THAT EMERGENCY
CARE GIVER FUNDING TIME LINES BE
EXTENDED IT SHOULD BE AT LEAST A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAYS BUT EVEN
MORE CRITICALLY GOOD CAUSE MUST
BE BUILT INTO THIS PROGRAM SO
THAT IT'S NOT THE FAMILIES THAT
ARE THE ONE SUFFERING WHEN THE
COUNTIES.
ARE NOT ABLE TO COMPLY WITH THE
TIME LINES -- SO WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THIS
PROPOSAL.
THANKS VERY MUCH ANY COMMENTS
FROM SOCIAL SERVICES.
I CAN WE HAVE A POSITION ON THIS
ONE HAPPY TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH FOLKS ABOUT -- ABOUT THIS
IF IT'S OF LEGISLATIVE PRIORITY
OKAY THANK YOU -- ALEJO.
FINANCE HI THIRTY THREE MUCH
HELP ON THE NEXT ONE TO EUROPE
IN THE NEXT ONE GOOD ALL RIGHT
SO WE HAVE A TRANSPORTATION TO
SCHOOL OF ORIGIN TIME OF
PLACEMENT.
RIGHT AMY WHAT SO I'LL BE BRIEF
ON THIS AS WELL BECAUSE I AM A
YOUNG PERSON JOINING ME. TO
SPEAK TO THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
ISSUE -- BUT ESSENTIALLY I
APPRECIATE THE EARLIER
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT SCHOOL
STABILITY AS WELL ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT RIGHTS THAT A
YOUNG PERSON IN FOSTERCARE HAS
IS THE RIGHT TO STAY IN THEIR
SCHOOL ORIGIN AND TO EFFECTUATE
THAT RIGHT THERE IS FUNDING. TO
ALLOW A CARE GIVER TO TRANSPORT
THE CHILD TO THE SCHOOL OF
ORIGIN THAT FUNDING DOESN'T
START UNTIL THE FAMILIES FLLY
APPROVED TO BECAUSE OF THE
DELAYS AND RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL WHAT THAT MEANS IS.
IF THEY DON'T GET THE FUNDING
AND TELL THEIR PROVED THEY CAN
GO A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO
HUNDRED DAYS WITHOUT ACCESS TO
THAT FUNDING THAT'S THE MAJORITY
OF A SCHOOL YEAR.
AND SO THAT THREATENS THE
ABILITY TO ACTUALLY KEEP THAT
SCHOOL STABILITY IN PLACE AND I
AM IMPORTANCE HERE TO REALLY
SPEAK TO THE PROPOSAL IN MORE
DETAIL.
THANK YOU.
HI EMILY WATSON -- I'M WITH
CALIFORNIA'S CONNECTIONS
SACRAMENTO -- CHAPTER I'VE BEEN
PROSECUTORS SIXTEEN I'M STILL
FOSTER CARE.
AND I MOVE LIKE THREE DIFFERENT
SCHOOLS I ONLY KNOW WHAT HIGH
SCHOOL I GRADUATED FROM --
BEFORE ENTERING CARE MY WHICH
WILL SCHOOL WAS KIND OF LIKE A
HOME A SAFE PLACE WHERE I CAN
GET AWAY FROM ALL THE BAD THINGS
THAT WERE HAPPENING INSIDE MY
HOUSEHOLDS.
AND EDUCATIONAL STABILITY IS
IMPORTANT TO ME BECAUSE IT GIVES
FAST YOU THINK ME A CHANCE TO BE
A KID.
A STUDENT AND ALSO HOPE.
I WAS UNABLE TO STAY IN MY
SCHOOL OF ORIGIN BECAUSE IT WAS
CONSIDERED TOO FAR OR IN THE
BEST INTERESTS WHICH IS JUST
SACRAMENTO TO ELK GROVE.
AND SO I FELT LIKE I WAS BEING
PUNISHED AND STEPPED AWAY FROM.
MY HOME MY FRIENDS MY SIBLINGS
AND ALSO MY EDUCATION BECAUSE OF
SOMETHING I HAD NO CONTROL OVER.
AND WE REQUEST.
YOUR SUPPORT OF OUR BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO ENSURE THAT
REIMBURSEMENT FOR TRANSPORTING A
CHILD TO THEIR SCHOOL OF ORIGIN
IS INITIATED.
AT THE TIME OF PLACEMENT SO WE
CAN BE STUDENTS AND HAVE A
CHANCE TO DRIVE LIKE EVERY OTHER
CHILD KID.
OKAY THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS FROM
FORMER SOCIAL SERVICES I WOULD
JUST REST REFERENCE MY PREVIOUS
TESTIMONY ON THIS ISSUE.
OF THE BRITISH SCHOOLS ABILITY
RIGHT THANK YOU A ALEJO.
FINANCE THE QUESTIONS OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO
NOW WE'LL TAKE A PUBLIC COMMENTS
ON THE PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENT
SO -- IF YOU CAN LINE UP AND
JUST MAKE NOTE PLEASE TRY TO
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS WITHIN A
MINUTE TELL US WHICH ONES YOU
LIKE -- ARE LIKE THE BEST AND
ALSO OF SOMEONE'S READY SAID
WHAT YOU'RE ABOUT TO SAY YOU CAN
SAY DITTO I SUPPORT I SAY THE
SAME THING PRES PERSON SAID.
ALRIGHT SO WELCOME [inaudible]
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MONIES FRANCIS
MARTINEZ ON WITH AS HERE YOU BY
TWO ONE AND I'M ALSO SEPIA
SOCIAL SERVICE WORKER -- MINUTES
USE AND THE FOSTER SYSTEM HAVE
EXPENSE MULTIPLE PLACEMENTS.
THESE USE WILL BOB PUSHIN TEST
THE RESOURCE PARENTS.
HOME WITH SO WE NEED MORE RFA
HOMES AND WE NEED THE FAMILY
URGENT RESPONSE SYSTEM TO HELP
STABILIZE YOUTH WHO ARE JUST
TRYING TO COURT JUST ACTING OUT
TO SEA -- THE RESEARCH PASS WILL
GIVE UP ON THEM AND THE OF
FAMILY OR TO RESPONSES TO WILL
HELP RESOURCE PARENT -- SHOW
THAT THEIR LOVED UNDER UNDER
THERE FOR THE LONG RUN THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
I AM A KEY MARKET THE HAIRS OF A
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE AND I'VE
BEEN.
IN THE CHILD WELFARE FOR ABOUT
TEN YEARS I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
THE FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE
SYSTEM BECAUSE IS IS WHEN THE
USER HAVING BEHAVIOR AND MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES THEY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO HAVE.
A CONTACT LINE THE HOT LINE FOR
THEM AVAILABILITY SO THEY CAN
AVOID BEING IN CONNECTION WITH
THE PD.
ALSO WOMEN SUPPORT WITH HE
FAMILY THE RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL BECAUSE IS IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR CHILD THE TEEN
EVEN TO BE IN GROUP HOMES THEY
NEED TO BE IN A HOME WHERE THEY
HAVE LOVING PARENTS SO I SUPPORT
THAT TOO THANK YOU.
BYE THANK YOU.
I WOKE UP JOHNSON.
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE.
LA COUNTY I'M REPRESENTING A SEE
I YOU SEVEN TWO ONE AM IN
SUPPORT OF THE FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE SYSTEM.
AND ALSO THE RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
ANYONE WITH THAT THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
INITIAL FIFTEEN MILLION IN THE
THIRTY MILLION ON GOING FOR
FIRST -- AND ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE TWENTY FOUR POINT FOUR
MILLION TO FULLY RESTORE THE RFA
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME HELLO ROB LANE
WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IS ONE OF
THE CO SPONSORS FOR THE FAMILY
RETURN RESPONSE SYSTEM WE
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL.
OKAY THANK YOU OKAY.
DANIEL A CALIFORNIA LINES OF
THàNH FAMILY SERVICES IN
SUPPORT OF THE URGENT RESPONSE
SYSTEM AND SCHOOL OF ORIGIN
TRANSPORTATION.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
TESTING A CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT OF THE FAMILY STABILITY
FUNDING THE FAMILY TO RESPONSES
SEMINARY SAYS FAMILY APPROVAL
PROPOSALS -- IT UP WE HEARD A
LOT ABOUT HOW TO CRITICAL TIME
IS IS HERE IMPLEMENTATION
COUNTIES A PLANE KEY ROLE IN
THESE.
INVESTMENTS WILL HELP US TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE RECRUIT RETAIN
AND SUPPORT RESOURCE FAMILIES
AND RESPONDING URGENT SITUATIONS
SO ASK FOR SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME PLACE KEVIN CLARK I'M A
CURRENT -- STUDENT AT UC
BERKELEY'S SCHOOL SOCIAL WELFARE
AS WELL AS A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
I LIKE TO SUPPORT THE FAMILY --
TO RESPONSES THEM I CAN'T TELL
YOU HOW MANY TIMES -- MY FOSTER
MOTHER HAD TO CALL THE POLICE.
BECAUSE OF BEHAVIOR HEALTH
ISSUES EXPERIENCE AS AN
ADOLESCENT.
AND THE THE BRIGHT LIGHTS AND
ALL THE PEOPLE IN FRONT OF THE
FIRE TRUCKS AND ALL THE CAR COP
CARS IN FRONT OF OUR HOUSE IS
JUST BY A LOT OF STIGMA.
AND A LOT OF ATTENTION TO OUR
HOUSE AND WHAT IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN LIKE.
IF SHE HAD SOME OTHER KIND OF
OUT RESOURCE AN OUTLET TO
CONNECT WITH TO PROVIDE SUPPORT.
THANKS OKAY THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON JACKI ONE
WITH GRAYSON AND CHILD --
POVERTY CAMPAIGN SO I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THE FIRST AS WELL AS
THE SCHOOL BOARD IN.
A TRANSPORTATION WHICH WAS A
RECOGNITION THE TASK FORCE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME HELLO PATRICIA GUESTS
WITH SENECA FAMILY OF AGENCIES
THE STATE WHY PROVIDER CHILDREN
SERVICES.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE FAMILY
URGENT RESPONSE RESPONSE SYSTEM
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME AFTERNOON DEVIN ANDERSON
ON BEHALF OF THE CEMETERY COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
OF THE FAMILY OR TO RESPONSE
SYSTEM PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
BOCANEGRA CANADIAN MARTHA GROW
REPRESENTING LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE SCHOOL OF ORIGIN
TRANSPORTATION -- PROGRAM IS A
PILOT PROGRAM LOS ANGELES COUNTY
HAS -- IMPLEMENTED AND SEEN A
VERY SUCCESSFUL AND EFFECTIVE
FOR FOSTER YOUTH AND ALSO THE
CONTINUED EMERGENCY CARE GIVER
FINDING OF THE TIME A PLACEMENT
AND THE RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
BACK A GONZALEZ NATIONALIZATION
OF SUCH WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF ALL OF THESE AT PROPOSALS I
WANNA POINT OUT THE FIRST
PROGRAM WHICH WE THINK IS A VERY.
INNOVATIVE PROGRAM THAT WILL
REALLY HELP FOSTER YOUTH AND
THEIR CAREGIVERS WHEN THEY'RE IN
CRISIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
HELLO JOINT -- CORRECT
CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER OF
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT OVER
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND YOUTH IN
SACRAMENTO PLASTER AND LOS
ANGELES COUNTIES.
WE ARE HERE TO ON SUPPORT OF THE
FIRST.
I'M SYSTEM PROPOSAL AS WELL AS
THE COMMUNITY CAN YOU EMERGENCY
CARE GIVER FUNDING AT TIME OF
PLACEMENT.
AS WELL AS THE SCHOOL OF ORIGIN
IT'S KIND OF PLACEMENT THESE
<c.red>SSUES.</c>
GREATLY IMPACT OUR YOUTH AND OUR
CLIENTS AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
DATA ON ALL THREE OF THOSE
ISSUES I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COURT APPOINTED SPECIAL ADVOCATE
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON DEBORAH
BROWN ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN NOW
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SUPPORT OF
THE FIRST PROGRAM AS WELL AS THE
EMERGENCY CARE GIVER AND THAT A
SCHOOL BOARD IN TRANSPORTATION
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
KRISTIN POWER THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS IN SUPPORT OF
CARE GIVER AND USE IT SUPPORTS
THROUGH FEB FIRST AND THE FIRST
PROGRAM.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON ADRIN
SULTAN WITH THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE IN STRONG SUPPORT
TODAY OF THE FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE CENTER.
WE STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT THIS
MEETS THE GOALS OF THE CC ARE TO
PROVIDE MORE IN HOME SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS AND FURTHER REDUCE
TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCES FOR FOSTER
YOUTH AND THEIR FAMILIES THANKS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
IN LAYERS CALIFORNIA COALITION
FOR YOUTH IN SUPPORT OF THE
FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE SYSTEM
AND THE CONTINUED EMERGENCY CARE
GIVER FUNDING AT TIME OF
PLACEMENT PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
GEN REX FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CARE GIVERS AND MORE
IN SUPPORT OF ALL THAT FUNDING
ASKS WHICH WE REALIZE IS A LOT
BUT WERE.
IN THE TRENCHES HERE AND WE AND
WE THINK ALL OF THESE ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT TO MAKE A CC OUR
SUCCESS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
DIANA BOY WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
OF COURSE IN SUPPORT OF THE
FAMILY STABILITY FUND -- AS WELL
AS THE EMERGENCY CARE GIVER
FINDING AT THE TIME A PLACEMENT
AND THEN ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CHEAPER PATIENT OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
FAMILY STABILITY FUND.
OKAY THANK YOU.
OKAY CENA THEM AND ALSO TO MAKE
FIGHT IT TO GET SO I JUST WANT
US -- SAY IS -- FIRST OF OF
COURSE -- SHE THE THE THE
VARIOUS PROPOSALS -- DOES IS
POINT OUT THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE
THAT WE WE WANT LOOK AT WHAT
COMES IN THE REVISED -- TAKE A
LOOK ITS ANYTHING'S BUT I THINK
AS WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE MAKE.
THIS IS -- THE C. C. R. WHICH IS
HE WAS A PRETTY PRETTY AMBITIOUS
EFFORT BY THE STATE AND WE'RE IN
THE MAIL OR IN THE PROCESS OF
TRYING TO MAKE IT WORK RIGHT AND
SO -- AND WE HAVE YOU KNOW THE
DIFFERENT LOTS OF DIFFERENT
PIECES TO IT AND SALAS LOTS OF
DIFFERENT PIECES WE HAVE TO GO
MAKE WORK AND AS WE'RE TRYING TO
MAKE IT WORK AND PUT ALL THOSE
PIECES TOGETHER AND IDENTIFYING
WHAT ARE THE THINGS WE MIGHT
NEED TO MODIFY AND CHANGE -- WE
ALSO I THINK MANY OF THESE
PROPOSALS REALLY ARE ABOUT
SAYING THAT YEAH WE HAD CERTAIN
DIE.
DEADLINES AND TIME LINES THAT WE
HOPE YOU WERE ABLE TO HEAD.
ANYTIME YOU TRY.
TO CHANGE THINGS A LOT SOMETIMES
THINGS FOLLOW BEHIND BUT WE NEED
TO BE SURE THAT IN THE
TRANSITIONS.
THAT -- THAT THAT -- THAT PEOPLE
YOU KNOW THAT THE THE FAMILIES
ARE DEAD BASICALLY WAS LIKE
FLYING AN AIRPLANE RIGHT.
DELETING IT CHANGING THEIR
FLIGHT FLIGHT RIGHT AND IF YOU
DON'T DO IT RIGHT YOU DON'T THE
PLANE CRASHED IN THE WHOLE THING
GOES.
SO -- IT'S NOT THE BEST ANALOGY
BUT ANYWAY.
BUT I I WOULD JUST SAY IS THAT --
CERTAINLY WILL TAKE ALL THESE
ANSWERS CONSIDERATION OBVIOUSLY
WE HAVE TO DO IN THE FRAMEWORK
OF A TOTAL BUDGET BUT I MEAN I
THINK MANY OF THESE ARE REALLY
ABOUT BE SURE WE WE HAVE THE
FUNDING IN THE TRANSITION THAT
WE DON'T HAVE.
FAMILIES AND MORE FOR AN EQUALLY
IMPORTANTLY TO FOSTER CHILDREN.
IN IN A IN A LURCH -- WHAT WE'RE
DOING THAT SO WE'LL CERTAINLY BE
TAKING A LOOK AT EACH OF THESE --
SO X. EIGHTY ONE JUST MAKE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT BEFORE WE MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT SIGNS WITH ONE LAST
ITEM AND THEIR DISSECTION -- I
AM -- BECAUSE I WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A RECESS UNTIL ABOUT THREE
THIRTY AFTER HE FINISHED THE
NEXT ITEMS I KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE I JUST WANNA GIVE YOU A
HEADS UP FOR PEOPLE IN NEED.
TO STEP OUT -- BECAUSE I AM
FORTY I HAVE TO GOD.
GO TO A BRIEF MEETING BEFORE --
AND ALSO.
WE HAVEN'T HAD A STRETCH BREAK
EITHER AS WELL AND SO.
I THINK IT'S A GOOD TIME FOR
PEOPLE TO RE CENTER THEMSELVES
AND WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
ANOTHER VERY IMPORTANT TOPIC
OBVIOUSLY MENTAL HEALTH -- AND
TO AND SUBSTANCE USE TREATMENT --
WHEN WE COME BACK SO BUT I JUST
WANT TO GIVE A HEADS UP FOR ALL
THE ONES WHO ARE LIKE -- I'M NOT
REALLY I'M HERE FOR THE NEXT
SECTION.
THAT GIVES YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND
DO WHATEVER YOU NEED TO DO UNTIL
THREE THIRTY FOR THAT.
SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
LAST ITEM THEN ON PART A AND
THAT IS -- THE THE C. P. FOR THE
CAR HEALTHCAE SERVICE VCP OF
FOSTER YOUTH TRAUMA INFORMED
SYSTEMS OF CARE.
THANK YOU.
ROBERT DEGREE WISH -- ACTING
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE FIVE
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SERVICES PCS -- SO --
FOR AB TWENTY EIGHTY THREE WERE
LOOKING FOR THREE AYE RESOURCES
TO HELP SUPPORT IMPLEMENTATION
OF TWENTY EIGHTY THREE AB.
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHTY THREE OF TO
SUPPORT STAFF -- PARTICIPATION
ON THE JOINT INTERAGENCY TEAM --
PROVIDE DEVELOPING AND PROVIDING
RECOMMENDATIONS SO LEGISLATURE --
ADDRESSING MULTI YEAR I PLAN
CAPACITY AND ALSO ADDRESSING
INFORMATION SHARING AND PRIVACY
ISSUES.
FAMILIAL THIS FINANCE NOW ALL
RIGHT SO -- OKAY SO BASICALLY --
WE NEED MORE STAFF TO DO THE
WORK WE NEED TO GET DONE.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- IS THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS ITEM YES IT
WOULD BE A STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE
BCP WE WERE THAT SPONSORS OF THE
BILL AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE.
THE DEPARTMENT'S EXCELLENT
ATTENTION TO THIS REALLY
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE.
AND WE THINK THEY NEED TO HELP.
OKAY THANK YOU.
OKAY SEEN OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
WE WILL HOLD -- THIS ITEM OPEN --
IN ADDITION NIGHT SHOULD MAKE
THAT.
BIG NOTE THAT WERE HOLDING OUT
HOPE AND ALSO THE OF THREE DEEP.
FIVE PROPOSALS WERE INVESTMENT
WE PREVIOUSLY HEARD.
US ABOUT THAT -- WE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL -- FOR THIS
COMMITTEE UNTIL HEARING UNTIL
THREE THIRTY THANK YOU
HEARING
OF THE SUCH A BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER.
THREE WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
PART BE -- WHICH WILL.
STARTING WITH THE PART OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES COVERING -- MENTAL
HEALTH -- SO -- BECOMING MENTAL
HEALTH HEALTH.
INCLUDING -- THE FOR HEALTH OF
SERVICES THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICE OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION.
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA BE COVERING
CALIFORNIA HEALTH SO THESE
FINANCING AUTHORITY AND FINALLY
WRAPPING UP WITH THAT PHARMACY
HOSPITALS AND BEFORE WE BEGIN I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO MAKE NOTE
THAT -- FIRST OF ALL I WANT
THANK EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE I
KNOW IT'S BEEN A READY A LONG.
DAY AS WE WENT THROUGH -- OUR
SOCIAL SERVICES I WOULD ALSO
MAKE NOTE JUST RECOGNIZE THAT --
SO FAR THIS YEAR READY -- THIS --
THE I COMMITTEES ON HEALTH
REJECT INCLUDES ALL THE MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE -- ACTUALLY
OF HELD -- TO HEARINGS IN
CONJUNCTION WITH ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE ON MENTAL HEALTH --
ALSO IN ADDITION TO THAT --
WE'VE ALSO -- THE SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE ON ALSO ALSO LED A
HEARING IT WITH US ALSO ASSEMBLY
HEALTH COMMITTEE ON THEY ARE
DRUG.
THIS WAS ACTUALLY ON A SUBSTANCE
USE SO.
pMEMBERS OF THIS SUBCOMMITTEE --
INCLUDING MYSELF HAVE -- HELD A
READY -- I DON'T KNOW FAILING.
EIGHT AT LEAST EIGHT HOURS OF
HEARINGS ON THIS VERY TOPIC.
OBVIOUSLY NOT BUDGET RELATED
SPECIFICALLY BUT IN TERMS OF
BACKGROUND I THINK WE'VE ALREADY
DONE A LOT OF WORK THIS YEAR.
SO -- IT BUT ALSO INDICATING HOW
IMPORTANT THIS TOPIC IS TO TO
ALL OF US -- NOT ONLY OF COURSE
THE MEMBERS SUBCOMMITTEE BUT TO
BOTH THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY AS
A WHOLE.
SO WITH THAT INTRODUCTION I
WANNA -- FIRST -- WELCOME
EVERYONE HERE AND LET'S DO THE
ROUND ROBIN OF INTRODUCTIONS OF
BEFORE YOU BEGIN.
THANK YOU.
WELL DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE
SERVICES HE AND BRENDA GREAT
WISH DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE
SERVICES THANK YOU HELLO.
MELENDEZ ONLY YOU.
MARKET IN LA ON FINANCE.
ANON CONFIRMING OF FINANCE.
CHRIS COOKED PHONE FINANCE.
OKAY THANK YOU SO -- ISSUE
NUMBER ONE IS OUR COMMUNITY
MENTAL HEALTH OVERVIEW.
SOURCES AND LIKE YOU KNOW
EVERYTHING ALREADY SO I'M NOT
SURE.
BUT I'LL BE SUPER BRIEF THOUGH
JUST AT THE BASICALLY I THINK
THE MAIN HIGHLIGHTS WITH THE
LIKE THE THE WHAT YOU SEE IS THE
BIGGEST.
CHALLENGE IS A COLLEGE DEGREE
FOR THE COMING YEAR -- BUDGETARY
EARLY SO.
SURE YEAH SO IT JUST AS A TABLE
SETTING THE THE COMMUNITY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES WE HAVE ARE BOTH
MEDI CAL IN ON MEDI CAL.
OVERALL THE BUDGET IS ABOUT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
CURRENT YEAR AND EIGHT AND A
HALF BILLION IN THE BUDGET YEAR
I SAID KERN YOUR FRUSTRATION I
DON'T KNOW WHATEVER NOT.
WELL TAX -- ABOUT TWO BILLION IS
MENTAL.
ME TO SAY WHICH I KNOW WILL BE
TALKING ABOUT LEADER AND THEN --
AND THREE BILLION TO ABOUT
FEDERAL FUNDS AND THE REST IS A
MIX OF COUNTY AND STATE GENERAL
FUNDS -- OBVIOUSLY A YEAR WHERE
THAT WE CONTRACT WITH A FIFTY
SIX COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PLANS
TO PROVIDER SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES -- THIS YEAR WAS
THE FIRST YEAR THAT WE HAD --
THE NEW NETWORK ADEQUACY
REQUIREMENTS IN PLACE -- WE ARE
WE WILL BE ANNOUNCING --
TOMORROW SANCTIONS ON SOMEHOW
SOME COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PLANS
THAT HAVE NOT -- COME INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH THEIR CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLANS WITH RESPECT TO
HAVING THE CORRECT NUMBER OF
PROVIDERS WILL CERTAINLY MAKE
SURE.
THAT -- YOUR STAFF AND AND THE
COMMITTEE GET THAT INFORMATION
AS WELL -- OUTSIDE ESPECIALLY
MALLHEALTH OBVIOUSLY WE DO ALSO
PROVIDE MILD TO MODERATE A
SERVICES THROUGH OUR MANAGED
CARE PLANS IN OUR FEE FOR
SERVICE SYSTEM -- OUTSIDE OF THE
MEDICAL SYSTEM WE DO ADMINISTER
FOR DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT TO
OUR STATE FUNDED SO IMAGES SAY
AS WE TALK AS WE'RE GOING TO
TALK ABOUT LEADER.
AS WELL AS NINETEEN NINETY ONE
REALIGNMENT THAT THAT ALSO
SERVES INDIVIDUALS OUTSIDE OF
THE MEDICAL PROGRAM AND THEN
THERE ARE TWO FEDERAL.
GRANT PROGRAMS THAT WE
ADMINISTER THAT COUNTIES RECEIVE
FUNDING FROM THE MENTAL HEALTH
BLOCK GRANT WHICH IS ABOUT
SEVENTY MILLION AND THE PATHWAYS
FOR TRANSITIONING FROM
HOMELESSNESS -- WHICH IS ABOUT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ANY COMMENTS FROM ALEJO
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
ALL RIGHT -- SO ACTUALLY I DID I
DID HAVE BELIEVE AND I DO HAVE A
FEW QUESTIONS [inaudible]
THE AGENDA.
NO SO AND THEN TO TRICK ME -- NO
I MY POOR STAFF THEY USUALLY
COME WITH QUESTIONS LATER ON
THEY ALWAYS ANTICIPATE ALL OF
THEM -- SO.
IT DIDN'T ACTUALLY IN IN IN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE -- IN THE CAR YOU
KNOW WE TALKED ABOUT NINETY ONE
REALIGNMENT WE TALKED ABOUT THE
CONTEXT OF A JUSTICE FIRST JUST
BECAUSE THAT WAS THE FIRST NIGHT
ONE REALIGNMENT ITEM THAT CAME
UP BEFORE THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND IS.
YEAH AND YOU KNOW WE'RE GONNA BE
DELVING MORE INTIMATE AND MAKES
AS A BUT THIS IS REALLY PROBABLY
THE ONLY PLACE WHERE WE HAVE
AFTER YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT
MAYBE ABOUT.
OUR ABOUT THE PART COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH -- AND SAID WE PLANS AND
WEEDS ARE EXPLORED THAT YOU MADE
MENTION OF THE FACT THAT SO CAN
YOU SPEAK A LOT MORE AND YOU
MADE REFERENCE TO OVERSIGHT RATE
AND LAST YEAR I THINK THE CMS
SAID YOU KNOW YOU NEED.
TO DO MORE OVERSIGHT -- ALTHOUGH
I SAY SOME OF THAT'S PERHAPS
MORE TECHNICAL OVERSIGHT.
IN MANY WAYS STRAIGHT AND
CERTAINLY IT NETWORK ADEQUACY IS
IS AN ISSUE.
BUT BUT I GUESS I JUST WANT TO
TOUCH ON YEAH AND AND I KNOW I
BROUGHT THIS UP AT THE PREVIOUS
THING.
SO FIVE AND I WASN'T AROUND FOR
NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT SO WHAT
MY BUDGET CHAIR TALI MITCHELL
WOULD SAY THAT BECAUSE SHE WAS A
STAFFERS AND SHE SHE SHE
REMEMBERS THE PAIN OF THAT I I
WASN'T AROUND FOR THAT BUT BUT I
DO UNDERSTAND THAT.
IN THE NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT
WELL CERTAINLY SOME OF IT WAS
ABOUT HOW MONEY FLOWS THROUGH A
CERTAIN ALSO REQUIREMENTS IN
TERMS OF LEVEL LIKE LEVELS OF
SERVICE OR SOME SORT OF THIS IS
THAT.
CORRECT ME YEAH YOU DEMI ISN'T
JUST LIKE OKAY YOU ACTUALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR FRESH CERTAIN
YOU KNOW.
LEVEL SERVICE CORRECT YES OKAY
SO SO TO WHAT DEGREE I MEAN IT'S
POSSIBLE BECAUSE AFTER ALL
MENTAL HEALTH THE MAN DOESN'T
ALWAYS CORRELATE WITH YOUR VISA
LASSEN CELL STACKS -- SO WHAT.
TO WHAT DEGREE DOES.
DTS BECAUSE NOW MENTAL HEALTH
PART OF YOUR DEPARTMENT --
MONITOR IT OVERSEAS THAT ASPECT
OF OF OF BE SURE THAT COUNTIES
ARE ACTUALLY MEETING THEIR
REQUIREMENTS BEYOND JUST -- THIS
IS HOW MUCH MONEY YOU'VE GOTTEN
THIS AT CETERA TO SAY THAT THIS
IS THE THE THE BUT YOU'RE WHAT
THE OBLIGATION WAS BACK IN
NINETY ONE AND WE'RE ACTUALLY
GONNA MATTER YOU ACTUALLY
ACHIEVING THAT LEVEL OF EFFORT.
YEAH SO FOR SURE AND I CAN SPEAK
TO THE MEDI CAL PIECES -- I
DON'T KNOW THEM BUT NOT MEDI CAL
IS MY OKAY I KNOW I'M A DOUBLE
THE ADVENT OF THE TO GO ON THE
MEDI CAL.
YEAH I JUST ASK YOU REALLY THE
MEDICAL THAT.
NO THIS IS REALLY TO THE MEDICAL
SERVE TERMS OF DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES IN YOUR ROLE
OVERSEEING THE MEDIC ABSOLUTELY
STILL.
WE HAVE A VARIETY OF WAYS THAT
WE DO OVERSIGHT SO ONE OF THE
MAIN WAYS AS WE DO I TRY ANNUAL
AUDITS OF THE MENTAL HEALTH PLAN
SO SIMILAR TO HOW WE DO ANNUAL
AUDITS.
OF OUR MANAGED CARE PLANS WE DO
OBVIOUSLY NOT EVERY YEAR IT'S
EVERY THREE YEARS OF OUR OF OUR
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PLANS AND
THAT LOOKS AT SORT OF ACROSS THE
BOARD AT THE UTILIZATION THAT'S
HAPPENING THE FUNDING THAT'S
BEING SPENT.
OUR CLAIMS COMING IN
APPROPRIATELY ARE IS THE CORRECT
DOCUMENTATION HAPPENING -- ALL
OF ALL OF THOSE KIND OF THINGS
THAT YOU WOULD BE DOING SORT OF
IN TERMS OF OVERSIGHT OF OF THE
HEALTH PLAN WE DO THAT -- EVERY
THREE YEARS WE ALSO HAVE OUR
EXTERNAL QUALITY REVIEW
ORGANIZATIONS SIMILAR AGAIN TO
OUR MANAGED CARE -- STE SIDE --
TO MEDICAL MISTER SIDES THAT
GOES OUT AND DOES THINGS ABOUT
TIMELY ACCESS AND IS NOW ADDING
THE NETWORK ADEQUACY COMPONENTS --
AND LOOKING AT QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS AND ON TOP
OF THAT WE JUST SORT OF DO OUR
NORMAL YOU KNOW LIKE.
BRENDA AND HER TEAM WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE COUNTIES TO TRY
TO PROVIDE AS MUCH TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND IDENTIFY WHEN
THINGS ARE ARE GOING WRONG I
WOULD SAY -- I THINK AS THE AS
THE PROGRAM HAS MOVED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES I THINK WE DO HAVE A
DIFFERENT APPROACH THAN.
IT WAS HOW IT WAS MANAGED
PREVIOUSLY -- SO I DO THINK IT'S
BEEN A CHANGE IN RELATIONSHIP IN
A CHANGE IN PROCESS AND FOR
STAFF. TO TO SORT OF SWITCH TO
MORE MORE MORE OF AN OVERSIGHT
AND REGULATOR ROLE SIR TRYING TO
MAKE IT MORE LIKE WHAT WE DO ON
THE MEDICAL MANAGED CARE SIDE SO.
I THINK WE'RE STILL GETTING
THEIR THIS WILL BE THE FIRST
TIME COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PLANS
HAVE BEEN SANCTIONED -- WITH
RESPECT TO ANY ASPECT OF OF THE
CONTRACT AND SO I THINK THAT WE
ARE STILL.
BUILDING THAT AT DECISIONAL
CAPACITY AND SORT OF MAKING SURE
THAT BOTH OF US.
BRENDA AND HER TEAM AS WELL AS
THE COUNTIES AND SEE EACH DAY
ARE UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU KNOW
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO REALLY.
MAKE SURE COMPLIANCE IS
HAPPENING THAT PEOPLE ARE
GETTING THE SERVICES THAT
THEY'RE OWED -- AND THAT THAT'S
HAPPENING VERY CLEARLY AND SO A
COUPLE OF OTHER THINGS THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING BECAUSE ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT I THINK
SOMETIMES PEOPLE FACE.
IS WHEN THERE'S A QUESTION OF
WHETHER IT IS ESPECIALLY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICE OR IS IT A HEALTH
PLAN SERVICE.
SO WE'VE HAD THAT COME UP IN THE
PAST FEW YEARS WITH.
PARTICULARLY WITH RESPECT TO
PARTIAL HOSPITALIZATION FOR
EATING DISORDERS.
AND SO WE'VE YOU KNOW WE WORK TO
IDENTIFY IDENTIFY AS MUCH CLEAR
POLICY THROUGH INFORMATION
NOTICES MALL PLAN LETTERS BUT
THEN WE DO SERVE -- IN SOME
CASES AS SORT OF A DISPUTE
RESOLUTION TO HELP BOTH PLANNED
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEIR
OBLIGATIONS ARE -- AND TYPICALLY
IN THOSE CASES IT'S ABOUT A
FIFTY FIFTY SPLIT SO WE DO SORT
OF HAVE THAT AD HOC STUFF THAT
WE DEAL WITH WHEN WHEN ISSUES
COME UP.
NEWS SO I GUESS WHEN YOU KNOW
WHAT.
AREAS THAT THERE ISN'T I GUESS A
LOT OF PLAN REGULATION OF
MONITORING STUFF BUT EXISTING
EXISTING YEAH IT BUT I GUESS
WE'LL IN EIGHT THE POSE THIS
QUESTION I THINK THE DIRECTOR
CAN WHEN THE HEARINGS -- IS THAT
DO YOU KNOW THAT IS SO CLOSE
THIS RIGHT YEAH. FOR THE
POPULATION RIGHT I MEAN DO YOU
KNOW WHAT THE DEMAND ARE NEEDED
IS IN THE POP AND AT LEAST A
MEDI CAL QUALIFYING POPULATION
AND MEDI CAL POPULATION -- WE
ACTUALLY MEETING THAT GREAT AND
AND SO SO YOU KNOW CERTAINLY
WHEN PEOPLE SEEK SERVICES AND
THAT AND SO FORTH BUT IT'S ALSO
POSSIBLE THAT SOMEONE.
THERE MAY NOT BE SEEKING THEM
ARE THEY'RE GETTING LOST IN THE
PROCESS AND SO FORTH SO ARE WE
DOING SOMETHING MORE PROACTIVE.
TO BE SURE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE OUR MENTAL HEALTH GOALS --
AND AND SO I THINK THE OTHER
PART OF IT IS A SITE FROM YOU
KNOW DID YOU GET YOUR PAPERWORK
ON TIME AND DID SO AND WHEN THEY
SAID THEY NEED HELP GET THIS.
GET SOMEONE ON TIME ET CETERA.
THANK YOU ABOUT AND YOU KNOW WE
THOUGH THAT'S ON THE OUTSIDE TO
THE MORE PRACTICE -- QUALITY
MEASURES TO LOOK AT HOW THE
POPULATION IS DOING OVERALL AND
THINKING ABOUT I THINK ONE OF%
THE OTHER THINGS WE'VE ALSO
TALKED ABOUT.
IS IS THAT.
YOU KNOW SHOULD WE HAVE A GREAT
RECOGNIZING EACH COUNTY
CERTAINLY HAS THEIR OWN
PRIORITIES SHOULD WE BE HAVING
MORE STATE.
WIDE MENTAL HEALTH GOALS RAIDERS
CERTAINLY AND OUT.
OF MY COLLEAGUES I GO WE SHOULD
DO SOMETHING ABOUT X. OR Y. OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT AND YET.
I CAN LOOK AT THEM I SAID WELL
GO TALK TO YOUR PART.
OF THE POOR TO SUPERVISOR TALKED
HIM OUT BECAUSE THERE'S NO WAY
IS THERE SOME WAY -- TO TO TO TO
REQUIRE PEOPLE REPORT MEASURES
ON ON ON AND NOT A HEALTH
OUTCOMES -- THAT HAVE BEEN
BIPARTISAN DEFY BY STATE NOW
WHETHER THEY CHOOSE TO FOCUS ON
THAT NOT THAT'S UP TO THEM BUT
AT LEAST WE EVEN HAVE SOME DATA
BACK SO WE CAN REPORT BACK TO
THE PUBLIC AT LARGE.
HOW WE'RE DOING ON THESE MENTAL
HEALTH MANAGERS SO WE ARE
PLANNING ON STARTING TO TRACK
THE HEAT IS MEASURES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES I WILL SAY THERE'S NOT
AS MANY?
BUT THE IDEA IS I MEAN I REALLY
SEE THIS IS THE STANDARDS AGAIN
THAT'S A HEALTH PLAN APPROACH
BUT I'M LIKE BUT EVEN DOING IT
ON THAT COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
PLANS APPLYING THE HEATING
MEASURES TO COUNTY MIDDLE HEALTH
NO BECAUSE THEY ARE THEY ARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS WE JUST.
RIGHT HAVEN'T TRADITIONALLY OKAY
WELL -- MY SISTER TAKING A MORE
OF A PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH
SAYING LIKE OKAY YOU KNOW.
WE MIGHT HAVE BILL GOALS FOR THE
POPULATION RIGHT AFTER ALL THE
WHILE THEY'RE PROVIDING HEALTH
CARE SIR IS THAT -- MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES YEAH DELIVERING
SERVICES THEY ALSO ARE PART OF A
AND MAYBE THAT'S SOMETHING WE
SHOULD HAVE A CONVERSATION
CONJUNCTION WITH IT'S JUST NOT
MEDICAL LOAN BUT BASICALLY
THINKING ABOUT.
THE STATEWIDE MENTAL HEALTH
GOALS AT THE YOU KNOW.
OBVIOUSLY WE YOU'RE DEALING WITH.
WHETHER IT'S PEOPLE IS NOT A
HEALTH NEEDS FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
HOMELESS SUBSTANCE USE RIGHT
OPIOIDS BIG THING -- PEOPLE OR A
CAR SERRATED WHEN -- THAT WONDER
RELEASED -- SO NOW THEY GET
SERVICES BUT MINE NOW THAT HER
SENT OUT THE DOOR DAY AFTER WE
HAD A GREAT SOCIETY.
THINGS LIKE THAT I MEAN SETTING
SOME GOALS ABOUT AND THAT AND
PART OF IT IS TWELVE NOW THAT
THEY'RE NOT GETTING MENTAL
HEALTH THROUGH THE PRISON SYSTEM
THEY NEED TO GET IT THROUGH THE
MEDIC OUT PROGRAM NOW RIGHT.
ABSOLUTELY SO ACTUALLY YOUR TALK
ABOUT THINGS THAT MAKE ME VERY
EXCITED BECAUSE A LOT OF THIS IS
THE WORK OF THAT WERE REALLY
LOOKING TO BUILD ON WHEN WE HAVE
THE RENEWAL OF OUR WAIVERS BOTH
ARE NINETEEN FIFTEEN BE AND ARE
A LIVING FIFTEEN NEXT YEAR SO WE
HAD.
STARTED THIS WORK LAST YEAR WITH
A VERY EARLY LOOK I THINK.
I MAY HAVE TESTIFIED AT SOME
POINT TO THIS WE HAD A LIKE A
50% STAKE HOLDER GROUP IT WAS
ABOUT IT'S ESSENTIALLY ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF MEDICARE.
AND SO I TALK ABOUT IT AND MY
TEAMMATES I WOULD TALK ABOUT IT
TOO MUCH THAT WOULD PROBABLY GET
ANNOYED BUT THEY THINK THAT.
THEY'RE TRYING TO COME OVER LAST
LIKE THE I REALLY TALK ABOUT IT
AS LIKE A FIVE TEN FIFTEEN YEARS
LIKE REALLY THINKING ABOUT HOW
DO WE WANT THE PROGRAM TO LOOK
AND THAT SPECIFICALLY ALSO HAS A
GOAL OF AROUND INTEGRATION AND
MAKING SURE THAT.
PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO GET ACCESS TO
ALL THE SERVICES THAT THEY NEED
AND NOT JUST THE HEALTH SERVICES
I MEAN I THINK -- YOU KNOW WE'RE
DOING A LOT OF STUFF WITH THE
WHOLE PERSON CARE TO TRY TO
REALLY GET THE OTHER SORT OF
SOCIAL.
NEEDS BEING MET AS WELL BUT
SPECIFICALLY WITH MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE HOW DO WE MAKE
IT A MUCH EASIER SYSTEM FOR
PEOPLE I MEAN I SO I TALK ABOUT
RATE I DON'T KNOW.
PEOPLE MAY HAVE TO ACCESS
SERVICES IN FIVE DIFFERENT
SYSTEMS IN THE MEDICAL PROGRAM
THAT'S THAT'S NOT HOW WE WOULD
HAVE BUILT IT TODAY IF IT WAS
BEING BUILT TODAY SO WHAT SHOULD
IT LOOK LIKE IT THIS IS WHERE.
IT COMES TO THE FIVE AND TEN AND
FIFTEEN BECAUSE MAYBE
SOMETHING'S WILL TAKE LONGER BUT
BUT WHAT SHOULD IT LOOK LIKE AND
HOW DO WE GET THERE SORT OF
TRYING.
TO TRYING TO MANEUVER AROUND THE
VERY VALID REASONS THE STRUCTURE
EXIST THE WAY IT DOES TODAY FROM
FINANCING REASONS TO DELIVERY
SYSTEM REASONS.
BUT IF WE WANTED TO CHANGE IT
WHAT'S IT LOOK LIKE AND THEN IS
THERE A PATHWAY TO GET THERE SO
THAT WE CAN MAKE IT A MUCH
BETTER SYSTEM FOR THE
BENEFICIARY.
AND THAT INVOLVES TRACKING ALL
THE THINGS THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT IN TERMS OF HAVING THESE
BROADER GOALS OF OVERALL HEALTH.
NOT JUST OUR PHYSICAL HEALTH OR
DENTAL HEALTH OR MENTAL HEALTH
BUT REALLY WHAT'S THE HEALTH OF
THE COMMUNITY WHAT'S THE HEALTH
OF THE INDIVIDUAL AND SO.
I'M REALLY EXCITED ABOUT IT I
THINK WE HAVE SOME INTERESTING
IDEAS THAT WILL BE EXCITED TO BE
CHATTING MORE ABOUT IT WILL BE
HAVING -- ANOTHER PUBLIC PROCESS
IN THE FALL TO KICK OFF THE
WAIVER RENEWAL STUFF AND SO
THAT'S I'M IS THE THING I'M MOST
EXCITED ABOUT THESE DAYS THOUGH.
OKAY WELL YOU KNOW WHAT TO DO
EVERYONE COME TO MY OFFICE
BRAINSTORM.
I'M ALWAYS WELCOME.
WELL I DID WANT TO JUST TOUCH ON
THAT BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW IN
TERMS OF THE AGENDA IS ABOUT THE
ONLY PLACE WE CAN TOUCH ON THAT --
OKAY SO -- ALL RIGHT WELL WITH
THAT -- LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
AND LOOKING AT HOW WE YOU KNOW
HOW WE MAKE OUR MEDI CAL OR
MEDICAL MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
WHEN WE CAN GET MORE INTO.
SOME OF THE OTHER PIECES BUT I
MAKE IT WORK BETTER FOR US SO
ALL RIGHT -- LET'S THEN MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO AND USUAL
OCCURRENCES COMPLAINT
INVESTIGATIONS AND DISASTER
RESPONSE.
BRENDA GREATEST DCS -- SO WERE
SEEKING -- TEN POSITIONS TO
SUPPORT -- AND IT IN A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN THE
VOLUME OF UNUSUAL OCCURRENCES
THAT WE'VE -- HAD IN OUR
FACILITIES -- MANY OF THE THIS
INCREASE HAS BEEN DUE.
TO OF THE ESTABLISHMENT OF NEW
FACILITY LICENSURE CATEGORIES
NEW FACILITIES UNCERTIFIED
PROGRAMS -- AND TO INTERVIEW
INCREASED INTERACTION WITH OTHER
STATE AGENCIES AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS WE ALSO HAVE -- A
MORE -- MORE OF A HIGH NEEDS
POPULATIONS THAT WERE SERVING
AND OUR FACILITIES -- SO ARE WE
HAVE A AND A INCREASE IN PEOPLE
WITH -- BOTH MENTAL ILLNESSES
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
AND I'M JUST THE A CUTIE IN
GENERAL HAS INCREASED SO --
WE'RE SEEKING POSITIONS TO
SUPPORT THAT WORKLOAD AS WELL AS
YOU KNOW WITH THE INCREASE OF
DISASTERS THAT WE'VE HAD FOR
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS --
PARTICULARLY WITH THE WITH
REGARD TO THE WILD FIRES -- WE
ARE ABLE TO RECALL -- I GET
GRANT FUNDS FROM THE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND SO I THIS WOULD
BE STE BE ABLE TO SUPPORT AND
CONTINUE SUPPORTING THAT
WORKLOAD ON FOR THE GRANTS.
THANK YOU COMES FROM OHIO
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
OKAY WELL THAT'S CERTAINLY ONE
BE SURE YOU ACTUALLY YALA'S
ASTOR KNOWING YOU HAVE THE ON
GOING PATIENTS -- PEOPLE NEED
HEALTHY PROBABLY AT NEW ONES.
YES.
ALL RIGHT WE NEED TO BUILD THAT
CAPACITY OKAY -- LET'S MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE THE DRUG
MEDI CAL ESTIMATES.
SURE SO AMERICANS CAN -- SO THE
DRUG MEDICAL PROGRAM BUDGET
WHICH INCLUDES THE ODS WAIVER
WHICH I KNOW IS THE NEXT ITEM IS
ESTIMATED AROUND -- FIVE HUNDRED
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
CURRENT YEAR AND SIX HUNDRED
NINETY MILLION IN THE BUDGET
YEAR.
THE BOOK OF THAT FUNDING IS
COMING FROM FEDERAL FUNDS
SIMILAR TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
SIDE -- WITH THE REMAINDER BEING
COUNTY FUNDS AND SOME STATE
GENERAL FUNDS -- AS WAS LAID OUT
IN THE AGENDA THERE'S REALLY
FOUR MAIN MODALITIES IN OUR DRUG
MEDIC HELP PROGRAM THE NARCOTIC
TREATMENT PROGRAM OUTPATIENT
DRUG FREE.
INTENSIVE OUTPATIENT AND
RESIDENTIAL ONE OF THE THINGS TO
NOTE FROM A BUDGETARY
PERSPECTIVE IS WE HAVE REVISED
THE METHODOLOGY FOR DOING THE
DRUG MEDI CAL ESTIMATE --
STARTING IN THE NOVEMBER
ESTIMATE THAT YOU ALL HAVE IN
FRONT OF YOU -- IT'S REALLY TO
MAKE IT MORE SIMILAR TO HOW WE
DO THE REST THE ESTIMATE AND
ACTUALLY HOW MONEY ACTUALLY
FLOWS.
THE BIGGEST CHANGE IS REALLY AS
HOW WE MEASURE CASELOAD SO --
WHEN WE GOT WHEN THE PROGRAM
CAME OVER THEY IT WAS WAY THAT
IT USED TO BE DONE AND THAT WE
HAD DONE IT UNTIL WE WERE ABLE
TO MAKE THIS CHANGE WAS TO DO
YOU?
UNDO BUT HE DID ANNUAL USERS --
EVERY OTHER PLACE WHERE WE DO --
CASELOAD WE DO AVERAGE MONTHLY
ELIGIBLES AND SO WE WERE ABLE TO
MAKE THAT CHANGE SO.
TRYING TO COMPETE DO COMPARISONS
BETWEEN SORT OF APPROPRIATIONS
STUFF AND AND THIS ESTIMATE IS
CHALLENGING BUT FROM NOW ON
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO MAKE THOSE
COMPARISONS AND UNDERSTAND SO
NOTHING FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGED IN
THE PROGRAM IT JUST THE
METHODOLOGY CHANGED.
AND SO YOU'LL DEFINITELY SEE
SOME SOME DIFFERENCES FROM FROM
A PREPARATION BUDGET -- THE
OTHER THING I NOTE FROM --
BUDGETARY PERSPECTIVE AS WE DO
CONTINUE TO SEE A SHIFT OF
FUNDING OUT OF SORT OF THE DRUG
MEDI CAL BE SENT INTO THE ODS
WEAVER.
AS WE CONTINUE TO HAVE MORE
COUNTIES -- GO INTO THAT WEAVER
SO JUST JUST FLOODING THAT FOR
YOU -- THE OTHER THING THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING IS AGAIN I SORT
OF SIMILAR TO WHAT I SAID ON THE
MENTAL HEALTH SIDE.
REALLY TRYING TO INCREASE OUR
COMPLIANCE IN OVERSIGHT EFFORTS
ON THAT COUNTY SYSTEMS NOT JUST
AN ODS WHICH ARE MORE LIKE --
THE IMAGE BEES IN TERMS OF BEING
ORGANIZED EVERY SYSTEMS BUT ALSO
IN THE STATE PLAN.
SERVICES SO WE DID UNDERTAKE --
SOME ACTIONS LAST YEAR RELATED
TO AN AUDIT WHERE -- FORTY FIVE
OF THE COUNTIES WERE FOUND TO BE
OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH A THAT
THE PROVIDING STATE PLAN
SERVICES.
WE DID HAVE -- ESSENTIALLY
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS THAT WE
PUT IN PLACE WITH THEM IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS OF TODAY IT
THEY ALL HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS THEY ALL DO FINALLY
HAVE DRUG MEDI CAL CONTRACTS
WHICH THAT.
THERE WAS THE CASE WHERE THERE
WERE SOME COUNTIES THAT DIDN'T
EVEN HAVE CONTRACTS.
AND WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THEM TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
GET.
CONTRACTS WITH PROVIDERS AND ARE
PROVIDING SERVICES WE DID HAVE
SOME COUNTIES WHERE THERE WERE
ZERO CLAIMING FOR DRUG MEDI CAL --
REALLY THEY ARE USING THEIR
THEIR BLOCK GRANT TO TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO BUT WE WORK.
BUT WE DO SO WE WEREN'T SEEING
MEDI CAL SERVICES EVEN THOUGH IT
WAS LIKELY MEDI CAL PEOPLE -- SO
WE'RE WORKING ALSO THE ON
REPORTING AND DIFFERENT WAYS
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH THAT THE
BLOCK GRANT THAT I KNOW WE HAVE
A B. C. PIER RELATED TO THAT
WILL TALK ABOUT LATER.
SO -- DO WE JUST GO INTO THE
WORKPLACE LIVER SYSTEM.
TO OKAY WELL WE WHILE WE WAIT
TELL THEM ANY COMES FROM ILIO
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
JUST ACTUALLY JUST A CURIOSITY --
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT SERVICES
CASELOAD.
TWENTY SIX TWENTY EIGHT THIS IS
WHAT IT IS.
IT JUST ALL OF THE NUMBERS LOOKS
PRETTY SMALL AS SMALL SO HE'S
LIKE WANTING LIKE IT'S IS THIS A
VESTIGE OF SOMETHING OR IS THIS
A OUR DAILY GIVEN THE POPULATION
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE NUMBER
PEOPLE ON MEDICARE PROGRAM.
I JUST LOOKED LIKE OUR HEAVENLY
OF THIS THREE OF OUTSIDE OF THE
ODS WAIVER.
RESIDENTIAL WAS A VERY LIMITED
BENEFIT IN TERMS OF MEDI CAL
BENEFITS SO IT WAS USE AND PERI
NATAL.
BECAUSE OF IT BECAUSE OF THAT I
AM THE RESTRICTIONS -- YOU KNOW
SO MOST OF THE STUFF WASN'T IS
NOT A STATE PLAN SERVICE TO
RESIDENTIAL STATE PLAN SERVICES
PRETTY SMALL IT'S REALLY.
IN THE ODS WAVERED WORD WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE MUCH MORE
RESIDENTIAL SERVICES OKAY SOUNDS
CURES LIKE WHO THESE PEOPLE WORD
AND ENDED UP IN THIS PROGRAM
YEAH ALL TWENTY EIGHT OF THEM.
PEOPLE ARE KIDS.
BASICALLY OKAY AND ALL RIGHT A
SMALL NUMBER THEM NOT NOT LIKE
THE BRIGHT ELATION WHERE IN IT
THOUGH COLUMN EXISTS LARGER QUE
ALL RIGHT JUST WONDER LIKE OKAY
THAT.
IS YOU SEE SMALL NUMBERS LIKE
OKAY THAT BECAUSE SOME PLACE IN
THE AND SO YOU'RE ALSO SEEING
BECAUSE SOME OF THE LARGEST
COUNTIES HAVE MOVED INTO THE ODS
WAIVER.
OKAY THE STATE PLAN NUMBER IS
GOING TO BE SMALL BECAUSE IT'S
REALLY SMALL COUNTY IS THAT
RIGHT SO TODAY'S ECKLEY THESE
ARE THE REMAINING COUNTIES WITH
THIS ARE OKAY IN THAT DOWN AND
IT'S A SMALL BENEFIT YOU SMALL
BENEFIT OKAY ALL RIGHT.
NO IT'S I DO LOOK AT THE STABLES.
OKAY ISSUE NUMBER FOUR THAN THIS
ALRIGHT THOUGH DS WAIVER OR SO
REALLY JUST CONTINUING ON FROM A
LOT BECAUSE I THE TOTAL BUDGET
NUMBER WAS INCLUSIVE ODS.
WE HAVE TWENTY SIX COUNTIES WHO
ARE -- OPERATING THE ODS WEAVER
WE DO HAVE FOR ADDITIONAL ONES
THAT WE ANTICIPATE WILL BE UP BY
THE END OF THE FISCAL YEAR EL
DORADO TULARE SAMBAR BENITO AND
SACRAMENTO -- WE ARE ALSO
CURRENTLY STILL WORKING WITH --
EIGHT OF THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
COUNTY.
THAT ARE WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH PARTNERSHIP HEALTH PLAN. TO
ME TO HAVE DOUBLE WORDS THERE
BUT WORKING IN COLLABORATION
PARTNERSHIP HEALTH PLAN -- FOR
PARTNERSHIP HEALTH PLAN ACTUALLY
OPERATE YOU KNOW THE SERVICES
THE CLAIMS TO THE CONTRACTING --
WE'VE MADE TREMENDOUS PROGRESS
WITH PARTNERSHIP IN THE COUNTIES --
IT IS A VERY DIFFERENT MODEL
THAN THOUGH ONE AND EVERYWHERE
ELSE IT WILL BE A CAT
ESSENTIALLY LIKE A CAPITATED
PAYMENT THAT THAT YOUR BUT THE
COUNTIES ARE PAYING TO THE PLAN --
BUT WE'VE MADE A LOT OF PROGRESS
PARTICULARLY IN RECENT MONTHS ON
GETTING THAT RATE METHODOLOGIES
CLEANED UP AND SO I THINK WE'RE
WE'RE IN A GOOD PLACE WHERE WE
THINK THAT THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
START IN THE BUDGET YEAR
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO SO LIKE.
PRETTY MAKING SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS THIRD BRING IN.
MOST OF THE COUNTIES AND GET
THAT AND OF AMERICA BECAUSE IT
IS A 70% AND WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
THE POPULATION IS READY AN
ODIOUS.
PRETTY GOOD CHARLIE A LOT
BECAUSE A A HURTS THAT THINKING
REMEMBER SEVENTY OR SOMETHING
BECAUSE WE A LOT THE CAVITY.
ALRIGHT WITH THAT [inaudible]
FACT CHECK.
WELL SINCE I GAVE THROUGHOUT THE
NUMBER AND YOU CAN'T BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR OKAY ALL
RIGHT -- OKAY.
BECOMES FAMILIAL FINANCE.
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY.
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE WE HAVE FOUR
FOR BECAUSE THREE PIECES OF
LEGISLATION -- DRUG MEDI CAL
CHAPTER LEGISLATION.
DOES HE WANT THE SOME PEOPLE FOR
THAT.
AND SO WE ARE SEEKING A SIXTEEN
POSITIONS -- TO IMPLEMENT -- SB --
EIGHT TWENTY THREE SB TWELVE
TWENTY EIGHT AND AB -- TWENTY
SIXTY ONE ESSENTIALLY TO TO
SUPPORT THE WORK WITH SPD --
TWENTY TWENTY THREE MAKING SURE
THAT -- ALL THE RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT FACILITIES AT THE IN%
CALIFORNIA I'M MEET A SAM
CRITERIA IS AMERICAN SOCIETY OF
ADDICTION MEDICINE -- SB --
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT SUPPORTING --
THE GOAL TO AND PATIENT
BROKERING.
AND I AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY ONE
ADDING -- YOU KNOW SUPPORTING
THE SPOT AT TELEHEALTH.
OR ANY COMMENTS FROM AVAIL THIS
FINANCE.
OKAY WELL HE'S CERTAINLY IS
ALLEGE THEY LIKE TO SEE THAT
WHEN WE PASS LAWS THAT THERE
SHOULD BE IMPLEMENTED -- ALL
RIGHT ISSUE NUMBER SIX THE S. A.
P. T. BLOCK GRANT COMPLIANCE AND
AUDIT ENHANCEMENT SURE I'M --
WEB -- ACHIEVED A RECOUNT WELL
WAS SAYING WITH OUR INCREASED
OVERSIGHT OF OUR SUBSTANCE ABUSE
PREVENTION AND TREATMENT BLOCK
GRANT OUR SEEKING THE FOURTEEN
POSITIONS -- TO HELP US DEVELOP
INTERNAL CONTROLS FOR OUR FISCAL
ACCOUNTING PROCEDURES -- MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE APPROPRIATE --
REPORTING TIME FRAMES AND
PROCESSES FOR THE SUBSTANCE OF
ABUSE ON PREVENTION TREATMENT
BLOCK GRANT -- AND ALSO SO THAT
WE CAN INCREASE OUR ENHANCE OUR
MONITORING OF OUR OF OUR ROOTS
OF RECIPIENTS ARE COUNTIES.
OKAY THANKYOU ANY COMMENTS FROM
ALEJO [inaudible]
FINANCE COMMENTS [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
MARCH.
OKAY VERY GOOD -- SO WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO NOW IS ACTUALLY -- THE
NEXT ISSUE WE HAVE. ONE TWO
THREE FOUR SIX SEVEN EIGHT THANK
YOU HAVE A PROPOSAL FOR
INVESTMENT SO BEFORE WE GET INTO
THOSE -- FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO
DO IS TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS ON
THIS SECTION.
ISSUES ONE THROUGH SIX FOR
AROUND -- COMMITTEE MENTAL
HEALTH AND DRUG MEDI CAL AND IS
THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE
ITEMS WE THREE DISCUSSED.
THESE COME TO THE BACK MIKE FUND.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
JOHN VALENCIA HERE ON BEHALF OF
L. KERMES INCORPORATED WHICH IS
A MANUFACTURER OF THE MEDICATION
SISTER TREATMENT.
LONG ACTING INJECTABLE
NALTREXONE BRAND NAMES OF A
TROLL AS A RESULT OF STATE
LEGISLATION ENACTED IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EFFECTIVE LAST YEAR IS
NOW AVAILABLE THROUGH NARCOTIC
TREATMENT PROGRAMS.
AS A PRODUCT UNFORTUNATELY THE
DEPARTMENT IS OFFERED DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES OFFERED UP
TO REASONS WHY -- ANCILLARY
SERVICES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
AVAILABILITY OF THE PRODUCT
ITSELF ARE NOT YET IN PLACE
FIRST OF ALL THE DEPARTMENT HAS
CONTENDED THAT IT LACKS SPECIFIC
DIRECTION. TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
ADOPTING REIMBURSEMENT RATES AND
THE ASSOCIATED CODES FOR
ANCILLARY SERVICES SUCH AS
PHYSICIAN INJECTION FEE --
PSYCHOSOCIAL SUPPORT AND EVEN
YOUR ANALYSIS SO WE HAVE
PROPOSED TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND
TO ITS COUNTERPART IN THE
ASSEMBLY LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
PROVIDE THAT GUIDANCE.
EARLIER IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE DEPARTMENT
PUBLISHED A MEMO TO THE FIELD
INDICATING THAT THE ENABLING
LEGISLATION. TO PROVIDE EXPANDED
MATT AVAILABILITY IN OUR KIND OF
TREATMENT PROGRAMS DIDN'T
PROVIDE ANY FINANCING WHICH WAS
INTERESTING BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATION WAS NEVER ANALYZES
HAVING.
COST.
SO THE SECOND PART OF THE
PROPOSAL THAT WE'VE ADVANCE TO
THE COMMITTEE ACTUALLY ASKED THE
DEPARTMENT TO IDENTIFY THAT
COSTS WITH THAT WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
OKAY NOW IS THIS -- ACTUAL
BUDGET REQUESTS IN ROUND THAT
ARE SO.
IT IT TO THE COMMITTEE OKAY ALL
RIGHT SO WE'RE SO IT THIS SO
WE'RE GONNA BE HEARING ALL
DIFFICULT INVESTMENT OKAY YES.
BY ITEM NUMBER THREE OKAY THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN ARE WHOLLY
MEASURE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION ALCOHOL DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES -- I'D LIKE -- TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT WE DID SUBMIT A
LETTER OF MY RECOMMENDATIONS
BOTH -- AS A RESULT OF TESTIMONY
FROM.
THE PRIOR HEARINGS AND THE ODS
WAIVER AND ALSO TO THIS HEARING
WITH SOME SPECIFIC BUDGET
RECOMMENDATIONS AND I'D JUST
LIKE.
TO IN TERMS OF TODAY TALK ABOUT
THE THE PROPOSAL ABOUT THE THE
HOSPITAL DETOX -- PROVISION AND
SPECIFICALLY TO INCLUDE
FREESTANDING ACUTE PSYCHIATRIC
AND CHEMICAL DEPENDENCY
HOSPITALS IN STATE
REIMBURSEMENTS -- FOR A SAM
THREE POINT SEVEN AND FOUR POINT.
OH I THIS IS NOT NOT REIMBURSED
CURRENTLY BY THE STATE AND
COUNTIES.
I DO NOT SEE THAT THEY WANT --
TO OR HAVE BEEN.
A RELUCTANT -- TO ADDED INTO
THEIR FUNDING THROUGH THE ODS
WAIVER.
AND AS A RESULT IT REALLY IS
CREATING AN ACCESS TO TREATMENT
AND PEOPLE JUST CAN'T GET INTO
THE TAX THEREFORE THEY CAN'T GET
INTO TREATMENT SO.
IT'S AN ISSUE THAT IS OF GREAT
CONCERN TO US -- AND THEN -- AT
THE THE OTHER THING THAT OUT
THERE IN TERMS OF THIS BUDGET
THAT WE MENTIONED IS THE THE
CORRECTION ACTION ACTION PLAN
FOR THE A SUBSTANCE USE OF THAT
WE UNDERSTAND THAT MONEY IS
GOING TO BE COMING OUT OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SAFTEY BLOCK
GRANT MONEY AND IT'S
ADMINISTRATIVE STUFF SO.
THAT THE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT -- THAT IT DOES COME OUT OF
ADMINISTRATION AND NOT OUT OF
THE TREATMENT SERVICES AND THE
REST OF IT WE WILL BE PUTTING
INTO A WE HAVE PUT INTO A LETTER
FOR OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU YOU IN A
LITTLE OVER TIME BUT I NEED AT
THAT COVER SOME GROUND THERE
OKAY THANK YOU.
HI MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
FIRM A DATING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES REPRESENTING ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES I JUST WANT TO
PUT IN A NOTE ABOUT -- DH CS IS
A ROLE AND AND OVERSIGHT AND
COMPLIANCE WHICH THEY ARE
STARTING TO DO A REALLY GOOD JOB
ON BUT IT'S ALSO FOR ASSISTING
THE COUNTIES.
AND THERE'S A BALANCE BETWEEN
THE OVERSIGHT AND COMPLIANCE
SINCE POTENTIAL SANCTIONS AND
COUNTIES ACTUALLY BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES -- WE WORK
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH DH CS WITH
THEIR STAFF WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THE ADDITIONAL POSITIONS I
THINK IT'S REALLY SMART TO THINK
ABOUT.
SOME THINGS ARE OUTSIDE OF THE
BOX AND HAVE SOME MORE STAFF
THERE BUT AGAIN I WANT TO PUT IN
A CAUTIONARY NOTE ABOUT --
OVERSIGHT THAT ALSO ASSISTANCE
AS OF THE STATE DEPARTMENT TO
HELP COUNTIES THE CONTRACTORS--
DO WE'RE SUPPOSED TO DO
SOMETHING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELL.
CERTAINLY I THINK -- DID IT.
PERHAPS A LITTLE BIT THIS CAN BE
A BIT OF A CHALLENGE IN TERMS OF
YOUR NOT REGULATORY HAVING
DINNER AT THE REGULATORY YOU NOT
REGULATORY AGENCY -- YOU'RE ALSO
SO IN TERMS OF THIS BALANCE
BETWEEN OF COURSE YOU WANT TO
THERE'S ALL.
ACTUALLY IF YOU ACTUALLY HAVING.
TO I GUESS PUNISHER OUR OUR
SANCTIONS SOMEONE THAT'S A
FAILURE IN ITSELF BECAUSE THERE
HAD TO GO THAT FAR RIGHT NOW I
MEAN IDEALLY WE WOULD HAVE NO
ONE WOULD EVER NEED TO BE
SECTION BECAUSE I WAS PERFORMING
AT PAR.
AND THAT THAT'S THE IDEAL -- BUT
WE ARE THAT WE WE KNOW THAT'S
AND SOMETIMES HE CAN'T MEET THE
IDEAL BUT WE WANNA TRY TO HELP
PEOPLE REACH THAT IDEAL FIRST
AND IF THEY CAN'T THEN
UNFORTUNATELY.
ARE IF THEY'RE NOT WILLING OR
NOT SHOWING ENOUGH.
THEY'LL EFFORT AND THEN
FORTUNATELY SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO
THEN -- SECTION SO -- STRIKING
THAT BALANCE A TEACHER SOMETHING
THAT -- THE THAT PART IS LOOKING
AT ABSOLUTELY I MEAN I THINK
THAT HAS BEEN ALWAYS ARE ARE ARE.
IF THINKING IN TERMS OF HOW DO
WE ASSIST BEFORE HAND HOW DO WE
ASSIST ONCE THE PROBLEMS
IDENTIFIED BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
A POINT WHERE THE PROBLEM IS NOT
BEING RESOLVED -- WE HAVE FOUND
THAT IT HAS HELPED IN OTHER
SITUATIONS TO TO TAKE THIS STEP
IN ORDER TO EMPHASIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF CHANGE.
WELL OKAY THANK YOU AND US AND
CERTAINLY YOUNG BUT AGAIN THAT
IT.
I THINK WE HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT.
IF WE LET A A SITUATION GO ON
THAT THAT IS NOT WHERE WE SHOULD
BE THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUFFERING FOR THAT AND THAT'S
WHY WE CAN'T LET IT.
CONTINUE FOR TOO LONG CELL OKAY
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT SO LONG AND
DO THEM AND ASK YOU TO PERHAPS
EVERYONE CAN MOVE OVER A LITTLE
BIT WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND DAY
HERE THE HIGHER UP FOR FILLS FOR
INVESTMENT IN THE WILL TAKE%
PUBLIC COMMENT ALL OF THEM
COLLECTIVELY -- SO YOU PEOPLE
AND TELL ME WHICH ONES THEY LIKE --
SO WE'RE GONNA START -- WITH THE
SUBSTANCE USE COUNSELORS IN
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS AND WE
HAVE THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS -- SO WE
ASK -- THAT TO COLLECTIVELY I
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
TESTIFYING OKAY THE TWO OF YOU
YOU GOT THREE MINUTES TOGETHER.
TOTALS.
SCOTT SAID THREE MINUTES EACH
SORRY.
BUT IT'S THIS -- THANKS VERY
MUCH DOCTOR TO MADDEN REVIEW IN
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN WE ARE REQUESTING.
A THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
BUDGET TO HELP CREATE A PROGRAM
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT TO PLACE
NAVIGATOR SET HOSPITALS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
ON A REQUEST WHICH WE APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT FROM LAST
YEAR -- WHICH MOVED INTO A
CONFERENCE ON FOR SHE DIDN'T
MAKE IT.
TO THE FINAL MIX THAT'S REAR
AGAIN -- IT WAS MODELED AFTER
PROGRAM AT UC DAVIS AND WE'VE
SEEN GREAT SUCCESS IN THIS
PROGRAM AND ACTUALLY WITH ME
TODAY I'VE TAMI TREVINO WHO IS
THE PURE NAVIGATOR AT UC DAVIS
HE'S BEEN THERE FOR FOUR YEARS.
AND HE'S HERE TO TALK ABOUT HIS
SUCCESS AND WHAT HE DOES AND
CONNECTING PATIENTS TO THE
SERVICES THAT THEY TRULY NEED.
CANCER AT A UC DAVIS MERGES SHE
ROOM.
PEOPLE COMMANDED THE EMERGENCY
ROOM -- DETER -- HI WELCOME
HOLLIGER HAVING TROUBLE IT'S ONE
OF THE WORST DAYS OF THEIR LIFE
IN OUR LOS TO SCARED THEY DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO DO.
SO NEAR TO HELP HIM OUT KIND OF
GUY ITEM SET UP THE TREATMENT
PLAN FORM WHEN THEY LEAVE -- WE
STARTED BEEPING OFFERING PROGRAM
WHAT WE STARTED GETTING PEOPLE
ON PEOPLE ARE FING WHICH I'VE
SEEN.
LIVES JUST CHANGE IT IT'S IT'S
IT'S AWESOME IT'S IT'S UP SO
MANY LIVES ESPECIALLY THE AGES
FROM EIGHTEEN TO THIRTY FIVE IT
SEEMS LIKE.
IT'S REALLY CHANGE OUR LIVES I
GET.
CALLS ALL THE TIME IT'S IT'S
IT'S REALLY EXCEEDED.
ALONE MY HEART GOES OUT TO THEM
WHEN I SEE A DRUG ADDICT OR
SOMEBODY ON THE STREET FALLING
DOWN I'M BIG ON THE GUY PULLS
OVER AND HELPS THEM OUT.
I DEDICATE THE REST OF MY LIFE
TO HELPING THESE PEOPLE IN.
AND I FEEL LIKE I'M LONG WOULD
DISTINGUISH STARTED TRYING SOME
CANCERS BUT WE NEED SOME HELP.
WE WE NEED IT WE NEED MORE HELP
WE NEED MORE CANCERS START
PLACING ANOTHER YARDS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
YEAH.
AND IF THERE'S A LITTLE BIT MORE
TIME JUST TO GIVE YOU SOME
STATISTICS ARE WE SEEING A
REDUCTION UPWARDS OF 60% IN TURN
TO BE THE UTILIZATION SO FROM
THIS POPULATIONS I KNOW YOU
UNDERSTAND THIS TENDS TO BE A
POPULATION THAT CYCLES THROUGH
THE MERY DEPARTMENT ON A
REGULAR.
BASIS IN LOOKING AT OVER A
TWELVE MONTH BASIS WE FOUND THAT
THE UC DAVIS SAVED UPWARDS OF
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS AS A RESULT OF THAT
REDUCTION.
SO I KNOW WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
TRYING TO IDENTIFY PROGRAMS THAT
HAVE SHOWN SUCCESS IN TRYING DO
MY STATEWIDE BASIS WE REALLY
BELIEVE THIS IS A GREAT MODEL
AND SOMETHING TO ROLL OUT ACROSS
THE STATE.
OKAY I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
EIGHTY S. L. A. L. [inaudible]
FINANCE -- ACTUALLY VIEW
PROVIDED ANY THE TERMS OF DATA
AND COST SAVINGS.
HAVE YOU -- BAM DO YOU HAVE SOME
DOCUMENTATION OF THAT.
WE HAVE SOME INFORMATION -- YES
A LITTLE BIT INFORMATION IT'S IN
THE PROCESS OF GETTING PUBLISHED
SO IT'S A LITTLE BIT -- WE'RE
TRYING -- TO KICK IT OUT IN A
WAY TO GET TO HAVE BEEN A LITTLE
MORE DETAIL A YES WERE WERE MORE
HAPPY TO SHARE THAT.
OKAY SO I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT -- A KNOW THAT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH LA -- ON WAS
IS THAT -- WE CAN GET DATA LIKE
THAT TOO LA -- THEY CAN USE THAT
IN THEIR EXAMINATION AND
CERTAINLY -- SINCE FINANCE
WHAT'S THE GOVERNOR -- I HOPE
FINANCE CAN DO THE SAME I CAN
ASK EARLIER TO DO STUFF.
THAT -- HOPING THAT FINANCE CAN
DO THE SAME AS WE LOOK AT WE
LOOK AT THESE PROPOSALS LIKE
THIS ONE AND WE HAVE STRONG DATA
THAT SHOWS SAVINGS WE CAN
HOPEFULLY LOOK AT IN THAT
CONTEXT AS WELL SO.
YEAH WE'VE AS MEANS OF FINANCE --
WHO'VE BEEN ASKING SOME
QUESTIONS LOANS AND LINES OF
WORK.
WE'RE GOING TO BE WORKING HARD
TO GET YOUR INFORMATION.
EXCELLENT OKAY WELL THANKS VERY
MUCH THANK YOU TESTIFYING.
OKAY NEXT.
IS THE EXIT -- EXPANSION OF
EXPERTS. TO OPIATES AND OTHER
TRUCKS FROM THE CALVET BEHAVIOR
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
THANK ABOUT PAMELA TIME TOM RENT
FREE WITH THE COUNTY BE ABLE
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
SO WE ARE REQUESTING I HAVE A
BUDGET REQUEST OF TWO POINT FIVE
EIGHT MILLION ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR DH CS TO EXPAND THE CURRENT
MEDI CAL BENEFIT FOR ADULT.
ALCOHOL MISUSE SCREENING AND
COUNSELING TO INCLUDE SCREENING
FOR THE MIS USE OF OPIOIDS AND
OTHER -- OTHER DRUGS.
WHICH SEEING WITH THE ALCOHOL
SCREENING WHICH IS NOW --
ROUTINE THAT THAT DID HAS HAD IT
HAS HAS MARK MARK BENEFITS -- IN
IN OUR SPECIALLY WHEN IT'S BEEN
FOLLOWED BY BRIEF INTERVENTION
REFERRAL TO TREATMENT BUT EVEN
THE DATA SO THAT EVEN DOCTORS
JUST EVEN ASKING THE QUESTION
ABOUT A PERSON'S ALCOHOL USE IS
ACTUALLY SHOWN TO DECREASE
PROBLEM DRINKING SO.
WELL -- WE THINK THAT NOW THE
WOULD -- WITH THOSE POSITIVE
OUTCOMES -- THAT SCREENING A
BRIEF INTERVENTION FOR ILLICIT
DRUG USE.
HAS RECEIVED LESS ATTENTION BUT
WE THINK GIVEN THE CURRENT
OPIOID CRISIS THAT THIS IS
IMPORTANT THAT.
WE WE EXPAND THIS BENEFIT SO IF
THE SCREEN FOR OTHER DRUGS AS
WELL THE INTENT OF COURSE IS TO
STRENGTHEN THE LINKAGES AND
REFERRAL PATHWAYS BETWEEN
PRIMARY CARE.
AND SPECIALTY SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT -- IS WE AS
WE WORK TO CONFRONT THE OPIOID
CRISIS THAT CLAIMS THE LIVES OF
MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS EVERY YEAR -- WE
MUST -- BEEN ABLE ARE PUBLICLY
FUNDED HEALTH SYSTEMS TO
IDENTIFY MORE PEOPLE WITH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER AND
CONNECT THEM TO CARE --
EXPANDING THE SCREENING TO
DETECT THE MISUSE OF OPIOIDS AND
OTHER DRUGS AS ONE COST
EFFECTIVE STRATEGY THAT WE CAN
USE. TO ACHIEVE THESE GOALS OF
THE DEPARTMENT ESTIMATE -- THAT
TWO POINT FIVE EIGHT MILLION
WELL I WOULD BE NECESSARY THAT
WOULD ALSO DRAW DOWN ABOUT FIVE
POINT EIGHT TWO MILLION AND
FEDERAL FUNDING -- TO MATCH
ABOUT SO WE THINK IT'S A GOOD
INVESTMENT WE WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANKS.
THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS FROM
DEPARTMENT OF SERVICES ALEJO
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH ALL RIGHT.
NEXT UP WE HAVE THE YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH FIRST AID TRAINING FOR
TEACHERS AND SCHOOLS.
IS RUNNING ON THAT [inaudible]
ONE OKAY.
PROBABLY FROM EACH DAY YES
[inaudible]
RIGHT WELCOME.
SOUNDS LIKE A VERY FAMILIAR
PROPOSAL [inaudible]
OKAY.
ARRANGE THIS DID AT ONE POINT
THE GOOD MORNING I DON'T THINK
ANYTHING THAT.
BECAUSE OF THE GOOD AFTERNOON IT
UP TO SAY GOOD EVENING YET.
A LITTLE BIT OF HOPE THANK YOU.
I'M I'M DOCTOR LEE UNDER CLICK
HARVEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AGENCIES.
AND WE ARE PLEASED TO BE JOINED
BY PHOEBE HDA CHILDREN NOW AND
LADY GAGA'S BORN THIS WAY
FOUNDATION TO CO SPONSOR A
BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR ONE POINT
SIX EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS. TO
PILOT YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH FIRST
AID TRAINING SINCE SCHOOLS IN
NORTHERN CENTRAL AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. TWO SIMILAR TO CPR
TRAINING THIS IS A SIX HOUR IN
PERSON TRAINING DESIGNED FOR
ANYONE TO LEARN ABOUT MENTAL
ILLNESS AND ADDICTIONS INCLUDING
RISK FACTORS AND WARNING SIGNS --
THIS IS A LOW COST HIGH IMPACT
TRAINING AND CALIFORNIA WAS A
RECIPIENT OF A TWO YEAR SAM TO
GRANT TO IMPLEMENT THIS TRAINING
IN SCHOOLS THE OUTCOME WAS VERY
POSITIVE AND THIS BUDGET REQUEST
IS TO ALLOW FOR THE EXPANSION OF
THIS TRAINING IN OUR STATE.
MEMBERS WE KNOW THAT WE CAN'T
AFFORD TO LOSE ANY OF MORE OF
OUR CHILDREN ARE SINCE STAFF
INTO SCHOOLS WITHOUT TRAINING ON
HOW TO RECOGNIZE WHEN YOU'VE.
ARE SUFFERING AND IN CRISIS AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY HOW TO PROVIDE
THEM THE RESOURCES THAT THEY
NEED -- NEXT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE BUTTE STABLE QUICKLY DISCUSS
HOW THE TRAININGS WILL OPERATE
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL.
MISTER CHAIR ROBLIN FROM THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
REQUESTING FUNDING TO TRAIN
SCHOOL PERSONNEL AND THE TRI
CITY SANTA BARBARA AND MADERA
COUNTIES -- WHILE WE SUBMITTED A
PROPOSAL WITH MORE DETAIL TO
YOUR STAFF I JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT A COUPLE OF VERY QUICK
HIGHLIGHTS.
AS MY COLLEAGUE LEE ANDHRA --
SAID WE ARE REQUESTING ONE POINT
SIX EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS TO
TRAIN APPROXIMATELY FOUR
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FIVE TEACHERS. ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED AND TEN DISTRICTS
SUPPORT STAFF IN TWENTY
DISTRICTS NOT ONLY DOES OUR
BUDGET ASK REPRESENT THE YOUTH
NOT HEALTH FIRST AID TRAINING
BUT WE'RE ALSO REQUESTING
DOLLARS. TO COVER DEDICATED
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT
TECHNOLOGY CAPITAL AND OTHER
RELATED ESSENTIAL COSTS IN
ADDITION TO THE TRAINING WERE
ALSO REQUESTING AS YOU WERE
SPEAKING TO EARLIER THAT THIS
PILOT PROGRAM BE EVALUATED IN
THE SAME WAY THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION.
ASSESSES THEIR CURRENT PROGRAMS
THAT ARE LINKED TO THE STAMPS
THE DOLLARS -- WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT STORE LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES -- THE PILOT COUNTY AND
THE PILOT COUNTIES WERE
CONFIDENT THAT THIS FUNDING WILL
ALLOW US TO NOT ONLY.
PROVIDE THE TRAINING ABOUT
BROUGHT IN BEAVIORAL HEALTH
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES FOR
STUDENTS ARE PROPOSAL GOES ABOVE%
AND BEYOND SIMPLY INCREASING
REFERRALS.
BETWEEN COUNTY SCHOOLS AND
COUNTY PROGRAMS THIS REQUEST
WILL ALLOW US TO ADDRESS ISSUES
SUCH AS EARLY PSYCHOSIS AND
CHILD TRAUMA AT A MUCH MUCH
EARLIER AGE THANK YOU MAY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
I THANK YOU ANNE -- COMES FROM
THE H. YES ALEJO [inaudible]
FINANCE.
SO -- BILL WHETHER THINGS THAT
WELL WE HAVE A NEW SURGEON
GENERAL WHO TALKS ABOUT ACES AND
TOXIC STRESS -- SO -- AND SO HOW
DO YOU SEE THAT YOU WERE TRYING
TO TRAIN TEACHERS HERE -- AS
WELL AS OTHER SCHOOL STAFF -- SO
THE CITY SEALINK WITH WITH ALL
THAT.
I THINK ONE OF THE STRONGEST
LINKS THAT WE COULD PROVIDE --
OR ONE OF THE SONGS FROM THE
SIMILARITIES IS NOT A HEALTH FOR
STATUS SIMILAR TO CPR YOU DON'T
HAVE TO HAVE A MEDICAL
BACKGROUND IN ORDER PROVIDE.
PROVIDE THAT ASSISTANCE AND
REFERRALS SO AWAY THAT A STUDENT
WOULD RECEIVE -- THE ASUS
SCREENING WHAT A TEACHER WOULD
FIRST SEE AN ISSUE THAT THEY CAN
REFER TO A MENTAL HEALTH
PERSONNEL WHEN HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL AND THE NOT THAT'S
ON THE SCREEN WOULD BE PROVIDED.
OKAY EXCELLENT SO I MEAN AGAIN
WE'RE TRYING TO BUILD CAPACITY
WE'RE NOT SAYING OUR TEACHERS
ARE GOING TO BE YOU KNOW TAKING
CARE OF ALL THE MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS RIGHT.
BUT THAT BUT WE NEED TO GIVE
SOME TOOLS TO BE ABLE TO DRESS.
TO DO VOICE THAT FOR STATE RIGHT
NOW AN IMPORTANT PART OF THIS IS
THAT WE'RE NOT JUST FOCUSING ON
TEACHER FOR FOCUSING ON THE
STATE COMMUNITY RIGHT SO IT'S
DENTURES IT'S THE BUS DRIVER IT
UP -- THE HALL MONITOR BOOKS
THAT ARE COMING INTO CONTACT --
WITH STUDENTS THROUGHOUT THE DAY
WE REALLY WANT THIS TO BE A
COMPREHENSIVE COMMUNITY APPROACH
OKAY EXCELLENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR MUCH [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
EXCEPT BURKE COUNTY SUICIDE
PREVENTION STRATEGIC PLANS THE
STEINBERG ASTUTE WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON ADRIN SOLD SOME
OF THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE AND
WE ARE PROUD TO BRING THIS
PROPOSAL FOR TODAY WHICH IS
ABOUT PREVENTING SUICIDES IN OUR
STATE.
WE BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO BE
MUCH MORE PROACTIVE AT ALL
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT TO REDUCE
THIS ALARMING INCREASE IN
SUICIDES.
RECENT DATA FROM EARLIER THIS
YEAR -- FOUND THAT SUICIDES IN
THE U. S. ROSE 33% FROM.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN NEARLY FORTY THREE
HUNDRED CALIFORNIANS DIE BY
SUICIDE UNTIL AND TWENTY SIXTEEN
WHICH IS A 50% INCREASE FROM.
TWO THOUSAND ONE ACCORDING TO
THE LATEST FIGURES FROM THE US
CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
FOR PEOPLE UNDER.
THIRTY FIVE SUICIDE IS THE
SECOND LEASING LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH AFTER ACCIDENTS.
ACCORDING TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THE SUICIDE
RATE AMONG CHILDREN AGES.
TEN TO FOURTEEN JUMPED AN
ASTONISHING 210025% BETWEEN
NINETEEN NINETY ONE AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND ONE OTHER
STATISTIC THAT GOT MY ATTENTION
ABOUT WHO IS IMPACTED BY SUICIDE.
AND CALIFORNIA'S THAT ACCORDING
TO A STATE STUDY JUST OVER HALF
OR 51%.
OF THE RESPONDENTS SAID THAT
THEY HAD A PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
WITH SUICIDE SO THIS IS NOW THE
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED.
SO WE ARE PROPOSING THAT ALL
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES HAVE A
SUICIDE PREVENTION PLAN.
A COUNTY SUICIDE PREVENTION TASK
FORCE AND WRITING A SUICIDE
PREVENTION PLAN CAN HELP IN
IDENTIFYING GAPS OR MISSING
ACTIONS AND BETTER PROMOTE AND
COMMUNICATE ABOUT SUICIDE
PREVENTION.
ACTIONS COUNTIES THAT HAVE
DEVELOPED SUICIDE PREVENTION
PLANS HAVE REPORTED THAT THE
PLANS HAVE HELPED THEM TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND SUICIDE IN THEIR
COUNTIES. TO HELP GUIDE COUNTY
EFFORTS AGAIN IF I GOALS AND BE
ABLE TO MEASURE PROGRESS IN FACT
IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY WHERE
THERE HAS BEEN A CONCERTED
SUICIDE PREVENTION.
EFFORTS SINCE TWO THOUSAND TEN
THEY HAVE SEEN A SIGNIFICANT
DROP IN SUICIDE DEATHS.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SANTA CLARA COUNTY
SUICIDE DUSTER CREASE BY 11% AND
14% RESPECTIVELY.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT MUCH MORE
NEEDS TO BE DONE IN OUR STATE.
BUT THIS WILL REQUIRE A MULTI
FACETED APPROACH TO ADDRESSING
THE PROBLEM AND THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE BROUGHT FOR THIS PROPOSAL
TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU INCOMES MARKET
SERVICES L. L..
FINANCE OKAY.
RIGHT NOT THE THEY KNOW THAT
THERE WAS A A BILL ADDRESSING
THIS THAT WE'VE HEARD AND HEALTH
COMMITTEE AS WELL AND AS YOU
POINTED OUT THAT -- IT'S NO ONE
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH OF OUR
YOUTH COURSES I'D ANY AGE AS IS
TERRIBLE -- BT WE WE WE HAD --
THE THE RISING RATES OF SUICIDE
CERTAINLY EXTRA AND WHAT
CONCERNS UNDERSTATEMENT CELL AND
AND THAT WE WE NEED TO HAVE.
STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS THAT SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD OKAY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
NEXT ITEM FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE
PARTNERSHIP IN THE AT THE TULARE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
[inaudible]
HEY [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY.
AND YOUR HONOR.
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON THINK THINK
IS THE FIRST.
THE CALIFORNIA TRIAL I
PARTNERSHIP AND THIS MORNING YOU
MET MANY OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE ON
SENATE FLOOR WHEN THEY RECEIVED
THE RESOLUTION FOR FRIDAY I LIVE
MONTH.
THEY NAMED IT CHRIS THEY ARE NOT
ABLE TO STAY BUT CHRIS IS HERE
REPRESENTING THEMSELVES.
THE HISTORY OF FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE
IT BEGAN IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR
AS A DRINKING DRIVING PREVENTION
PROGRAM IS BALD MANY TIMES SINCE
THEN IT'S NOW YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS.
OPERATING IN FIFTY OF THE FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES ON MORE THAN SIX
HUNDRED SITES.
OUR REQUEST IS FOR SIX MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR TO BE ABLE TO
BRING THE RESOURCES BACK TO THE
LEVEL IT WAS IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT IN DOING SO WILL BE ABLE
TO SEE THAT.
OUR EFFORTS FOCUSED ON FRIDAY
NIGHT LIVE OR DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT YOU'VE SEEN SO FAR TODAY
MOST OF THE REQUEST.
FOCUS ON REMEDIATION TO STOP THE
BLEEDING ON MAJOR PROBLEMS.
FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE IS MORE OF A
PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH IT REALLY
IS A VACCINE TO HELP PROTECT
YOUNG PEOPLE FROM THE INFLUENCES
THE COMMUNITY AND ENGAGING THEM.
TO MAKE THEIR COMMUNITIES BETTER
PLACES SO THAT WE'RE NOT LOOKING
AT DOWNSTREAM PROBLEMS WERE
ADDRESSING BEFORE THEY BECOME
BIGGER PROBLEMS.
SO MAKING SURE THAT YOUNG PEOPLE
HAVE A SAFE ENVIRONMENT THAT
THEY GET INVOLVED WITH THEIR
COMMUNITY.
THAT THEY'RE GETTING SKILL
BUILDING OPPORTUNITIES AND THAT
THEY HAVE POSITIVE RELATIONSHIPS
IN THEIR AREAS.
SO IT BEGAN IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR AND SACRAMENTO IS OUR FIRST
AREA AND RIVERSIDE IS OUR SECOND.
AND IN FRESNO OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
FROM ROSE ABOUT WERE ABLE TO
DEMONSTRATE WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
AND REALLY CHANGING THE
COMMUNITY BY CHANGING BILLBOARDS
AROUND THEIR SCHOOLS BY CHANGING
THE ORDINANCES ON THE
AVAILABILITY OF ALCOHOL.
SO LAST YEAR WE WERE BEFORE YOU
WE MADE IT THROUGH CONFERENCE
BUT DIDN'T MAKE IT INTO THE
BUDGET.
SO WITH THE HELP OF TOM WE ARE --
EAGER TO SEE US BE SUCCESSFUL
THIS YEAR WITH YOUR SUPPORT.
GEN WITH BELIEVE ME THIRTY
SECONDS OF NO REAL QUICK ARE YOU
LEFT YOUR DAD SO HE HAS ARE SO
TOM RENT FREE WITH THE COUNTY BE
ABLE HELP DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
WERE FULLY SUPPORTING UP FRONT
AND I LIVES PROPOSAL -- THIS
PROGRAM IS ONE OF THE BUT THE
PRE MAYOR -- ELEMENTS OF OUR
PREVENTION SERVICES THAT THAT
OPERATES AND PROVIDED IN ALMOST
ALL OF OUR COUNTIES -- IT
REPRESENTS THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES -- AND IT
WORKS WELL IN IN IN CONJUNCTION
WITH ALL OF OUR EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE THE MENTAL HEALTH AND
AND SCHOOL CONNECTEDNESS HEALTH
AND SAFETY AND JUST THE
DEVELOPMENT OF OUR OF OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE.
SO THEY HAVE MORE POSITIVE
THINGS TO DO THAN GET INVOLVED
WITH SUBSTANCE USE AND ARE YOU
KNOW SO WE WE FULLY SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
AND WE ARE EVIDENCE BASED IN
EACH YEAR WE DO AN EVALUATION OF
THE YOUNG PEOPLE'S EXPERIENCE TO
BE ABLE TO DOCUMENT THE AFFECT
OF THE PROGRAM IN THEIR LIVES.
EXCELLENT RIGHT ANY COMMENTS AND
REGULAR SERVICES L. L..
FINANCE RIGHT QUESTION COMMITTEE
MEMBERS NOW.
SO I ACTUALLY JUST TO CLARIFY
THIS PROPOSAL FOR SIX MILLION.
EXITS AS FRIDAY LIFE FOR SHIP AT
THE TULARE COUNTY OF THE OFFICE
OF EDUCATION THIS IS NOT ONE
COUNTY RATE WOULD NOTICE WITH
ALSO FOR THE WHOLE THE CROSS IS
A FOR THE ENTIRE STATE SO OUR
STATE OFFICE HAPPENS TO BE AT
THE TULARE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION -- WE ADMINISTER
PROJECTS THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH THE
OFFICE OF TRAFFIC SAFETY.
AND HELP THEM ACHIEVE THEIR
GOALS BY CONNECTING YOUNG PEOPLE
IN POSITIVE ACTIVITIES AND
CHANGING THE NORMS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES WELL I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THAT CLICK THAT
CLARIFY THAT POINT JUST TO BE
SURE THAT PEOPLE THAN SEE THIS
IS A COMPANY OWNED ONE COUNTY.
PROPOSAL SO NOT -- THAT THAT
THAT THAT WE HAVEN'T SEEN HER
DOZEN AND THAT THAT THAT DOESN'T
AS THE INAPPROPRIATE.
EARLY IN FIFTY OF THE FIFTY
EIGHT IN THIS MAYBE HELP BRING
ON THE OTHER EIGHT COUNTIES
HONORING THEM BACK IN AND IT WAS
IS CERTAINLY -- QUITE THRILLED
TO MAKE ME TO USE THIS MORNING
AS WELL SO.
ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION THANK
YOU.
ALL RIGHT NEXT IS THE CHILDREN'S
CRISIS RESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS
TRAILER BILL PROPOSAL AND THAT'S
THE CALIFORNIA LANCE OF CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS
CHRIS STONER MERTZ I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES.
THIS TRAILER BILL WILL REPLACE
THE TERM CHILDREN'S CRISIS
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAM WITH
CHILDREN'S CRISIS PSYCHIATRIC
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT.
FACILITY OR P. R. T. F..
MAKING THE TERM CONSISTENT WITH
FEDERAL MEDICAID DEFINITIONS AND
THEREFORE ENSURING THAT IT IS
TREATED CONSISTENTLY WITH OTHER
PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT FACILITIES WITH REGARD
TO LICENSING CERTIFICATION.
AND PAYMENT THROUGH THE E. PST
TEAM MEDI CAL BENEFITS.
ARE YOU HEARD MICHELLE TENS DATA
AROUND SUICIDE -- IN ADDITION.
OF CALIFORNIA'S POOREST CHILDREN
ONE IN TEN MEET THE CRITERIA FOR
SERIOUS EMOTIONAL DISTURBANCE.
WE CERTAINLY HAVE A CRISIS OF
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
IT FOR KIDS -- PETER T. F.'S CAN
PROVIDE TWENTY FOUR HOUR
INTENSIVE TREATMENT AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO HOSPITALIZATION
AND ARE CRITICALLY NEEDED AS
PART OF A CONTINUUM OF CARE FOR
CHILDREN.
UNDER TWENTY ONE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
AB ONE FIVE OH ONE AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIDLEY SCOTT IS
THE BILL THAT CREATED A
LICENSING CATEGORY FOR C. C. R.
PEAS.
IT WAS SIGNED INTO LAW IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN IT WAS
INTENDED TO FILL A TRUE GAP IN
CALIFORNIA'S MENTAL HEALTH
CONTINUUM OF CARE FOR CHILDREN
AND PROVE CARE. FOR THOSE
CHILDREN EXPERIENCING A MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS.
THE PRIMARY FUNCTION OF C. C. R.
PEAS IS TO PROVIDE A SHORT TERM
CRISIS STABILIZATION THERAPEUTIC
INTERVENTION.
AND SPECIALIZED PROGRAMMING AND
THEN UNLOCK STAFF SECURED
SETTING WITH A HIGH DEGREE OF
SUPERVISION STRUCTURE.
WITH THE GOAL OF SUPPORTING A
RAPID AND SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION
OF CHILDREN BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY.
THIS WAS SUPPORTED BY A BROAD
COALITION INCLUDING YOUTH FAMILY
MEMBERS PROVIDERS COUNTY
ASSOCIATIONS AT CETERA.
THE BILL LANGUAGE REPLICATED
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM IN
MASSACHUSETTS CALLED COMMUNITY
BASED ACUTE TREATMENT OR SEE BAT
THE C. C. R. P. LIKE SEE BAT AND
THE CHILDREN'S CRISIS
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS AND ALL
OTHER STATES THAT WE REVIEWED.
ARE OPERATED UNDER THE FEDERAL
DESIGNATION OF P. R. F. P. R. T.
F.'S OR IF IT THAT IS MEDICAID
PARLANCE IT'S THEIR DESIGNATION.
TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE BACKGROUND
IN TWO THOUSAND ONE CMS
ESTABLISHED P. R. T. F. AS A NEW
CATEGORY OF MEDICAID FACILITY.
AND AN ADDITIONAL SETTING FOR
WHICH THE PSYCH UNDER TWENTY ONE
BENEFIT COULD BE PROVIDED.
THIS PROVIDED A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF THE CHILDREN'S
MENTAL HEALTH CONTINUUM OF CARE.
THAT ENSURES THAT THERE IS A
MEDICAID REIMBURSEMENT FOR A
COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE OF
SERVICES.
IN ONE RATE.
DURING THE PROCESS OF DRAFTING
AB FIVE OH ONE THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER C. C. R. P. FACILITIES
WERE GONNA FALL INTO THIS
CATEGORY OF P. R. T. F. WAS NOT
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSED.
WE WERE LOOKING AT WHAT TYPE OF
LICENSE CATEGORY WOULD WORK MOST
EFFECTIVELY -- THE S. T. R. T.
P. LICENSURE WAS THE MOST
COMPATIBLE WITH THE C. C. R. P.
MODEL.
AND SO THIS IS THE LICENSE
CATEGORY THAT WAS AGREED UPON.
THIS IS CREATED CONFUSION. TO
WRAP UP SENT UP.
BECAUSE THE C. C. R. P. IS A NOT
A FOSTER CARE PLACEMENT.
IT IS CLEARLY A PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITAL ALTERNATIVE.
I'M GONNA JUMP TO THE KEY POINT.
BECAUSE I KNOW I'M OVER MY TIME.
THERE IS NO FEDERAL REQUIREMENT
THAT EXISTS THAT STIPULATES
WHICH STATE AGENCY MUST LICENSE
THE PRC OFF.
THE ISSUE AT HAND TODAY IS THE
BILL IS THAT THE DEPARTMENT DOES
NOT BELIEVE IT HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO CERTIFY THESE PROGRAMS AS PR
T. F.'S THIS LANGUAGE.
THAT WE WOULD WE'RE PROPOSING IN
TRAILER BILL WOULD REQUIRE DH CS
TO CERTIFY C. C. R. PEAS AS P.
R. T. F.'S ENSURING FULL MEDI
CAL REIMBURSEMENT FOR THIS
TWENTY FOUR HOUR MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT.
IS VERY RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU AND
COMMENTS FROM THE BAR HEALTH
SERVICES ALPHABET SOUP SORRY
[inaudible]
LEO COMMONS.
FINANCE ALL RIGHT.
SO ACTUALLY I DID FOR PARK OF
SERVICES I MEAN.
THAT IS SET THAT.
THERE'S THIS RECOGNITION PROBLEM
OR IS IT THERE'S MORE IS FROM
YOUR TIME I'M NOT.
FAMILIAR WITH THE ISSUE SO I
WILL WE CERTAINLY DO HAVE
QUESTIONS WE CAN GET WE CAN GET
BACK OKAY ALL RIGHT SO JUST TO
GET A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT THE SITUATION IS THERE OKAY
ALL RIGHT.
THANKS RICK YOU SEVENTIES.
OKAY AND THEN WE HAVE FOR
FUNDING FOR PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATORS PUBLIC GUARDIANS
OF PUBLIC CONSERVATIVES.
CALPERS ASEAN PULLING WELL.
CAP BY -- AND I CAN TRY TO
PRONOUNCE THAT THE ACTION IN
THEIR CA PA PGD PC.
AND I KNOW THIS OF OTHER.
PEOPLE YOU COALITION AS WELL SO
THANK YOU WELCOME.
AFTERNOON SENATOR PAN -- AND
OTHER MEMBERS I'M SCARLET HUGHES
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC ADMINISTRATORS GUARDIANS
AND CONSERVATORS.
AND IN COLLABORATION WITH C.
SACK SEIU AND THE CALIFORNIA
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE ASKING THE
STATE TO PARTNER WTH COUNTIES
IN PROVIDING DESPERATELY NEEDED
FUNDING MILLION DOLLARS AN
ONGOING STATE FUNDING TO AUGMENT
NOT SUPPLANT COUNTY FUNDING. TO
SUPPORT OUR SERVICES OUR MEMBERS
ARE COUNTY EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
APPOINTED BY THE COURTS TO
ASSUME ALL RESPONSIBILITY FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS AND SEVERE COGNITIVE
IMPAIRMENTS INCLUDING CRIMINAL
OFFENDERS.
WHOSE RIGHT TO SELF
DETERMINATION HAS BEEN REMOVED
DESPITE THE VARIOUS MEANT
MANDATES PUT FORTH IN STATE LAW
WE RECEIVE NO STATE FUNDING IN
FACT AS NEAR AS WE CAN TELL WE
ARE THE ONLY.
MAJOR HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAM THAT DOES NOT RECEIVE
ANY DEDICATED STATE FUNDING OUR
SERVICES ARE FUNDED COMPLETELY
THROUGH COUNTY GENERAL FUNDS AND
WE DO NOT RECEIVE ANY DEDICATED
REALIGNMENT MONEY.
A RECENT SURVEY OF OUR MEMBERS
REVEALED COUNTIES ARE SPENDING
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
NINETY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR ON THESE PROGRAMS.
DESPITE THE SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF COUNTY FUNDING OUR MEMBERS
ARE STRUGGLING TO MANAGE
UNREASONABLE AND OVERWHELMING
CASELOADS.
UNDERSTAND WE DO NOT WE ARE NOT
IN A POSITION TO TURN DOWN CASES
THAT WELL AS THE COURT OFFICE
OFTEN OFTEN DICTATES EXACTLY
WHAT WE HAVE TO TAKE.
BASED ON LEGISLATIVE MANDATES
RECENT.
RESEARCH SHOWS THE TARGET
POPULATION THAT WE SERVE HAS
GROWN 30% IN THE PAST FIVE YEARS
THIS 30% INCREASE OF CASES IS
DUE TO CHANGES IN STATE LAWS AND
POLICIES.
WHICH HAS DRAMATICALLY INCREASED
REFERRALS AND INCREASE THE
COMPLEXITY OF CASES SOME OF
THESE LEGISLATIVE CHANGES
INCLUDE THE OMNIBUS
CONSERVATORSHIP ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX WHICH
SIGNIFICANTLY CHANGE THE PLAYING
FIELD.
BY REMOVING THE P. T. PC'S
DISCRETION THE FILE AND MAN IN
MANDATED THAT THE P. GPC PUBLIC
GARDENING CONSERVATORS FILE A
PETITION OF CONSERVATORSHIP WHEN
ANY COGNITIVELY IMPAIRED
INDIVIDUAL IS AT RISK OR
WHENEVER THE COURT.
BELIEVES IT WOULD BE BENEFICIAL.
BY MID AND ALSO BY MANDATING
INVESTIGATIONS BEGIN WITHIN TWO
BUSINESS DAYS TO NAME JUST A FEW
OF THE MANDATES ALSO RECENT
LEGISLATIVE CHANGES TO PENAL
CODE SECTION.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY HAS BECAUSE HE
HE EACH INCREASE IN REFERRALS
FOR CRIMINAL OFFENDERS WHO ARE
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL IN
DEEMED UNRESTORED COMPETENCY.
THEIR PROMPTLY RETURNED TO THE
COUNTY AND A CONSERVATORSHIP
SOUGHT SOUGHT.
AS THE LEGISLATURE DEBATES
FURTHER REFORMS AND POLICIES TO
DEAL WITH THE GROWING NUMBERS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HOMELESS
SEVERELY COGNITIVELY IMPAIRED
BECAUSE OF THE AGING POPULATION.
AND SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL AND
VICTIMS OF SEVERE.
PHYSICAL AND FINANCIAL ABUSE THE
NEED FOR PHP TPC SERVICES ARE
NEEDED MORE THAN EVER AND WE
WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS IF YOU'RE
GOOD OKAY SHE'D LEFT USE.
CASE.
SHE ONLY LEFT ABOUT FIVE SECONDS
ANYWAY SO LIKE OKAY.
ALL RIGHT -- ANY COMES FOR HIS
SERVICES ALEJO.
FINANCE WHICH COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SO I AM I GET I GUESS ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS I HAD BEEN ANALYST
FINANCE EARLIER MIGHT WANT TO
ANSWER THIS ONE IS IS THAT -- IS
MENTIONED THAT -- YOU KNOW.
WE THROUGH THE STATE LEGISLATURE
GOVERNOR'S AYE IT THAT HAVE HAVE
INCREASED THE WORKLOAD.
A CONSERVATIVE OR I THOUGHT.
IT IS YOURS GUARDIANS COULD
SERVICE -- SO -- SO -- THAT
DOESN'T ADD DAY DISSIDENT
TRIGGER A STATE NEED TO PUT CHEN.
TELL ANYTHING THE THOUGHTS ON
THAT OUT OF THE HISTORY OF WHAT
WHOSE WAS TO DO WHAT SO YES.
YEAH I DON'T THINK I HAVE ANY
COMMENTS I WOULD I'D BE CURIOUS
TO SEE THE DATA AND TO TO KNOW
LIKE WHAT WORKLOAD WAS INCREASE
BUT GENERALLY SPEAKING I THINK
WHEN THERE ARE INCREASED COSTS
THAT RESULT IN STATE MANDATES.
YOU KNOW THEIR CONVERSATIONS
WITH WITH THE ENTITY THAT COUNTY
SAID. TO ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE
AND IF THEY'RE LEFT AND UNFUNDED
THEN THERE'S YOU KNOW PROCESS
THAT.
COUNTIES CAN FILE STATE MANDATE
CLAIMS.
BUT I MEAN THOSE ARE
CONVERSATIONS THAT NEED TO BE
HAD IN LIKE.
YEAH OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL I MEAN
IT I MEAN WHEN ONE ROUTE WOULD
BE TO GO TO MANDATE COMMISSION
SAY BY THE WAY YOU KNOW IT'S AT
BUT I THINK THE OTHER PRO YEAH
YEAH I GUESS I GUESS RIGHT WE
TRIED THAT WE WENT TO THE STATE
MANDATE.
COMMISSION AND AND AND MADE A
CASE THEY DENIED IT BECAUSE THE
LAW IT'S IT'S CONTRADICTORY SO
THE LAW SAYS THAT THE COUNTY
DOESN'T HAVE TO HAVE A PUBLIC
GUARDIAN.
BUT AT THE COUNTY CHOOSES TO
HAVE APUBLIC GUARDIAN THEN WE
MANDATE THAT YOU DO ALL THESE
THINGS BUT THE POINT IS IS THAT
THAT SHIP SAILED A LONG TIME AGO
LIKE FORTY YEARS AGO THE
COUNTIES CREATED PUBLIC
GUARDIANS.
AND NOW PUBLIC GUARDING
CONSERVATIVES ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR ALL THESE CASES THE COURT IS
NOT GOING TO ALLOW US TO WALK
AWAY WE DON'T HAVE THAT
DISCRETION AT THIS POINT TO WALK
AWAY.
SO WE WERE CAUGHT IN A IN A
DOUBLE BIND.
THE STATE MANDATES SAID I'M NOT
IT'S NOT YOU PERSONALLY -- STATE
MANDATE SAID NO YOU DON'T
QUALIFY BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE
TO HAVE THIS.
BUT WE DO HAVE TO HAVE IT
BECAUSE OUR SOCIETY HAS GOTTEN
TO A POINT WHERE IT IS REQUIRED.
SO WE WERE WE WERE NOT ELIGIBLE.
DIMMING FOR TO COME RIGHT NOW IT
WOULD JUST SAY THAT I I THINK.
DEFINITELY WHEN THERE'S LAWS
PASSED A LOT OF THE TIMES THEY
THEY SAY THE COUNTIES MAY.
RATHER THAN SHALL AND SO WHAT
WITH IT MOST OF THE SELECTION OF
THE COUNTY AND WHETHER NOT THEY
WANT TO DO THAT OKAY WELL AS A
LIST OF THE SITE.
SO I MEAN WE CAN.
WE CAN.
WEEK AS I'M NOT A LAWYER SO WE
COULD NOT TAKE THE LAW -- BUT I
THINK SO SO MAYBE LEGALLY NOT
MANDATED BUT I I I I DO WONDER
ABOUT -- THE STATE'S
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROVIDE SOME
FUNDING.
BECAUSE OF WHAT WORK WE'VE
REQUIRED SO I MEAN IT'S IT'S NOT
STRICTLY YOU KNOW.
THE MAN A COMMISSION VOTE CENTER
OF ANY JUST PHILOSOPHICALLY
RIGHT NOW EXACTLY WHILE MUCH IN
THAT CENTRO THE WE CAN DEBATE
ARGUE BUT I'M JUST SAYING
CONCEPTUALLY.
SOMETIMES ON A SAY WELL YOU
DON'T THE COUNTIES ARE SUPPOSED
TO DO THAT IT'S NOT.
THE STATE YOU KNOW STATE BY
VOTERS CREATING MORE WORK.
PERHAPS WE OUGHT. TO FOR A IN IN
AND AGAIN I DON'T KNOW ENOUGH
ABOUT THESE PROGRAMS OKAY I HAVE
TO SAY BUT IT SOUNDS AS IF THE
STATE CURRENTLY DOES NOT PROVIDE
ANY DIRECT FUNDING FOR THAT
RIGHT SO OKAY WELL I THINK I
THINK SO ANYWAY.
I'M STE.
SURE YOU CAN HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE THE WITH THE WITH THE
FINANCE AND I DON'T AS EARLY
OVERLOOKED AT THIS ISSUE ABOUT.
RISING WORKLOAD.
FOR THE MINISTERS GUARDIANS
CONSERVATIVES.
OUR STATE ACTIONS THAT HAVE
RESULTED IN CHANGES IN THE ROLE.
NO WE AND NOT HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ANALYZE THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM BUT WE'D
STILL BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
PROPONENTS -- TO GET SOME MORE
ANSWERS TO THE LEGISLATURE HERE
TO YOUR POINT SENATOR MOST
PEOPLE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT
PUBLIC CONSERVATISM PUBLIC
GUARDIANS ARE WHAT THEY DO AND
WELL THAT'S A THIS WAY.
BUT YOU REALLY NEED ONE YOU
LEARNED ALL TOO FAST RIGHT.
OKAY THANK YOU SORRY THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
OKAY SO THAT -- CONCLUDES OUR
PRESENTATION FALLS INVESTMENT SO
NOW WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS ON
THEM SO YOU -- AGAIN ASK YOU TO
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO A MINUTE
OR LESS AND TELL US WHICH ONES
YOU REALLY LIKE RIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN FARMING
DATING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AGAIN AND WE WANT TO
THANK YOUR COMMITTEE FOR GIVING
THE TIME AND SPACE ON THE AGENDA
FOR THESE PROPOSALS TO BE HEARD.
C. SACK IS IN SUPPORT OF TO THE
PROPOSAL'S THE LAST.
TWO THE TERM CHANGE OR THE
LICENSING CATEGORY CHANGE FOR
CHILDREN'S CRISIS RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAMS.
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE TO
US AND IT WAS PART OF HOW THE
BILL WAS DESIGNED AB FIVE OH ONE
SO I THINK IT'S A SIMPLE CHANGE --
IS SIMPLE LICENSING CATEGORY
CHANGE MORE STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE
OF THAT WE ARE A CO SPONSOR OF
THE LAST ONE THAT YOU JUST HEARD
AND HAVE NOTHING TO ADD TO THE
CONVERSATION YOU'VE ALREADY HAD
EXCEPT THAT WERE -- IN STRONG
SUPPORT IT IS THE FIRST TIME
WE'VE ASKED FOR STATE FUNDING
AND IT PUBLIC GUARDIANS
CONSIDERS AN ADMINISTRATORS ARE
AT THE INTERSECTION OF ALL THE
POLICY ISSUES WE WORK ON
HOMELESSNESS.
PUBLIC SAFETY.
CROWDED ER'S YOU NAME IT PUBLIC
GUARDIANS ARE PART OF THAT
EQUATION SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
DANIEL A CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES IN
SUPPORT OF MENTAL HEALTH FOR
STATE.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME MERE MARTIN HERE BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE A REDEFINITION OF
CHILDREN'S CRISIS RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAMS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
IT RESULT IN WHAT THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT OF THREE
THE PROPOSALS PRESENTED TODAY
THE YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH FIRST
AID TRAINING.
THE THE CHILDREN'S CRISIS
RESIDENTIAL TRAILER BILL AND THE
SUBSTANCES COUNSELORS AND
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
HI TERRY MEMBERS MITCHELL CAPITA
WITH THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION AND WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE SIXTY
EIGHT MILLION FOR PUBLIC
GUARDIANS OF STATE FUNDING WE
REPRESENT -- PUBLIC GUARDIANS
WHO WORK ON CONSERVING
INDIVIDUALS -- FOR THAT COUNTIES
AND IT'S TRUE THAT THEIR
WORKLOAD HAS INCREASED AS A
RESULT OF VARIOUS STATE POLICIES
NOT JUST IN HEALTH CARE BUT AS A
C. SECT MENTION DO TO
HOMELESSNESS AND AS WELL AS THE
MOVEMENT OF INDIVIDUALS FROM
STATE HOSPITALS TO THE LOCAL
LEVEL -- THE FRIENDS A CASELOAD
HAS REALLY EXPANDED QUITE A BIT
AND SO WE THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE
FOR THE STATE TO BEGIN TO
SUPPLEMENT COUNTY FUNDING TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S ADEQUATE DUE
PROCESS FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME WE HONOR CLICK
HARVEY ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH AGENCIES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE CHILDREN CRISIS
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAM GENIUS THANK
YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT DEBORAH
BROWN ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN NOW
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE A YOUTH
MENTAL HEALTH HELP FOR STATE
FUNDING.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON AYE RENAL
TOMORROW ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES.
IN SUPPORT OF THE PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATORS PUBLIC GUARDIANS
PUBLIC CONSERVATIVES FUNDING
THANK YOU PROPOSAL.
OKAY THANK YOU.
DOCTOR TO MADDEN AND NOT BE
GIVEN AUTHORITY TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF ADDICTION MEDICINE IN
THEIR IN SUPPORT OF OUR REQUEST
REPAIR NARRATORS EMERGING
DEPARTMENTS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SERRA
STRATTON AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF SAN FRANCISCO'S DEPARTMENT OF
AGING AND ADULT SERVICES.
AND WE OPERATE PUBLIC
CONSERVATIVE -- PUBLIC GUARDIAN
AND PUBLIC ADMINISTRATOR FOR THE
CITY AND COUNTY.
THESE THREE PROGRAMS PROVIDE
CRITICAL SAFETY DATA SERVICES
FOR VULNERABLE POPULATION.
AND TO WE SUPPORT.
THIS.
A STATE FUNDING PROPOSAL SO WE
CAN MAKE INCREASED NEEDS FOR
PROTECTIVE SERVICES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS CHRIS COOPER AND
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO
TULARE. TO HIM A KINGS NAPA AND
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATOR GUARDIAN -- BUDGET
ASK -- WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE ACTUALLY FOR
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT.
JUST LIKE CHILDREN IN THE
SIXTIES AND SEVENTIES WERE
KNOWLEDGE DOES A SPECIAL CLASS
OF CITIZENS IN NEED OF
PROTECTION BY THE STATE.
THAT THE STATE APPEARS TO BE
STARTING TO UNDERSTAND TO
MEASURES LACKEY DOC BUT A THE
OMNIBUS CONSERVATORSHIP BACKED
AND THE CHANGES TO PENAL CODE --
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FOR INCOMPETENT
NON RESTORE BILL OFFENDERS THAT
THERE IS A SPECIAL CLASS OF
ADULT CITIZENS.
AND AS C. SACK MENTIONED THE PA
PGP STE'S STANDS AT THAT
INTERSECTION AND SO WE VERY MUCH
ACID ALLEGES THAT THE SENATE IN
THIS COMMITTEE MOVE FORWARD ON
THAT BUDGET ASK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
I COULD AFTERNOON.
WITH THE DINNER WITH ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK ON THIS IS IN
RESPONSE TO THE US BYRD
STAKEHOLDER ASK -- WE THINK THAT
SPENDING EXT A SPURT TO DRUGS --
OTHER THAN ALCOHOL IS ESSENTIAL
FOR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AS
COMMITTEES OF COLOR WITH
SUBSTANCE USE DEPENDENCY ARE
HIGHER -- ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE
CRIMINALIZED THAN WHITE
AMERICANS WE ALSO SEE THIS AS AN
EQUITY ISSUE AS WE KNOW THAT THE
RISE OF MORTALITY FOR OVERDOSES
AMONG THE LOT NEXT AND BLACK
COMMUNITY.
HAS BEEN HAS STEADILY INCREASED --
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE SUPPORT
THE EXPANSION OF A SPUR TO DRUGS
OTHER THAN ALCOHOL OKAY THANK
YOU.
WELCOME.
KELLY BROOKS I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR
VENTURA AND SANTA CRUZ COUNTIES
IN SUPPORT OF THE SIXTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE PUBLIC
GUARDIANS PUBLIC ADMINISTRATOR
SOME PUBLIC CONSERVATORS.
BOTH BOARDS ARE REALLY DOING THE
PROPOSAL AS PART OF THEIR
EFFORTS ON HOMELESSNESS THE
INVENTOR COUNTY THAT POINT IN
TIME COUNT INCREASED 40% BETWEEN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY
NINETEEN AND THERE'S AN
UNPRECEDENTED -- HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENT IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
AS WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M TYLER INDIA
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION ON AND IN ADDITION
TO THE ON PROPOSALS THAT WE
PRESENTED ON WE ARE PROUD TO BE
A CO SPONSOR ON THE ON THE
FUNDING FOR PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATORS PUBLIC GARDENS
AND PUBLIC CONSERVATORS.
AND WE'RE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE
C. C. R. P. LICENSING CHANGE AND
AS CITY COUNCILLORS AND
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME PLANS KEVIN CLARK I'M A
STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY SCHOOL
SOCIAL AFFAIRS WAS A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH.
AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
LICENSING CHANGE FOR CHILDREN'S --
CRISIS RESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
I PATRICIA GUEST WITH SENECA
FAMILY OF AGENCIES IN SUPPORT OF
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
CLARIFY THE LICENSING STATUS OF
THE CALIFORNIA -- AT CRISIS
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAM SO THAT THEY
CAN BE FULLY REIMBURSED FOR THE
TWENTY FOUR HOUR CARE THAT
THEY'RE PROVIDING THANK YOU I
THANK YOU -- CONDUCTOR AGAIN DR
GERM COURT CALIFORNIA FROWN LIVE
I RECEIVED A NOTE FROM ONE OF
OUR ADULT ALLIES WHO COULDN'T BE
HERE I WILL.
EMAIL THAT TO YOU ALONG WITH
NOTES FROM OTHER YOUNG PEOPLE
WILL COME TO YOUR OFFICES IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL.
WELCOME.
CRISTINA MERTZ CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE I IN SUPPORT OF YOUTH
MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID IN THE
COUNTY SUICIDE PREVENTION PLANTS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
SO -- WITH THAT -- ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OKAY SO WE
WILL -- HOLD OPEN -- EACH OF
THESE PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENT
ALL OF THE OTHER THINGS.
OKAY WELL JUST TO FOR THE RECORD
WERE HOLDING OPEN ISSUES NUMBER
TWO THREE FOUR FIVE SIX AND
PROPOSALS AND ISSUE NUMBER.
SEVEN AND I THINK WITH THAT
WE'RE GOING -- TO MOVE ON TO THE
PART HEALTHCARE SERVICES AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
WELCOME.
AND WILL.
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND DO THE ROUND
ROBIN INTRODUCTIONS AGAIN FOR
THE RECORD.
ALRIGHT SO LET'S GO AHEAD
EVERYONE INTRODUCE THEMSELVES
AGAIN SO START.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO BE DOING
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR THE MIDDLE
SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION OKAY.
UNDER BRITISH DEPARTMENT HEALTH
CARE SERVICES [inaudible]
HELLO.
BRUNDTLAND IS ILLEGAL MARK
NEWTON ALEJO AND IT'S ANON
COMMENT FROM THE FINANCE.
CRISCO TEHAMA FINANCE THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SO -- FIRST ISSUE IS
JUST -- OVERS -- MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT OVERSIGHT AND
POLICY DEVELOPMENT.
AND I THE FOCUS ON THE
HIGHLIGHTS HERE.
ABSOLUTELY US THROUGH A PRETTY
GREAT WISH ARE WE ARE SEEKING
THIRTEEN POSITIONS -- WERE
SEEKING TO RE DIRECT FUNDING%
FROM AN EXISTING -- TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON
ALLOCATION THAT WE HAVE TO RE
DIRECTED -- THERE'S QUITE A BIT
OF THE EMPHASIS ON STRENGTHENING
OUR OVERSIGHT FOR THE MOBILE
SERVICES ACT THROUGH -- AUDITS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR AS WELL AS LITTLE ARE
HOOVER COMMISSION -- AND AS WELL
AS SOME -- HEARINGS LAST YEAR
AND SO WHILE WE'VE REALLY YOU
ARE TAKING A CLOSE LOOK AND
DETERMINED THAT -- YOU KNOW IT
WOULD BE -- A GOOD IDEA TO
REDIRECT FUNDS FROM AT A TV
CONTRACT WERE NOT EXPENDING ALL
OF OUR FUNDS -- TO REALLY FOCUS
IT INTO OUR STRENGTH AND OUR
OVERSIGHT AND MONITORING SO ARE
THE FOR THE POSITIONS WOULD BE
USED TO STRENGTHEN OUR FISCAL
OVERSIGHT -- AND OUR POLICY IN
OUR PROGRAM OVERSIGHT.
AND I THINK WE HAD SEVERAL
QUESTIONS HERE.
WE'RE GOING TO ANSWER THOSE
ABSOLUTELY -- SO I THINK ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS -- HAD TO DO WITH --
DESCRIBING ACTIVITIES PERFORMED
BY CA BHS AND BEARDED SHOWS IN A
LONG STANDING CONTRACTOR WITH
THE FORMER DEPARTMENT MENTAL
HEALTH AND CURRENT BERMAN HEALTH
CARE SERVICES -- AND AND THEY
REALLY HELP US WITH ARM -- UP
PROVIDING TRY TO TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO THE COUNTIES IN
TERMS OF EVALUATION DESIGN -- AS
WELL AS ON E. LEARNING MODULES
AND WEBINARS WE DO THINGS WITH
THEM LIKE OUR EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES SYMPOSIUM OUR MEDICAL
DIRECTORS TRAINING FISCAL
LEADERSHIP INSTITUTE THESE ARE
ACTIVITIES THAT WE PLAN TO
CONTINUE WITH OUR WITH WITH
THREE ZERO VHS SUCH WERE RIGHT
OUT SUPPORT TO THE COUNTIES --
AND COUNTIES YOU KNOW THROUGHOUT
THE TWO THOUSAND TWELVE OR SINCE
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE GET DIRECT
ALLOCATIONS NOW FOR OF MHSAA
DOLLARS SO THEY'RE ABLE TO SPEND.
THE DOLLARS THAT THEY RECEIVED --
TO ON TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT TAYLOR'S TO
THEIR NEEDS SO SPECIFICALLY SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT I WASN'T THAT
WERE DONE THROUGH THE CA BEACH
AS PRIME CONTRACTOR ONE TIME
THAT CAN NOW BE DONE.
THROUGH COUNTIES THEMSELVES ARE
THINGS ON MY COMMUNITY TO FIND
TO THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND
THEY CAN COUNTIES CAN STEP
PRIORITIES ON ON THE TRAINING
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAT
THEY NEED TAYLOR TO THEIR NEEDS
[inaudible] ONE AND THEN YOU
WANT ME TO RUN TO THE FISCAL
REGULATIONS AS WELL -- SO -- YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE HAVE RISE THAT PUT
OUT FOR COMMENT ARE ARE FISCAL
REGULATIONS -- THOSE ARE INCLUDE.
THEY ARE DRESSED -- ALLOCATION
AND EXPENDITURE REQUIREMENTS
INCLUDING INTEREST PRUDENT
RESERVE MAINTENANCE RECORDS
REVERSION AN APPEALS -- IT TALKS
ABOUT AMENDING THE REVENUE
EXPENDITURE REPORTS TO COLLECT
CURRENT DATA HAD TO ADDRESS
CURRENT DATA NEEDS IT ALSO TALKS
ABOUT THE WITH HOLDS THAT WE CAN
DO ON AN HSA DISTRIBUTIONS IF --
ROBIN EXPENDITURE REPORTS ARE
NOT REPORTED IN A TIMELY MANNER
AND SO WE BELIEVE THESE -- MHSAA
FISCAL ROEG'S WILL HALL --
STANDARDIZE THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ADMINISTRATION ACROSS
ON THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
AND THAT -- IT THE ALSO HELP US
ON IN TERMS OF I AM SUPPORTING
COUNTIES TO GET MORE COMPLETE
AND ACCURATE DATA FOR TRACKING
AND TRANSPARENCY.
THANK YOU I THINK MISTER CHAIR
SO WE'VE -- TO BE DOING ON
BEHALF KNOW HOW SERVICES OVER
SENATE COMMITTEE COMMISSION --
THE GENDER RAISES THE ISSUE OF
THE CHALLENGE THAT WE SEE IN
TERMS OF RECONCILING NUMBERS AT
THE COMMISSION IS CURRENTLY
USING TO REPORT FISCAL
TRANSPARENCY AND SO WE'VE PASSED
OUT OF THE SCREEN SHOT -- ON OUR
WEBSITE AT THE MOMENT THE
COMMISSION HAS TAKEN REVENUE
EXPENDITURE REPORTS AND CREATED
A BASICALLY DIGITAL MAP OF THESE
REPORTS.
THAT ALLOWS THE PUBLIC AND
POLICY MAKERS TO BASICALLY CLICK
ON A COUNTY AND SEE HOW MUCH
MONEY A COUNTY RECEIVED BY
FISCAL YEAR BY IMAGES A
COMPONENT.
HOW MUCH MONEY IS SPENT BY
COUNTY BY YOUR BY COMPONENT AND
HOW MUCH MONEY IS LEFT AVAILABLE
IN THE BANK?
THIS IS PART OF A LARGER EFFORT
THAT WE'RE DEVELOPING.
THAT WOULD ACTUALLY ALLOW THE
PUBLIC TO SEE THE DOLLARS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE THE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE FUNDED WITH THOSE DOLLARS
AND THEN THE HARD PART IS THE
OUTCOMES.
THE INTENT OF THIS WORK IS TO
ACTUALLY SUPPORT THE COMMUNITY
PLANNING PROCESS THAT IS
REQUIRED IN THE MIDDLE HOW
SERVICES ACT.
THE IDEA IS THAT SOMEONE FROM
THE PUBLIC SHOULD BE ABLE TO
WALK INTO THAT PROCESS AND HAVE
THE BASICS IN BASIC INFORMATION
AT THEIR FINGERTIPS TO REALLY
ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT THEIR
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
AND HOW WELL IT'S WORKING.
WE THINK THIS WORK IS HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE -- THE STATE'S HISTORY
IN THE COUNTY HISTORY IN TERMS
OF REPORTING WAS NOT GREAT BUT
AS WE RELEASE THESE THESE
FIGURES AND CREATED PUBLIC
AWARENESS IT IT CREATED
ATTENTION ON THE PROBLEM AND THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN VERY
RESPONSIVE AND COUNTY SOME VERY
RESPONSIVE.
THE CHALLENGE WE HAVE IS THAT
UNDER THE TERMS OF AB ONE
FOURTEEN AS THE DEPARTMENT HAS
BEGUN TO GO BACK TO TWO THOUSAND
AND FOUR TO RECONCILE.
RECEIPTS REVENUES SPENDING IN
UNSPENT FUNDS THAN WHAT WE'RE
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
NUMBERS THE DEPARTMENT HAS DON'T
MATCH WITH THE NUMBERS THAT
WE'VE BEEN RELYING ON WHICH OF
THE COUNTY ARE YEAH OURS WHICH
ARE CERTIFIED BY THE INDEPENDENT
AUDITOR CONTROLLERS.
SO WE ARE WE'VE RAISED THE ISSUE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT WE HAVEN'T
SAT DOWN YET BUT I THINK THERE'S
A COMMITMENT TO SIT DOWN AND
FIGURE THAT OUT.
OUR CONCERN IS THAT.
IT BY LINKING THIS DATA TO A
THIRD PARTY CERTIFIED REPORT
FROM THE COUNTIES WE HAVE A HIGH
DEGREE OF CONFIDENCE THAT THE
DAY THAT THE ORIGINAL DATA
SOURCES GOOD.
OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT BECAUSE
OF CHANGES IN THE WAY IN WHICH
THE DEPARTMENT HAS.
COUNTING EXPENDITURES AND
REVENUES BY YEAR THAT THE
NUMBERS DON'T MATCH.
AND WE DON'T WANT TO CREATE
CONFUSION ON THE PART OF FOR
EXAMPLE -- COUNTY SUPERVISORS
WHO ARE LOOKING AT THEIR OWN
COUNTIES NUMBERS AND COMPARING
THEM TO THE STATE'S NUMBERS AND
THEY DON'T LINE UP AND SO SO
WHAT WE'VE RAISED WITH SAFF AND
WE DAM OUT.
ALL OF THESE TOOLS WITH STAFF
WITH YOUR STAFF.
IS THAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
SIT DOWN.
AND DEVELOP A AN AGREED UPON
UNIFORMS STRATEGY FOR COUNTY
REPORTING AND STATE REPORTING SO
WE HAVE A SINGLE SET OF NUMBERS
THAT ARE VALID AND RELIABLE.
THAT WORK HASN'T BEEN DONE YET
BECAUSE THE THE FISCAL RAGS ARE
NEW BECAUSE THE CHANGE AND IN
THE ACCOUNTING APPROACH HAS JUST
HAPPENED BUT IT BUT WE'VE WE'VE
BEEN HIGHLIGHT THAT AS A
CHALLENGE.
IF THE COMMISSION IS GOING TO BE
ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD AND UPDATE
THE FISCAL REPORTS IF WE WERE TO
DO THAT NOW FOR EXAMPLE WITH
COUNTY DRIVEN REPORTS WE WOULD
SEE THAT IT WOULDN'T NECESSARILY
MATCH ON A COUNTY BY COUNTY
BASIS WITH THE STATE'S NUMBERS.
WE THINK THAT'S A PROBLEM.
CERTAINLY CAN CAUSE A LOT OF
CONFUSION.
ABSOLUTELY UP COSTS DID YOU HAVE
MORE TO SAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
EDWARD WE ARE COMMITTED TO
SITTING DOWN WITH THE AC AND AND
FIGURING THAT OUT BUT ARE YOURS
ARE BASICALLY LIKE COSTS REPORTS
AND SO WOW WHAT GETS SUBMITTED
AND CERTIFIED CAN CHANGE
AFTERWARDS BECAUSE COUNTIES MAKE
UPDATE SO -- SO EVEN YOU KNOW
THE METHODOLOGY IS LIKE -- YOU
KNOW IN A DIRECTORY EWING SAID
THAT -- METHODOLOGIES CAN CHANGE
OVER TIME -- SO CAN THE NUMBERS
THAT THE COUNTY IS -- SUBMIT
BASED ON YOU KNOW JUST CALL
CORRECTIONS OF INACCURACIES AND
SUCH SO I THINK WE JUST NEED TO
SIT DOWN AND KIND OF WORK IT OUT
TOGETHER AND JUST MAKE SURE.
THAT -- THAT WE CAN FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO MAKE THAT SURE THE
NUMBERS LINE UP SO WE HAVE SOME
IDEAS FOR THAT AND WE'RE GONNA.
WE'RE ALL WORKING HARD WORK IT
OUT OKAY ALL RIGHT HELLO I WAS
MILLION THE NO ALL RIGHT.
FINANCE [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
OKAY SO I AM.
YEAH I'M AND I THINK THAT -- YOU
KNOW WHAT ONE OF THINGS THAT
THAT IS OBVIOUSLY NO ONE THE
AUDITOR'S REPORT CAME OUT AS
DURING SUBCOMMITTEE AND WE
COULDN'T FIGURE I RECONCILE WE
HEARD DTS NEVER BOTHER TRACKING
THE NUMBERS SO -- BECAUSE AND
THEY INITIATIVE IT SAYS THAT YOU
DON'T SPEND THE MONEY IT COMES
BACK.
AS LIKEWELL WE DON'T KNOW
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T TRACK WHATEVER
I MEAN THAT THAT I THINK THAT
WAS -- I THINK THAT LED TO A
TREMENDOUS LOSS OF CONFIDENCE
AND AND SO -- AND AND I THINK IT
WENT WELL -- I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS IS THAT -- WE NEED TO BE
SURE BECAUSE MOST OF THE SITE
AND THE SERVE TIES A LITTLE BIT
TO SOME OF MY QUESTIONS AND THE
BEGINNING OF AROUND WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A HEALTH OVERALL
IS THAT.
WHAT WE SAW THIS EVEN POLLING
SHOWS THAT MENTAL HEALTH LIKE
HEALTH CARE'S PRETTY MUCH ON TOP
RIGHT -- OF OF OF OF
CALIFORNIANS MIND AND AND
ACTUALLY MENTAL HEALTH AS FAR AS
HEALTH CARE DATE.
AND I'LL TELL YOU THAT LAW MY
COLLEAGUES LIKE WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH
RIGHT AND THERE'S BY DIFFERENT
BUILDINGS SO FORTH.
ETCETERA BUT I THINK THERE'S
ALSO AYE FEEL THERE'S
FRUSTRATION THAT THE FROM PEOPLE
EVEN PEOPLE WHO ARE FAIRLY
INVOLVED IN MENTAL HEALTH -- THE
THAT.
WE DON'T REALLYKNOW WHAT'S.
GOING ON RIGHT IT'S BECAUSE IT'S
ALL IT'S LIKE WELL EACH COUNTIES
DOING THEIR OWN THING AND SO
FORTH AND SOME OF ITS TO THE WAY
WE STRUCTURED NOW THE THE
PROPOSITION SO FORTH BUT ALSO
THAT WE DID IT IT.
IT SEEMS.
I THINK PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY'RE
NOT THEY'RE HAVING DIFFICULTY
GETTING ACTION INFORMATION --
THE OUT IT SEEMED INDICATE THAT
PEOPLE REALLY FIND RULES A START
WITH YOU KNOW SECOND COUNTY
FOUND OUT THE COUNTY OF SITTING
IN A WHOLE.
BUNCH OF MONEY AND THAT WAS ON
THE ONLY OTHER COUNTY IN
MEANTIME OR SAY WHAT WE HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS IN THIS THE
NATION TO SELL PROPERTY THE
THREE GIVE THIS OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO DO ALL THE STUFF AND WE
CERTAINLY SEE THE NEED.
AND YOU'RE TELLING ME WHAT
SPENDING THE MONEY AND WHAT'S
GOING ON THERE RIGHT.
AND SO IT AND AND THEY'LL LIVE
WHILE CERTAINLY NOT THIS YEAR
BUT YOU KNOW NOT SO MANY YEARS
AGO PEOPLE START SAYING WELL YOU
KNOW IS.
THAT THAT DON'T DO WE STILL NEED
THIS NOT THAT WE DON'T NEED THE
RESOURCES BUT IS THIS NOW THIS
IS ALREADY WORKING RIGHT.
AND AND THERE ARE SOME CERTAINLY
SOME I THINK SOME SOME SOMETIMES
UNWARRANTED CRITICISM ABOUT WHAT
THEY DID FIND OUT WAS BEING
SPENT.
I THINK SOMETIMES YOU ON VALUE
PREVENTION TYPE ACTIVITIES AND
PEOPLE STARTED PICKING ON STUFF
SO.
SO WE NEED TO BE SURE WE GET
THIS RIGHT -- BECAUSE THERE'S
THERE IS NEED OUT THERE WE NEED
TO ALSO FIGURE OUT HOW AND
THAT'S WHY TALK ABOUT LIKE
THINGS LIKE STATEWIDE GOALS AND
SO FORTH BECAUSE IN SOME SENSES.
BUSINESS WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
DOING SOME REALLY GOOD STUFF AND
LOTS OF DIFFERENT COUNTIES AND I
CAN A TAKE OFF SEVERAL OF THEM
BUT THE SAME TIME IT.
PEOPLE DON'T SEE THE NEEDLE
NESTLE MOVING AS MUCH AS THEY
LIKE TO SEE IT RIGHT SO -- AND
DOWN RIGHT HERE WE HEARD TODAY
YOU KNOW WE SO SIDE RATES ARE
GOING UP WE NEED TO HAVE
SOMETHING RIGHT AND AND TO FEEL
LIKE HOMELESSNESS RIGHT NOW NOT
ALL OF HOMELESSNESS IS MENTAL
HEALTH OKAY I'VE DONE MY
COMPLETE THE TO BUT CERTAINLY
DOES A PIECE RIGHT AND WE TALK.
ABOUT RECIDIVISM AND PEOPLE MY
GAME AT ALL THREE WE TALKED WITH
THE OPIOID CRISIS AT A WHOLE
HEARING ABOUT THAT GREAT.
AND THEN SAID BOWL HOW ARE WE
MOVING THE NEEDLE ON THAT YET WE
HAVE.
YEAH WE HAVE ALL THESE DIFFERENT
PARTS AND IT SEEMS HARD TO
EXPLAIN TO PEOPLE ALL THIS IS
ACTUALLY WHAT WE'RE DOING ABOUT
IT SO -- SO I THINK -- YEAH I'M
HOPING THAT SO PART OF PART OF
ITS SMALL THINGS LIKE
RECONCILING NUMBERS AND PART OF
IT IS ALSO -- YOU KNOW AND THIS
IS SOMETHING YOU KNOW CERTAINLY
WORKING WITH COUNTIES BUT BUT I
THINK WE DO WE NEED TO NEED TO
THINK OF SOME KIND OF BETTER
STRATEGIC FRAMEWORK THAT'S MORE.
EXPLAINABLE I GUESS AS MORE
COMMUNICATIONS VALUE TO THE
PUBLIC THAT SHOWS THAT WE'RE
ACTUALLY MOVING THE NEEDLE.
AND HOPING WE CAN TRY TO GET
THERE.
HELLO MY THE CELL DAVID TELL ME
IF YOU HAVE A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE ON THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YEAH AND
I THINK THAT'S EXACTLY WHERE THE
COMMISSION IS COMING FROM AND
PART OF THIS EFFORT AROUND BEING
ABLE TO CREATE VERY EASILY
ACCESSIBLE AND UNDERSTANDABLE
INFORMATION ON THE DOLLARS THE
PROGRAMS AND THE OUTCOMES IN THE
OUTCOME IS THE IS THE IMPORTANT
PIECE.
IS THAT IS OUR DEFINITION OF
PUBLIC ACCOUNTABILITY PUBLIC
OVERSIGHT -- IS THAT HOW CAN THE
STATE THROUGH THE WORK THAT
WE'RE DOING REALLY HELP THE
PUBLIC UNDERSTAND THE DECISIONS
THAT ARE BEING BEING MADE.
AND WHAT WHAT THE OUTCOMES ARE
THE OUTCOME WORK IS THE MOST
DIFFICULT WORK -- WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO DO SOME ANALYSIS OF FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS.
pOUTCOMES BUT OVERALL THE DATA
EXPRESS A LOT OF CHALLENGE AND
PART OF THAT CONVERSATION IS.
AS WE BEGIN TO UNDERSTAND WHERE
THERE ARE CHALLENGES WHAT ROLE
DOES THE STATE HAVE OR CAN HAVE
TO SUPPORT THE ABILITY COUNTIES
TO IMPROVE.
AND IN SO PART OF THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT WE'VE BEEN
HAVING INTERNALLY ARE WHAT ARE
THE WAYS IN WHICH THE STATE CAN
INCENTIVIZE AN INFLUENCE AND
SHAPE.
IN IN WAYS THAT ARE VERY MUCH
INFORMED BY THE DATA ANALYTICS
YOU'RE RIGHT SOMETIMES YOU DO
HAVE TO DO THE MUNDANE WORK OF
RECONCILING NUMBERS BECAUSE WE
DON'T WANT TO CREATE THAT LACK
OF CONFIDENCE.
WE CAN GET THE FUNDAMENTALS
RIGHT LIKE HOW MUCH MONEY IS
THERE.
IWILL POINT OUT THAT IN THE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING ITS ITS
VERY FOCUSED ON THE IMAGE TO SAY
BECAUSE THOSE ARE THE DOLLARS
THAT ARE EASIER TO TRACK.
BUT THE IMAGES SAY IS ABOUT 25%
OF THE OVERALL MENTAL HEALTH
FUNDING.
AND SO AGAIN.
OUR THIS SITE THAT ALLOW YOU TO
SEARCH TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
COMMUNITY PROGRAMS RIGHT NOW --
IT'S NOT LIVE YET BECAUSE A
COUPLE LITTLE GLITCHES BUT IN
THE NEXT YOU KNOW THREE OR FOUR
DAYS IF NOT TOMORROW -- WE HAVE
REQUIRED THAT CAN'T DAY COUNTIES
BUT ONLY IN P. E. I. INNOVATION
PROGRAMS TO REPORT ON HIS BEING
SERVED BY RACE ETHNICITY AGE
GENDER SEXUAL ORIENTATION
VETERAN STATUS DISABILITY STATUS.
AND SO THE INTENT REALLY IS TO
MAKE IT EASY TO UNDERSTAND THE
INVESTMENTS OF BEING MADE.
WHO HAS ACCESS IN ADDITION?
TO THE KINDS OF OUTCOMES ARE
BEING ACHIEVED BASED ON THOSE
DEMOGRAPHIC CHARACTERISTICS.
BUT AGAIN THAT'S ONLY IN THE P.
I. PIECE BECAUSE THAT'S THE
LIMIT OF THE COMMISSION'S
AUTHORITY TO REQUIRE THE COUNTY
TO SUBMIT THAT INFORMATION.
AND SO YOU KNOW FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF THINGS THE STATE COULD
ENHANCE THAT WOULD MAKE IT
EASIER TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S IN
PLACE TODAY WHAT'S WORKING.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY WHAT'S
WORKING FOR WHOM AND WHERE
BECAUSE WE DON'T RECEIVE MENTAL
HEALTH CARE AT THE STATE LEVEL
WE RECEIVE IT IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
YOU KNOW BASED ON WHO WE ARE AND
BASED ON WHO ARE NEEDS ARE INTO
THAT LEVEL OF DETAIL IS VERY
CAPTURE BULL.
BUT THE SYSTEM WE HAVE IN PLACE
TODAY AREN'T SET UP TO DO THAT
AND SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS ANSWER QUESTIONS WE CAN
ANSWER WITH THE DATA WE HAVE.
WITH THE INTENT OF DEMONSTRATING
THE CAPACITY AND THE VALUE OF
THAT WORK SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY MOVE THE STATE TOWARDS
INVESTING MORE TIME AND ENERGY
AND FOCUS ON THAT THAT LEVEL
ABOUT COME INFORMATION.
BIGGEST AT THE ON TERMS OF OF
FOR DATES YES I MEAN IT'S AS YOU
POINTED OUT.
THE TOTALITY OF AN IMAGE A
FUNDING IS ABOUT A QUARTER RIGHT
NOW IT'S A QUARTER SO AND THE
SITE PEOPLE DON'T SIT BACK AND
GO AND HA FINDING ANY IF THAT
AND BETTER A. L. AT IT.
AND I GOT SADDER SO OFTEN IT'S A
SO THE STORY NEEDS TO BE
COLLECTED LIKE WHAT WHAT'S THE
VALLEY'S MUCH OF THE POT AS
POSSIBLE RIHT SO.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT OFTENTIMES
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT WE DON'T
THE OVERSIGHT WE BRING YOU UP
YOUR TOBY AND WE'RE LIKE MENTAL
HEALTH AND LIKELY EARLY I I ONLY
GOT THIS PIECE OF IT I DON'T YOU
KNOW I OVERSIGHT YEAH I DON'T
GET TO OVERSEE ALL OF THAT.
GREAT SO.
AS WE CAN IF THERE'S SOME
MECHANISM WE CAN WORK WITH THE
COUNTY TO TO PROVIDE SO WE CAN
ACTUALLY TELL THAT STORY TO THE
PUBLIC ABOUT WHAT WE REALLY DO
WHAT WE'RE DOING MENTAL HEALTH
AND ALSO GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY
THEN TO MOVE THE SHIP IN THE
DIRECTION.
THAT WE NEED TO TO BE SURE WE
ADDRESS THERE AT THAT THE
PUBLIC'S TOP PRIORITIES.
SURE AND I MEAN I THINK WE HAVE
STARTED THAT WORK I THINK. TO
TELL BRENDA IN TERMS OF JUST HER
SHE'S SHE'S BIG DATA PERSON
SHE'S EXCELLENT AT AT THE
PERFORMANCE OUT COME SYSTEMS
THAT WE HAVE THOSE OF NOW BEEN
ADDED TO HAVE.
THE RACE ETHNICITY AND SOME OF
THE STUFF THAT THAT -- FOR YOU
IN WAS TALKING ABOUT AND SO I
THINK THAT IS WHERE WE'RE GOING
AS WELL AND BEING ABLE TO REPORT
THAT ON THE WHOLE THE WHOLE
SYSTEM -- BECAUSE IT IS
CONFUSING BECAUSE I WAS THE
EMERGENCY MONEY CAN ALSO FUND
MEDI CAL SO IT JUST BECOMES A
WEIRD -- A WEIRD MIXTURE SO THAT
IS SORT OF THE WORK THAT WE HAVE
STARTED OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS
AND AGAIN NUMBER AND HAS REALLY
LED AND AND WE'RE CONTINUING TO
BUILD ON HOW DO WE HAVE BETTER.
DATE INFORMATION TO SHARE ACROSS
THE MEDICAL PROGRAM ANYTHING YOU
KNOW GOES BACK TO WHAT I SAID
BEFORE I MEAN WE REALLY ARE
LOOKING AT HOW DO WE HAVE JUST A
FUNDAMENTAL PICTURE OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
AND WHO'S GETTING SERVICES AND
WHERE SERVICES NOT GETTING
PROVIDED AND HOW WHAT THEN CAN
WE DO ABOUT THAT SO ABSOLUTELY --
AND I I AGAIN I I THINK BRENT
AND HER TEAM IS DONE HAVE DONE A
TREMENDOUS JOB IN GETTING -- A
SIGNIFICANT MUCH AMOUNT MORE
DATA THAN IT USED TO BE.
HEARD ON THE MENTAL HEALTH SIDE
AND SO HOW DO WE THEN WORK
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S ALL I MEANT -- WITH WHAT
MEASURES WERE LOOKING AT AND HOW
WE'RE MEASURING THINGS I THINK
IT'S AN IMPORTANT CONVERSATION
AND I KNOW I NUMBER AND IT DOES
WORK PRETTY CLOSELY WITH.
THE COMMISSION BUT BUT YES WE
WILL OBVIOUSLY CONTINUE TO DO
THAT.
OKAY IS TO DETECT ADMINISTERED
AIR.
SO -- IN THE COMMENT ABOUT THE
THE SO THE PURVIEW OF THE
COMMISSION FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
IS EMBEDDED IN THE WELFARE AND
INSTITUTIONS CODE AND WHILE THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THAT
CREATED THE COMMISSION.
THE CHARGES ON IN THE HOUSE
SERVICES ACT ARE THINGS LIKE
REDUCING UNEMPLOYMENT.
AND REDUCING HOMELESSNESS --
SUPPORTING EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES
FOR CHILDREN PREVENTING THE
ONSET OF MENTAL ILLNESS SO WE
ACTUALLY DON'T THINK ABOUT OUR
PURVIEW IS ONLY IMAGES THEY
FUNDED PROGRAMS THAT'S GOOD WE
TAKE THAT WE SAID THE MONEY'S
HERE.
THE POLICY IS ACTUALLY QUITE
BROAD AND IT'S ACTUALLY BROADER
THAN THE TRADITIONAL ROLE OF THE
DEPARTMENTS.
WEATHER WAS THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE
UNDER THE PREVENTION LANGUAGE IT
BEGINS TO TALK ABOUT THINGS LIKE
PREVENTING OUT OF HOME
PLACEMENTS.
AND SO FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE WE
THINK THAT THE QUESTIONS PER
VIEW IS OVER THE ENTIRE MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM.
REALLY THINKING MORE ABOUT WELL
BEING.
AGAIN DRAWING UPON THAT PO THAT
PREVENTION LANGUAGE AND SAYING
HOW DO WE PREVENT THESE BAD
THINGSFROM HAPPENING SO THAT WE
ACHIEVE OUTCOMES FOR THE
COMMUNITY.%
THAT ARE NOT DRIVEN NECESSARILY
BY ELIGIBILITY STANDARDS OR A
MEDICAL NECESSITY IT REALLY IS
MORE OF A PUBLIC HEALTH
ORIENTATION AROUND MENTAL HEALTH
THAT TALKS ABOUT KEEPING FAMILY
SAFE HEALTHY IN SCHOOL AT WORK
AT HOME OUT OF TROUBLE.
AND AND AND WITH THAT PURVIEW WE
THINK MORE ABOUT THE
COMMISSION'S AUTHORITY IS PRETTY
BROAD.
IN THE SENSE THAT ARE
AUTHORITIES TO ADVISE THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
OFFER TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
THEN THE SPECIFIC AUTHORITIES
THAT YOU'VE PROVIDED US THROUGH
EITHER STATUTORY BUDGETARY
THORNY WELL I I GUESS I'D SAY IS
THAT.
DURING FROM POLICY POINT OF VIEW
OF MUCH BROADER RIGHT RIGHT AND
IS IS ABLE TO PUBLIC HEALTH
APPROACH IS ON OF THE BACKGROUND
PUBLIC HEALTH.
FIRST STAFF DATA DATA SOCIAL
STRATEGY POLITICAL WELL RIGHT
THAT'S RIGHT JULIUS RICHMOND.
I'LL CHECK MODEL SO RIGHT SO --
AND SO WE NEED WE DO YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT HOW IT
TOGETHER DATA IN A WAY THAT WE
CAN GET A BETTER PICTURE OF
WHAT'S GOING ACROSS NOT JUST ONE
PART OF MONEY BUT ACROSS THE
DIFFERENT POTS.
AND THEN ALSO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
POLITICAL WILL WE HAVE TO BILL
TELL THE STORY OF WHAT WE'RE
DOING RIGHT PEOPLE SEE THINGS
AND THEY GO OKAY.
WE SHOULD DO SOMETHING IN HOW DO
WE BUT CAN.
YOU KNOW BE ABLE TO TO TO BUILD
OUT POLITICAL WELL OBVIOUSLY IS
AN ACTIVE POLITICAL A CREATED
POP -- SIXTY THREE HOW DO WE
SUSTAIN THAT AND THE WAY TO TO
BE SURE THAT BECAUSE IT.
THE NATION ITSELF PROVIDE
RESOURCES AND OTHER TYPES OF
THINGS BUT AT THE SAME TIME
INCLUDING CREATE OVERSIGHT
COMMISSIONS AND THEN HOW DO WE
DIDN'T TAKE THOSE RESOURCES AND
AND MOVE THE NEEDLE RIGHT.
AND I THINK RIGHT NOW PEOPLE ARE
SHIRT OR SEEN THE NEEDLE MOVE AS
AS MUCH AS THEY'D LIKE TO SEE IT
MOVE AND THAT DOESN'T MEAN
DEPARTING WORK AND SOME THE
EDITS THINK THAT.
IT MAY BE FRAGMENTED AND MAY NOT
BE REPEAL SHARED IN A WAY THAT.
PEOPLE IT THAT THAT PEOPLE SEE
THAT STORY PLAY OUT AS MUCH AS
STATE LIKE TO AND RECOGNIZING
THAT A GOOD CHUNK OF MENTAL
HEALTH.
PEOPLE ARE GONNA.
DIVIDE BETWEEN THE PARTS YOU
KNOW DON'T EVEN COME FROM DAMAGE
AS A FUNDING RIGHT NOW SO.
WOULD BE HAPPY TO TELL YOU HAVE
A MOVING THE NEEDLE ON THEIR THE
PSYCHOSIS -- WELL I'M LOOKING
FOR A GOING OF ACTUALLY NEXT
RIGHT OKAY ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS ALRIGHT WELL LET'S GO
AHEAD AND TALK ABOUT HOW THE
MOON AND YOU DON'T REALLY
PSYCHOSIS RESEARCH AND TREATMENT.
DO YOU WANT ME TO PRESENT THE
GOVERNOR'S OVAL FIRST YES ONCE
YOU GO HEAD.
YES FEES THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR I WAS THE ORDER IN
THE AGENDAS OF JUST YOU KNOW TRY
TO TRY TO FOLLOW THE RULES -- A
AMERICAN WILL DEPARTMENT HEALTH
CARE SERVICES SO YES SO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS PROPOSING A
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATION.
IN FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY
TO ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO HAVE
A COMPETITIVE GRANT PROCESS TO
HELP FUND PROJECTS THAT
DEMONSTRATE INNOVATIVE
APPROACHES TO DETECTING.
AND INTERVENING EARLY ON IN IN
IN CHILDREN'S LIVES -- BEFORE
SORT OF PSYCHOSIS HAS SAID
INTERFERE AT RISK OF PSYCHOSIS
THERE'S CERTAINLY BEEN A LOT OF
EVIDENCE OVER THE PAST RECENT
YEARS AND THEY'RE CERTAINLY
PROGRAMS FUNDED BY ROBERT WOOD
JOHNSON AND OTHERS.
THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT AS AS A
FOUNDATION FOR THIS PROPOSAL --
I'VE SEE WORKING AWFULLY WITH
THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE WHO HAD
THIS PROPOSAL AS AS ONE OF THEIR
THEIR OPTIONS AND SO THE IDEA
HERE IS THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
HAVE A COMPETITIVE GRANT PROCESS
THAT WOULD NOT JUST BE.
TWO BIG THE COUNTY IS IT WOULD
BE TO PROVIDER ORGANIZATIONS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
NONPROFIT ENTITIES AND REALLY
TRYING TO ENCOURAGE SOME SOME
SORT OF TESTING OF WHAT ARE THE
BEST APPROACHES THAT THEN ONCE
WE HAVE SOME OF THOSE HOW DO WE
SCALED UP ON ON THE GRANDER
STATEWIDE SKILL.
WE THE REQUEST ALSO DOES ALLOW
US USE A PORTION OF THE MONEY
FOR ADMINISTRATIVE -- THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT WE HAVE TO
DO IN TERMS OF PETITIONS AND
THINGS AND SO -- WE ARE WE ARE
DOING THAT AS WELL BUT IT'S A
PART OF THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION.
THANK YOU COMES FROM LA --
FINANCE.
RIGHT ON YES THANK YOU SO A FEW
YEARS AGO THE COMMISSION --
HIRED UNIVERSE CALIFORNIA DAVIS
TO ACTUALLY DO SOME ANALYSIS OF
THE SERVICES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
SPECIFICALLY TO ADDRESS --
PSYCHOSIS OR THE PSYCHOSIS
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS.
AND FOUND THAT THERE WAS WIDE
VARIATION AND HOW COUNTIES ARE
PURSUING THESE PROGRAMS AND MANY
COUNTIES TO ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE
OR THE PSYCHOSIS PROGRAMS.
AND SO -- A. B. THIRTEEN FIFTEEN
THEN ESTABLISH THIS EARLY SECOND
BE PLUS PROGRAM A PSYCHOSIS PLUS
PROGRAM AND REQUIRES THE
COMMISSION TO ESTABLISH AN
ADVISORY BODY AND THEN MAKE
FUNDS AVAILABLE.
FUNDING THAT WAS ENVISIONED TO
COME THROUGH DONATIONS AND SO
WE'VE ACTUALLY EXPLORED MODELS
LOOKING AT THE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND HOW OTHER STATES DO.
MODELS TO SECURE PRIVATE
DONATIONS I CAN TELL YOU THAT IS
VERY CHALLENGING TO SECURE AND
PRIVATE DONATIONS INTO STATE
GOVERNMENT -- BUT AS PART OF
THAT ORIGINAL WORK AND THEN --
RECOGNIZING THE DIRECTION OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR AND
SIGNING THIRTEEN FIFTEEN AND
THROUGH OUR RLES -- WORKING
WITH COUNTIES AROUND INNOVATION
FUNDS WE WORK FOR THE UC DAVIS
TO ACTUALLY BRING TOGETHER A
CORE GROUP OF COUNTIES TO CO
INVEST IN DEVELOPING AN EARLY
PSYCHOSIS.
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
LEARNING INFRASTRUCTURE WITH THE
INTENT OF GATHERING THE DATA OUT
OF THESE VARIOUS COUNTY PROGRAMS
AND AND THEN UNDERSTANDING THEM
AND AND ANALYZING THEM IN WAYS
THAT THEY RECEIVE THEIR DATA
BACK.
SO THAT THEY AN BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHICH APPROACHES ARE
MORE EFFECTIVE FOR WHICH KINDS
OF PEOPLE ALL KINDS OF DIAGNOSIS
IN BUT POINTS IN TIMES IN TERMS
OF THEIR TREATMENT.
THROUGH THIS WORK UC DAVIS WAS
ABLE TO WORK WITH FOR COUNTIES
TO SECURE A HALF MILLION DOLLARS.
OF COUNTY INNOVATION FUNDS TO
BUILD THAT LEARNING NETWORK WITH
MORE COUNTIES INTERESTED IN SORT
OF YOU KNOW BUYING IN ARE
PARTICIPATING IN THIS LEARNING
THAT WORK AND THEY WERE ABLE TO
DRIVE DOWN AN ADDITIONAL ONE AND
A HALF MILLION IN PHILANTHROPY
TO SUPPORT THAT.
OUR INTENT IS TO ACTUALLY BUILD
THIS LEARNING NETWORK THAT IS
STATEWIDE THAT RESULTS IN EVERY
COUNTY HAVING ACCESS TO AN
EVIDENCE BASE.
OR LEARNING BASED SB PLUS
PROGRAM THAT OR STRATEGY BECAUSE
WE RECOGNIZE THAT SOME
APPROACHES WILL BE REGIONAL OR
MULTI COUNTY COLLABORATIONS IN
TERMS OF THE SERVICE DELIVERY.
WERE ALSO PARTNERING WITH UC
DAVIS UCSF AND UC SAN DIEGO IS
PART OF A NATIONAL EFFORT TO
BUILD A NATIONAL NETWORK OF DATA
ANALYTICS AROUND HOW THESE EARLY
PSYCHOSIS PROGRAMS.
CAN BE EFFECTIVE AND SO ON YOU
KNOW IN SEEING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL -- AND RECOGNIZING THAT
WE HAVE A PROGRAM WITH NO
FUNDING AND THE DEPARTMENT HAS
THERE'S A FIVE FUNDING PROPOSAL
FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
BUT THE COMMISSION IS ASKED IS
CONSIDER MERGING THESE.
TO OUR PREFERENCE WOULD BE TO
BUILD OFF OF THE WORK THAT WE'VE
ALREADY DONE.
BUT WE WERE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT
IF THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR NOT
INCLINED TO DO.
THAT WE WOULD WELCOME THE
DEPARTMENT TO TAKE OVER THE
LEADERSHIP IN THAT ROLE IT
DOESN'T MAKE A LOT OF SENSE FOR
US TO RUN THIS PROGRAM WITH NO
FUNDING -- WHILE THE DEPARTMENT
SEPARATELY IS ISSUING GRANTS.
IDEALLY WE THINK THE GOAL REALLY
IS THAT LEARNING STRATEGY AS YOU
SAID IT'S THE DATA IT'S
UNDERSTANDING.
IT BUT IT'S ALSO THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IT'S THE WAYS IN
WHICH OUR RESEARCH AND ACADEMIC
EXPERTS.
AND PROVIDERS IN COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE BEING SUCCESSFUL CAN
SHAPE AND SUPPORT AND GUIDE
OTHER COUNTIES TO ACTUALLY DO AN
EFFECTIVE JOB.
SO THAT WE CAN MOVE THE NEEDLE
IN TERMS OF HOW QUICKLY RESPOND
WITH EARLY PSYCHOSIS HOW
EFFECTIVELY WITH ME RESPOND.
AND WE WOULD SAY IDEALLY
SUPPORTING PEOPLE WITH THESE
CONDITIONS TO ACTUALLY ACHIEVE
OUTCOMES INCLUDING EMPLOYMENT
BECAUSE THAT'S ONE OF THE GOALS
OF THE ACT.
THANK YOU RIGHT THANK YOU SO --
THEN YOU'D GET AT IT SO.
I DON'T MEAN TO SO IT IS THERE
ARE THERE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ABOUT -- BECAUSE OF SOUNDS LIKE
YOU KNOW WE HAVE ONE EFFORT
GOING ON HERE WHICH IS NOW.
WELL FUNDED THROUGH PRIVATE
TODAY WHICH IS LIMITED RIGHT
WELL WITH LEVERAGE THE COUNTY
DOLLARS YOU DID THAT WAS NINETY
DOLLARS ARE COMING IN RIGHT SO
THINKING ABOUT.
SAID IF AT THE YUBA HOW THE TWO
COULD COME TOGETHER AS A YEAH I
I GUESS I FINANCE OKAY AS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AGAIN IS ONE
TIME DOLLARS I I THINK WE
ENVISIONED IT AS YOU KNOW.
SOMETHING THAT COULD BE IT'S A
ONE TIME INVESTMENT AND THEY
COULD THEN PROMPT -- ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS.
IF YOU KNOW OTHERS SIEVE IF
INDIVIDUALS IN THE COMMUNITY
FIND IT.
THOSE EFFORTS ARE A WORTHWHILE
TO INVEST IN THE FUTURE WE JUST
WANT TO KNOW THAT -- THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL [inaudible]
IS.
AVAILABLE FOR NOT JUST COUNTIES
AS NOTED -- RIGHT -- THAT IT'S
IT'S AVAILABLE FOR OTHERS AND
THEN ALSO A. B. -- THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN WAS VERY SPECIFIC THAT
IT DOESN'T SPECIFY STATE FUNDS
IT'S IT WAS FOR FOR DONATIONS
AND SO.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYTHING
PRECLUDING THE DEPARTMENT FROM
ENGAGING WITH THE COMMISSION AND
LEVERAGING THE KNOWLEDGE THAT
THEY THAT THEY'VE GAINED WITH
SOME OF THE WORK THAT THEY'VE
ALREADY DONE -- BUT AGAIN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WAS A ONE
TIME INVESTMENT AND THEN TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE SPARKS
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS.
BACK BILLS EFFORTS CAN CONTINUE
TO BE DONE THROUGH THE
COMMISSION WELL I I GUESS I
GUESS WHAT I WOULD URGE IS IS
THAT -- RECOGNIZING YOU HAVE AN
EXISTING BALL.
LAW RIGHT -- THAT SAID ONE THING
I THINK WAS DOWN IT WAS DESIGNED
THAT WAY BECAUSE AT THE TIME
YOUR PRIVATE THERE WAS A SUPPORT
WITHIN ADMINISTRATION FOR
FINDING IT THAT'S WHY WE ALWAYS
PUT IN THE OKAY YOU WANT.
CREATIONS YOU APPROPRIATE MONEY
WILL SAFE PRIVATE DONATIONS
RIGHT BUT TREATED A CERTAIN
STRUCTURE -- APPRECIATE ACTUALLY
WHAT THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR
BEING WILLING -- TO TO DESIGNATE
EVEN ONE TIME AT ONE TIME FUNDS
TO HELP GET THIS BUT AS THE
SEEDS.
THANK THAT THEY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY SAY OKAY INSTEAD OF
HAVING TO SEPARATE I MEAN --
EFFORTS SCISSOR IT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT -- WELL WOULD NOW WE JUST
TAKE THAT MONEY AND WE DUMP IT
INTO THE YOU KNOW.
AND AND TO BE THIRTEEN THIRTY
FOR THE THIRTEEN FIFTEEN I EVER
I THINK THE THING IS IT'S A OKAY
WILL SAY THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
LET'S SEE WHAT WE HAVE HERE AND
THINK HOW WE TAKE THE BEST OF IT.
DOES SO THAT THEY CAN LEVERAGE
EACH OTHER AND AND GET THE MOST
POSITIVE IMPACT GREAT I THINK
THAT'S WHAT WE ALL WANT IN THE
END THEY THEN SO.
WHEN THE SUMMER MULLIN ROAD IS
BILL HE DID IT UNDER TWO
CONSTRAINTS THAT HE HAD TO FACE
AND TO GET THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS?
THE GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING
SOMETHING IN THE BUDGET BASED ON
IT AND SO -- AND SO IN ORDER TO
GET AGAIN I THINK WE ALL WANT.
WELL TRY TO TACKLE THE SAME VOTE
THE SAME ISSUE OR SIMILAR ISSUES
SO WE SHOULD THINK ABOUT HOW WE
MAXIMIZE THE OPPORTUNITY THAT
RECOGNIZING THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IS A ONE TIME AND OF
COURSE YOU KNOW FUNDING BEYOND
COUNTIES I THINK THAT'S A GOOD
IDEA.
ALL RIGHT -- SO THAT DID NOT
SAYING THAT -- WELL WE NEED TO
TURN IT INTO THIRTEEN FIFTEEN I
THINK LOW DIVIDE SAY IS LIKE IS
THAT ARE SAYING OKAY WELL WE
HAVE THIS PROGRAM HERE AN WE'RE
GONNA CREATE A WHOLE NEW PROGRAM
OVER HERE AND THEN WHICH IS ONE
TIME ALSO AND THEN WILL HAPPEN
IS IS THAT.
THEY'LL TO TO SHOULD SOMEHOW
COME TOGETHER.
RIGHT.
SAID.
AT A TIME TO FIGURE THAT OUT
REYES SAID IN A ONE SPEAK FOR
THE DEPARTMENT IN SAYING THOUGH
THAT I THINK YOU KNOW THE
COMMISSION DEPARTMENT OBVIOUSLY
HAVE A RELATIONSHIP AND THERE'S
NOTHING FOR CLEANING THEM FROM
HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS NOW.
OKAY YEAH AND AND JUST AGAIN
JUST TO NOTE THOUGH AS WELL A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT BETWEEN THE
TWO PROPOSALS THAT ARE.
THE GOVERNOR'S -- WHAT THE
PROPOSAL IS MEANT TO BE A
COMPETITIVE GRANT OKAY THE CELL?
WILL BE DIFFERENT BY AGAIN
NOTHING FOR CLEANING AND FROM
WORKING TOGETHER RIGHT WELL SHE
THE SAME GOAL.
IF YOU AS WELL WHAT WE WOULD ASK
ADMINISTRATION TO CONSIDER
INVESTING THE FUNDS INTO THE
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN PROGRAM WHICH
WAS SUPPORTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION LAST YEAR WE
RECOGNIZE THE DIFFERENT
ADMINISTRATION -- SAME
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- SO YOU
KNOW AGAIN THE THE LAW REQUIRES
THE COMMISSION TO APPOINT AN
ADVISORY BODY OF SUCH A MATTER
EXPERTS. TO ESTABLISH THE
CRITERIA AND INCLUDING THE
NOTION OF COMPETITIVE GRANTS --
AND ALSO YOU KNOW I THINK.
IT'S THE IDEA THAT THERE IS AN
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE THAT IS
MOVING FORWARD THAT IS SECURED
COUNTY DOLLARS THAT IS ENGAGING
WITH OUR FEDERAL COUNTERPARTS
THAT IS BUILDING THIS
COLLABORATIVE.
AND SO WHETHER THAT WHETHER THE
FUNDS ARE ADMINISTERED THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ARE THROUGH THE
COMMISSION.
IT'S THE IDEA THAT THE STATE HAS
ESTABLISHED AN EARLY PSYCHOSIS
STRATEGY.
AND IT IT IS.
BACK TO THAT ISSUE A PUBLIC
PERCEPTION IS VERY DIFFICULT ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMISSION TO
EXPLAIN.
TO THEM THE CHECKER THE
TAXPAYERS WHO FIND PROPER SIXTY
THREE WHY THE STATE WOULD
ESTABLISH A DUPLICATE STRATEGY.
TO ACHIEVE A COMMON GOAL.
THE SO WE WOULD ASK
ADMINISTRATION TO CONSIDER AGAIN
OUR PREFERENCE WOULD BE TO PUT
THOSE FUNDS IN THE THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN PROGRAM.
IF YOU'RE UNWILLING TO DO THAT
BUT THE THIRTEEN FIFTEEN PROGRAM
INTO THE APARTMENT HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
AND FINANCES WILLING TO HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION.
WELL THAT THAT THANK YOU I MEAN
THAT I WOULD JUST HOPE THAT WE
CAN HAVE THAT CONVERSATION SO
THAT.
WHATEVER RIVERS WHATEVER WE HAD
AND UP IN NAY THAT WE HAVE A HE
IDEALLY A COORDINATED IS A
UNIFIED WAY OUT OF THAT'S TOO
STRONG A WORD BUT YOU KNOW IT'S
IT'S STILL AT THE FIFTY SICKLY
STATE STRATEGY DID SAID OF THE
STATE'S STRATEGY.
THAT THE MOVIES FORTIN BUILDING
ON THE INVESTMENTS VERY MADE SO
BY THE ALSO CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS PARTICULAR
CHARACTERISTICS THAT ARE
DIFFERENT -- THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSING THAT DOES MEAN DOES
I'M SAYING THAT THOSE CHARACTERS
X. HAVE TO GO AWAY RIGHT -- SO
LET'S -- AND DEALT BUT ANY BILLS
WRITTEN AT THE TIME IT WAS
WRITTEN SO AND BY THE WAY YOU
KNOW WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
GOVERNOR SO WE COULD WORK AND
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE I WOULD
MAKE THE MODIFICATIONS NECESSARY
TO MAKE THE THING WORK THE WAY
THAT.
GOVERNOR RIDGE WOULD LIKE TO
WORK IN THE LEGISLATURE WOULD BE
AGREEABLE TO WRITE BUT LET'S
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION.
OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR RIGHT
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- I THINK BECAUSE SO
THAT CONCLUDES THE CITY INDIANA
RIGHT.
SO -- SOON WHICH GOT MY
PAPERWORK.
FOR UPS OF RIVER.
OKAY BUT WITH THAT OKAY THE BILL
DOES THE SECTION RIGHT SO OKAY
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
SECTION WE'LL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUES ONE AND TWO
THIRDS PUBLIC COMMENTS -- SO
THAT'S ALL RIGHT WELCOME.
THE AFTERNOON ADRIAN SULTAN WITH
THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE FIRST
WE'D LIKE TO SAY WERE INCREDIBLY
SUPPORT OF THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
EARLY PSYCHOSIS PROGRAMS.
AS OUTLINED IN THE BUDGET THESE
PROGRAMS ARE ABSOLUTELY GAME
CHANGERS IN THE MENTAL HEALTH
DELIVERY FIELD -- THEIR EVIDENCE
BASED PROGRAMS THEY SEEK TO
INTERVENE AT THE FIRST SIGNS AND
SYMPTOMS THAT SOMETHING IS WRONG
AND A YOUNG PERSON.
AND WE'VE BEEN TALKING A LOT
TODAY ABOUT THE CHALLENGES IN
OUR FIELD ABOUT RISING SUICIDE
RATES THESE PROGRAMS ARE
EFFECTIVE IN REDUCING SUICIDE
RATES AND REDUCING HOMELESSNESS.
AND REDUCING A CURSORY SINCE WE
CAN'T SAY ENOUGH ABOUT THE
EFFECTIVENESS THAT THESE
PROGRAMS -- HAVE WE WERE THE
SPONSORS OF A. B. THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN BACK IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WHICH SET UP THE STATE'S FIRST
EARLY PSYCHOSIS.
PROGRAM AND WE WORKED IN
pCOMMISSION FOR TWO YEARS AND
PULLED IN NATIONAL AND STATE
EXPERTS INCLUDING LEADING
EXPERTS AT THAT ARE UC SYSTEM
WHO -- KNOW ABOUT THESE PROGRAMS
TO SET UP THE FRAMEWORK -- IN IT
YOU KNOW FOR AN EARLY PSYCHOSIS
PROGRAM.
AND IT YOU KNOW IT REALLY YOU
KNOW IN THE ALWAYS HE HAS BEEN
DOING A LOT OF WORK -- TO SET UP
THIS PROGRAM IN FACT THEY HAVE
SET UP AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE FOR
THE EARLY PSYCHOSIS PROGRAM THAT
WE HAVE IN OUR STATE AND JUST
SENT OUT NOTICES TO ALL OF THE
MEMBERS.
AND THESE ARE EXPERTS IN THE
FIELD IS OUR LEADING RESEARCHERS
THAT THESE ARE YOU SEE PROGRAMS
THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS OF LIVED
EXPERIENCE THEIR PRIMARY CARE
EXPERTISE SO QUITE A BIT OF WORK
HAS HAS BEEN DONE HERE.
AND IT'S ALL PART OF WHAT WE SEE
IS A GREATER EFFORT IN OUR FIELD
TO TRANSFORM OUR SYSTEM OF CARE
WERE INTERVENING AT STAGE ONE
AND TWO VERSES STAGE OUR IS
WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW.
I'M ORRY ACCOMMODATION IS THAT
WE ALIGN THE WONDERFUL TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
WITH THE STATE'S EXISTING EARLY
PSYCHOSIS PROGRAM OUT THAT THAT
WE SEE.
THANK THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELEN ROTH DELTON A TEACHER HOW
THE KIDS -- ON ISSUE ONE I WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW IF YOU'RE LOOKING
AT DATA HOW TO COUNTIES WORK
WITH SCHOOLS OR DO THEY AND THE
SECOND IS WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE
MHS DOT HSA DOLLARS ARE SPENT AS
THE MEDI CAL MATCH.
WHEN A REALIGNMENT DOLLARS ARE
ALSO AVAILABLE THANK YOU?
WELL I GUESS THAT WAS PUBLIC
COMMENT OF ANYONE WANT TO
COMMENT ON THE THOSE QUESTIONS
ARE NOT [inaudible]
POINT.
NINE I WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION WE DON'T
KNOW THAT AT THE MOMENT RIGHT I
WE'VE ACTUALLY DESIGNS THAT
FISCAL TRANSPARENCY.
DOCK AT TOOLS SO THAT IT CAN
ACTUALLY REFER RECEIVE
INFORMATION ON ALL.
ALL OF PRIMARY SOURCES OF MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT A PARTY
MENTAL HEALTH DOLLARS SO THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY TELL THE THE WHOLE
STORY INCLUDING THINGS LIKE HOW
THAT DRAWDOWN IS HAPPENING.
PART OF THE REASON WE THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT IS BECAUSE THE
MEDI CAL PIECES THE ONLY REVENUE
STREAM WHERE THEY WORK THE STATE
OR IN THIS INSTANCE THE COUNTIES
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE.
ACTUALLY HAS SOME DISCRETION IN
TERMS OF THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT COMES AND THE OTHER THREE
PRIMARY SOURCES ARE BASED ON AS
YOU MENTIONED EARLIER VEHICLE
LICENSE FEES AND AND SALES TAX
RIGHT.
SO UNDERSTANDING.
PATTERN IN TERMS OF LEVERAGING
LOCAL DOLLARS TO DROUGHT ON
FEDERAL DOLLARS IS ESSENTIAL IN
TERMS OF OUR ABILITY TO
UNDERSTAND IF WE HAVE THE RIGHT
MIX.
OF RESOURCES AND REVENUES GOING
INTO THE SYSTEM AND IF FOR
MAXIMIZING TO THE EXTENT THAT WE
CAN DO THAT.
WITHIN THE OPTION FOR COUNTIES
TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT HOW THEY
INVEST RIGHT.
UNFORTUNATELY THE WAY THAT OUR
DATE IS COMING IN WE WERE IN AND
WE'RE NOT EXPERTS ON THE OTHER
MENTAL HEALTH DATA -- BUT WE'RE
NOT SAYING THAT WORK BEING DONE
AND WE THINK THAT NEEDS TO BE
PART OF THE STATE'S AGENDA.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER COMMENTS
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT --
IMAGES THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
AND AND WE'RE GONNA BEGIN WITH
THE REVIEW AND WE DO HAVE A GOOD
RIGHT UP AND SINCE AND SO IT'S
LIKE I'M THE ONLY ONE UP HERE
AND I'VE HEARD THIS BEFORE WE
CAN KEEP IT VERY BRIEF I THINK
SEPARATELY SO -- AS YOU KNOW OUR
OUR PRIMARY FUNCTIONS ARE TO
ADVISE THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO REVIEW AND APPROVE
INNOVATION PLANS -- WE'RE DOING
SOME REALLY EXCITING THINGS MORE
RECENTLY OF THAT THE THE TECH
BECAUSE THIS WORK AS AN EXAMPLE
WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN ABLE TO WORK
WITH THE COUNTIES. TO DESIGN A
SERIES OF MULTI COUNTY LEARNING
COLLABORATIVE'S ON INTEGRATED
SERVICES -- FOR YOUTH AND YOUNG
ADULTS ON STRATEGIES TO REDUCE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT ON
STRATEGIES TO STRENGTHEN SCHOOL
MENTAL HEALTH.
I'M IN AGAIN YOU HAVE HEARD THIS
BEFORE -- WE ARE WORKING TO DO
DATA LINKING BETWEEN MENTAL
HEALTH AND SCHOOLS MEANT WE'VE
DONE SOME ANALYSIS OF MENTAL
HEALTH AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
PART OF THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE WE
HAVE IS ONCE WE KNOW THOSE
CHALLENGES S I MENTIONED
EARLIER WHAT WE DO ABOUT IT AND
AND SO WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO
THINK STRATEGICALLY.
ABOUT HOW WITH THE RESOURCES WE
HAVE IN THE STAFF WE HAVE THAT
WE CAN PROVIDE THAT TA.
EXACTLY TO YOUR POINT DR PAN.
THAT WE CAN MOVE THE NEEDLE AND
TELL THAT STORY.
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE WE WANT
THAT NEEDLE TO MOVE AT THE
STATEWIDE LEVEL AND WE ARE
SEEING EXAMPLES OF EXCELLENCE
ACROSS THE ACROSS THE STATE.
POCKETS OF EXCELLENCE IN THE BIG
CHALLENGE IS HOW DO WE TAKE IT
OUT OF THAT POCKET OF EXCELLENCE
AND MAKE IT A STATEWIDE
INITIATIVE.
AT AT IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS TO
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER THEM BUT
INTEREST OF YOUR TIME YOU HAVE
HEARD THIS BEFORE BUT I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TELL OUR STORY.
THANK YOU AND CERTAINLY VERY
IMPORTANT -- THAT SELL -- ELEVEN
COMMENTS.
FINANCE [inaudible]
RIGHT.
OKAY SALUTE SAID AGAIN THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THAT PRESENTATION
SAID THERE I SAID THERE IS THERE
IS GOOD WORK GOING ON I DON'T I
DON'T WANT ANYWAY IMPLY THAT
THERE ISN'T -- AND THE OUIJA
FIGURE HOW BETTER TO COMMUNICATE
THAT SO -- OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWO WHICH IS
CENTERS THAT TRANSITION STAFF
AND TEMPORARY TO PERMANENT --
YET I DID I JUST VERY QUICKLY WE
DID GIVE YOU A LITTLE HAND OUT
OF THIS IS OUR INNOVATION
DASHBOARD THAT SHOWS.
THE THE THE LEVEL OF INVESTMENT
THAT COUNTIES ARE MAKING THE
TIME IT TAKES US TO APPROVE AND
THAT AND THE COUNTIES THAT ARE --
INVESTING IN A PARTY THAT I
FORGOT TO MENTION THAT -- I ITEM
TO SO WE HAVE LIKE MANY AGENCIES
BECAUSE OF CHANGES OVER TIME WE
HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL WHO IS IN
WHAT WE CALL THE BLANKET BEING
FUNDED.
BY THE COMMISSION WITH OUR
OPERATING DOLLARS BUT FOR WHICH
THERE ISN'T A POSITION THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS LEADING
EFFORTS ACROSS MANY DEPARTMENTS
TO RECONCILE AND MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S ALIGNMENT BETWEEN HOW
MANY PEOPLE ACTUALLY HAVE ON
STAFF.
AND BOTH YOUR CHART AND THAT
THIS IS AND THE AND THE THE
POSITIONS THAT ARE REFLECTED IN
THE BUDGET SO THIS IS A REQUEST
TO SIMPLY -- ALIGN THE NUMBERS
WITH THE REALITY AND THAT
REALITIES CHANGED BECAUSE OF
SOME ORGANIZATIONAL SHIFT THAT
HAPPENED YEARS AGO OKAY.
INCOMES FAMILIAL FINANCE ARE A
GOOD OF ISSUE NUMBER THREE
INVESTMENT MENTAL HEALTH
WELLNESS ACTS TRIAGE GRANT
FUNDING.
RIGHT SO WE PROVIDED YOU ALSO
WITH A LITTLE HAND OUT THAT HAS --
ON THAT THE FRONT SIDE IT LISTS
THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TRIAGE
GRANT APPLICATIONS AND THEN THE
COUNTIES THAT RECEIVED FUNDS --
BY COMPONENT YOU MAY RECALL THAT
IN THE PAST WE'D SHARED WITH THE
WITHTHE COMMITTEE THAT WHEN THE
COMMISSION MADE THESE FUNDS
AVAILABLE TO THE COUNTIES THE
COUNTY'S PRIORITIZED BASED ON
THEIR MOST URGENT NEEDS AND WHAT
WE FOUND IS QUITE OFTEN.
COUNTIES WERE NOT PRIORITIZING
CHILDREN AND SO THE COMMISSION
MADE A COUPLE OF DECISIONS. ONE
IT MADE A DECISION TO SET ASIDE
50% OF THE FUNDS THROUGH OUR
ADMINISTRATIVE AUTHORITY FOR
CHILDREN.
AND WITHIN THAT DESIGNATE A
PORTION FOR SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH
AND AS YOU CAN SEE -- THEY WERE
FIFTY FOUR APPLICATIONS RECEIVED
THIRTY WERE FUNDED THE REQUEST
WAS FOR ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING AND OVERALL WE WERE ABLE
TO PROVIDE ABOUT EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
LAST AT PRIOR TO LAST YEAR THE
COMMISSION HAD RECEIVED THIRTY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR FOR
THIS PURPOSE.
AND COUNTY STRUGGLE TO SPEND
THESE DOLLARS AND THERE WAS A
LARGE -- POCK POCKET OF UNSPENT
FUNDS THE COMMISSION HAD ASKED
TO REINVEST INTO THE PROGRAM.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
RECOGNIZING THAT THOSE FUNDS
HADN'T BEEN SPAN RECOMMENDED
REDUCING THE FUNDING DOWN TO THE
LEVEL OF FUNDS THAT.
MORE ACTUALLY REFLECTED WHAT
COUNTIES HAD SPENT.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT DECISION IN
THE CONTEXT OF THINKING OF THESE
FUNDS AS ACTUALLY.
SORT OF PROVIDING A A UNIT OF
STAFFING FOR COUNTIES AND IF THE
ARGUMENT WAS THAT THE FUNDS WERE
NECESSARY THEN LET'S REPURPOSE
THESE FOR OTHER NEEDS.
HOWEVER WE DON'T THINK OF THESE
FUNDS AND THAT WAY WE THINK OF
THESE AS INCENTIVE FUNDS.
AND WE AT THE AND I'LL GIVE YOU
THE EXAMPLE THE SCHOOL COUNTY
COLLABORATIVE'S.
THERE'S TREMENDOUS UNDERSTANDING
IN THIS BUILDING AND IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ABOUT THE MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS OF CHILDREN IN OUR
SCHOOL SETTING SCHOOLS WHERE THE
CHILDREN ARE IN OFTEN NGUYEN
WERE ABLE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
CHILDREN WERE ABLE TO ENGAGE
WITH FAMILIES.
IN WAYS THAT ARE MORE CULTURALLY
AND SOCIALLY APPROPRIATE
UNDERSTANDING STIGMA THAN THAN
IS POSSIBLE OUTSIDE OF THE
SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT OUR CAPACITY
TO USE THESE DOLLARS TO
INCENTIVIZE.
COUNTY SCHOOL PARTNERSHIPS FOR
EXAMPLE IS TREMENDOUS AND SO --
WE'RE ASKING FOR RESTORATION OF
THE FUNDS NOT BECAUSE THE MONEY
WASN'T USED ORIGINALLY BUT
BECAUSE OF THE POTENTIAL TO USE
THESE DOLLARS TO SHAPE HOW
COUNTY SPEND THEIR OWN MONEY.
IN WAYS THAT CAN ADDRESS ISSUES
OF HIGH STATEWIDE CONCERN
PARTICULARLY SCHOOL MENTAL
HEALTH BUT NOT LIMITED TO THAT.
AS THE TRIAGE PROGRAM IS
DESIGNED TODAY IT IT
AGGRESSIVELY FOCUSES ON REDUCING
HOSPITALIZATIONS RESIST REDUCING
CRIMINAL JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT.
AND AGAIN IN THIS CONTEXT WE
FOCUSED ON SCHOOLS THE
COMMISSION IS ASKING FOR
RESTORATION BUT ALSO
CONSIDERATION OF FREEING UP
CONSTRAINTS ON HOW THESE DOLLARS
ARE USED SO THAT WE CAN CREATE A
BROADER SET OF INCENTIVES.
THE DOLLARS ARE ONLY AVAILABLE
TO COUNTIES THEY'RE ONLY CRISIS
AND WE SEE THIS AS ONE OF THE
STATE'S MOST SIGNIFICANT TOOLS
IN SHAPING HOW COUNTIES USE
THEIR DOLLARS WE WANT TO BE ABLE
TO LEVERAGE THESE FUNDS. TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE ALL TWO BILLION
OF MHSAA BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
THE EIGHT AND A HALF BILLION
THAT IS AVAILABLE OVERALL. TO
REALLY SUPPORT THE ABILITY OF
COUNTIES TO FOCUS ON ISSUES
WHERE THEY HAVEN'T ON THEIR OWN
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT MEANS IT
CAN OVER THE LONG OVER THE
LONGER TERM REDUCE STATE COSTS
AND IMPROVE OUTCOMES STATEWIDE.
I THANK YOU LA YOU COMMENTS
FINANCE.
OKAY.
THE SHOWS GOING AS YOU NEED
ANSWERED THE QUESTION WHICH WAS
THAT MAYBE WE NEED TO LOOK AT DO
WE ARE WE OVERLY RESTRICTED THE
FUNDS THAT WE NOT PUT ENOUGH
INTO -- OTHERS T. AIR EDUCATING
THE FOLKS THAT YOU TRY TARGET TO
THIS TO WHY WOULD PEOPLE WEREN'T
ASKING AS MUCH FOR THE MONEY
RIGHT SOMETIMES IT'S BECAUSE
VIEW THE YOU SAY WELL WE ARE TO
GIVE YOU MONEY FOR ACTS BUT
ACTUALLY THE RESTRICTIONS ARE
NECESSARILY THE ONES THAT.
THE OF THE FACILITY ACTUALLY
USING THE MONEY SO -- SO AS SOON
THAT'S PAR YOUR PROPOSAL IS THAT
WE SHOULD TRY TO LOOSEN SOME OF
THOSE CONSTRAINTS ABSOLUTELY YES
OKAY -- DURING THE RATE THE PART
OF THE REASON THE COUNTY
STRUGGLE TO ALLOCATE THESE FUNDS
WAS BECAUSE THEY WERE LIMITED
PERSONNEL.
AND SO ONE COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE
HAD A VERY WELL INTENTIONED
PROGRAM TO REDUCE -- E. R.
UTILIZATION.
RIGHT AT THE ISSUE CAME UP OF
WHO WHO'S SUPERVISES THE STAFF
THE E. R. OR THE COUNTY.
OKAY HAND DELAYS IN NEGOTIATING
AN ANIMAL YOU RESULTED IN IT
THIS COUNTY ACTUALLY WAS I ABLE
TO TAP THE FUNDS FOR TWO YEARS
NOW BECAUSE THERE WAS A LOT OF
CONFLICT GOING ON HAD NOTHING TO
DO WITH THE FUNDS RIGHT.
WE'VE PUT IN PLACE
ADMINISTRATIVE REQUIREMENTS THAT
THOSE FAMILIES HAVE TO BE IN
PLACE BEFORE YOU ASK NOT AFTER
YOU ASKED IN ORDER TO SHORTEN
THAT TIME FRAME.
BUT IT REALLY HIGHLIGHTS THAT AT
THE TIME AND I WASN'T HERE AT
THE TIME.
THE INTENT WAS TO SORT OF CREATE
A SURGE OF STAFFING.
PART OF THE PROBLEM WITH THAT IS
COUNY STRUGGLE TO SUSTAIN
STAFFING WHEN THEY HAVE TO GET A
THREE YEAR GRANT IT'S ALSO HARD
TO HIRE PEOPLE FOR THIRTY SIX
MONTH JOB I PARTICULARLY
RECOGNIZING THE WORK FORCE
CHALLENGE WE HAVE IN THIS FIELD.
SO ABSOLUTELY THE COMMISSION IS
LOOKING AT THIS VERY DIFFERENTLY
AND SAYING THIS ISN'T ABOUT
SEARCH OF STAFFING. FOR CRISIS
IT'S ABOUT HOW CAN WE CREATE
INCENTIVES TO SUPPORT CLAVINET
PARTNERSHIPS AND IN SOME CASES
ON THE SCHOOL MENTAL HEALTH
DOLLARS THE COMMISSION RECEIVED
NUMEROUS CALLS FROM SCHOOLS WHO
WANT TO PARTICIPATE.
BUT FIRST BUT FOR OFTEN VERY
GOOD REASONS THERE COUNTIES ONE
IN A POSITION THEY DIDN'T HAVE
THE STAFF TO APPLY.
THEY WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SUSTAINABILITY PIECE THE LAW WAS
PRESCRIPTIVE AND IT DID NOT
ALLOW US. TO HAVE THE SCHOOL
RECEIVED THE DOLLARS AND TO
EITHER DO THAT IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE COMMUNITY CARE PROVIDER
OR OR EVEN HAVE THE SCHOOL APPLY
AND PARTNER WITH THE COUNTIES
AND HAVE A GO THAT WAY.
AND SO YES WE WOULD ASK FOR SOME
LOOSENING OF THE CONSTRAINTS SO
THAT WE CAN BETTER TAILOR THE
PROGRAM TO THE NEEDS OF THE
COUNTIES.
ALL RIGHT MAKES LICENSED ME.
ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER COMMENTS
OKAY SO -- I THINK SO LET'S GO
AHEAD TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS ON
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVER
SITE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION.
THE ITEMS WE JUST DISCUSSED.
WELCOME.
I AND ALLEN RUN THOUSAND
TEACHERS FOR HOW THE KIDS WERE
IN FULL SUPPORT OF ITEM THREE
ISSUE THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI THERESA COMSTOCK WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS -- WE SUPPORT
RESTORING THE 40% -- FUNDS BACK
INTO THE TREE I WAS FUNDING AND
AND ESPECIALLY APPRECIATE THAT
IT REQUIRES A COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION.
AND THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIVISION THANKS THANK YOU.
OKAY.
MEN'S KEVIN CLARK.
STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY SCHOOL
SOCIAL WELFARE AND FOR FOSTER
YOUTH.
FULLY SUPPORTED ISSUE NUMBER
THREE RESTORATION OF PERSONNEL
FUNDING.
OKAY THANK YOU ALTHOUGH I THINK
WE'RE TRYING TO TURN IT NOT INTO
PERSONAL FUNDING SPECIFICALLY.
BUT THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
UP PATRICIA GASH SENECA FAMILY
THE AGENCIES SENATE HAS PROVIDED
SCHOOL BASED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS.
AND OUR EXPERIENCE HAS TAUGHT US
THAT FOR CHILDREN AT RISK OF
DEVELOPING MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES SCHOOLS ARE THE BEST
PLACE TO IDENTIFY THESE CHILDREN
EARLY.
AND PROVIDE IN THE SERVICES AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU AND THERE FOR WERE IN
SUPPORT EVER STRING THE TRIAGE
FUNDING FOR THIS COLLABORATION
THANK YOU EXCELLENT THANK YOU.
OKAY NTSC NO OTHER COMMON WE'RE
GONNA HOLD OPENS OF ACTUALLY
DIFFERENT FOR THE RECORD -- ON
THE PREVIOUS SECTION WHICH WAS
PART HEALTHCARE SERVICES AND
IMAGE IT'S MHS OVER SEND COUNTY
COMMISSION WERE HOLDING OPEN
ISSUES BOTH ONE AND TWO AND THEN
ON THE METAL HOLDS OVER SIZE.
AVERSE THAT REGIS OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION OF
REVIEWS.
AS ISSUE TWO AND THREE WILL HOLD
OPEN AS WELL SO THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
AND THE WORK OF THE COMMISSION
THANK YOU.
SO MUCH RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
FACILITIES FINANCING AUTHORITY.
AND WE'RE STILL TALKING ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH.
SO OVERVIEW AND REAPPROPRIATION
INVESTMENT IN MENTAL HEALTH
WELLNESS FUNDING [inaudible]
SO.
SINCE FOR NINETY SECTION WOULD
ASK EVERYONE DO THE
INTRODUCTIONS AROUND AGAIN
BEFORE WE BEGIN.
OKAY GO HEAD START WITH THE THE
AGENCY FIRST DIRECTIONS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS FRANK
MORE IS IT THE DIRECTOR WITH
CHAPTER.
I COULD AFTERNOON CAROLINE
ABILITY SHARA WITHOUT TOUGH AS
WELL.
HELLO.
PRIME LENDERS LA YOU AND MARK
NEWTON ELIA FINANCE.
LIMóN CHEN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE JACOB LAMB FINANCE.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THESE BEGIN
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US TODAY --
BUT WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS THAT WERE PART OF THE
AGENDA NIGHT I EXPECT I'LL
ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS HOPEFULLY
YOUR SATISFACTION AS I READ MY
PREPARED REMARKS -- CHAPARE IS A
FINANCING AUTHORITY LOCATED
WITHIN THE STATE TREASURER'S
OFFICE.
WE HAVE A NINE MEMBER BOARD MADE
UP OF THE STATE TREASURER WHO'S
THE CHAIR PERSON THE STATE
COMPTROLLER DIRECTOR OF FINANCE.
TO MEMBERS APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR TO MEMBERS APPOINTED BY
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ONE
OF THOSE MUST BE A PHYSICIAN AND
ONE MUST BE A HEALTHCARE
FACILITY EXECUTIVE.
OKAY SO ACTUALLY -- WE HAVE A
GOOD WRITE UP ABOUT JAFFA SO AT
THE HIGHLIGHTS OF THE OR
ORGANIZATION WE KNOW WHO SITS ON
THE BODY AND SO FORTH SO SORRY I
DON'T.
HAVE IT.
THANK YOU.
I'LL GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT YOU
ASKING QUESTIONS ABOUT OUR GRANT
PROGRAMS PARTICULARS ALL THIS
GIVE YOU AN UPDATE ON THOSE
GRANT PROGRAMS.
AN UPDATE ON THE GRANT PROGRAMS
IN ANY OTHER ISSUES YOU SEE
COMING UP THIS COMING YEAR BUT
THEY'RE GETTING.
THE CHILLS HOSPITAL PROGRAM WE
WE ADMINISTER FIVE ACTIVE GRANT
PROGRAMS THE FIRST BEING THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL PROGRAM --
WE ADMINISTER -- THREE CHILLS
HOSPITAL PROGRAMS ONE WAS
APPROVED BY THE VOTERS AS PROP.
SIXTY ONE AND THE NUMBER TWO
THOUSAND FOUR ELECTION THAT WAS
A SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR BOND -- ONE WAS APPROVED
AS PROP THREE IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT FOR NINE AND EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND ONE WAS
RECENTLY APROVED AS PROP FOR IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FOR ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS --
THE FIRST YOU PROPOSITIONS
FUNDED CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS FOR
EIGHT NONPROFIT CHILDREN'S
HOSPITALS AND FIVE UC TROLLS
HOSPITALS AND THE THIRD.
OF THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
BOND FUNDED -- CAPITAL PERMITS
FOR THE SAME EIGHT NONPROFIT
CHILLS HOSPITALS AND FIVE UC'S
BUT ALSO EXPANDED THE UNIVERSE
TO INCLUDE A PUBLIC OR PRIVATE
NONPROFIT HOSPITALS TO PROVIDE --
CSS SERVICES.
PCS SERVICES A BUILDABLE
HOSPITALS WHICH WE ESTIMATE
THERE PARKS MY HUNDRED AND SIXTY
CAN COMPETE FOR ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION OF THE ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS AVAILABLE
UNDER THIS BOND.
WE JUST FINISHED REGULATIONS FOR
THIS PROGRAM AND ONCE APPROVED
BY -- A. L. L. CHILLED HOSTELS
LEGALTO SUBMIT APPLICATIONS ON
AN ONGOING BASIS AND ELIGIBLE
HOSPITALS WEBER DEADLINE OF
MARCH THIRTY AT THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO APPLY.
AND THE SECOND A GRANT PROGRAM
WE MINISTER OF THE COMMUNITY
SERVICES INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM PROVIDES SIXTY SEVEN AND
A HALF MILLION DOLLARS IN GRANT
FUNDS TO EXPAND ACCESS TO JAIL
OR PRISON A VERSION PROGRAMS.
AND FOR SERVICES FOR THOSE WITH
MENTAL ILLNESSES SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DISORDERS OR WHO HAVE SUFFERED
FROM TRAUMA.
BUT WE ARE CURRENTLY ACCEPTING
APPLICATIONS FROM COUNTIES FOR
THIS PROGRAM.
AND THE APPLICATION DEADLINE IS
APRIL THIRTIETH THIS THIS THIS
YEAR.
THE NEXT PROGRAM IS CALLED OUR
LIFELINE GRANT PROGRAM THE
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR GRANT
PROGRAM TO ASSIST SMALL AND
RURAL HEALTH CARE FACILITIES.
INCLUDING COMMUNITY BASED
CLINICS THAT MAYBE FINANCIALLY
AFFECTED BY A REDUCTION OR
ELIMINATION OF FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ASSISTANCE AND THAT
HAVE LITTLE TO NO ACCESS TO
WORKING CAPITAL.
APPLICATIONS FOR THIS PROGRAM
ARE ACCEPTED INTO CONTAINING
BASIS WE HAVE ALLOCATED
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS OF THE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
WITH TWELVE THE PATELLA TOLD ME
KNOWS REMAINING TO BE ALLOCATED.
WE RECENTLY ANNOUNCED THAT
REVISIONS BY THE US DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES TO
TELL TEN REGULATIONS -- WE
CONSIDER THOSE TO BE A FEDRAL
TRIGGERS AND WE URGE FACILITIES --
TO WHO HAVE ALLOCATIONS TO APPLY
FOR US FOR GRANT DISTRIBUTIONS.
AND WORKING WITH THEM TO DISPUTE
JUST BE FUNDS.
ARE ALSO WORKING WITH FACILITIES
TO SUBMIT NEW APPLICATIONS
REMAINING TOLD ME IN DOLLARS
THAT ARE ON ALLOCATED.
THE NEXT PROGRAM IS OUR
INVESTMENT IN MENTAL HEALTH
WELLNESS GRANT PROGRAM.
IT'S A HUNDRED FORTY TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM
AVAILABLE TO COUNTIES OR THE
DECIMATED NONPROFIT AGENCIES.
AND THIS MONEY TO BE ABLE TO
EXPAND ACESS TO A CAPACITY FOR
COMMUNITY BASED MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS TO SUPPORT CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENT.
EXPANSION AND SOME LIMITED START
COSTS FOR CRISIS STABILIZATION.
FOR CRISIS RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
FOR PURE RESPITE CARE AND FOR
MOBILE CRISIS SUPPORT TEAMS.
THE PROGRAM IS CLOSED TO NEW
APPLICANTS BUT WE CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH GRANTEES TO SEE THE
PROJECTS ARE COMPLETED THROUGH
FRUITION.
AS A NOW FORMED IT OUT OF A
SEVEN UNDER SIXTY PROPOSED BEDS
ARE OPEN AS A RESULT OF THIS
FUNDING.
AND OPERATIONAL AND ALL ONE
HUNDRED TEN PROPOSED MOBILE
CRISIS SUPPORT TEAMS ARE NOW UP
AND RUNNING.
A FOLLOW ON TO THIS PROGRAM THE
INVESTMENT IN MENTAL HEALTH WHEN
THIS GRANT PROGRAM FOR CHILDREN
AND YOUTH -- ESPECíFICAMENTE
PRESSES A CONTINUING CRISIS
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN AND YOUTH
TWENTY ONE YEARS OF AGE ONE ARE
UNDER -- THE LEGISLATURE
APPROPRIATED APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY SEVEN POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO BE MADE AVAILABLE
COUNTIES OR DISNEY NONPROFIT
AGENCIES. FOR SERVICES SIMILAR
TO THE TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
PROGRAM BUT IN THIS CASE SOLELY
FOR THE BENEFIT OF CHILDREN AND
YOUTH TWENTY ONE YEARS OF AGE
AND YOUNGER.
THE APPLICATION DEADLINE FOR THE
PROGRAM WAS FEBRUARY TWENTY
EIGHTH OF THIS YEAR AND
UNFORTUNATELY ONLY SIX
APPLICATIONS ARE RECEIVED BY
REGENCY. FOR ONE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS OUT OF THE
TWENTY SEVEN POINT SEVEN MILLION
AVAILABLE.
A PLUS AN ADDITIONAL TWO POINT
NINE MILLION DOLLARS FOR FUNDING --
PERSONNEL IN STAFFING FUNDING AT
A FOUR MILLION DOLLARS AVAILABLE.
AND ALL THIS FUNDING WAS FOR
CRISIS.
MOBILE CRISIS SUPPORT TEAM
VEHICLE PURCHASES AND FOR THE
STAFF FOR THOSE -- VEHICLES.
WE WILL BE ADVERTISING ANOTHER
FUNDING ROUND FOR THE PROGRAM
ONCE WE HOPEFULLY HAVE
LEGISLATIVE FIXES TO THE PROGRAM
THAT WE'RE PROPOSING HERE TODAY.
WE WE ARE PULLED ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES TO SEE WHY THEY DID NOT
APPLY FOR THE PROGRAM.
AND WE RECEIVED A RESPONSE RATE
OF OF PROPERTY 47%.
AND WE ASK THEM -- WHY UP ALMOST
HALF OF THE RESPONDENTS SAID AT
THE SHORT APPLICATION PERIOD WAS
AN IMPEDIMENT TO THEM APPLYING?
A 6060% SAID THAT THE SHORT TIME
WANT TO EXPEND FUNDS WAS AN
IMPEDIMENT.
AND ALMOST 70% SAID THAT LACK OF
GRANT WRITING STAFF WAS AN
IMPEDIMENT TO APPLYING.
AND THAT WE BELIEVE THAT THESE
PAYMENTS CAN BE ADDRESSED BY
ALIGNING AND EXTENDING THE
FUNDING SOURCES FOR THE PROGRAM.
IN ADDITION 30% SAID AT THE LACK
OF FLEXIBILITY WAS AN IMPEDIMENT
TO APPLYING.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT CAN BE THAT
CAN BE ADDRESSED BY GIVING
CHAPTER THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE
GRANTS FOR ANYONE OF THE FOR
INTENDED USES OF THE PRO OF THE
FUNDS.
AND SO OR PROPOSAL.
WE HAVE BEFORE YOU TODAY -- WITH
A LINE AND EXTEND THE FUNDING
SOURCES FOR THE PROGRAM --
CURRENTLY -- THE TWENTY SEVEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
CAPITAL APPROPRIATED AND A JUMP
ON REPURPOSE REAPPROPRIATION ALL
THE DIFFERENT COMPANIES
DEADLINES RANGING FROM.
200-019-22000 AND TWENTY WE
SUGGEST ALIGNING EXTENDING TE
CUMMINS DEADLINES TO JUNE
THIRTIETH OF TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
AND WE BELIEVE THIS WOULD
PREVENT ELEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
OF THE TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLAR MHSAA FUNDING.
AND THE GENERAL FUND
REAPPROPRIATION FROM EXPIRING ON
JUNE THIRTIETH OF TWENTY
NINETEEN IN THIS WE GET
APPLICANTS ADDITIONAL TIME TO
APPLY FOR PROGRAM.
SECONDLY WE ALSO PROVIDE.
THIS IS JUST PROVIDING
FLEXIBILITY IN THE USE OF THE
FUNDS CURRENTLY THERE'S BUDGET
CONTROL LANGUAGE IN PLACE THAT
WOULD -- ALLOCATE SPECIFIC
FUNDING BY PROGRAM AREA -- WE
SUGGEST PROVIDING THE
FLEXIBILITY ALLOCATE FUNDS
OUTSIDE THESE ESTABLISHED
PARAMETERS AND TO GIVE US THE
ABILITY TO WARD -- GRANTS TO
DESERVING APPLICATION SUBMITTED
TO THE AUTHORITY BASED ON OUR
BEST ESTIMATES.
NOW WE ALSO ASKED POLL --
COUNTIES TO QUANTIFY THEIR NEEDS
FOR ADULTS AND CHILDREN AND
YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH FACILITIES
AND THE RESULTS OF THE SURVEYS
WE HAVE AVAILABLE FOR YOUR TEETH
FOR HERE. FOR YOU TODAY.
AND SO -- WE AND THE M. OUR
PROCESS ABOUT THE LANGUAGES IN
THE AGENDA AND IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR US BE HAPPY ANSWER
FOR YOU.
THANK YOU A COVERS FROM LA -- NO
FINANCE. FOR THE RECORD WE DON'T
CURRENTLY HAVE A POSITION ON
THIS PROPOSAL AND WE KNOW IT'S
NOT PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
AND WE HAVE BEEN PROVIDING TOP
OF THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WERE
HAPPY TO CONTINUE DOING SO.
OKAY BUT JUST TO CLARIFY THE
FUNDS THAT.
HE'S TALKING ABOUT -- THE IS
THIS IS NOT PART OF OUR GENERAL
FUND OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT
CORRECT.
THESE ARE PRETTY PRETTY
PREVIOUSLY -- APPROPRIATED ARE
ALEC AT BUDGETED FUNDS CORRECT.
THAT IS CORRECT.
OKAY SO THE THESE FUNDS ARE
CURRENTLY BUILT INTO THE
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FISCAL YEAR
RIGHT OKAY CELL SO WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT SIX STANDING THE OF
RE APPROPRIATING THEM THEN GIVE
ME A LONGER DEADLINES AND WHAT
PEOPLE CAN CAN CAN APPLY FOR THE
PURPOSES OKAY.
AND AND AND CONCERNS FROM LA AS
PERSPECTIVE ON THAT RIGHT OKAY.
ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD -- RIGHT AND
I THINK.
SO ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS.
CASEY NO PUBLIC COMMENT --
THANKS VERY MUCH WE WILL HOLD
ITEM OPEN AND BRING IT WILL
CITING AT AFTER ME REVISED OKAY
THANK YOU THANKS FOR MUCH.
OKAY -- NEXT UP IS THE PURPOSE
STATE HOSPITALS AND THANK YOU
OFFER I DON'T KNOW HOW LONG
YOU'VE BEEN WAITING.
HOPEFULLY NOT SINCE TEN THIRTY
IN THE MORNING.
YOUR BEING HERE.
THANK UNFORTUNATELY IT IS SAFE
TO SAY AND NUMBER TO ANYONE
WHO'S AT THE END OF A BUDGETS OF
THREE HEARING SHOULD BE PROUD OF
THE FORMING THEIR FAMILIES THAT
THEY MIGHT NOT BE MAKING IT HOME
FOR DINNER ON TIME.
ACTUALLY I TELL MY WIFE THAT
EVERY THURSDAY SINCE I'M HERE
[inaudible]
SO OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO EVERYONE CAN
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES FOR THE
RECORD FIRST PLEASE.
GOOD EVENING STEPHANIE CLINTON
AN ACTING DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS.
CHRIS EATON'S DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS GIVE.
ELLEN BACHMAN DEPUTY DIRECTOR
STATEWIDE QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITAL THANK
YOU VALUE.
SORT OF BORED LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
FINANCE.
I'M WEARING TO BURN FINANCE.
CRISCO TEHAMA FINANCE.
YOU GUYS ARE REALLY HANG IN
THERE.
IT'S VERY GOOD OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO WHAT WE GO AHEAD
AND BEGIN WITH THE NUMBER YOU
WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT WE HAVE A
WELL WRITTEN THAT DESCRIPTION OF
THE DEPARTMENTS AND SINCE I'M
THE ONLY SUB COMMITTEE MEMBER
HERE I THINK I'VE HEARD THIS IS
MY THIRD TIME AROUND.
NOT THAT IS ALL VERY IMPORTANCE
OF YOU JUST HIT THE HIGHLIGHTS
OF THE ISSUES YOU SEE THAT
YOU'LL BE A NEED TO ADDRESS THIS
COMING BUDGET YEAR.
SO -- THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS OPERATES THE STATE'S
MENTAL HEALTH A PRINTED MENTAL
HEALTH HOSPITAL SYSTEM PROVIDING
DAILY CARE MENTAL TREATMENT --
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN WE SERVE NEARLY TWELVE
THOUSAND PATIENTS WITH AN
AVERAGE DAILY CENSUS ACROSS OUR
HOSPITALS OF OVER FIFTY EIGHT
HUNDRED PATIENTS.
WE SERVE. SIX DIFFERENT
COMMITMENT TYPES -- 89% OF OUR
PATIENTS ARE GENERALLY FORENSIC
AT 11% OUR CIVIL COMMITMENTS --
WE ALSO OPERATE THE CONDITIONAL
RELEASE PROGRAM THE JAIL MAYES
COMPETENCY TREATMENT PROGRAMS
THIS YEAR WE STARTED THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY COMMUNITY BASED
RESTORATION PROGRAM WHICH WAS
DIFFERENT THE DIVERSION PROGRAM
THAT WILL BE TALKING ABOUT LATER.
AND WE ARE ALSO -- IMPLEMENTING
THE DIVERSION PROGRAM THAT'S
BEEN OUR PRIMARY FOCUS THIS YEAR
AS WELL AS INTO NEXT YEAR.
THAT'S THE HIGHLIGHTS FOR YOU.
THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS FROM
ALEJO.
APARTMENT FINANCE.
I JUST MAKE NOTE THAT YOU GET
WHAT TWENTY THREE THOUSAND FROM
THE LOTTERY PEOPLE MORE PEOPLE
NEED TO PLAY THE LOTTERY RIGHT
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY IN AGAIN APPRECIATE THAT --
IT DOES REMIND EVERYONE THAT
THERE'S A LOT THERE IS A LOT A
LOT THAT THIS DEPARTMENT DOES
AND AND THAT IS TO SAY HOSPITALS
TAKE CARE OF WHICH I KNOW YOU
DIDN'T.
AT MY DIRECTION DID NOT GO
THROUGH EACH OF THESE SO --
LET'S MOVE ON THEN TO ISSUE TO
STATE HOSPITALS PROGRAM UPDATES.
IF THERE'S A NUMBER OF UPDATES
IN HERE THAT WE'RE GOING TO GIVE
IN SO THE CROSS THREE OF US
WE'RE GOING TO BE TAG TEAMING --
SO I'M GONNA START OFF WITH THE
MENTAL HEALTH AND HE'S BEEN A
METROPOLITAN STATE HOSPITAL BED
EXPANSION.
AND FOR THIS WE'RE REQUESTING
HUNDRED NINETEEN POINT THREE
POSITIONS AND EIGHTEEN POINT SIX
MILLION IN NINETEEN TWENTY AND A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY POSITIONS AND
TWENTY POINT ONE MILLION ON
GOING.
AND THIS IS FOR ACTIVATION OF
UNIT FOR TWELVE AND UNIT -- FOR
FOURTEEN AT METROPOLITAN FOR A
TOTAL OF NINETY TWO BANDS AND
THIS IS PART OF A SERIES OF
PROPOSALS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE AND THE
PAST YEARS -- IT RELATED TO THE
INCREASE SECURE BED CAPACITY
PROJECT RELATED TO OUR ATTEMPTS
TO ADDRESS THE ON GOING INCREASE
AND RE FURROWS OF INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL PATIENTS -- AND WE
WERE -- PROVIDED FUNDING AND AND
THE TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN
BUDGET -- TO ACTIVATE THREE THE
FIRST THREE UNITS OF THIS --
PROJECT AND THIS IS THE FUNDING
FOR THE LAST TWO AND IN THIS I
REQUEST IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
PRIOR I REQUEST.
I JUST KEEP GOING [inaudible]
IN.
PROCEEDINGS ALL PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON THE JAIL BASED
COMPETENCY TREATMENT PROGRAMS.
SO -- THE DEPARTMENT IS
REQUESTING A TOTAL OF TWELVE
POINT THREE MILLION TO SUPPORT
BOTH -- CURRENTLY ACTIVATED AND
TO ACTIVATE NEW JVC T. PROGRAMS --
IN THIS REQUEST IS COMPRISED OF
OF THREE DIFFERENT COMPONENTS
THE FIRST IS ONE POINT WE ARE
REQUESTING ONE POINT ONE MILLION --
IN FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND A ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION ON GOING TO
SUPPORT THE EXISTING THE
INCREASES IN EXISTING JBC T
OGRAM COSTS THAT'S PRIMARILY
CENTERED AROUND.
THREE OF OUR CURRENTLY ACTIVATED
PROGRAMS IN SACRAMENTO CINEMA
AND SEE AN DIEGO COUNTIES.
THE SECOND REQUEST IS FOR ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING TO
SUPPORT AN INCREASE OF SEVENTY
FOUR NEW GBC T. BEDS ACROSS FIVE
COUNTIES.
AND THEN THE THIRD REQUEST IS
FOR TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE
THOUSAND BEGINNING IN THE BUDGET
YEAR AN ON GOING TO FIND AN
INCREASE IN PATIENTS RIGHT
SERVICES AND TO MAKE THOSE
SERVICES AVAILABLE.
TO PATIENTS IN THE G. B. C. T.
PROGRAMS.
AND THE NEXT ONE IS THE PATIENT
REVENUE.
HE SHOULD DRIVEN -- ANY REQUEST
AND WE'RE REQUESTING TEN POINT
FIVE MILLION IN FISCAL YEAR
NINETEEN TWENTY AN ON GOING TO
PROVIDE FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE
OPERATING COSTS RELATED TO
PROVIDING CARE AND TREATMENT FOR
PATIENTS -- SINCE TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE THIRTEEN WE'VE INCREASED
OUR STATE HOSPITAL SENSES BY
FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN
THIS INCREASE AND SINCE THIS IS
THE RESULT OF NEWLY ACTIVATED
BEDS ACROSS THE STATE HOSPITALS
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS.
AND FOR THESE BETTER ACTIVATIONS
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF LAST
YEAR'S PROPOSAL RELATED TO THE
METROPOLITAN STATE HOSPITAL BEDS
WE JUST SPOKE ABOUT -- WE
RECEIVE FUNDING FOR THE
POSITIONS AND ASSOCIATED STAFF
AN OPERATING.
STAFF OPERATING EXPENSES OF
EQUIPMENT BUT DID NOT RECEIVE
ANY FUNDING ADJUSTMENTS FOR THE
PATIENT RELATED IT WE ANY.
THE NEXT ITEM IS ARE FOR THE
HOSPITAL POLICE OFFICER ECONOMY
AND FOR THIS REQUEST WERE
REQUESTING TO CONVERT THREE
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS TO
PERMANENT FULL TIME POSITIONS
AND FIVE POINT EIGHT MILLION ON
GOING TO CONTINUE THE EXPANDED
HOSPITAL POLICE OFFICER ACADEMY.
I SAY TO THE NO BETTER AS GOING
TO THAT AT THE TIME THAT THE
HOUSE YEAH SURE ARMS THIS IS THE
ONLY THIS IS THE ONLY ONE OF THE
PROGRAM UPDATES THAT WE HAVE
COMMENTS ON SO -- WE AGREE WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION THAT THE PICK
ACADEMY DOES NEED TO CONTINUE TO
OPERATE OUT ITS EXPANDED
CAPACITY -- HOWEVER EVEN WITHIN
A PROJECTED INCREASE IN OFFICER
ATTRITION RATE THE ACADEMY COULD
BE PRODUCING EXCESS GRADUATES
WITHIN THREE YEARS.
AND SO WE'RE RECOMMENDING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED FUNDING
FOR THIS PROPOSAL ON A THREE
YEAR LIMITED TERM BASIS --
HOWEVER IF THE OFFICER TUITION
RATE IS LOWER THAN PROJECTED THE
DATE AT WHICH THE ACADEMY IS
PRODUCING ACCESS OFFICERS COULD
OBVIOUSLY MOVE UP AND SO WE'RE
ALSO RECOMMENDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT. TO REPORT ANNUALLY
ON ITS EFFORTS TO RECRUIT
OFFICERS -- SO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN MONITOR THE
VACANCY RATE DETERMINE WHETHER
IT FUNDING NEEDS TO BE ADJUSTED
WHETHER UP OR DOWN IN THE
MEANTIME.
OKAY THANK YOU IS ANY COMMENTS
FROM FINANCE ON THIS FOR UPDATE.
YEAH A I I THINK OVERALL YOU'LL
SEE A COMMON THEME WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
BUDGETS IN THAT THEY WERE
STARTING TO TAKE A DIFFERENT
APPROACH AND TO IDENTIFY OUR
REOCCURRING NEED.
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS SOMEONE OTHER
PARTICULARLY WITH THE HOSPITAL
POLICE ACADEMY AND THE ISSUE
THAT YOU HEARD BEFORE -- BEFORE
THIS WITH OPERATING EXPENSES AND
EQUIPMENT.
WILL BE SOMETHING THAT THE THE
DEPARTMENT AND FINANCE WILL BE
CONTINUALLY TO UPDATE YOUR TWO
YEAR RATHER THAN ONE LARGE
REQUEST WHEN WE HAVE AN EMERGING
NEED SO WE CAN CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS OUR INCREASES IN COSTS.
PARTICULARLY WITH THE HOSPITAL
POLICE ACADEMY AGAIN THIS WILL
BE SOMETHING WILL MONITOR TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE SEE THAT THESE
RESOURCES ARE NO LONGER NEEDED
WILL BE ADJUSTING ACCORDINGLY
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT ON GO AND CONTINUE
THEN.
THE NEXT ITEM IS AN UPDATE ON
THE ENHANCE TREATMENT PROGRAM.
WE'RE REQUESTING ARE WE
ANTICIPATE A SAVINGS OF ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
A REDUCTION IN TWELVE POINT
SEVEN POSITIONS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE DELAY IN CONSTRUCTION OF THE
FOURTH ETP UNIT.
WHICH WILL BE LOCATED AT D. S.
H. PATTON -- AS YOU RECALL AB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN AUTHORIZED
IMPLEMENTATION AND OPERATION OF
A PILOT ATP FOR A LIMITED TIME --
IN.
THE PREVIOUS BUDGET ACTS WE WERE
APPROVED CONSTRUCTION FUNDING
FOR FOR PILOT UNITS THREE
THIRTEEN BAD UNITS THAT
ATASCADERO FOR MALE PATIENTS AND
ONE TEN BED UNIT AT PATTON FOR
FEMALE PATIENTS -- WE RECEIVED
FUNDING IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BUDGET AX. FOR EACH OF THOSE
UNITS -- BASED ON ANTICIPATED
CONSTRUCTION TIME LINES AN
ACTIVATION DATES -- WE ARE
ANTICIPATING AN ADJUSTMENT IN
THE COMPLETION DATE FOR THE
PATENT ATP FROM SEPTEMBER TWENTY
NINETEEN TO JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY AND THIS CHANGE RESULTED
FROM A LONGER TIME LINE TO GET
STATE FIRE MARSHAL APPROVAL.
OF OUR PLANS LAST YEAR THOSE
PLANS WERE APPROVED IN SEPTEMBER
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE PROJECT
IS CURRENTLY OUT TO BID AND WILL
PROVIDE AN UPDATE IN THE MAY
REFRESH.
ALSO JUST WANTED TO NOTE ON THE
LINE ITEM THAT THE AGENDA --
BASED ON INFORMATION THAT WE
PRESENTED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INDICATED THAT THE FIRST
UNIT HAS BEEN COMPLETED -- THAT
WAS THE ESTIMATED TIME LINE THAT
WE WE THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO BE
COMPLETED IN FEBRUARY I'M BASED
ON WHEN THE TIMELINE ON THAT WE
HAD WHEN WE ARE PREPARING
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOCUMENTS THAT
THAT PERSON IS STILL UNDER
CONSTRUCTION AND HAS NOT
ACTIVATED YET OKAY SO THOSE
ANTICIPATED.
BUT THAT SOUNDS LIKE THE FIRE
MARSHAL AND THE LEAD FOR THE
FIRST ITEM FOR THE FIRST UNIT
IT'S BEEN MORE AROUND I'M COULD
JUST CONSTRUCTION CHALLENGES
AROUND YOU KNOW SITE -- WHEN
THEY GET INTO THE SITE AND THEY
FIND EXISTING CONDITIONS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT?
FACING WHAT HAPPENS WE ACTUALLY
OPENED SOMETHING UP RIGHT NOW.
TO CLEAN WHEN THEY'RE OLD
FACILITIES ACCESS OKAY ALL RIGHT.
OKAY THANKS ITEM THEN.
THE NEXT ITEM IS THE MANAGEMENT
PETROUS SHORT POPULATION
SERVICES ADJUSTMENT AND THIS IS
A REQUEST TO INCREASE THE
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY -- BY
SIX HUNDRED AND SIX THOUSAND IN
NINETEEN TWENTY AND I'M GOING ON
OUR CURRENT APPROVED AUTHORITY
IS A HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX POINT
SEVEN MILLION.
I COUNTIES REIMBURSE US -- DAILY
BED RATE FOUR LPS PATIENTS ARE
TREATED IN OUR HOSPITALS
ADDITIONALLY COUNTIES REIMBURSE
FOR PATIENTS THAT ARE AMENDED --
AS A MISDEMEANOR INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL PATIENTS PACE --
BASED ON THE ESTIMATED
COLLECTIONS FOR THE LPS AND
MISTER MINUTES THE CURRENT --
REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY IS NOT
ESTIMATED TO BE SUFFICIENT FOR
NEXT YEAR.
I THINK THAT THE THE NEXT TWO
ITEMS IN A MINUTE DISCUSS OUR ON
THE CONDITIONAL RELEASE PROGRAM
THE FIRST ONE BEING -- FOR OUR
NON SVP POPULATION SO THIS IS
PRIMARILY SERVING R. AND G. I AM
DO AND I. S. T. POP -- THIS
REQUEST IS OF FOUR ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN
TWENTY AN ON GOING TO SUPPORT
THE INCREASE HOT COSTS IN
HOUSING TO SUPPORT OUR CONRAD
POPULATION.
THIS IS PRIMARILY ATTRIBUTED TO
JUST THE OVERALL INCREASE IN
HOUSING COSTS ACROSS THE STATE --
PRIMARILY IN MOST NOTABLY IN OUR
BOARDING CARE -- TO SERVICE
POPULATION WITHOUT THIS
AUGMENTATION OUR POPULATION WILL
CONTINUE TO DECLINE [inaudible]
OKAY.
OUR SECOND REQUEST A SPECIFIC TO
THE SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATOR
PROGRAM THIS IS A STANDARD
CASELOAD ADJUSTMENT.
SO IN THE CURRENT YEAR WE ARE
REQUESTING SEVEN HUNDRED AND
SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND IN
ANTICIPATION OF THE CASELOAD
INCREASE -- BY FOR ADDITIONAL SB
PIECE BY THE END OF TE FISCAL
YEAR.
AND THEN IN THE BUDGET YEAR RICK
WE ARE REQUESTING TWO POINT ONE
MILLION -- FOR AN ADDITIONAL TWO
SB PEAS TO COME OUT INTO THE
COMMUNITY THE REASON WHY THAT
COST IS SO MUCH HIGHER IS THAT
WE DO PRO RATE THE COST
ACCORDING TO TH SCHEDULE WHEN
SOMEONE COMES OUT [inaudible]
OKAY.
RIGHT THANK YOU.
THEY SAID NO OTHER COME WITH ANY
OTHER CAN COMMENT ON ANYTHING
ELSE.
ANYOTHER COMMENTS ON THE
UPDATES RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THESE
UPDATES -- WHILE YOU MOVE AHEAD
TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE WHICH IS
INCUMBENTS STAND TRIAL DIVERSION
COMMUNITIES TREATMENT.
AND IT WAS A BIG THING IN THE
BUDGET LAST YEAR.
SO THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET
ACT PROVIDED -- THE DEPARTMENT
HUNDRED MILLION TO CONTRACT WITH
COUNTIES TO DEVELOP NEW OR
EXPAND EXISTING POST.
DIVERSION -- PROGRAM BECAUSE
BOOKING VERSION PROGRAMS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS THAT -- TO HAVE BEEN
FOUND OR HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
BE FOUND INCOME TO STAND TRIAL
ON FELONY CHARGES.
ULTIMATELY THE GOAL THE
DIVERSION PROPOSAL WAS TO REDUCE
REFERRALS TO THE DEPARTMENT AS
WELL AS TO DELIVER INDIVIDUALS
WHO CAN BE SAFELY TREATED IN THE
COMMUNITY OUT TO MORE
APPROPRIATE COMMUNITY MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT.
IN THE COMMUNITY TO PREVENT
THEIR RE ENTRY INTO THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
OUR DIVERSION IMPLEMENTATION
TEAM IS BEING LED BY A MISS
EATON'S -- HAVE YOU BEEN HEARING
FROM AND THEN DOCTOR AND KATE
MORE BURTON -- FRONT WHO IS OUR
MEDICAL DIRECTOR AND DIRECTOR OF
CLINICALOPERATIONS DIVISION AND
THEY'RE GOING TO ANSWER THE TWO
QUESTIONS THAT WERE I'M PROPOSED
IN THE ENGINE.
HELLO AGAIN.
I'M IN A PROVIDE YOU A AS A
RESPONSE TO THE FIRST QUESTION
ABOUT WHERE WE ARE WITH SOME
COUNTIES RECEIVING AWARDS SO --
WE'VE TAKEN THE APPROACH TO
IMPLEMENTATION IMPLEMENTATION OF
DIVERSION THE D. S. H. DIVERSION
FUNDING PROGRAM.
SORT OF FOCUSED ON THREE DOMAINS
AND THAT IS ONE FIRST COUNTY
IMPLEMENTATION HOW CAN WE GET
FUNDS OUT TO THE COUNTIES AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE -- TO
TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO THE COUNTIES TO
SUPPORT THEM WHAT THEY'RE
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION
NEEDS AND THEN THE THIRD DOMAIN
BEING DATA COLLECTION AND
RESEARCH EFFORTS -- ON THE
COUNTY IMPLEMENTATION FRONT --
OF THE TOTAL THAT WE WERE WE
WERE AUTHORIZED A HUNDRED
MILLION NINETY ONE MILLION WAS
EARMARKED FOR WHAT WE CALL OUR
TOP FIFTEEN COUNTIES.
AND THOSE TOP FIFTEEN REALLY
COMPRISED -- THEY REFLECTED OUR
HIGHEST RATE OF I. S. T.
REFERRALS AND SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
AND SO WE WORKED IN PHASES TO
DISTRIBUTE THE FUNDING REALLY
FIRST FOCUSING ON THAT FIRST
BATCH OF NINETY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS SO IN OCTOBER WE REALLY
WE RELEASED OUR FIRST REQUEST
FOR LETTERS OF INTEREST TO THE
COUNTIES.
ALL FIFTEEN COUNTIES RESPONDED.
OF THAT -- WE HAVE -- CURRENTLY
WE'RE WORKING WITH SIX COUNTY IS --
IN THE CONTRACT PROCESS ONE
PROGRAM LA COUNTY HAS ALREADY
ACTIVATED BEGINNING IN MARCH AND
AS OF TODAY HAS ALREADY DIVERTED
SEVEN INDIVIDUALS -- BUT OF
THESE SIX PLUS AN ADDITIONAL
THREE THERE ARE COMING ON LINE
WE WILL HAVE COMMITTED.
ABOUT SIXTY ONE POINT TWO
MILLION OF OUR NINETY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WE HAD
AUTHORIZED.
AND THE PROJECTION IS TO SERVE
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY
EIGHT I. S. T. OR ASSUME TO BE
I. S. T. PATIENTS -- FOR THE
REMAINING EIGHT POINT FIVE
MILLION WE ISSUED A SECOND ROUND
FUNDING REQUEST TO OTHER
COUNTIES THAT MAY BE INTERESTED
IN IN -- PARTICIPATING IN THE
PROGRAM.
THAT WAS RELEASED IN DECEMBER --
WE RECEIVED.
LETTERS OF INTEREST FROM
THIRTEEN COUNTIES AND THOSE
APPLICATIONS ARE DUE LATER THIS
MONTH IN APRIL.
ON THE TECHNICAL ASSIST
ASSISTANCE FRONT WE'VE WE'VE
ESSENTIALLY PARTNERED WITH ALL
OF THE THE VERY STAKEHOLDERS SO --
V. -- CALIFORNIA COUNSEL IN
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES JUDICIAL COUNCIL THE
OAC COUNCIL OF STATE GOVERNMENTS
JUSTICE CENTER.
AND SO ON AND SO WE'VE REALLY
BEEN BRAINSTORMING AND WORKING
TOGETHER TO TO TO IDENTIFY WITH
THOSE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE NEEDS
ARE OF THE COUNTIES -- IN
FEBRUARY WE HELD AN IN PERSON
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SESSION FOR
TOP FIFTEEN COUNTIES REALLY
FOCUSED ON HOW DO WE IDENTIFY
ELIGIBLE CANDIDATES FOR
DIVERSION PROVIDING RISK
ASSESSMENT TRAINING AS WELL AS
LEARNING FROM ONE ANOTHER ON
WHAT OTHER COUNTIES ARE DOING --
ON THE DIVERSION FRONT -- AND
WE'VE ALSO DEVELOPED A SERIES OF
WEBINARS TRAININGS ARE ALSO ON
THESE TOPICS RISK ASSESSMENT --
IDENTIFICATION OF ELIGIBILITY OF
OF CLIENTS -- AND THEN WE'VE
ALSO LAUNCHED A A PUBLIC WEB
PAGE AN INFORMATION PAGE THAT
WE'RE USING IS SORT OF A
REPOSITORY FOR THE INFORMATION
THAT WE'RE SHARING WITH COUNTIES
IN THAT WE ARE FINDING -- ON THE
SERVICES FRONT -- Y'ALL HAD ALSO
ASKED FOR WHAT TYPES OF SERVICES
ARE BEING -- PROVIDED TAR
DIVERSION CLIENTS AND SO
GENERALLY IT'S IT'S BOTH IN JAIL
SERVICES AS WELL AS OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY SO AS INDIVIDUALS ARE
IDENTIFIED -- IT THERE ARE
ASSESSMENTS AND EVALUATIONS THAT
DO OCCUR IN JAIL -- TO IDENTIFY
PROSPECTIVE CLIENTS WHILE THOSE
CLIENTS ARE GOING THROUGH THE
COURT PROCESS TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY MAY ACTUALLY.
BE APPROVED BY THE COURTS TO BE
DIVERTED THEIR RECEIVING -- SOME
IN JAIL TEATMENT AS WELL AS
MEDICATION FOR STABILIZATION
BEFORE THEY TRANSITION OUT INTO
THE COMMUNITY.
AND THEN ONCE THEY'RE IN THE
COMMUNITY WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS
THAT MOST OF OUR PROPOSALS ARE
AROUND DEDICATED HOUSING TO
SERVE THIS POPULATION.
AND IN THE IN THE DEDICATED
HOUSING WE'RE SEEING INTENSIVE
CASE MANAGEMENT -- MEDICATION
MANAGEMENT ONE ONE ONE ONE AND
GROUP THERAPY.
THE SOCIALIZATION LIFE SKILLS AS
WELL AS SOME SUPERVISION -- OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS AS WELL AS
TRANSPORTATION TO OTHER
APPOINTMENTS SUCH AS MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS -- ON THE ON THE
COUNTY MATCHING REQUIREMENTS OF
FOR LARGE COUNTIES WE DO
REQUIRED A 20% MATCH WHICH COULD
BE EITHER CASH MATCH OR IN KIND
MATCH.
IT. FOR SMALL COUNTY IS THAT HER
WITH A POPULATION OF TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND OR LESS WE DO
REQUIRED A LOWER MATCH AND
THAT'S 10%.
WE DO REQUIRE THAT ITS LOCAL
MATCHING FUNDS SO THAT COULD BE
NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT LOCAL
IMAGES SAY DOLLARS COUNTY
GENERAL FUND -- THEY REALLY ARE
PRECLUDED FROM MATCHING WITH
OTHERS STATE FUNDED GRANT
PROGRAMS ARE SUBTLY FOR
FEDERALLY FUNDED PROGRAMS -- AND
ON THAT FRONT WE THROUGH OUR
CONTRACTUAL AGREEMENTS WITH THE
COUNTIES ARE REQUIRING THAT THEY
REPORT TO US ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
WHAT -- MATCHING FUNDS THEY'RE
USING AND THEN THAT SOURCE AS
WELL THEY DO THEY DO TO PROVIDE
A PLAN TO US UP FRONT BUT THEN
WHAT ULTIMATELY HAPPENS
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR MIGHT BE
DIFFERENT SO WERE WERE REQUIRING
THE COUNTIES TO TO REPORT TO US
[inaudible]
VALUATION.
OKAY I WAS GOING TO TURN IT OVER
TO DR WARBURTON TO TALK ABOUT
THE OUTCOMES OKAY [inaudible]
RIDLEY.
THE QUESTION IS HOW DO WE INTEND
TO EVALUATE THE OUTCOMES FOR THE
PROGRAMS WE BASICALLY HAVE A
THREE TIERED APPROACH THE FIRST
IS THE BASICS WHICH IS.
THE TWELFTH STATUTORILY REQUIRED
OUTCOMES WHO ARE WE DIVERTING
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE WE DIVERTING
ARE WE SEEING A REDUCTION IN THE
RATE OF REFERRAL VII'S TEAS.
ARE COUNTIES -- SERVING THE
ACTUAL NUMBER AS COMPARED TO THE
CONTRACTED NUMBER -- COMPARED TO
PROJECTED NUMBER EXCUSE ME
WHAT'S THE COST OF TREATMENT
INTO THEY HAVE SOME A
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS -- WE HAVE
A LITTLE BIT MORE IN DEPTH
COATING PROCESS THAT WE'RE
OFFERING COUNTIES THAT IS
CONSISTENT WITH OUR CODING THAT
WE DO THREE UC DAVIS OF WITH
SEVERAL THOUSAND NOW I IS TEAS
AND THEN WE HAVE -- A SOUGHT
NATIONAL PARTNERS SO WE HAVE
APPLIED FOR AND RECEIVED A
TECHNICAL SSISTANCE GRANT FROM
THE SAME TO GAIN CENER WHICH IS
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE CENTER.
WE START THAT IN A COUPLE OF
WEEKS AND WE'VE ALSO --
SUBMITTED A LETTER OF INTEREST
TO MET WITH JAY POWER WHICH IS --
MASSACHUSETTS INSTITUTE OF
TECHNOLOGY CENTER FOR LINKING
RESEARCHERS WITH STATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
HEY COME AS FAMILIAL.
FINANCE [inaudible]
SO -- YEAH ONE DISPOSAL FIRST
CAME FORWARD -- I CAN REMEMBER
IS AT THE TOP OF MY HEAD BUT I
MEAN THERE'S SOME PRETTY
AMBITIOUS GOALS FOR NONE NOW TO
REDUCTION AND I. S. T. E.
REFERRALS -- CARRY ON TRACK TO
MEET THOSE.
I MEAN I AND I REALIZE YOU JUST
SAID YOU'RE ST GET GETTING
STARTED BECAUSE SOUNDS LIKE YOU
HAVE QUITE GOT THE MONEY OUT
SEVEN YOU GOT SOME RIGHT BECAUSE
YOU HAVE YOU SAID.
DID FIFTEEN COUNTY SAID YOU GOT
SIX COUNTIES NOW YOU CAN ADD
THREE MORE RIGHT. SIXTY ONE
POINT RATE IS ABOUT 61% OF THAT
EL AND I APPRECIATE DIVERTED
SEVEN PEOPLE IN ALL OF LAST LAKE
COUNTY I MEAN THAT'S A START BUT
I SAID I HOPE THAT'S JUST
BECAUSE WE'RE REALLY EARLY ON
IT'S GONNA BE A LOT LARGER SEVEN
FOR LA COUNTY.
EL RIGHT I MEAN WE ARE PROJECTED
TO SERVE AT LEAST WITH THESE
NINE CONTRACTS ALMOST FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY PEOPLE.
DEBT AND DIVERSION AWAY THE THE
LAW WAS WRITTEN IS THAT -- AN
INDIVIDUAL COULD BE IN DIVERSION
FOR UP TO TWO YEARS SO THAT THE
IN THE NUMBER OF THAT WE HAVE
PROJECTED TO REDUCE FROM OUR OUR
WAIT LIST.
MIGHT NOT NECESSARILY BE AN
ANNUAL NUMBER BUT OVER AT LEAST
A TWO YEAR PERIOD AND AND
CERTAINLY NO FROM THE VALUATION
STANDPOINT.
THE CELL WILL IN NUMBERS NUMBERS
BUT ALSO.
THIS BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE COST
EFFECTIVENESS RIGHT I MEAN PART
OF THE PART OF WHAT WAS PROPOSED
LAST YEAR WAS THAT.
I MEAN OBVIOUSLY I THINK THERE'S
A BENEFIT TO TRYING TO DIVERT
DUMB IN ITSELF AS VALUE ITSELF
THAT WAS THAT WAS -- SPINS THE
OF LARGE BUDGET.
SAVINGS THAT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN
AS A RESULT OF THAT AS WELL
RIGHT.
FROM PEOPLE NOT GOING TO THE
STATE HOSPITAL SYSTEM.
IT WOULD.
ULTIMATELY REDUCE OUR IN THE
WOULD BE SEVEN HUNDRED PEOPLE
THAT WOULD BE REDUCE FROM OUR
WAIT LIST -- THAT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY TRANSLATE TO SEVEN
PEOPLE NOT IN OUR BEDS BECAUSE
WE HAVE A LINE GOING REFERRALS
RIGHT SO IT REDUCES THE IT.
RELIEVES THE PRESSURE -- AND
HOPEFULLY WILL HELP US CLOSE
THAT GAP AND EVENTUALLY NOT HAVE
TO COME FORWARD WITH ADDITIONAL
PROPOSALS FOR CAPACITY RIGHT
EXACTLY YOU WOULD HAVE TO BUILD
MORE FACILITIES IT DOESN'T COME.
OKAY.
HI BECAUSE OTHERWISE ALTERNATIVE
IS.
FOR COMING IN TO ME IS.
SAY OKAY WE NEED TO BUILD MORE
FACILITIES EXPANDER HOSPITALS
AND SO FORTH.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT OKAY.
BUT WHAT WE MOVE ON THEN TO
ISSUE NUMBER.
FOUR S. ATASCADERO POSSIBLE
WATER BOOSTER PUMP SYSTEM.
AND THIS IS A REQUEST FOR A
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN THOUSAND IN
GENERAL FUND TO FUND THE
PRELIMINARY PLANS FACED -- FOR A
NEW POSSIBLE WATER BOOSTER PUMP
SYSTEM. TO UPGRADE THE IDEAS H.
ATASCADERO MEAN WATER SYSTEM
WHICH HAS EXPERIENCE PRESSURE
DROP PROBLEMS FOR APPROXIMATELY
THIRTEEN YEARS -- WHEN WE HAD
THE REDUCTION WATER MAIN
PRESSURE PUTS THE MAIN FIRE
SPRINKLER SYSTEM AT RISK OF NOT
BEING ABLE TO FUNCTION
APPROPRIATELY?
SO INSULATION OF THIS BOOSTER
PUMP WILL CORRECT THIS ISSUE AND
REDUCE THE REST TO OUR PATIENTS
AND STAFF.
AND OUT SOUNDS PRETTY NECESSARY
IN THE MOUTH IS PROBABLY IN
SOMEWHAT IN THE RANGE OF OUR
BUDGET [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SORRY I ALSO HAVE
PEOPLE COME A I'VE BEEN A CAL
COMEY AND I GET HUNDRED YELLOW
WELL WE HAVE A CORRECTION OF TWO
BILLION DOLLARS SO YOU KNOW I
HAVE SOMETHING THAT'S A HUNDRED
THIRTEEN THOUSAND LIKE OKAY.
IT IS NECESSARY SO.
ALL RIGHT -- LA -- ANY COMMENTS.
FINANCE OKAY ALL RIGHT.
WILL MOVE ON ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
INCREASE COURT APPEARANCES IN
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT REQUESTS.
AND FOR THIS ONE I'M JOINED BY A
ADAM MISTER CADI WHO IS OUR
IDEAS EACH CHIEF COUNSEL AND I
APOLOGIZE I DIDN'T -- INTRODUCED
TO MISTER GEORGE MAYNARD WHO IS
OUR ADMIN DEPUTY WHO IS HERE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS THAT WE HAVE ON
THESE -- CONSTRUCTION ITEM SO --
BEAM FOR THE INCREASE COURT
APPEARANCES -- ITEM WE'RE
REQUESTING FIVE POINT FIVE TO
YOUR LIMITED TERM POSITIONS ON
THE GENERAL FUND INCREASE OF
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN
THOUSAND IN NINETEEN TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO ADDRESS THE
INCREASING COURT HEARINGS
RELATED TO INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL REFERRALS.
AND PUBLIC RECORDS ACT REQUEST --
AND I'M GOING TO ASK MR COUNTY
TO PROVIDE YOU SOME ADDITIONAL
DETAILS ON THIS.
GOOD EVENING -- YES SO FOR THIS
REQUEST -- THE FIVE POSITIONS
ARE TO SUPPORT THE ONE HUNDRED
AND 53% INCREASE IN COURT
APPEARANCES RELATED TO THE I. S.
T. WEIGHTLESS THAT WE'VE
DISCUSSED EARLIER -- ESSENTIALLY
THE RECORDS ARE ISSUING ORDERS
TO SHOW CAUSE AGAINST THE
DEPARTMENT FOR NOT BEING ABLE TO
TIMELY ADMIT PATIENTS.
TIAS SAGE LEGAL DIVISION
ATTORNEYS MUST APPEAR AT THOSE
SUPERIOR COURT HEARINGS TO
DEFEND APARTMENT EXPLAINED
APARTMENTS EFFORTS. TO TIMELY
ADMIT PATIENTS -- THESE ARE
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS BECAUSE
WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT THE DIVERSION
PROGRAM IN THE NEXT TWO YEARS
WILL BRING DOWN THAT WAIT LIST
BUT UNTIL THAT TIME WE NEED TO
TURN RESOURCES TO EXPLAIN
DEPARTMENTS POSITION.
ADDITIONALLY THE PUBLICRECORDS
ACT REQUEST OF INCREASED FROM
TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX
REQUESTS IN. TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN TO PROJECTION OF FIVE
HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS LISTED IN
THE B. C. P..
THAT'S ALMOST A TWO HUNDRED AND
20% INCREASE.
THE THAT INCREASES GENERATED --
BOTH FRIEND PATIENTS AS WELL AS
PLAINTIFFS COUNSEL'S AND OTHERS
SEEKING -- INCREASINGLY MORE
COMPLEX DOCUMENTS TO THESE
POSITIONS WOULD SUPPORT
RESPONDING TO THOSE PUBLIC
RECORD ACT REQUESTS.
OKAY LA -- AND COMMENTS FINANCE.
OKAY SO WE PAY FOR THE COURTS
AND PAY FOR LAWYERS [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE MONITORING.
WE'RE HELP ALL RIGHT OKAY WELL
JUST AS IMPORTANTLY.
ONE OF ACCESS TO JUSTICE SO.
AND RIGHTS OKAY ISSUE NUMBER SIX
PRIVACY PROTECTION PROGRAM.
BUT FOR THE SUMMER REQUESTING
NINE PERMANENT FULL TIME
POSITIONS ONE MILLION TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY THREE THOUSAND IN
GENERAL FUND IN NINETEEN TWENTY
AND ONE MILLION TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND I'M GOING TO
ESTABLISH A SYSTEM WIDE PRIVACY
PROTECTION PROGRAM.
AND PROVIDE EVER SAID SITE OVER
THE SYSTEM WIDE PRIVACY
COMPLIANCE I MISS THE CUT WILL
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL DETAILS.
A YES THANK YOU THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF HEALTH INFORMATION
INTEGRITY A IS THE STATE'S
OVERSIGHT AND CITY OVERHEAD BY
COMPLIANCE.
AND AT THE CARILLO HIGH AS
THEY'RE CALLED -- AUDITED DS
EACH AND THEY FOUND THERE WERE
SIXTY ONE FINDINGS IN THERE ON A
RELATED TO OUR PRIVACY SECURITY
ADMINISTRATIVE AND PATIENT RATES.
PROTECTIONS AND MEASURES THAT
ONE OF THE FINDINGS WAS THAT D.
S. H. LACKS AS SYSTEM MY PRIVACY
PROGRAM THAT WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR OUR POLICIES OR
PROCEDURES OR TRAINING.
OR MONITORING AND COMPLIANCE
INCIDENT BREACH RESPONSE AND
RISK MITIGATION.
SO THIS PROPOSAL SEEKS TO
ESTABLISH THAT ENTERPRISE WIDE
PRIVACY PROGRAMS WITH -- ONE
POSITION EACH OF OUR FIVE
HOSPITALS AND FOR POSITIONS AT
T. S. H. SACRAMENTO TO REALLY
IMPLEMENT THAT STANDARD --
STANDARDIZE PRIVACY PROGRAM AND
ENSURE COMPLETE COMPLIANCE WITH
STATE AND FEDERAL PRIVACY LAWS.
THANK YOU COMMENTS MILLION --
FINANCE ALL RIGHT THAT WILL
CERTAINLY.
THE SHARED STATE HOSPITALS
SHOULD BE.
A CAR ON PRIVACY SELF THANK YOU.
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN CONTRACT IT'S
SERVICES AND PATIENT MANAGEMENT
SUPPORT.
IT IS A THIS ITEM A REQUESTING A
PERMANENT POSITIONS AND ONE
MILLION EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND IN
NINETEEN TWENTY AND ONE MILLION
SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND I'M GOING.
ON IN THESE POSITIONS WILL
MANAGE AND SUPPORT THE EXPANSION
OF THE JAIL BASS COMPETENCY
RESTORATION PROGRAMS THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY PRESENTED.
ADDRESS THE INCREASED REFERRAL
PROCESSING WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED
WITH AN INCREASING I GUESS HE
REFERRAL CASELOAD AND PROVIDE
RESOURCES FOR DATA MANAGEMENT
ANALYSIS RELATED TO G. B. C. T.
PART -- PROGRAMS GIVEN THE
INCREASING CASELOAD AND
EXPANSION OF PROGRAMS FOR I. S.
T. IS IN THE DEPARTMENT -- THESE
RESOURCES WILL SUPPORT AND THREE
DIFFERENT UNITS WITHIN OUR
ORGANIZATION AND THAT SUPPORT
THE AFOREMENTIONED
RESPONSIBILITIES [inaudible]
I OVER [inaudible]
FINANCE SO.
SO WE'RE GONNA A I REALIZE ARE
STILL HIGH WE'RE TRYING.
TO DECREASE THE NUMBER VICE THE
REFERRALS STRAIGHTNESS AHA SO
THIS IS BECAUSE OF AN INCREASE
OF DISTRICT.
RECONCILE THE TO GET BACK TO ME
THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY OUT ABOUT
EIGHT HUNDRED ON THE WAIT LIST.
TO YOU ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED
ELEVEN WE WERE AT ABOUT NINE
HUNDRED TO IT THAT AND THOUSAND
LAST THIS TIME LAST YEAR.
SO WE HAVE AND WE OPENED UP THE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY BED I'M
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAM THIS
YEAR SO WE HAVE SEEN SOME
REDUCTION IN THE WAIT LIST -- WE
HAVE THE METROPOLITAN STATE
HOSPITAL BEDS COMING ONLINE --
IN THE COMING MONTHS -- SO.
HOPING THAT -- WITH THOSE --
INCREASES IN THE JOB IN A
COMPANY THAT WE WILL START TO
SEE AT THE TO GAIN SOME
REDUCTION ACTION OKAY SO THE SO
THIS IS ACTUALLY SUED BECAUSE
YOU NEED INCREASED CAPACITY
GIVEN.
THE FACILITIES YOU'VE HAD TO
OPEN IF YOU ARE OPENING --
ALTHOUGH WE'RE TRYING TO WORK AT
THE OTHER END TO NOT HAVE TO
KEEP OPENING MORE FACILITIES AND
DECREASE THE BACKLOG.
RIGHT RIGHT THESE ARE THE
RESOURCES ASSOCIATED WITH ALL OF
THE INCREASE REFERRALS EVEN
THOUGH WE'RE REDUCING WEIGHTLESS
THOSE RIGHT.
CONTINUING TO COMMENT SO THE
REFERRAL BASES AND I'M RE
WRITING HOPEFULLY TOMORROW OUR
HOPE IS WE CAN REDUCE REFERRALS
IN THE FUTURE RIGHT RIGHT FOR
THE HUNDRED RALLY IN AND RIGHT
CURRENTLY THEY'RE STILL IN A
VERY VERY HIGH.
YEAH WE'RE JUST STARTING ON THAT
OKAY ALL RIGHT BUT IN TERMS OF
THIS YOU'RE LOOKING DOWN THE
LINE THE PEOPLE WERE HIRING FOR
THIS ARE STILL GONNA BE NEEDED
OUT INTO THE FUTURE RIGHT.
OUR IS THIS BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
WE'RE HERE WE'RE HOPING WE BRING
DOWN THE REFERRALS.
YEAH BUT WERE.
SO I JUST LAST YEAR BECAUSE WE
WERE OPENING A LOT OF D. B. C.
T. SO IT TO THE EXTENT THAT WE
NEED ALL OF THE STILL CONTINUE
TO NEED ALL THE G. B. C. T.
RIGHT WILL STILL NEED THOSE
RESOURCES.
AND THE REFERRALS THAT THEY YOU
KNOW DEPENDING ON WHERE THEY
LEVEL OFF.
WE'LL HAVE TO REASSESS THAT BACK
CURRENTLY AT THE CURRENT LEVELS
YOU KNOW AND TO THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE OKAY AT THIS POINT.
OKAY.
BECAUSE OF THE THE REFERRALS
COME DOWN WILL HIT THIS NEAR
DOWN HERE TRYING.
TO RIGHT SOMEWHERE OKAY IT'S AN
RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY.
THE COMMON AREA I THINK I
CHECKED WITH THE GUYS ARE --
THEN FINALLY DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
GOOD EVENING.
I DON'T THINK ANY STATE
FACILITIES DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
RIGHT.
YES IT'S DIFFERENT MAINTENANCE
YES.
SORRY SORRY.
THANK YOU AND TODAVíA SAGE IS
REQUESTING GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE FOR A 200-019-2000
TWENTY BUDGET NAME OUT OF THIRTY
FIVE MILLION -- TO ADDRESS THE
LONGSTANDING MAINTENANCE ISSUES
THAT ARE REQUIRED THROUGHOUT THE
DEPARTMENT -- AS I'M SURE YOU
ALL KNOW OUR HOSPITALS ARE QUITE
OLD -- SO WE'RE LOOKING TO USE
THESE FUNDS TO SHORE UP SOME OF
THE MORE IMPORTANT RESOURCES AT
THE HOSPITALS -- THE THIRTY FIVE
MILLION INCLUDES PROXY TWO
MILLION FOR LITERATURE REDUCTION
RETROFITS. THIRTY ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION IN ROOF REPAIRS AND
REPLACEMENT AND ABOUT ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION -- FOR ROAD REPAIRS
ACROSS ALL FIVE FACILITIES.
ANY COMMENTS LU.
YES SO WE DON'T HAVE CONCERNS
WITH PROVIDING THE THIRTY FIVE
MILLION TO THE DEPARTMNT
HOWEVER WE ARE CONCERNED BECAUSE
THE DEPARTMENT DOES HAVE A FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG AND RIGHT
NOW THERE IT'S ONLY ABLE TO
SPEND.
ABOUT ONE POINT NINE MILLION A
YEAR ADDRESSING THAT BACKLOG SO
WE THINK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD ASK THE DEPARTMENT TO
COME FORWARD WITH A PLAN ABOUT
HOW IT'S GOING TO IN A LONG TERM
BASIS OUTSIDE OF THE SORT OF ONE
TIME APPROACHES.
ADDRESS THAT THAT -- BACK
WALKING DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
ALSO TO HELP THE LEGISLATURE
EXERCISE OVERSIGHT OF THE THIRTY
FIVE MILLION WE ARE RECOMMENDING
THE APPROVAL OF SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING LANGUAGE.
THAT WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT TO REPORT BY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE ON HOW THE BACKLOG
CHANGE FOLLOWING THE PROVISIONS
OF THE FUNDING.
AND IF THE BACKLOG INCREASED WHY
IT INCREASED AND WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS DOING TO BETTER
MANAGE ITS FACILITIES TO PREVENT
INCREASES LIKE THAT IN THE
FUTURE THIS WILL PUT THE
LEGISLATURE IN A POSITION TO
KNOW.
WHETHER IT NEEDS TO STEP IN AND
TAKE STEPS TO HELP THE
DEPARTMENT BETTER MANAGE ITS ITS
FACILITIES OR JUST THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THEY HAVE OKAY MAKING
FINANCE.
COMMENTS ALL RIGHT.
YES I WOULD JUST ADD ONE COMMENT
TO DREW'S POINT IS THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY UNDERGOING AN
INFRASTRUCTURE MASTER PLAN.
AND CRITICAL INSPECTION OF ALL
OF OUR FACILITIES WHICH WILL
HELP US TO DEVELOP THE LONG TERM --
DEFERRED MAINTENANCENEEDS THAT
WE HAVEN'T COME UP WITH A
STRATEGY FOR HOW WE DRESS OF AND
WHEN YOU EXPECT TO COMPLETE THAT
PLAN -- WE JUST KICKED OFF ABOUT
A MONTH AGO AND IT'S ABOUT
EIGHTEEN MONTHS PROJECT AND WILL
BE DOING IN PHASES AND GETTING
REPORTS FROM OUR PROVIDER
ARCHITECTURAL PROVIDING FIRM --
ON EACH PHASE WITH RECOMMENDED
SHORT TERM LONG TERM AND MEDIUM
TERM SOLUTIONS AND FUNDING NEEDS
FOR THOSE OKAY SO USAGE SO AGAIN
WE ASK YOU WHEN YOU EXPECT TO
GET IT DONE YOU SAID YOU JUST
STARTED SO WE'RE LOOKING AT WHEN
DO YOU THINK YOU CAN COME BACK
TO IT.
WITH US WITH THE REBEL LEADER
ROUGHLY TWO YEARS EIGHTEEN
MONTHS TO TWO YEARS.
WITH A FOUR OKAY THIRTY OF THE
ENTIRE SYSTEM OKAY ALL RIGHT
WELL I THINK YOU HEARD FROM THE
LA -- I AB AGREED TO BE IS IT
THAT SOME UNITY YOU.
DISPUTE HIS NUMBER ABOUT FOR OUR
BILLION OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE DOING
IT MORE DETAILED STUDY BUT YET I
WE KNOW WHERE THE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION NEED IS NOW.
OKAY RIGHT OKAY SO BECAUSE I
THINK WE WE NEED TO THINK MORE
SYSTEMATICALLY ABOUT THIS I
APPRECIATE THAT AND THE BRAIN
BRAIN THE THESE FORD BYE THINK
WE NEED TO THINK.
AND DON'T TELL US A LITTLE BIT A
JOKE IS EVERY I THINK EVERY
SEGMENT THE STATE WE'RE HEARING
ABOUT SPURRED MAINTENANCE AND
MAINTENANCE BACKLOGS AND SO
FORTH AND ALSO I THINK THE OTHER
PART IS IS THAT -- AND
RECOGNIZING WE HAVE A LOT ROOFS
AND SO FORTH YOU KNOW YOU ALWAYS
WONDER THAT YOU DON'T FIX A ROOF
THAT DAMAGE GETS WORSE AND WHAT
I MEAN.
THAT IT DOESN'T STAY STILL ALL
RIGHT IT'S JUST AND THOUGH.
SO WE US WE NEED A PLAN TO START
TACKLING THESE AND PRIORITIZING
SO THAT YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
FURTHER DEGRADATION YOUR
FACILITIES.
AS WELL AND RECOGNIZING ALSO THE
NATURE OF OUR BUDGETS AND
ECONOMIC CYCLES THAT WE WANT TO
BE SURE WE HAVE A STRATEGY THAT
WHEN WE HAVE THOSE FUNDS
AVAILABLE WE CAN TRY.
TO GET ON TOP OF THEM -- SO --
SO I GUESS WE'LL PUT A MARKER
FOR TWO YEARS FROM NOW RIGHT WE
EXPECT TO HAVE A THE BACK THE
PLAN WILL BE SPEAKING BEFORE
THEN ON OUR FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
OKAY AND THEN IN THE MEANTIME
HOPEFULLY WHEN I HAVING MORE
DAMAGING BETWEEN.
IT'S A BY THE OF IT BUT SO BY
THE WAY I MEAN IT'S THE THINGS
AS THIS QUESTION I KNOW YOU'RE
DOING YOUR ASSESSMENT BUT OKAY
THIRTY FIVE MILLION FOR THIS
YEAR IS THAT MEAN WORDS THAT
MEAN ACTUAL SAYS IT.
WE STAY STILL IS STILL FALLING
BEHIND WITH THIS.
THAT TAKES CARE OF SOME OF THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY NEEDS OUT OF
THAT FOUR HUNDRED IN THIS THIS
PART OF FUNDS BUT CERTAINLY WITH
THE AGE OF OUR AND WE ALSO HAVE
SOME OTHER CONSTRUCTION FUNDS
THAT ARE -- GETTING READY TO
KICK OFF AS WELL SOME
SIGNIFICANT ROOF PROJECTS AS
WELL SO WE'RE TRACK TACKING THE
HIGHEST PARTY FIRST BUT
CERTAINLY -- THE REST OF THE
FACILITIES ARE CONTINUING TO
THIS GREAT TO SOME DEGREE YEAR
BY YEAR.
OKAY SO -- BUT AGAIN I KNOW
YOU'RE DOING ASSESSMENT I'M JUST
THINKING LIKE YOU KNOW WE DO --
BUT I YEAH.
IF YOU READ IT IF YOU RUN AN
OFFICE COMPLEX OF THE OF RESERVE
STUDIES I MEAN THAT I GUESS MY
QUESTION.
IS AGAIN.
THESE ARE YOUR HIGHS PARTY
PROJECTS I GOT IT SO WITH THE
THIRTY FIVE MILLION ARE WE
BASICALLY STAYING STILL ARE WE
STILL FALLING FURTHER BEHIND I
DON'T THINK I DON'T.
HAVE DONE OVER THERE CATCHING UP
A LITTLE BIT ITSELF IS A SMALL
FRACTION OF THE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION OF THE LORD'S.
AFTER WE DO THIS THIRTY FIVE
MILLION.
HELLO OTHER THINGS ARE GETTING
OLDER TOO I WAS GONNA BE A YEAR
OLDER SO IS THIS IS THIS.
IS THIS ABOUT BASICALLY GPS AT
FOUR HUNDRED WELL I MEAN AGAIN
YOU'RE DOING SAVE IT AT FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION ARE LEAST
FALLING A LITTLE BEHIND ARE WE
ACTUALLY GET CATCHING AND WEALTH
CATCHING UP TO BE VERY SLIGHT
ABOUT BUT I'D JUST TRYING TO GET
A SENSE OF WHAT WHAT.
WHAT WHAT WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
GONNA BE STANDING NEXT YEAR?
YEAH I I THINK YOU KNOW AS AS
APARTMENT HAS IS MENTIONED
THEY'RE DOING THEIR PLANS ARE
RIGHT THE OVERALL NEEDS.
IN ADDITION THERE'S EXISTING
DOLLARS ALTHOUGH VERY LITTLE TO
DO.
GENERAL MAINTENANCE BY THESE
FACILITIES ARE VERY OLD SELECT A
TO SAY THAT YOU'RE STAYING ON
PAR I DON'T KNOW IF I
NECESSARILY AGREE WITH THAT NOR
WOULD I THINK THE DEPARTMENT
WOULD.
I WOULD THINK THAT THIS HELPS.
OKAY SO SO I GUESS AND AGAIN
RECOGNIZING AGES FACILITIES AND
AS YOU'RE DOING AS AS IF YOU'RE
ASSESSING EVERYTHING RIGHT I
ASSUME THAT WHY SHOULD ASSUME.
I HOPE THAT IT'S NOT JUST BIKE
OKAY WE NEED TO FIX THIS AND
THIS AND THIS RIGHT BUT DAISY
LIKE OKAY THIS IS THE LIFE CYCLE
OF THESE DIFFERENT ITEMS SO WELL.
WE MIGHT NOT SIX THIS YET.
AN EX NUMBER YEARS WE ANTICIPATE
WE WOULD HAVE TO REPLACE AFFECTS
ADULTS THAT WAY YOU KNOW I MEAN
IT'S IT'S NOT JUST A LIST OF
THINGS TO GET FIXED RIGHT NOW
BUT ALSO YOUR IF I CAN RESERVE
STUDY YOU'RE SORT OF LIKE TO
DISSIPATING WHAT YOU FUTURE
CASTLE YOU.
AND SO YOU KNOW FROM YEAR TO
YEAR IF WE DON'T PUT X. AMOUNT
OF DOLLARS AND WE'RE FALLING
BEHIND AND IT REALLY IS IT'S
BEEN PROTECTION TO RIGHT I MEAN
SOMETHING THINGS HAPPEN RIGHT
NOW BAD WEATHER EVENT AND NOW
TREE FALLS THE REASON YOU HAVE
TO FIX THAT ONE NOW.
WAS GONNA LAST ANOTHER TEN YEARS
OR SOMETHING BUT I'M JUST TRYING
TO GET IT THE TERMS OF THINKING-OF THIS IS A MORE DYNAMIC THING
THAT SIMPLY A ASSESSMENT IN A
LIST OF THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
FIXED.
YEAH AND WE DON'T HAVE OUR
CAPPELLI PEOPLE HERE AT LEAST
FROM FINANCE BUT THEY DO ALSO
HAVE -- I BELIEVE IT'S A FIVE
YEAR PLAN FOR THE RIGHT HOSPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS AS WELL SO
BEYOND JUST THE GENERAL
MAINTENANCE.
THEY ARE CONTINUOUSLY ASSESSING
AND AND DOING THOSE THE PLANNING
FOR THE LARGER CAP OUTLAY
PROJECTS AS WELL OKAY SO I MEAN
I THINK THATSERVE ALONG WITH
THE LA I WAS SAYING WE WE WANT
TO BE SURE THAT WE'RE GOOD
STEWARDS OF OUR PROPERTIES WALLS
ARE FINANCES AND AS WE'RE
PUTTING.
TOGETHER THIS PLAN AND GETTING A
SENSE BECAUSE BUT CERTAIN YEAH.
SO SO WE KNOW WHERE WE'RE AT AND
WHERE WE'RE HEADED TO AND I
THINK THAT THAT AND SO THAT WE
CAN MAKE THE RIGHT DECISIONS
RIGHT AND NOW SOMETIMES FISCAL
CONSTRAINTS WILL BE WILL.
WE KNOW WE'RE FALLING BEHIND AT
LEAST WERE CONSCIOUSLY DOING IT
RIGHT AND IF THERE'S OPERATE TO
CONSCIOUSLY GET AHEAD.
WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO DO THAT TO
SELL BUT IF WE JUST DON'T KNOW.
WE THINK WE ARE WHATEVER SO WE
NEED A ROADMAP.
AND WE HAVE A PRETTY DETAILED
ROAD MAP OF WHAT WE ARE ABLE TO
SEE OVER THE YEARS IN THE IN THE
THE STUDY OF OUR FACILITIES WITH
THE EXPERTISE WE HAVE.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE MASTER PLAN
WILL GO MUCH DEEPER TO THAT AND
AND ADDRESS ART OUT YEARS TEN
TWENTY THIRTY YEARS DOWN THE
ROAD.
BUT CERTAINLY THAT FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION REPRESENTS A LOT OF
STUDY AN EVALUATION OF OUR
SYSTEMS PRIMARILY ESPECIALLY IN
AREAS OF PATIENT SAFETY --
FIRELIGHT AND SAFETY FOR THE
FACILITIES FOR THE STAFF AS WELL
OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL.
APPRECIATE WERE.
SCRATCHING THE SURFACE HERE BUT
THAT THAT THAT THAT.
AND CERTAINLY WE WANT TO TAKE
CARE OF THEM BUT SERIOUS STUFF
BUT IT.
I THINK IT'S HELPFUL TO KNOW --
EVEN.
THAT'S WAS ASKING I'M I FALLING
FOR IT IS THAT THE THIRTY FIVE
MILLION WE STILL FALLING FURTHER
BEHIND -- WAS TAKING EVERY
TREADING WATER SO THAT'S THAT
THAT'S THAT BECAUSE MAYBE MAYBE
SHOULD DO MORE THIS YEAR I DON'T
KNOW.
OKAY I BURGER I HAVE YOUR
REQUEST WITH WITH WITH EXCEPT
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION IF IT WAS
ON THE TABLE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THAT'S A QUICK
RIGHT ON THE TAPE THERE YOU GO
ALL RIGHT OR ANYTHING MORE YOU
TAKE IT OKAY ALL RIGHT GOT IT
ALRIGHT.
ALL RIGHT THERE YOU GO.
FINANCE WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT
THAT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT ANYTHING ELSE
THEN OKAY -- PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ALL THE ISSUES BEFORE US ON
STATE HOSPITALS IS THERE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT YES.
GOOD EVENING MR TERM MEMBERS WHO
SHALL MUCH THERE ON BEHALF TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION WE WON AT THINK THAT
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITAL ON FOR
THEIR WORK ON DICEY BACKLOG AND
WE SUPPORT THEIR REQUESTS FOR
THE BANK.
BUT EXPANSION TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THING COFFIN TO STAND
TRIAL POPULATION ON THE ISSUE OF
THAT I JAIL SPACE COMPETENCY --
WE FEEL THAT THE SHARES FEEL
THAT THIS IS BEEN A PRETTY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM -- BUT IT IS
A PART OF THAT KIND OF A MULTI
PRONGED APPROACH TO A TREATISE
POPULATION SO -- WE EXPRESS OUR
AT GRATITUDE FOR THE COMMITTEE
AFTER CONSIDERING AT THESE
PROGRAMS AND FOR THE FUNDING
THAT MIGHT COME THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
OKAY THANK YOU SAY KNOWN ALSO
THE MICROPHONE.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION TO HOLD OPEN I
GUESS I AM ON THIS -- UPDATES OF
STRENGTH.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WELL ISSUED -- BECAUSE
ISSUE LUNCHES OVERVIEW RIGHT SO
ISSUE TO ISSUE THREE ISSUE FOR
ISSUE FIVE ISSUE SIX ISSUE SEVEN
ISSUE EIGHT WILL HOLD ALL THIS
OPEN AND WE'LL.
SEE WHAT MAY REVISED BRINGS US
BEFORE YOU VOTE ON THIS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS
AND WORK AT STATE HOSPITALS.
I THANK YOU FOR COMING LAST
ASSYRIAN WAITING.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
SO WITH THAT THAT COMPLETES THE
AGENDA OF THE THIS HEARING OF
THE BUDGETS -- AND FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE ON
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AND SO
WE ARE ADJOURNED